hey this is andrew brown your cloud
instructor at exam pro bringing you
another complete study course and this
time it's the hashicorp terraform
associate certification made available
to you here on freecodecamp so this
course is designed to help you pass and
achieve hashicorp issued certification
and the way we're going to do that is by
going through lectures follow alongs
cheat sheets and even a practice exam so
you can prove on your resume and
linkedin you got that terraform
knowledge so you can go get that devops
job or get that promotion you've been
looking for to tell you a bit about me
i'm previously the cto of multiple
edtech companies 15 years industry
experience five years specializing cloud
i'm it was community hero i published
multiple free cloud courses and if you
ever want to buy me a drink coconut
water is what i drink uh if you i just
want to take a moment here to thank
viewers like you because it's you that
make these free courses possible if you
want to know how you can support more
free courses like this the best ways to
buy our additional study materials at
exam pro dot co forward slash terraform
for this particular course so this is
where you'll get study notes flash cards
quizlets downloadable lectures
downloadable cheat sheets practice exams
ask questions get learning support and
so if you want to access the free
practice exam cheat sheets you do have
to sign up but there is no credit card
required there's no trial limit and
you're not going to get spammed okay if
there are course updates they are going
to appear within a link within the
youtube and also on the exam pro
platform and just make sure that you
have access to these corrections
additions modifications uh before you
start this course so you're making sure
you are consuming the latest version so
that you have the best chance of passing
if you want to keep up to date on uh new
courses that i'm working on the best
places to follow me on twitter at andrew
brown and i'd love to hear if you passed
your exam what courses you'd like to see
next and there you go so let's go jump
into the course now
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're at the start of our journey
asking the most important questions
first which is what is the terraform
associate so the hashicorp terraform
associate is a specialty certification
in terraform and it is an infrastructure
as a code tool that is both declarative
and cloud agnostic so you might be
considering getting the certification if
you are seeking a devops engineer role
if you enjoy automating infrastructure
or writing scripts if you have knowledge
uh working with multiple cloud service
providers like aws gcp azure or you
enjoy designing and entering on
end-to-end infrastructure life cycles so
terraform is the third most uh
cloud skill that is in demand for devops
roles so it goes aws azure terraform and
kubernetes so terraform is the industry
standard for infrastructure as a code i
know aws really likes cloud formation
but you know when you're using more than
one provider and most companies are
they're going to be turning to terraform
this is not a difficult exam however
grasping terraform requires a bit of
patience since uh it requires a bit of
uh silic uh circular learning to fully
understand certain concepts so when i
say that it's like you'll go over
something you'll kind of get it then
you'll go put it into practice and
you'll come back to the original lecture
content and then it will all make sense
so you just have to kind of work through
it with having partial information it's
kind of like doing math back in the day
for high school so terraform is easy to
learn but it definitely is hard to
master so
just because you pass this terraform
associate doesn't mean you're an expert
in it but definitely means that you're
gonna have the skills to meet the job
requirements for junior devops roles or
you know if you're upskilling okay so
there are multiple ways that we can look
at this i call it the multi-cloud
roadmap because everything that
hashicorp does is all about uh
multi-cloud workloads and a prerequisite
of doing this kind of stuff is actually
having base knowledge in uh different
providers so if we're looking at
certifications you have the google cloud
engineer you could have any any sort of
um aws certification could be the
solutions architect could be the
developer
but generally the sysops is probably the
most aligned and then you have your
azure administrator or maybe your
azure
developer the az204 and then there's
also kubernetes because kubernetes
workloads can come in there so that's
the ckad
so very common is you'll pick up one or
two certs in your associate tier for one
of the csps and then you're going to
move on to your terraform associate
certification uh hashicorp
while i'm making this video does not
have that many certifications beyond the
associate track as you can see they only
have a single professional up here and
it's for vault would they make a
terraform professional i don't know um
but you know that'd be interesting to
see if you wanted to know where to go
after your associate i would probably go
over to console because that is uh like
cloud networking or multi-cloud
networking that is agnostic and then
maybe you might want to go over to
vaults
if you are
uh interested to go the vault route and
again this is outside of the terraform
roadmap but you could just take one of
those associates and move to vaults and
then go to the take the professional if
you're doing the kubernetes track then
you you would probably want to go over
to console there but really we're
focused on here is this over here okay
so how long does it take to pass uh this
exam so here i have kind of a scale here
we're going to look at beginner and then
experience so i i describe a beginner as
someone who's never written
infrastructure as a code uh has not
previously focused on automating
infrastructure and doesn't hold an
associate level certification if this is
you you're looking at a 30 hour study
time you really should go obtain
a
cloud service provider associate before
you take this exam you don't have to but
it's generally recommended for the
experienced person
this is someone who is written
infrastructure's code maybe it's been
cloud formation maybe it's been armed
templates but maybe it's just not
terraform
they are already working in a devops
role automating infrastructure writing
scripts and they hold an associate level
they probably have professionals too so
they're looking at 12 hours study time
okay so there's a large window of time
but my recommendation is that you spread
it out across 14 days study one to two
hours obviously it's going to vary based
on uh what you're doing here but that
will pretty much get you there okay
what does it take to pass this example
you're going to have to watch the
lecture
materials and memorize key information
you absolutely need to do hands-on labs
it's really going to cement your
knowledge here when i made this course i
did all the lecture content first and
then when i did my follow alongs i just
had so many misconceptions
because the um
the actual documentation did not exactly
match what was in practice so it's very
important that you do that and i would
strongly recommend some practice exams
and the great thing is i have practice
exams for you on our platform and not
only that i have a full free practice
exam for for you with 57 questions like
that's a full set just like the real
exam so i strongly recommend that you go
redeem it uh you could probably pass
just with the free one but you know if
you want to help support the platform
then go pay to unlock all the rest of
the study material content okay
um in terms of the content outline there
is a lot of domains here so we have
understand infrastructures of code
understand terraform purpose under stand
terraform basics use terraform cli
interact with terraform modules navigate
the terraform workflow
implement uh and maintain terraform
state regenerate modify configuration
understand terraform cloud enterprise
capabilities and the interesting thing
is that they don't give a a distribution
in terms of the weighting so it's my
assumption that um and when we look at
the exam guide outline you'll see that
they'll have sub domains under each one
so i would imagine that if you know if
there's like five questions under or
five sub domains under 1.0 then that
kind of tells you the waiting for that
section uh but we'll talk about that
when we get the exam guide because
there's some interesting stuff there
okay where do you take the exam well you
can take an in-person test center or
online from the convenience of your own
home
and it's only with one
test center and this is with psi
when i say test center i mean like uh
they're a network of test centers around
the world and this is a project
experience so there is a supervisor
who monitors students during the
examination so uh you know to make sure
that it's legit okay in terms of grading
you have to get a 70 percent to pass
around that just like every other
exam out there it probably uses scaled
scoring so it's not always exact if you
get exactly on the dot seven percent
doesn't necessarily mean you pass so
make sure you aim for 75 percent for
your exam okay
there are 57 questions that affords
about 17 questions that you can get
wrong there's no penalty for wrong
questions so absolutely make sure that
you always take a guess the format of
the questions are multiple choice
multiple answer and this last one's
interesting but there's fill in the
blank and this is where you type a
single word answer so they might ask you
like what is the name of the terraform
save file and you just write in
terraform.tf state
so you know it could be as simple as
that the duration of the exam is one
hour but that is plenty of time you get
one minute per question a little bit
more than just a minute so your exam
time is 60 minutes but your seat times
90 minutes see time is meaning that you
show up
30 minutes early and you make sure
you're ready so you can review the
instructions
if you have to work with your online
proctor to make sure your workspace is
secure accept and read the nda
complete the exam provide feedback of
the exam so make sure you get paid for
that time
this exam is valid for 24 months so that
means two years before recertification
one little thing i want to note here is
about terraform version considerations
when i designed this course it was
designed around the 1.0 specification of
terraform so terraform is always
incrementing inversion so for your
studies you may always need to look at
the feature set of versions that go back
three minor versions from the current
stable version so if it's 1.0 like uh
which the exams at least when i sat it
wasn't even at 1.0 it's probably like
point 15 or 0.14
but my point is that i designed this
kind of be like a bit future proof so
it's this course is not going to go
stale for a couple years but i do want
you to tell you that like you know if
the exam is based around let's say like
the terraform version that's out is one
point uh you know six uh that doesn't
like the exam is always a bit behind it
so you know the exam might be 1.0 and
then that means that the content exam
would cover these three things okay so
throughout this course i will cover
older stuff but i'll also cover newer
stuff and i'll give more emphasis on and
you'll see me do that throughout the
course okay so for terraform
certification is heavily dependent on
practical knowledge so as as long as you
take the time to apply the knowledge uh
you'll have a good chance of passing
regardless of the differences in
versioning and
uh more than half of this course is
hands-on okay so the bulk of it is
hands-on um you could pass just doing
lecture content so like when i sat the
exam
i had done a i like like a very simple
walkthrough and then i made all my
lecture content and i was able to pass
no problem uh but again i have a
background in devops and i understand
how this stuff works so it was easy for
me to translate that if you are new or
you're not confident you should really
do all those practice exams so there you
go and let's take a look at the actual
exam guide okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are on the hashicorp
certification website looking at
terraform associate and we're going to
take a look here at the exam guide
because i have some commentary that i
want to share with you about it
and what i found really interesting with
the way they design their courses is
that everything that you see pretty much
shows up on the exam so there is 57
questions on the exam and but down below
here there is just shy of 57
subdomains and so the great thing here
is that pretty much
every single question will map to one of
these
and you're not going to be worried about
having to figure out things outside of
this pool so that really is going to
narrow
what you need to study for uh it creates
a lot of less
like confusion or guesswork or over
study and i really appreciate that and i
did not until i actually
finished like i got certified and made
the lectures in the labs and my practice
exams and i realized wow that makes it a
lot easier from a study perspective but
when i came into this i thought the exam
was going to be something like aws where
what they do is they have all these
domains and subdomains and subtopics and
then besides that then they also have
like appendix and then the service and
features list and so basically
more than half like half of more than
half of the stuff that they say here you
might not even experience an exam and
that's really frustrating because you're
really over studying here
and i really like hashicorp's approach
here so if you really do want to know
what you know just go down the list here
and say do i know what all of these
things are and if you can checkbox those
off you're very likely to pass okay
um
i do want to say that this is uh dated
even like right now as we talk because
this is not based off of terraform 1.0
this exam guide outline and we can tell
because we see terraform taint if you
look up terraform taint
this is a deprecated command
um so it has been replaced with
terraform apply
with the hyphen replace but do not worry
i've taken care of all of that for you
in the exam so you do not have to worry
about any kind of confusion we are going
to cover things outside of just this
exam guide outline because after talking
to da's
their technical writers product
marketers i feel that there's going to
be additional content coming in the
update like terraform cloud because i
feel like that needs a lot more
attention here and so i was i was sure
to pack this course with a lot of extra
stuff so that the lifespan of this
course is gonna be a lot longer than
what is being shown here okay
so
yeah uh hopefully that gives you kind of
an idea and some confidence going into
this exam uh but let's jump into the
real content okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and what i want to do is walk you
through a few of our practice exam
questions just to give you an idea of
what it will be like on the real exam
and where we might have had to make some
adjustments to help your study so what
you'd have to do to access this practice
exam is you'd have to be signed up and
logged in to the exam pro platform make
your way over to the hashicorp terraform
course accept the free tier or pay for
full access but once you go there you'll
scroll all the way down to the bottom
and you should see three or four
practice exams at the time of writing
this we're still writing the questions
so that's why they're not shown in the
video here but what i want you to do is
to go to the first practice exam and
notice that there are 57 questions you
get an hour
on on the exam here and we have a
breakdown based on domain now the
percentage is not something that uh
terraform or hashicorp provides so we
just had to break it down based on the
coverage of questions that we saw in the
exam guide outline and so that should be
accurate enough and that's kind of what
it felt like on the exam so i don't
think that's going to be a problem if we
click into here we're just going to look
at some of the questions i'll talk
around them so the first one here is we
have how do you create a workspace and
it's showing us a bunch of cli commands
and so on the exam you do need to know
um uh you know cli commands and the
difference of them and the questions can
be as simple as this where you're just
choosing the option and some are obvious
distractors like there isn't there is no
one called terraform workspace branch
okay so just understand that you not
just need to know the conceptual ideas
behind terraform but also it in practice
okay
another one here would be the terraform
registry can search based on the
following search terms we have an option
to choose multiple uh questions and so
this is something that you will see on
the exam where you're choosing multiples
of something i didn't get a lot on my
exam but i cannot say for certain like
how many questions would show up like
this um but you know they're not really
that hard to figure out okay and this
question is about um a tool or sorry uh
the
public terraform registry website and
that is just a
uh
a public-facing website if we go to
registry.terraform.io here it's this
website here so it's not just the
tooling of terraform itself but it's the
ecosystem around it's a terraform cloud
the terraform registry things like that
another type of question you will see
and i think it's over here is what they
will do is they'll ask you to fill in
the blank now we don't have that support
in our platform just as of yet but the
idea is they'll say like okay uh we'll
ask you a question or we'll even give
you um maybe they'll have like
underscores and they'll say fill in this
thing and you'll literally have to type
the answer in but the answer is gonna be
like a word answer so
on the exam i literally had a question
which was like where is the api stored
and it was actually terraformed at tf
state but i did not know i could not
recall the name of it which is kind of
embarrassing but uh you know that is the
level of fill-ins that you'll have to do
and you're very likely to see some code
on the on the clut exam too so if i just
click through here really quickly you
may see a code block okay and you might
have to decipher it so that's the
difficulty of the exam i would not say
this is a hard exam but you just have to
understand the scope of those kind of
questions and make sure that you have
well-rounded study in both practical and
conceptual concepts of terraform so
hopefully that helps you out okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at what is
infrastructure is code and before we
talk about that we need to talk about
the problem with manual configuration so
manually configuring your cloud
infrastructure allows you to easily
start using new cloud service offerings
to quickly prototype architectures
however it comes with a few downsides so
it's easy to misconfigure a service
through human error it's hard to manage
the expected state of the configuration
for compliance it's hard to transfer
configuration knowledge to other team
members and so this is why uh
infrastructure code is going to really
help us out so um infrastructure is code
commonly abbreviated to iac and you'll
see that a lot in this course allows you
to write a configuration script to
automate creating updating or destroying
cloud infrastructure notice i gave great
emphasis on automate or automation
because that is really key to
infrastructure's code iec can also be
thought of as a blueprint of your
infrastructure ic allows you to easily
share version or inventory your cloud
infrastructure and just to kind of give
you a visualization imagine you write a
script and that's going to uh provision
uh and launch a bunch of cloud services
that are all interconnected okay
[Music]
all right so we're taking a look at
popular iac tools and so of course this
course is about terraform but by
understanding all the options out there
you understand why we're using terraform
and one thing that is very important to
understand is the difference between
declarative and imperative iec tools
those are the broad categories that we
see
for iac so let's start with declarative
so the idea here is what you see is what
you get everything's explicit it's more
verbose but there's zero chance of
misconfiguration and this all relies on
the fact that they use a scripting
language such as json yaml xml in the
case of terraform they have their own
language called hcl but the way these
languages are structured is that they're
very verbose
and there's not a lot of programming
logic involved
so for azure we have arm templates and
azure blueprints for aws we have
cloudformation for google we have cloud
deployment manager and then there is of
course terraform which has many cloud
service providers such as aws azure gcp
kubernetes and a lot more
but these are all in the declarative
category
on the right hand side we have
imperative so you say what you want and
the rest is filled in everything here is
implicit uh it's less verbose but you
could end up with misconfiguration and
when i say that it's that like if you
were to find um let's say a virtual
machine you might not have to provide
every single uh option that you would
normally do and it would fill in the
rest but if you weren't aware of what it
was doing that's where you could end up
with misconfiguration
though i would say that imperative tools
generally try to always
have their defaults as best practices so
you're not usually in a bad position uh
but you know you might end up with
something you don't expect uh imperative
can do more than declarative so there's
just some very hard limitations with
declarative languages uh so there's just
cases where you want to do imperative uh
and the idea here is imperative
languages use programming language you
know like python ruby javascript golang
you know whatever it is uh there's
likely an sdk for it
and so it's just a lot more
programmer friendly a lot of developers
like imperative tools
so aws has their own called cloud
development kit cdk and it technically
only supports aws i say technically
because hashicorp has a very cool
library that allows you to generate out
uh terraform hcl files which allows you
to work with anything but when we're
just talking about cdk on its own it's
just for aws then you have plumi it
supports aws azure tcp
and kubernetes um so it can do a lot so
why would you choose with your team to
use declarative over imperative well it
just really depends on your um your team
right so like if they're all used to if
they're all administrators and they're
used to using jason yaml and they're not
good programming languages uh that is
one reason why you might want to use
declarative over imperative um the other
thing is just you know
you prefer to know exactly every single
thing that was defined right you don't
want anything
left up to a chance and so that is
another reason why you might want to use
declarative but both are great options
it just really depends on your team's
knowledge and what your goals are okay
so we just looked at imperative and
declarative but i just want to clarify
that terraform even though it's a
declarative language it has imperative
like features so i've coined the phrase
declarative plus and so terraform kind
of gives you the best of both worlds so
you have declarative and imperative and
then the three types so our yaml json
xml we have terraform language which
actually utilizes hcl underneath and
then you have programming languages on
the right hand side like ruby python
javascript uh what have you right so
when we're looking at yaml or json these
are very limited languages
or scripting languages where
you know you don't really have any kind
of complex data types you probably don't
have a whole lot of
robust functions but in some cases you
can extend that base behavior so in the
case of cloud formation which uses yaml
or json files they have a concept called
macros so you can extend it a bit but
again it's very inflexible and so a lot
of people are led to go and use cdk so
terraform is great because it kind of
has a lot of stuff you'd see in
programming languages like for loops
dynamic blocks locals it also has
complex data structures and a lot of
functions around using those data
structures and so it allows you to stay
in that declarative world but having the
stuff that you generally need when
you're in the paradive world when you're
in the imperative side the idea is that
the language is what you're utilizing so
you can do anything that the programming
language allows you to do
but i just wanted to kind of show you
that terraform sits in the middle okay
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we are looking at infrastructure life
cycle so what is infrastructure
lifecycle it's the idea of having
clearly defined and distinct work phases
which are used by devops engineers to
plan design build test deliver maintain
and retire cloud infrastructure when
we're talking about like sdlc so
software development life cycle there's
usually a really great visual that i can
show for you but for infrastructure life
cycle especially cloud infrastructure
life cycle there isn't something that is
well defined which is weird by the
definition but
i think that there's just nobody's
agreed upon one yet or nobody's made the
graphic yet so i just don't have
anything to show you for that but i just
want you to get familiar with the term
infrastructure life cycle because you're
likely to hear it again but one
particular infrastructure life cycle
that is pretty common is ones that talk
about day zero day one and day two so
the idea here is this is a simplified
way to describe phases of infrastructure
life cycle so when we say we are on day
zero we are planning and designing our
infrastructure
on day one we are developing and
iterating it so we might be uh you know
deploying or provisioning it and
actually testing it in the cloud and
then day two is actually when we go live
with real production users and maintain
it and the idea of mentioning day zero
one and two is to say well when does iac
start and the idea is it starts on day
zero okay the days do not literally mean
a 24-hour day uh it's just a broad way
of defining where in the infrastructure
project we would be okay
[Music]
so after defining what infrastructure
life cycle is what advantage or what
advancement are we going to have when we
add iac to our infrastructure life cycle
well the first thing we're going to get
is reliability so ic makes changes
impotent consistent repeatable and
predictable i'm going to give extra
attention here to impotent because it is
a very strange english word but no
matter how many times you run your ic
you will always end up with the same
state that is expected that is a very
important concept of iec
whereas if you use configuration
management there's no guarantee of that
that's why you use a terraform over
something like ansible okay you have
manageability so enable mutation via
code revise with minimal changes and
then you have sensibility so avoid
financial and reputational losses to
even loss of life when considering
government and military dependencies on
infrastructure so there you go
[Music]
okay so it impodent is a very important
concept to infrastructure as code and so
we're going to give it a little bit more
attention i wouldn't stress out about
the pronunciation uh there's more than
one way to pronounce it in english and
i've probably even said it wrong uh in
the previous slide so
just be uh
forgiving on that part okay but the idea
is that let's stage a scenario between a
non-edipotent example and an independent
example so when i deploy my iac config
file it will provision and launch two
virtual machines that is what i'm
expecting okay and that is what i get
but what happens when i go and i update
this infrastructure code file saying
maybe i want to increase the size of the
vms or some of the configuration i
deploy that again when it's
non-independent
what will end up happening is i will end
up with two additional virtual machines
with the new configuration and the old
ones will be there and so this is
something you might not want because you
just want to have a file that says
exactly the state that you expect okay
so when we have something that is
idepotent
the idea is we will go and we will
define our two virtual machines and we
will get our two virtual machines but we
go and we update that file and we deploy
again and what happens this time is it
just ends up modifying the original
virtual machines or if it really can't
and it has to it might delete them and
recreate them but the idea is that we
end up in a state of exactly what we
want so in the first case we expected
two but we ended up with four but with
the inopponent uh case we expected two
and we always end up with two so
hopefully that makes that very clear
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and what i want to do here is concretely
define the difference between
provisioning deployment and
orchestration now in practice sometimes
these have overlapping responsibilities
so you might say provisioning when you
really mean deployment or vice versa
it's not a big deal
we all get kind of mixed up about it but
i did want to just take the time to make
sure that we understand what these
things are supposed to mean okay so the
first on our list here is provisioning
so to prepare a server with systems data
and software and to make it ready for
network operation if you're using a
configuration management tool you are
most likely provisioning because that's
what these tools do so puppet ansible
chef bash scripts powershell or cloudnit
so you can provision a server when you
launch a cloud service and configure it
you are provisioning it okay
then you have deployment so deployment
is the act of delivering a version of
your application to run a provision
server deployment could be performed via
a bus code pipeline harness which is a
third-party deployment tool jenkins
github actions circle ci there's a lot
more other providers out there then you
have orchestration so orchestration is
the act of coordinating multiple systems
or services orchestration is a common
term when working with micro services
containers and kubernetes so
orchestration could be done with
kubernetes salt or fabric so if you're
working with containers uh generally
like you use the word orchestration
especially with kubernetes because
you're working with thousands
of uh microservices okay so you know
hopefully that helps you
know the difference between those three
again it's not a big deal if you don't
perfectly know them
but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at
configuration drift so this is when
provision infrastructure has an
unexpected configuration change due to
team members manually adjusting
configuration options malicious actors
so maybe they're trying to cause
downtime or breach data or side effects
from apis sdks or cli so you've written
some code that uses a cli in the bash
script
and it does something you did not expect
to happen
so here an example could be imagine you
have a server like a database
and a junior developer turns off delete
on termination for your production
database this could be a problem where
let's say there's an accidental deletion
of the database
this feature would protect the database
from deletion but if it's turned off you
don't have that right so configuration
drift going unnoticed could be a loss or
breach of cloud services and residing
data or result in interruption of
services or unexpected downtime so
there's a lot of
downsides to uh neglecting or not
noticing configuration drift so what can
we do about this so how to detect so
there's three things detect um
we can fix it and then prevent it okay
so to detect configuration drift if you
have a compliance tool uh it can detect
misconfiguration so aws config can do
that azure policies can do that gcp
security health analytics can do that
some of these are constrained to
security things not just configuration
general but there are tools there
for all the cloud service providers
there is built-in support for drift
detection for it was cloud formation
it's called confirmation
drift detection
other providers don't necessarily have
that
if you're using terraform which is this
which is all this course is about you
have the terraform state files which
says what the state of things should be
so that's how you could detect
configuration drift
how to correct configuration drift well
compliance tools can remediate so again
abs config you can create a custom
lambda to say hey when this happens then
do this so set the configuration back
into place with terraform you can use
the refresh and plan commands which
we'll look at in detail in this course
or you can manually correct it so if the
option was changed you could do that not
recommended to do that
another thing would be tearing down and
setting up the infrastructure again
because that would bring it back into
its original state
that could be a risky thing to do um
depending on how you have things set up
or it could be it could be fine right
then there's prevention so
this is a the important thing and kind
of why we're talking about configuration
drift which is all about immutable
infrastructure so always create and just
destroy never reuse so that might be
blue-green deployment strategies um
servers are never modified they are all
they're just always deployed with a new
version uh the way you would do that
would be baking ami images or containers
via aws image builder or hashicorp
packer or a build server like gcp cloud
run or
code build like aws
but the idea is that you're not
modifying after they're deployed you'd
have that image already ready to go
another thing you could use is git ops
so uh you would version control your iac
like within github or something like
that and you would peer review every
single uh um
change via a pull request to the
infrastructure so hopefully that gives
you an idea of things we can do to
tackle configuration drift okay
[Music]
we were just talking about immutable
infrastructure but i just want to give
it a bit more attention here so
the idea is um we are going to first
develop our infrastructure as a code
file terraform cloudformation what have
you and then we're going to go ahead and
deploy that so we'll end up with our own
virtual machine and that virtual machine
needs to be configured so you need to
install packages and things like that
that's where cloud in it would come into
play ansible puppet chef salt whatever
configuration management tool you want
to use
the problem here is that
there's no guarantee that that
configuration is going to stay in place
so that's where immutable infrastructure
comes into play so we develop our
infrastructure as a code file terraform
cloudformation and then we're going to
go ahead and do our configuration by
building a virtual machine or building a
container so we can use something like
packer
and then the idea is once we are happy
with our configuration
what we're going to do is bake that
image and put it in an image repository
and then
that image is going to be referenced
when we do our deploy and so that's
going to make sure that our
infrastructure is always immutable okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the concept
or methodology of git ops so this is
when you take infrastructure as code and
you use a git repository to introduce a
formal process to review and accept
changes to infrastructure code and once
that code is accepted it automatically
triggers a deploy and changes that
infrastructure so here's my illustration
through it so the idea is you would have
a terraform file and you would place
that in something like github you would
apply your commits and when you're ready
you'd make a pull request you would
merge that pull request into the main
branch or whichever branch is set up for
production and that could trigger
something like github actions
and github actions would then trigger a
terraform uh plan and and accept it or
maybe you have to manually intervene to
say okay i accept these changes but then
it would roll out those changes now
terraform does have their own and it's
pretty darn similar but i thought mine
was a bit easier to read but the idea is
you have your git repository uh you have
your pull request uh this is pulling
from terraform cloud because you can uh
have files and state managed there uh so
that is another means to do it but
that's generally how it works okay
[Music]
so we were just looking at immutable
infrastructure but what i want to do is
just kind of cement in your head things
that you should be asking yourself as a
devops engineer so that you kind of lean
towards uh that immutable uh kind of way
of thinking and so this is mostly gonna
be applicable for virtual machines but
let's just ask some questions of things
we should be thinking about so what's
gonna happen if we deploy our virtual
machine and there is a physical failure
of the hardware by the provider so this
can sometimes happen on aws where they
have two status checks that have to
complete before a virtual machine is
ready sometimes they fail and so you
know your infrastructure is not raised
degraded or damaged right
then you have application failure so you
have this post installation script maybe
to install your application and there's
either a bug so introduced by developer
or maybe there's just a dependency and
it's changed and so it's breaking your
app
what happens when you need to deploy in
a hurry
what happens in worst case scenarios
where you have accidental deletion
compromised by a malicious actor need to
change regions maybe there's a region
outage and so the thing is is that when
you look at these things what happens
when multiples of these happen at the
same time because that's the problem
where you know it's like okay i have
something wrong with my application code
but i also have uh you know now we also
have a region down and so you don't want
to be dealing with more than one problem
at the same time and so that's we're
going to have an issue of agility in
terms of deployment another thing that
is overlooked is there's no guarantee of
one to one if you are configuring your
code after deployment
because if you um were to deploy a
virtual machine
and installed all the dependencies
and then you to were to deploy a virtual
machine literally a minute later one of
those dependencies could have a minor
revision and so that would be deployed
with that one minor revision so they
would look very similar but they aren't
one-to-one so by introducing golding
images which is an immutable
infrastructure idea you get a guarantee
of one one to one with your fleet you
have increased assurance of consistency
security you have uh you can speed up
your deployments the reason why you have
an improvement of security is because at
that stage you could um you could
perform kind of security checks and
things like that there on that image
before you roll it out
so i don't know i would just say that i
would recommend that you go with the
immutable infrastructure or baking your
images when you can if you're using bms
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to take a look here what
is hashicorp so hashicorp is who creates
terraform and they are companies
specializing in managed open source
tools used to support the deployment and
development of large-scale service
oriented software installations and they
have their own uh cloud platform called
the hashicorp cloud platform hcp and
it's a unified platform to access
hashicorp various products so uh the
main thing is that it's cloud agnostic
so hashicorp makes it really easy to
build cross-cloud
and they have support for all the three
main providers so aws gcp azure i'm sure
they have more support like kubernetes
and things like that they're highly
suited for multi-cloud workloads or
cross-cloud workloads and they have a
lot of products that will help you out
there so let's go through them quickly
so first we have boundary this is secure
remote access to systems based on
trusted identity this is console this is
a full featured service mesh for secure
service segmentation across any cloud or
runtime environment you have nomad this
is scheduling and deployment of tasks
across worker nodes in a cluster you
have packer which is a tool for building
virtual machine images that will be
later deployed or they will place them
in a image repository then you have
terraform which is infrastructure as
code software which enables provisioning
and adapting virtual infrastructure
across all major providers then you have
terraform cloud and this is just a place
to store and manage your iac
state files and things like that with a
team or just in the cloud by yourself we
have vagrant so building and
building and maintenance of reproducible
software development environments via
virtualization technology we have vault
so secrets management identity based
access encrypting application data
auditing of secrets for application
systems and users and lastly we have
waypoint a modern workflow to build
deploy and release across
multiple platforms so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at what is terraform
so terraform is an open source and cloud
agnostic infrastructure is a code tool
and terraform uses declarative
configuration files and the
configuration files are written in the
hashicorp configuration language hcl
and so that's what you can see on the
right hand side
we'll generally call it the terraform
language which we'll talk about later
but notable features of terraform are
installable modules plan and predict
changes dependency graphing state
management and provisioning
infrastructure in familiar languages
that's something you could do via aws
cdk so i wouldn't say it's
core to terraform but that's what they
listed on their websites that's what i
put in there and terraform registry
which has over 1 000
plus providers okay so there we go
[Music]
so we were just looking at terraform but
what is terraform cloud well it's a
software as a service offering for
remote state storage version control
integrations flexible workflows and
allows you to collaborate on
infrastructure changes within a single
unified web portal and this is all
accessible via
terraform.io and the first thing you'll
have to do is create yourself an account
on terraformio but it's free to start
with and they actually have a very
generous free tier that allows for team
collaboration for the first five users
of your organization that's not part of
the team's plan that's part of the free
plan and in the majority of cases you
really should be using terraform cloud
as your remote back end even if you are
an individual just because you know it
makes experience so much better the only
case that you might not want to use
terraform cloud is if you have a very
large company that's trying to meet
particular regulatory requirements and
it's not that terraform cloud
does not meet them but sometimes there's
just a long procurement process so in
the meantime you'd have to use something
like standard remote backend or atlantis
or maybe you need to investigate
terraform enterprise i do want to note
that uh terraform cloud and terraform
enterprise is the underlying software
known as terraform platform it's not
something you're going to ever have
direct access to but
just to clarify that terminology okay
[Music]
so what i want to do is just set you up
with understanding the terraform life
cycle this is not necessarily
described in the documentation anywhere
but it's something that is inherently
known when you're working with terraform
and it's definitely not
inclusive of every single command that
can be ran but the ones that you're
going to counter most often so at the
start you're going to be writing or
updating your terraform configuration
file okay and from there the first thing
you'll want to do is initialize your
projects and
or if you need to pull the latest
providers and modules you're going to
use terraforming it to do that as well
from there you're going to use plan so
plan allows you to speculate what will
change or generate a saved execution
plan that you could use later on when
you run plan validate happens
automatically but you could also run
this separately and ensures types and
values are valid ensures the required
attributes are present within your
configuration file from there if
everything is good you're going to
execute your
execution plan by running terraform
apply uh you can also from this point
use terror from apply to destroy
infrastructure so if you have things set
up there's actually a flag for it or you
can use the alias the terraform destroy
command and then you know as you work
you're just going to keep updating your
code and that is the terraform life
cycle so you know hopefully this gives
you kind of a a snapshot of what the
workflow will be
and i mean we'll be covering it tons and
tons of times over in this course okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at change
automation but to understand that we
need to first talk about change
management so this is a standard
approach to apply change and resolving
conflicts brought about by change in the
context of iac change management is the
procedure that will be followed when
resources are modified and applied via
configuration scripts so what is change
automation then it is a way of
automatically creating a consistent
systematic and predictable way of
managing change requests via control and
policies notice and i should have
probably emphasized this is change
requests saying i'm going to change
these resources terraform uses change
automation in the form of execution
plans and resource graphs which will
look at detail those two things in
upcoming slides and apply review complex
change sets so a change set is a
collection of commits that represents
changes made to a versioning repository
and
for iec uses change sets so you can see
what has changed by who over time so
when i say versioning repository that
doesn't necessarily mean git uh and if
you're using git ops i suppose you could
consider your change sets being
committed to that but something like
cloud formation when you apply a change
you actually have to accept a change set
uh and so the virgin repository is part
of aws and so
you know terraform you just kind of
accept it in place it's not necessarily
on your local machine but it gets
reflected in your state file okay so
change automation allows you to know
exactly what terraform will change and
in what order avoiding many possible
human errors a change automation is
essential to any iac tool they all have
it okay so there we go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at execution
plans so this is a manual review of what
will add change or destroy before you
apply changes and so let's say you type
in terraform apply it's not just going
to go ahead and do that it's going to
have you uh type in yes or accept the
value but what you can do is see the
resources or configuration settings that
will be added change or destroyed and it
will summarize them at the bottom and
then you'll have to type something like
yes in order to accept the changes okay
[Music]
something else i want to show you is
that you can actually visualize your
execution plans by using the terraform
graph command and terraform will output
a graphviz file you'll have to have
graphviz installed but graphis is an
open source tool for drawing graphs
specified in the dot language scripts
having the file name extension of gv
so i believe this is cross platform it's
open source but once it's installed in
your machine you can run terraform graph
and here this is linux so we're using a
pipe to say okay pass it over to graphis
which is dot
and that is going to then create an svg
file you can just open that in your
browser and the idea is you're going to
get this graph which kind of shows you
the relationship of the resources uh
here but we'll talk about the these
relationships in the next slide here
which is a resource graph okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at the resource
graph so terraform builds a dependency
graph from the terraform configurations
and walks this graph to generate plans
refresh state and more when you use
terraform graph this is a visual
representation or presentation of the
dependency graph if you're wondering
what a dependency graph is in
mathematics it's a directed graph
representing dependencies of several
objects towards each other so it's
pretty much like nodes
with relationships between other nodes
so that is one that i generated out from
terraform and so there's a few different
types here we have a resource node that
represents a single resource a resource
meta node represents a group of
resources but does not represent any
action on its own and provider
configuration node so represents the
time to fully configure a provider uh
will you need to know this for the exam
probably not do you need to know this in
great detail probably not because
there's a lot to the resource graph but
the idea here is just kind of like
terraform saying just so you know we're
using a graph database and graph
databases are very well suited for this
kind of stuff
and that's why terraform is very good at
figuring out conflicts uh and things
like that okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at terraform use
cases and the idea here is not
necessarily because it's going to show
up in the exam but the idea is to give
you a business use case or to highlight
the features as to why you'd want to be
using terraform and the first one here
is that it has exotic providers so
terraform supports a variety of
providers outside of gcp awesome azure
and sometimes is the only provider
terraform is open source and extendable
so any api can be used to create iec
tooling of any kind of cloud platform or
technology so you can make your own
provider there's some interesting ones
that they have like heroku or even
spotify playlists i have my own platform
called teacher seat and i want to have
iac um for my platform and so this is
what i'm going to be using terraform for
for multi-tier applications terraform by
default makes it easy to divide large
and complex applications into isolate
configuration script modules you'll
notice in this course that uh when you
have a bunch of terraform files they're
all treated as one
so that makes it really easy to split up
your uh your projects uh or your your
infrastructure so it has a complexity
advantage over cloud native ise tools
for its flexibility while retaining
simplicity over imperative tools then we
have disposable environments this is not
unique to terraform it's any kind of ise
tool but easily stand up an environment
for a software demo or a temporary
developer environment resource
schedulers so terraform is not just
defined to infrastructure of cloud
resources but can be used to
set dynamic schedules for docker
containers hadoop spark and other
software tools you can provision your
own scheduling grid on the last one here
is multi-cloud deployment terraform is
cloud agnostic and allows a single
configuration to be used to manage
multiple riders and to even handle
cross-cloud dependencies and that is a
big deal uh and is a very unique
offering to terraform okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at terraform core
and terraform plug-ins so terraform is
logically split into two main parts
terraform core which uses remote
procedure calls rpc to communicate with
terraform plugins and terraform plug-ins
so expose an implementation for a
specific service or provisioner uh
something that's interesting to know is
just terraform core is written in go um
you know you probably won't ever
encounter it but it's just a fact okay
and so here's the graphic that terraform
uses to kind of like explain uh
terraform core uh versus terraform
plug-ins and how they all relate um so
here's the terraform core and here are
the plugins notice we have uh providers
here which will cover provisioners uh
and they're just this is the group for
plugins overall um but yeah that's about
it um will it show up in the exam
probably not but it's good to understand
from a top level view the split between
these two things okay
[Music]
if you are new to terraform i just
wanted you to be aware of an additional
resource that you can use beyond this
course which is called terraform up and
running so it's a a book
and it has a deep dive into the internal
workings of terraform and this is really
great if you want to go beyond this
course beyond certification beyond the
basics because what we'll do is teach
you about testing with terraform cloud
zero downtime deployment common
terraform gotchas and compositions of
production grade terraform code there's
a lot more to it and this book in
particular is written by jim who's the
co-founder of grunt work and we do have
a whole section just on grunt work um
and the thing is i just wanted you to
know about this resource
you definitely don't need it to pass a
certification or to have
a good understanding or working of
terraform but you know at some point if
you want more i just want to point you
to that resource okay
[Music]
there's one other resource i want you to
check out for terraform this one is free
and just online and it's the terraform
best practices so it's an open book it's
a get book uh so it's essentially a wiki
and it basically covers the best
practices that are being used in the
industry and so this is stuff that is
separate from the terraform
documentation it's just good practices
you know if you're going to be using
terraform professionally within the
industry so i just wanted to make you
aware of this resource and to go check
it out okay
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
it's time to begin our follow along for
terraform and the first thing we need to
do is actually install terraform so what
i've done uh and this is in the
terraform associate folder this will all
be hosted on github so you can access it
later but what we're going to have to do
is make our way over to the hashicorp
learn website to get to the tutorials
terraform install cli because that's the
first thing we're going to need and then
once we make our way there we're going
to need to choose our installation
method so we have manual install
homebrew
os 10
chocolation on windows or linux so it's
just going to vary based on your
installation i'm not going to walk
through them all but i'm going to
definitely do the one that is for me so
i'm on windows 10. it's very common to
use the windows
subsystem of linux and so the way i
would go ahead and install this i would
open up my terminal and vs code and by
the way i recommend you probably follow
with vs code through all these tutorials
just because vs code has a very good
extension for
terraform okay but once we are there
what we can do is make our way over here
and because linux the linux variant i'm
using is ubuntu um i can go ahead here
and just go and start going through this
process so we would grab the first url
here and again it's going to vary based
on how you want to install
um so we'll go there and i already have
it installed so i'm just installing it
again
all right after short wait that line
finished there so we'll just proceed to
the next so we'll grab the gpg key
that's just going to verify that
we are grabbing from who we say we're
grabbing our code from so that takes two
seconds we'll go ahead and this will go
and uh add that repository so that we
can install from there
i believe this takes a second just as
well
okay that took a little bit more extra
time there but no big deal
and so now we are ready to actually
install the cli so we can now do our
sudo apt-get install terraform so just
copy and we'll go ahead and paste that
in there
after a short little wait there the
installation is finished and so what i
would just suggest is type in terraform
to make sure the command works and then
just type in terraform hyphen version
and just see what version you are using
as of this tutorial i'm using version
1.07 there's one other thing i want to
get set up for installation here and
that's going to be going over to the
extensions in vs code and making sure
that this
extension is installed because it's
going to give us
a bunch of options here i don't know
what they all are but i definitely know
that it's going to start format and do a
bunch of nice things for us okay so once
you have those two things installed our
installation step is over and what we
can do is begin on the getting started
section here okay
[Music]
all right so now that we have terraform
installed we're ready to uh go through
our first basic terraform tutorial and
the idea is to try to touch a bit of
everything going through
a very basic workflow um and the reason
i want to do this early on with you it's
not important for you to know what all
these things do and remember them
because we're going to cover them
multiple times throughout this course
but just to give you kind of an
end-to-end experience so you have a
point of reference
because it's really hard to learn
terraform because you have to kind of go
back a lot to uh remember information
okay so
we'll just start at the top here and
what i want to do is enter my getting
started folder i'm going to make a new
file called main.tf um the way terraform
works is you can name them files
whatever you want but generally the
standard practices use main tf when you
just have a single file or the entry
point file but i'm pretty sure the
terraform will read anything that starts
with tf and treat all the files as one
single file okay so once we have our
main tf we're going to need to add
ourselves a provider so what i'll do is
make my way over to my browser here and
i want to go to the terraform registry
so just type in terraform registry
and
what we'll do here is go and look at
providers and since we're going to start
with aws we'll click that in the top
left corner we have this use provider
and we can just go ahead and grab this
code okay
and so we'll go ahead and paste that in
and so now what you'll see here is we
have this terraform block that is our
terraform settings configuration we need
to have a provider at least a single one
and so we're using aws here
notice that the source is hashicorp aws
because this provider
is provided by hashicorp not abs
themselves but it is an official one so
it is in pretty good shape okay
uh notice the version is 03.580
um
i don't know much about the versions in
terms of how they matter um but i would
just say you probably want to stay up to
date to the latest okay
uh so down below we have provider aws
and this is where we're going to
configure our additional options so this
is where we would do like our aws
credentials but before we do that let's
go uh find whatever could we need to
provision ourselves a virtual machine
because that would probably be the
easiest thing that we could do so what i
want you to do is go back to the
terraform registry and we'll click on
the documentation because this is where
we're going to find all our information
for anything we want to provision okay
so if we want to provision ec2 instance
which is a virtual machine aws we'll
expand that uh there and i know that
it's called aws instance so i'm just
going to scroll on down here
and click on itabus instance
and right away we have ourselves a
a very easy example
i'm just going to scroll down here and
just see what else we have
so this all looks okay but you know what
i think that i'd rather go grab one from
the terraform
um tutorial here because i believe that
they have a much nicer one here for aws
so i'm just going to scroll on down here
yeah this one's a lot simpler so what
we'll do so just grab this code here
and we'll make our way back
okay and i think it's probably good to
set our region so i'm going to do us
east one
because that's where i like to deploy
things
uh and for profile we can set it as
default that's totally fine for now
and so notice here we have a bus
instance that's going to be the type of
resource we want to provision which is
an ec2 instance and then we're going to
name it whatever you want app server my
server i'm going to name it something
else here
tt micro is pretty standard this would
be the name so i'm just say my server
okay and then we need to get our ami i'm
just going to clear that out
so that's pretty much all it takes to
set up a resource for aws but we're
going to have to go get the ami instance
and we're also going to need to go get
our credentials so let's go do that next
all right so what i've done here is i've
logged into my aws account you are going
to have to create your own abyss account
and if you're looking for how to do that
just go to the readme here and just go
to aws and just go and create an account
it doesn't take that long to do
you will need a credit card that's just
like with any cloud service provider you
have to have a credit card to activate
the account doesn't necessarily mean
they're going to charge you anything but
you know there's the possibility in the
future that if you do use resources it's
possible to
uh
have it spend okay so what i want to do
is make my way over to
iam
and
i'm going to go to users
oops over here and i have a user here
but what i'm going to do is go ahead and
delete this user just because this is an
old one for me
i'm just going to start the process over
and create a new one now this is
considered a machine user because i'm
never going to use this user to log into
aws i'm only going to use it to generate
out pragmatic keys so i'm typing my name
in here andrew brown
uh and if you wanted to you could really
just type in terraform as well actually
that's what i'm going to do i only want
to give it pragmatic access so i
generated an access id and secret
um
i'm going to give it admin access so
what i've done here is i've created an
admin rule but let's just make a new
group we're going to call terraform
and we're going to give admin access
this gives you 100 access to all of aws
uh if you are uncomfortable that you can
try power user
but um
it used to be called power user anyway
if we can't find it that way we can drop
it down here and say um it must manage
policies
and there should be or there should be
like role based ones here ah job
functions there it is
and so
you know if admin access is too much you
can do power user and that usually
prevents people from creating users and
groups uh so that might be more uh or
or
less of a problem but i just want
everything to work for this tutorial so
i'm gonna do what everybody does and
we're gonna give admin access okay
and so now we have that new group um it
says no policies are attached not sure
why maybe i forgot to
attach them so i'll just go back in here
oh no it's there okay
not sure why i didn't say it was there
but we'll go back and i'll just check
box on terraform i guess it needed a
refresher
i will just hit next next create user
and so now i have an access id in secret
so this is going to vanish after i leave
this page so i want to leave it open and
what i'll do is go down below here i'm
going to open up my um aws credentials
so i'm not sure how to open this in uh
vs code so i'm just going to type in buy
or vim and i'm going to go to
tilde that's your home directory forward
slash dot aws and this is going to be in
credentials
okay and so here i can add that so we
want to have a default profile so i'll
make square braces type in default um
and then i need to put in these keys
so i don't remember i mean should be
just like aws
you know key something but i always
forget what it is so what we'll do is
just look it up say it was credentials
and it should just tell us here there
they are so this is generally what we're
looking for
so i'll just copy that
and i'm going to go ahead
and paste that in there
and i'll just clear out these keys
because these are not my real keys
i also like setting the region here so
i'm just going to set it to us east one
that is the uh the default region for
aws and has the most stuff well
technically your default region is going
to be whatever's near you but that's
where all new services are launched so
we're not going to run into any problems
if we use usc 1
and i'll go ahead and grab my key
okay
and we will go ahead and
paste that in
and i will go ahead and grab
this secret
okay and we'll paste that in
and i'm just going to double check if
that ends actually with a tilde i don't
think it does i think i introduced that
by accident so i'll just delete that out
and just double check because once you
leave this page you're not going to see
it again so a k
i e p m
k one that is for me and of course don't
ever show these to anybody um for me i
will i will be uh regenerating these so
uh by the time this is published you
won't have these and you can't
compromise my sandbox account which
wouldn't be a big deal anyway so i'm
just going to go ahead and save this
file
and
probably be smart to have the aws cli
installed so if you're wondering about
that
able cli
i already have it installed on this
machine but let's go take a look
um and see how it gets installed
oh this looks like something new
developer preview it with shell that
looks cool about cli install oh it's
over here so download unzip and then run
the linux installer so if we wanted to
do for linux
i'd go in here
and i would just go ahead and start
grabbing this stuff so
we'll just go and curl that file
it's probably a good idea to install the
cli here
after a short wait that finished there
so we'll go grab the next line here
which is to unzip it
all right so after waiting a little
while there it finally unzipped and so
we can go ahead and run the last command
which is pseudo
period aws
install
and so that shouldn't take too long
okay and so here it's just saying found
preexisting cli because i already have
it please rerun install script with the
update flag so you would not have to do
this but i'm going to do this because
you know i'm just trying to get it up to
date so that i'm on the latest while
doing this tutorial with you
i'll just give it a second to see if it
executes there
i think we'll just wait
okay great so now it is using the latest
so if i just type in a bus version
i have uh 2.2.38
what i will also do is just go ahead and
delete this uh zip here
that it placed in my directory and also
this aws directory just to make sure
that it's working if i delete it
just assuming that it didn't
install it in this directory here and
it's i mean it does say it's in user
local bin
but just as a sanity check there okay
so we'll type in version again
okay great and so now what we'll do is
just type in aws s3 list just to see if
there's anything there
um
so it has an issue let's just type in
adris i think it's ada's credentials to
authenticate
i haven't done it in a while so let's
just take a look at what we can do to
check that out
because we did set up the credentials
file but sometimes
sometimes you might have to
run a command here
so i'm just going to find that okay i'll
be back in a second
all right so i didn't have to look far i
just went to configuring to
configuration basis it's aws configure
not credentials
i'm not configuring new cli's all the
time here so what we'll do is just type
in database configure
and so here it has that key i still have
my uh my im open here so
i e so that is correct
and then that is forward slash y
h that looks correct
default region is uscs
um default output you know json sounds
good to me
so
uh you know if i do it
list that should work
because the signature you provided does
not match check your signing method so
just give me a second figure that out
okay
all right so i just tried another
command that i know that should just
work and it's just saying that they're
not valid at access credentials so if
it's having problems with those
then that generally means that we need
to go and
fix our credentials so maybe there's
like a hidden character we pasted by
accident or something you might not be
having this problem but i'm just going
to go ahead and double check so what
i'll do is go back over here and i'm
going to go back to my users or i am
and we will go to users
and we will go into terraform here
and we will go to our security
credentials
i'm going to delete those ones
you have to deactivate them first and
then i'm going to delete it
and we'll create new ones
we'll give this another go
it really likes to put that tilde in
there
and that uh doesn't end with a one
so you're saying i'm getting like weird
characters as i do this but just double
check to make sure they are correct
ak the start
eu on the end okay this is default that
looks correct to me the region looks
fine to me
so we'll go ahead and quit this and we
will try this again
great and so it works and i do have a
few uh s3 buckets there uh prior in the
sandbox here so
you might not might not get anything but
as long as you're not getting the error
that's saying does not match signature
or validation doesn't work so now that's
all set up
if we go back to main tf that means that
this here is going to use the default
profile so
that's going to make it easy so the last
thing we need to do to set up this
virtual machine is provided an ami and
the reason why is that an ami is a
required field so what i want to do is
just go back over to the documentation
here and if you scroll on down to
attribute references you can see
uh what is required so
um
well ami should be required i guess the
only thing that's required is the
instance type here maybe
uh am i in it
yeah i am
so
i might have went too far down here
oh instant type is optional
huh
off they're both optional okay maybe
it's just like one or the other
but i think that if we didn't have the
ami there we probably run into an issue
so let's go ahead and make our way over
to
ec2
and we're going to go ahead and grab
ourselves that ami id so we'll go and
make sure we're in north virginia which
is usc 1 we'll go ahead and launch a new
instance and i want the amazon linux 2
so i'm going to go ahead and grab this x
68 ami ami id
and it's really important that you watch
which region you're in because different
regions these ids are going to be
different okay
so again go ahead there and save that
and so technically we should be ready to
be able to do a plan and apply to
provision this but before we do that
there's a couple things that we should
do which is to try out doing format and
validate okay
[Music]
before we do format and validate what i
want to do is actually initialize this
project so go up and create yourselves a
new terminal if it's closed or not so i
actually have two open here so i'll just
close the other one
and i'm just going to type in clear here
and what i want to do is type in
terraform init
and before i do that i just want to show
you that right now there's only main tf
in here and so if i hit enter
it's going to say terraform initialize
an empty directory
oh you know what i did it in the
terraform associate by accident
so we're going to go into
getting started here and typing clear
and type in terraform and it again
and so what it's going to do it's going
to pull
whatever providers and modules are
defined so all we have is a aws provider
so that is what it's pulling right now
so i'll just give that a bit of time to
do that okay
all right so after a short little wait
there you'll notice that we have this
dot terraform directory and we also have
this terraform
lock hcl so this is a dependency lock
file it's going to tell us
uh what version of modules or providers
that we are using
um so because in the main tf you know we
have 3.580 so that's going to match
exactly that but if we said something
like
greater than or equals to this could be
a different version right so whatever
version is set here it's going to make
sure that it stays with that version as
long as we're not changing it okay
so there's that if we open up the
terraform file this has information
about our provider so the provider is
actually downloaded here and this is a
binary file so there's not there's not
anything to look at when we open it up
okay
so now that init is done what i want to
do is go ahead and show you format and
validate okay
all right let's take a look here at
format and validate so format is just a
way of making the files
syntax consistent and this is going to
really help you
reduce arguments within your team
because there's only gonna be one way to
write a terraform file and if you don't
write it the the way to the standard
format is going to correct it or
complain about it okay so one thing we
can do is change the indentation level
here uh and what i'll do is run and run
terraform format
and notice that it fixed the indentation
so that's all there really is to it it's
just dealing with the uh styling of the
actual file
um i'm not sure if it would do anything
for double lines let's see if that would
take it out i'm not sure
it doesn't so you know it's pretty much
just indentation and a few other things
besides indentation i don't know what
else it would do
then you have terraform validate and
this is really useful to make sure that
you have particular fields required so
i'm going to go ahead and comment these
out i'm going to type in terraform
validate
and it's going to tell me if my file is
valid
and it's saying here missing required so
it wants an aws instance to have a
instance type or launch template right
so remember it said it was optional but
one or the other is required so if we
add this back in
okay and type in validate we'll see if
it works
and now it's saying if you specify an
instance type you have to also have an
ami so we'll take that out there
and type in validate
okay
another thing i want to show you is
let's imagine that we just specified an
ami that doesn't exist something like uh
this doesn't exist
i just want to show you what validate
will do and what it will not do
so we type in terraform validate
that says it's valid because it's
checking you know do you have the
required attributes
and is it the right type so this is a
string
but it doesn't know the contents of that
string whether this is actually a valid
one and doesn't match up to usc's one
so just consider that validate doesn't
take care of everything for you okay
so yeah that's all there is to
format and validate and so we'll move on
to actually setting up a plan okay
[Music]
all right so now what i want you to do
is just give yourself a lot of room in
your terminal and type in terraform plan
and what this is going to do it's going
to generate a speculative plan of what
it would deploy
and so if we just scroll the top here
uh what you're going to notice here is
going to say this is what it's going to
create so see the green plus sign and
it's saying we're going to create a new
aws instance or resource here and this
is all the configurations that we're
adding to it and down below it's going
to say one added zero change zero
destroy
and so it's speculative in the sense
that it's not generating out a a plan
you can actually generate the plan to be
used by a terraform apply so notice it
says hyphen out option to save this plan
so
you know we don't need to generally save
out our plans but that is an option if
we want to do that for some pragmatic
use
but now that plan has been
shown here and we're happy with it what
we can do is go ahead and type in terror
from apply and it's going to do the
exact same thing it's going to show us a
speculative plan
um
exactly the same thing so it's running
basically terraform plan and then we're
going to review it and if we're happy
with it we're going to write the word
yes okay and so what that's going to do
it's going to go ahead and start
creating uh some uh some adress
infrastructure there and in particular
it's just a single ableist instance so
if we make our way over to aws and we go
to ec2
okay i can just close these other tabs
here
uh you'll notice that we have the server
and it's starting to spin up but if
you're familiar with aws you're probably
also familiar with cloud formation
cloudformation is what uh aws uses for
infrastructure as code it's their
native tooling for it i just want to
show you that there are no stacks like
these are for aurora serverless i just
couldn't delete them out but notice that
there is no underlying stack the
terraform is setting up so terraform is
responsible for managing the state and
uh it's not using cloud formation
underneath just so you're aware if we
make our way back here it says that it
is uh completed provisioning okay and so
what we'll do is make our way over here
and give it a refresh and notice that uh
even though it says that it's
complete it technically isn't because
the status checks aren't done
so
if you use cloud formation it would not
be considered done until we had a status
check one and two um i'm sure there's
some way to
check that with terraform to consider it
actually complete i'm not really sure at
this point in time how to do that but
i'm just pointing that out okay so we'll
just wait here for this to complete to
move on to the next step okay
[Music]
all right so after a long wait there our
two statistics are complete so what i
want to show you is how we would go and
update that infrastructure okay because
uh you know in the course we say that um
infrastructure code is
independent meaning that if you
define something
you know like a resource and you run
this again it's not going to create an
additional resource it's just going to
only have what you define which is you
expect there to be this single resource
here so what i'm going to do is just
change the c2 micro to a t2 nano
and then we'll go down below and type in
terraform apply
and we're just waiting for it to refresh
the state
and by the way any time you run
terraform plan or terraform apply it
actually runs validate every single time
so you don't have to run terraform
validate you can just do it as part of
your terraform plan or if you're doing
tearful reply you'll it'll be it'll also
run there as well okay so notice this
time we get this little uh tilde
squiggly here and it's showing what it's
going to change and so this is doing an
update in place or um yep and so that
means that
yeah update in place and so that means
that it's not going to destroy and
recreate that instance it's just going
to keep it in place and modify it so
we'll go ahead and type in yes
and we'll let that perform there and so
if we just make our way back over here
it should show us that we have a t2
micro and so if i refresh here
and we take a look here shouldn't take
too long
and it is stopping the instance okay but
it's not destroying it okay
all right so after a short little wait
there it's now a t2 nano coming back
over here you can see that it's still a
lapsing time it's checking to make sure
that it's possible probably because it's
in the initializing state
and uh yeah there we go so now it is
complete but you know like just because
it says update in place doesn't mean
that your instance or your service is
not going to be interrupted uh so that's
another consideration uh that updating
place does not mean that there's no
interruption of service okay
um yep
[Music]
all right so um we were able to change
the parameter of t2 nano but let's
imagine that we wanted to make that a
little bit more configurable so that we
could provide a instance type uh
pragmatically via a variable uh so so
we'll do next so what i want you to do
is make your way back over here to your
main.tf
and what we're going to do is define
ourselves a new variable
uh so it's like variable t2
oops sorry instance type
and just to look it up in the
documentation we'll just type in
variable terraform
i'm just trying to show you where you
can find this stuff very easily so if we
scroll on down notice here that we need
to define a type so this is just going
to be a string so we'll go ahead and
grab that
okay
and we can just make that a type string
and then when we want to reference this
what we do is just type in var
and then the name of the variable name
which is instance type
and so instead of setting it um you know
through here what we can do is we can
create like a tfrs files
or we can provide it as a a flag so what
i'll do first i'll just do a plan to
just show you how we can do it a few
different ways but i'm going to type in
var and i'm going to put the name of the
the variable so it's like instance type
equals
and i think i do double quotations here
t2 micro
and we'll see what we get as a plan here
okay so notice that it's using the t2
micro i could do this at like with a
medium as well here
okay so
that's just one way of changing it
another thing we can do is create
ourselves a terraform.tf vars file that
allows us to set a bunch of variables so
i'm going to go ahead and do that
so what we'll do is just create a new
file here until type in terraform dot tf
vars
and we'll say instance type
equals t2
large again i'm not going to execute
this i just want to show you
in the plan that's going to show up
okay and see that says a t2 large so i'm
going to go back here and just change
this to
a t2
t2 micro because that's what's on the
free tier for aws tt nano even though
it's smaller and more inexpensive it's
not
so if you are in the free tier i want to
keep you in that so you save any money
or have no spend uh notice over here on
the left hand side that we have this tf
state file this has been generated out
and notice that it's version four
because every time we've ran this it has
a new iteration okay
and this is basically defining the
current state of our
infrastructure so if you go through here
notice that it says type aws instance my
server what provider it's using what its
schema version is the ami here the
reference to the ami and all the
properties and these are all the
properties we basically saw here
uh like if we scroll up notice all these
things here they're pretty much all
defined in here exactly how it's going
to be defined
you aren't ever supposed to
manually modify this file
but it is something visible you can look
at and when we do deploy it is going to
show us the a backup here
so if we
if we ever happen to lose our tf state
file or we want to go uh
we can always grab that backup file okay
um but uh yeah so what i want to do here
is now that i have that tfr is in place
i'm just going to go ahead and actually
run apply and
actually i'm going to run plan first
sorry
so let's see this is t2 micro
okay it says t2 micro and what we can do
is just do terraform apply and this time
we're just going to do hyphen auto
approve you probably really want to do
this but if you just want to skip that
yes process you're like you know it's
going to be fine you can use the auto
approved flag to do that okay
so serious is the tt micro
and it's just starting to modify it okay
so uh now that we've done that i guess
we'll take a look at locals here but
we'll just let this finish updating and
then we'll move on to that okay
[Music]
all right so now let's take a look at
local values which seems very similar
locals which seems very similar to
variables but it's slightly different so
what i'm going to do actually it's right
here in the documentation so we'll go
down to local values
and this is kind of a way to dry up your
code and so if i just go grab this block
here
it's different from variables because
you know they generally are hard coded
but i go to here and say locals and then
if i had like a generic name i could say
name
and i could just say
you know andrew or
yeah andrew is fine
just say project name
and so if i wanted to use that somewhere
else if it says my server i could uh use
enter string interpolation
i believe it's this
yep
and if we have locals it's just going to
be local dot project underscore name
okay and so now if i just do a terraform
plan
oops
i have to type it right in
uh whoops let's do uh terraform validate
i think i'm using the syntax incorrectly
local is not a valid template control
keyword
um it should be because if we go back
over here
yeah see how it's referencing is local
and that's exactly what i'm doing it's
just that i'm using interpolation and i
might be using it incorrectly so what
we'll do is make our way over to
template strings terraform
and if we go down here
we have interpolation so i want the one
that is for
literals oh yeah this is for directives
and so we want interpolation so it's a
dollar sign just to show you like i've
done this whole course i've passed the
exam
i've used terraform and i i can't
remember so it's not a big deal if you
have to look things up okay so type in
tariff or validate here to see if that
is correct
good and so if we do terraform plan
okay
now you'll see that our tag would change
over to that so that's basically what
locals are it's just like a way of
having some
local variables that are in line with
your code okay
[Music]
let's take a look at outputs so i'm
going to go back to terraform here and i
think it's actually right here but yeah
variables and outputs and we'll go
output values and this is just a way to
get an outputted value and this is
actually a really good example where we
might want the private id or the public
id so we'll scroll on down below here
and this has its own section so we'll
paste that there and this is private id
and that is fine but i might want to get
something a little bit more fun
so we'll go here and just kind of see
what we can get
so we saw private id ip
um
argument reference right so we have
private id maybe we want public id here
public id
ip oops
yeah so let's give that a go instead i
think i'd prefer to get the public ip
because this is it is a public-facing
server
okay
and notice that this is not the name
right name we're gonna have to call this
my server right
and so outputs is gonna allow us to uh
see those values so what we'll do
uh i'm gonna run terraform plan and see
if there is any required change
i'm not sure if we have to deploy to get
that output working so we'll just run
here from plan first
and notice it says changes to outputs
and then it adds this as a plus so if i
was to type in terraform
outputs
there is commands for this
i don't seem to remember off the top of
my head so we'll just look at it up here
really quickly output
uh here it is
so
oh it's terraform output okay sorry it's
not the plural so we'll go here
and type in terraform output i just want
to see if it'll actually output it
without us doing it so it says warning
no outputs found so what we'll have to
do so the state file either has no
outputs defined or all the defined
outputs are empty please define and open
your configuration with output
or run terraform refresh to become
available so we don't need to run
terraform apply i don't think we
probably just run terraform refresh so
let's give that a go and see what
happens whoops
might be a good example of
using terraform refresh terraform
refresh is a command that is going to
make the state file match whatever the
the remote instance is so we already
have an instance up there and so that's
what it did it's probably a better
example to use output so now if we type
in terraform output
we should be able to get that value
there
only if you type it right though
okay so there it is and if we really
want it to be in particular we could say
instance
ip address
i really don't like the name of that i
might just change this here so we'll
just say um
public ip
okay i'm not sure if we can just change
on the fly there let's see what happens
if we do that
yeah see it's still the old one so in
that case i'll just type in terraform
refresh and see what happens
okay and notice the old one is still
there so
i think in that case we'd have to do
because this doesn't exist in our output
files anymore so i think it because
refresh just adds i don't think it's
going to remove anything
uh well actually it would if the server
was gone it would do that so but anyway
if we type in terraform outputs we get
do we get both of them
we do and so in that case i think we
would want to do a terraform plan
and see if there's any differences here
yeah notice it's going to remove it
there and so then that's how we'd have
to get rid of it so we just say
terraform apply
and we'll just say yes
and that's our opportunity to update our
tags and also get rid of this output
so you can see refresh doesn't work in
all cases
and so now if we type in terraform
output
you should get a list there
i just want to say like public id just
to get the exact one there
uh ip
okay cool so that that works great so
that's outputs
[Music]
so we've seen providers let's go take a
look at modules so what i want you to do
is go back to the internet here
and i want to
go back to the terraform registry
in this case i want to go grab some
modules so providers
uh you know providers are basically
one-to-one mappings
to the underlining api so like anything
in cloud formation is pretty much mapped
up here and modules are
basically um they're like conveniences
because they allow you to
configure a bunch of resources using a
more uh short form dsl okay so like if
we open up here the vpc this is a very
easy way for us to define an entire vpc
without having to create like each of
these resources individually so we had
to do this by hand to be a lot of work
so we'll do is go ahead and copy this
and we're just going to expand this a
little bit here
that's a bit hard because my fonts are
really large but you know of course
you'd probably be using a smaller font
and so what i want you to notice that it
starts with a module block and we're
providing it a source so terraform aws
modules vpc aws
and that's how it knows to map over to
this one over here on the terraform
registry
and this is just defining a new vpc as
long as we don't have any conflicts with
this block it should deploy no problem
so i'm going to go ahead and give that a
go so we'll just type in terraform apply
or plan
and actually before we even do a
terraform planner apply notice that the
module isn't installed so this is where
we'd have to type our terraform in it
and that's going to go ahead and grab
that module
great and so once we have that we can
now do our terraform plan
and we'll give it a moment here
and notice that it's going to generate a
lot of stuff out that's fine so we will
say terraform apply i just want to auto
approve that
save myself some
trouble that's going to go set us us up
a um a module i want to point out that
actually uh when you're writing files
out here and we're going to find this
later in the course that even
even when you write a single file like
main tf you are creating yourself a
terraform module because everything is
based off of modules
so you'll see that later on in the
course but we'll just wait here until
this is uh finished here okay
so after a short little wait there i
actually ran into an issue um here so i
probably
i was a bit too
too quick to just copy this over because
it is having some issues i think it's
because our provider is in us east one
and we're trying to specify something in
u.s west so that's probably our problem
so or this is actually europe which is
no surprise because anton who made this
is actually over in europe so it makes
sense that he might set it to that so
i'm going to do u.s east uh here
right and so that's something that you
have to understand that if you have a
provider it's going to be mapped to that
one actually if we wanted to keep it in
uh er eu
west this is a great opportunity to kind
of show you how to make another provider
as a reference so i'm just going to go
here and paste this in and we'll change
this to eu west
was it one or two
it's one
and so in here what we can do is set
ourselves up an alias
okay
and we could just say like
this is called uh you
uh
we'll just say this this is eu
or a to you
and i actually might not remember how to
do this exactly so i'm going to just
type in
terraform
resource alias because that's what this
is called
it's a meta argument
google europe
okay so i just wanted to know if i had
to type in google or something like that
in front of it so if we make our way
back over here
and we go back to the top here we don't
need to put the word adabas that's just
redundant so we'll just say eu
and if we go down to our
vpc here and type in provider
we'll say
aws eu
okay and so that should allow us to have
both i'm not sure if we have to run
terraforming it so we'll run tear from
plan first
it might say hey you got to run
terraform in it maybe
an argument provider is not expected
here let's just make our way back over
here oh because that's the within the
resource and i put it in the module
block so we'll just
cut that out here
and
it doesn't uh
doesn't have that so actually i wonder
how you'd set a provider for module
maybe you don't i'll be back here in a
second okay
all right so i just pulled up the
documentation here and here's a module
and it has this little provider's block
so let's give that a go and see if that
fixes their problem here
so i'll just paste this in providers aws
and we'll say eu
okay and see if that works
you know again it's not hard like if you
get stuck you pretty much google
anything
and so that did not error out and so if
i was to do a terraform apply auto
approve
that should work
and so i'll see you back here in a bit
okay
all right so i have one little uh error
here i actually typed in uh eu as uh
instead of us there and so again my
point is is that terraform validates not
going to catch these things you're only
going to find these uh when you actually
run them so we'll run this one more time
and i think it's going to work and i'll
see you back here
when this module is finished deploying
okay
all right so after waiting there it
looks like our vpc is ready so if we
make our way over to aws go to vpcs
of course this is in the european region
there so what we'll have to do is just
switch over there in a moment but i just
want to show you that it's not here
but if we go over
and find eu west
one which is apparently ireland
uh there it is so there's my vpc the one
we created there okay
so yeah
what we'll do next is we'll just kind of
break up these files and make things a
little bit easier to work with okay
[Music]
all right so let's make it a little bit
easier to work with our terraform file
here and what's really nice is that you
know we have this main tf but anything
that's named.tf is going to be treated
as a single file and so it's pretty
common to break these up into individual
files here so what i'm going to do is
call this one
providers dot tf
and i found out that you can only have
one terraform block and one required
provider block so if you're thinking
about making like uh one for each
provider and then the resources within
it that's just not possible
so we'll name that there
um
and i guess we'll bring these over as
well
probably a good idea to do that
okay and we have a variable pretty
common to make a variables.tf
so we'll say
[Music]
variables.tf here
and we'll grab our single
one there
okay and uh
so if we wanted to oh yeah probably in
outputs would be good too so we'll say a
new file here we'll say outputs.tf
and i think when we get to
module development i'm pretty sure this
is like the standard if i just it's in
my slides here we'll say like
uh
modules
if i go over to that there for a second
yeah it's in this section here
but yeah when we get over to this yeah
it's pretty common to have an outputs a
variables a main okay
and so we'll put our output there
you know the rest is up to you so we can
leave this in maine or we could try and
take this and put this into
one called aws resources
maybe that's what i'll do i'll just
rename this to aws
okay
and maybe we'll just keep a main around
and i'm not sure if
locals is i mean it treats it as one
file so it must work that way but i'm
just go ahead and paste that in there
i was thinking maybe it's like bound to
the file but it's probably just bound to
the module
and so i just want to make sure that
this all works i'm going to do terraform
plan here
and see what happens here i'm just
seeing if there's gonna be any kind of
errors
or just in general what are we gonna see
uh no changes so it read all the files
no problem so this is all good to go but
yeah you can break it up however you
like it's it's that easy okay
[Music]
okay so so far uh you know we said all
this infrastructure but what if we
wanted to go ahead and destroy it so
what we could do
is type in terraform
uh apply and i think it's destroy
i can't remember the flag off the top of
my head so let's go take a look here
just type in terraform apply
and go down to our flags
and it is called
should be in here destroy
oh it's not showing it i know that this
flag exists so we'll go over here i just
want to show you uh how that flag works
maybe it's like terraform destroy
probably better example here
well um
i know that there's a another flag that
we can write here it's like destroy
delete
well that's fine because you're not
really ever going to be doing it that
way you're always going to be writing
terraform destroy so that's what we're
going to do
you know what maybe it's under the plan
that i'm thinking of terraform plan
because maybe you make it in the plan
and then it gets moved along yeah
destroy mode here it is so i want you to
understand that um
you know that's how it would set it so
active destroy mode using hyphen destroy
so
i think when you use
plan or apply we could have done hyphen
destroy and that is equivalent to this
destroy command so i'll clear it out i'm
just going to try that there destroy
because i just want to show you that
that's an alias of destroy okay
or of apply
and yep so that would destroy all of our
resources
and so
i don't think it's really essential to
show you that but i just wanted to show
you how you'd run the terraform destroy
command and that would tear down all
your infrastructure
okay
but i want to keep it up because we're
going to move this infrastructure over
to terraform cloud and then we'll do a
destroy soon enough okay
[Music]
all right so now that we have
successfully created a resource
organized their files learned the basics
of
getting started up to you know this
point the next thing is to
create a terraform cloud workspace and
migrate our local backend to our remote
workspace and the reason we want to do
this is because we have this terraform
dot tf state file and this is what
contains
all of our information about the state
of our infrastructure and if we want to
collaborate with other people we need to
have it in shared space
and so terraform cloud is one of the
options and i would say the best option
out there and so i want to show you how
to use terraform cloud which by the way
is free um and so before we do that i
just want to show you uh uh what
workspace we're in so if you type in
terraform
workspace list what you're going to see
is a single workspace called default so
this is a special workspace which every
project comes with a default workspace
and you cannot delete it so here you
could create multiple workspaces like
development production to have different
variables for your infrastructure if
you're deploying to different um
uh different environments but for the
purpose of getting started we're just
going to work with the default but the
thing is right now these day files are
here locally and so what we need to do
is define a back end and so far uh the
back end that we're using is the local
back end and that would be defined we
had put it in our um providers probably
been smarter to just call this like
terraform this is the main you know this
is what i'm going to do i'm going to
take this here
cut this and i'm going to put this in
main because i think it makes more sense
over here
there's not like a true science to
putting things places you're just going
to have to feel them out so in this
terraform settings block this is where
we would specify our back end
okay and so right now we are using local
whether you specified or not you are
okay
and so we want to swap that out to
remote which will use terraform cloud so
what i will do
is we'll just say terraform local
migrate
uh because they have a nice tutorial
here for this
but i just want the code from it so this
is
pretty close to what we want
this is for multiple workspaces we're
just doing local
so this is what i want okay so what i'm
going to do whoops
is just bring this back on over
and i just want to copy this interior
part
and it doesn't matter if you put it
above or below providers but we'll have
a back end we're going to specify the
hostname we're going to need to set our
organization and we're going to need to
set our workspace name
so now what we're going to do
is make our way over to
terraform dot io
and what i want you to do is create
yourself a new account it does not
require
a credit card or anything it's very easy
to set up you just have to confirm your
email and then once you have done that
go ahead and sign in
and what you'll need to do is create
yourself an organization it'll probably
prompt you right away so it's very easy
just go here and give your organization
name and provide an email it's pretty
much those two options and once you have
your organization you can go ahead and
start creating workspaces and so i'm
going to create a new workspace here and
we're going to be presented with three
options version control workflow cli
driven workflow api driven workflow
version control workflow is let's say
every time we push to commit to our
repository then it would trigger
to do a terraform apply to execute the
code but we don't want to do that we
just want to use the cli which is what
we've been doing all along so here i'm
just going to say terraform
um
terraform example
well maybe i'll just say getting started
here actually getting started
and we will go ahead and create this
workspace
and now that we have the name of the
and the organization so we'll put those
in here so my workspace is called
getting started
and i just want to make sure i have the
right name for this
organization here
i think it just would be called whatever
it is so for mine it looks like it's
just called exam pro i think you'd match
it whatever's up here or okay
it doesn't work we'll find out in a
second though
so we will paste that in there
and so all we need to do to move from
our local to a remote is type in
terraform init
to migrate it over
and actually we probably need to log in
first so before we do that well i can't
stop it
that's fine
um so i'm just going to say no i don't
want to migrate just yet so i'm going to
type in terraform login first
because we want to authenticate with
terraform cloud
so i've already done this previously so
it already has a file saved over here
okay but what i'm going to do i'm just
going to delete mine you don't have to
do this i'm just going to delete mine so
you you can see a similar experience
okay so i do terraform login
and it's going to say if successful
terraform will store in plain text in
this area do you want to do this say yes
and all this is doing is generating out
an api token for a user so it's going
over here and
choose the description to help identify
the token later and this is just for
[Music]
pro
let's just say like terraform associate
maybe
because we're actually creating the
token
okay so your token
we can copy it out
um click on the token to copy and paste
it into your terraform login prompt to
continue so i'll hit copy
and we will go back to terraform here
and then we will paste in the value i
know you couldn't see it but i
definitely pasted it in and so it's now
been pasted in there
i'm going to go back here and hit done
and i'm going to go ahead and
delete my old tokens this is the one i
made a month ago so i'll go ahead and
delete that
and again you don't want to share these
tokens with anybody just make sure
um you know you keep those secret
because then they'll have access to your
terraform account
so now that we have that ready to go
it's actually kind of cool to have a
little getting started project here i
didn't even notice about it
but uh so now what we can do is type in
terraformingnet
because now that we have a local api key
and it's just going to say hey you have
a pre-existing state that was found
while migrating the previous local
backend to the newly configured remote
no existing state was found in the newly
configured remote backend do you want to
copy the state to the remote backend
before we do that i just want to go over
to our workspace and click into it just
to show you that we have nothing under
runs nothing under states nothing under
variables there's nothing in there okay
and so what i'm going to do here is just
type yes
and that's going to
take the terraform state file
and move it to your
workspace so it's finished that was
pretty quick so what i'm going to do is
go back over here
and we're going to just click on here
and
refresh
it looks like we also have the
instructions here which we could do so
if we go over to states here is our
state file so we open it up and it's all
the same contents of the terraform.tf
state so what we can do now
is go over here and we can go ahead
and delete this
normally you wouldn't want to delete
your backup but i just want to see if
when we run terraform apply if it'll
actually produce another backup backup
locally here
okay
and so
now that we have our infrastructure
there all we could all we need to do is
now run terraform apply so that's what
i'm going to do next
i'm going to go here
and type in tara from apply
and we'll see what it changes
like there's no infrastructure changes
so nothing should change but let's see
what happens the fact that we moved our
remote state over
okay so right away it say it says no
value for required variable so the thing
is we have it set in our tf bars over
here but the problem is is that the
workspace does not have it because
what's going to be running terraform is
actually
a run environment there's actually a
server that's part of terraform cloud
that executes your code
and so these variables are on a local
machine there's no way for them to get
up there so we have to go set them
under variables
we have two options here
so there's terraform variables so these
are settings used as the terraform.tfrs
to use a non-string variable
okay and then we have environment
variables so we have two different ways
to set it
the way i'm going to set it is a
terraform variable so we have a key and
a value
this is generally how you'd want to do
it so we have our instance type so we
will go and put the name in there and
this is going to be a t2 micro
okay and i'm just simply copying them
over notice over here we have a checkbox
for hcl so parse the field as the hcl
language that's if we wanted to do
something a bit more advanced mark it as
sensitive if we need to and that's not
something to do so this is going to be
the size and this is optional but i'm
just putting it the size of the ec2
instance
okay
and we'll go ahead and set that variable
great and so what we'll do is now try to
run this again
so now it's saying um
it's not saying no credential provider
so no val providers in the chain and so
we did specify
in our providers that we want to use our
profile default but the problem is is
that
this is not going to work for
this is not going to work for our
our workspace here because we actually
have to set it in here in the
environment variables
so what i'm going to do is just go look
up the terraform provider
oh sorry so we'll go to terraform
provider aws
i want to do this on the registry
and what we'll do is try to look for
authentication
um i'm just making sure that this is
what this says github so if you just
click back here in the top left corner
go to providers go to aws go to
documentation
usually in the beginning they'll have
like information in the guides that
explain like how to
configure it
and so that's what i'm just looking for
here
maybe just click on aws provider so yeah
here's the section on authentication so
he would say like access key access a
secret secret key but what we want to do
is set these environment variables
because that's the way we're going to
have to do with terraform cloud so we'll
do is go here and
specify this key here so we'll say
aws access key id and we're gonna have
to go get those credentials so i'm gonna
just type in by
aws credentials
and there's my key
so let's go ahead and copy that
again that's secret don't ever share it
with anybody and this is definitely
sensitive so we're going to mark that as
sensitive
and we'll save that
and the other one's going to be called
aws secret
access key
just making sure i spelt that right i'm
just looking off screen here to see if i
spelt it right
and we'll go ahead and copy that
paste that in just make sure there's no
uh trailing spaces we're going to say
that is also sensitive we also want the
region
so aws default region
and i'm going to set mine as us east one
that's not sensitive it's not a big deal
and so this should give us enough to be
able to execute that command now again
there is no new infrastructure to create
but just to get it to run is what we're
trying to do here i'm just going to
write and quit
and we will try terraform apply again
and now see if we get better luck this
time around okay
great so notice it says no changes your
infrastructure matches the configuration
so there hasn't been anything that has
changed so what i'm going to do is i'm
just going to do a terraform destroy
because i want to tear this all down and
then i want to maybe change uh the
variable within terraform cloud and
we'll do terraform apply just to make
sure that it does work with terraform
cloud and indeed we aren't losing our
old state file okay
so yeah again i just ran here from
destroy for real and i said yes so we're
just going to wait a while here until
all the infrastructure is destroyed and
i'll see you back here in a moment okay
all right so it took a little bit time
to actually just generate out the uh
delete plan so i'm just going to go
ahead and type yes
and that should proceed to destroy all
the resources we'll just give it a
moment here
there we go and so it's deleting
everything so i'll see you back here
when this is complete okay
all right so now that we destroyed our
infrastructure what i want to do is just
go ahead to our a to bus one here i just
want to comment out the module for the
time being just because we do not need
it uh there are three types of comments
in
terraform i believe we have this one so
we have
this is the like javascript multi-line
one
but you could also be doing this or this
it's up to you
and so what we'll do now is do a
terraform apply
and we'll notice that it's just going to
provision that ec2 instance
so i'm just waiting for it to show me
the option yes there we go so we'll type
in yes
and i'm going to go back to terraform
cloud
wherever i put it so i might have to go
back to terraform.io here i might have
closed it on my own
okay so here you can see that it's
applying right now we can even see it as
it's running so it did the plan over
here and now it's doing the apply
i could even cancel it from here if i
really wanted to
i just want to show you that you have
your previous states here so every time
you do a deploy it's going to store a
state file so it's technically versioned
notice that
if we open up our backups there's no
longer a terraform backup file
i suppose there's really no need for one
because if we have all these states
in here these are technically our
backups
so in the slides i might contradict that
and say that the file remains but
apparently it does not okay
and i'll see you here when this is done
okay
all right so after a short little wait
there it says it's complete
again we'll just go over here to our
overview we'll see that it has been
applied we can see the resources under
here and so this is our aws resource we
can even see our outputs as well and
that's pretty much all i wanted to cover
in the getting started so now it's all
just about clean up so what i want you
to do
is go back here and we're going to go
type in terraform destroy to tear down
all this infrastructure which is a
single server right now
and actually i'm just going to oops i'm
trying to stop it here i want to do i
think we can do auto proof here auto
approve
and actually if we wanted to do it the
other way we do destroy
auto approve
and i'll see you back here in a moment
when this infrastructure has been
destroyed okay
[Music]
all right so this is finished destroying
our infrastructure so now what i'm going
to do
is just go back to my workspace here and
i just want to go ahead and delete it so
we'll go down below and we'll delete
this terraform cloud workspace so i will
type in
uh the name of it so this would be
getting started
like you can keep it around it's not a
big deal also notice that it allowed
destroy plan so when enabled the setting
allows the destroy plan okay so that's
just a way of disabling it um so we'll
say getting started
great and so now that workspace is gone
and so we are done are you first getting
started we can get back to the main
course
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at terraform
provisioners so provisioners install
software edit files and provision
machines created with terraform and
terraform allows you to work with two
different provisioners we have cloud in
it and packer so cloud init is an
industry standard for cross-platform
cloud instance initialization when you
launch a vm on a cloud service provider
you'll provide either a yaml or bash
script uh and so for the case of aws
what you'll have is this box called user
data and so you can either put your yaml
or bash script in there it's the same if
you're using google or azure they both
have this box it might just not be
called user data
but that is using cloud init underneath
then you have packer this is an
automated image builder service you
provide a configuration file to create
and provision the machine image and the
image is then delivered to repository
for use if you've ever heard of ec2
image builder it's a very similar
service except that one's just for aws
i suppose for google you could use
google cloud run
and even on database you could use um
code build but packer is great because
it's cloud agnostic so you're going to
just build the image and then you can
deliver it
to any provider
provisioners should be used as a last
resort for the mo for more common
situations there are better alternatives
this is a warning that hashnote puts out
in their terraform provisioner section
and so i wasn't really sure why they
were saying this so i reached out to
anton and anton uh if you don't know him
he's an abe's community hero just like
myself
and so he specializes in terraform like
he wrote so many modules for the
terraform aws so he knows it pretty well
and he says here the main reason is that
provisioners will do something that
won't be reflected in the terraform
state and the better alternative for
that one is to use cloud provider
features like cloud init scripts i think
this comes back to immutability when
we're looking at uh the fact that we
want to um
lean towards doing an approach with
packer right we want to
um
bake our baker machines or virtual
machines and then deploy because that's
going to be probably the better
alternative
so if we wanted to use cloud init uh the
idea is we'd have to provide a cloudant
yaml file which is a a very particular
format you can find them on the cloudant
website uh and the idea here is we have
these run commands so let's just like
bash commands here to start and stop
apache we can install our packages here
do an update do an upgrade we'll have to
pass along our ssh key here that's a
very important component to that
once we have that file configured
we can reference it as a template file
over here call it user data and then
we're going to pass it on to this
section here for user data so that when
we launch up this vm and this one in
particular is for aws that's going to
pass it to that user data okay
now you might be asking well where's all
these other provisioners because there's
a lot of other tools out there so
terraform used to directly support
third-party provisioning tools in the
terraform language but they were
deprecated uh because it was considered
to be poor practice suggesting better
alternatives as we were just talking
about so you might be asking where is
chef where is puppet where is salt
and the thing is is that you can
technically still use chef and puppet
through cloudinet because cloudnit
actually supports uh some dsls in there
i've never used this before myself but
it doesn't look too complicated but the
idea is that there's just not direct
support so you're not going to use it
directly in the language you can use it
through cloud in it if you really need
it one thing i didn't see mentioned
anywhere was ansible and this one's a
little bit confusing because there's a
lot of videos online about terraform and
ansible working very well together and
they're complementary uh technologies so
ansible is a little bit different than
these other ones because it does more
than just configuration management so
maybe that's the reason there um but
anyway the point is is that there's no
direct support for these anymore you've
got to use cloud in it and generally if
you can use packer instead when you're
working with virtual machines okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at local exec
which allows you to execute local
commands after resource is provisioned
so the machine that is executing
terraform so what's doing the terraform
apply is where the command will execute
in a local environment could be
your local machine so your laptop or
workstation a build server like gcp
cloud build abs code builder jenkins or
terraform cloud run environment so that
is a single use linux virtual machine so
just an example and there's a lot of
cases where you might want to automate
but the idea here is after you provision
a vm you need to supply the public ip to
a third party security service to add
the vm ip address and you could
accomplish this by using locally
installed third party cli on your build
server and so there is a bit of
overlapping responsibility between
terraform outputs versus local exec
because the idea is that by getting um
uh by getting data out after something
is provisioned or something like that
you can do something pragmatic but the
idea here is terraform outputs allow you
to output results after running
terraform apply local exec allows you to
run any arbitrary commands on your local
machine commonly used to trigger
configuration management like ansible
chef or puppet okay
let's take a look at some example code
for a local exec so here we have a bunch
of examples on the right hand side and
so i just kind of want to walk through
some of the commands that we can use but
before we do that just let's take a
quicker look here at the code so notice
we have a resource like about instance
in web and then we are specifying a
provisioner being a local exec and then
we have a command that is being executed
under there okay so hopefully that makes
it pretty clear but let's just kind of
work through the options we have
available to us so the first is we have
a command and this is required and this
is the command you want to execute so
notice that
we are doing
an echo there so it's whatever is
possible there and i think by default
it's using bash okay so if you're using
linux that's what it would be using uh
we could also set a working directory we
don't see an example there on the right
hand side but if you wanted to
say where the command will be executed
that's something you could do so maybe
you want it over here another thing is
the interpreter so this is the entry
point for the command i think by default
again it would probably use bash if your
linux machine but you could say use bash
ruby it was cli powershell whatever you
want okay
if you needed to pass environment
variables in maybe you need a key and
secret
so the example here is you know we are
printing out those keys and then putting
them into a
credentials yaml file so that could be
an example there okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at remote execs
so this allows you to execute commands
on a target resource after a resources
provision so the idea is you have a
local machine executing terraform and so
the idea is that when remote exec
happens it has a script and it's sending
that off to the target so this case it
could be a provision virtual machine and
this is where the command is going to
run so a remote execute is useful for
provisioning a virtual machine with a
simple set of commands for more complex
tasks it's recommended to use cloud init
and strongly recommend it in all cases
to bake golden images via packer or ec2
image builder if you want to use
something more complex like ansible or
something
[Music]
let's take a look at an example of a
remote exact script so here we have a
couple and just to quickly go through it
the idea is you define your resource so
here it's just a virtual machine on aws
and we are provisioning our provisioner
is going to be remote exact and so we're
able to put these inline commands and
say okay let's run puppet apply and then
we'll use console join which is the cli
for hashicorp console
so
there are three different modes for
remote exec the first is inline list of
command strings which is what we are
seeing over here
and then the other option is we can
provide a script or scripts so the idea
is that you would um well you just
specify those locations and it would run
it
what's interesting here is that it
doesn't say um like because we saw with
local exec that we could use an
interpreter and so it's my assumption
that it's just going to use bash or it's
going to use a script that is executable
right where you have a shebang on the
top there
and so that's something you know i might
test out it's not something that's going
to be on the exam but maybe we'll just
test out that theory because it's not in
the documentation as of the time i'm
recording this
[Music]
let's take a look at the file
provisioner and this is used to copy
files or directories from our local
machine to the newly created resource so
here we have some on the right as an
example so again we have a virtual
machine that we're deploying to aws
we've set the provisioner as file and we
are specifying a source file and a
destination so source is going to be uh
the file that's on your local machine or
whoever is uh the considered the local
that you might also want to provide
content directly so in this example here
you see that we're literally just giving
it a string
and then there's the destination where
you want that file to be
i don't have it shown in the code
example here but there's a high chance
that you would have to provide a
connection block so that you could say
okay i need to use ssh or
winrm to gain access to that machine
okay
[Music]
so we just mentioned that there's a
connection block so
it tells the provisioner or resource how
to establish a connection so here is a
big example on the right hand side so
this is using the example for a
provisioner file
and here we are specifying our
connection block and this one in
particular is for ssh as you can see and
there's a bunch of different parameters
like the user the password the host
you could also
use a bastion host i don't i'm not
showing it here but if you're using ssh
you could specify a bunch of keys in
order to do that because maybe you need
to go through a bastion first
for uh windows remote management you
also have that option down below okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at null
resources so this is a placeholder for
resources that have no specific
association to a provider
it's a bit confusing but it makes sense
once you run into some use cases for it
so here is a big example where we have
an aws
instance and we're defining a cluster
and so we need a null resource here
because we want to
run this trigger and that's generally
why you're going to be using all
resources is to trigger a resource so
triggers is a map of values which should
cause this set of provisioners to re-run
so values are meant to be interpolated
references to variables or attributes of
other resources and uh triggers are
interesting because i think we also see
them in terraform cloud i'm not sure if
this is the same kind of functionality
but um yeah that's in all resources okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and in this follow along we're going to
be um learning all about provision or so
what i want you to do is make sure you
have a new folder and cd into that
folder and we are going to create
ourselves a new main.tf file and we're
going to go set up a new workspace in
terraform cloud so i'm going to choose
the cli driven way of doing it i'm going
to call this workspace provisioners
okay and we're going to get some default
uh code here that we can copy in so i'll
just paste that into my main tf that's
just going to set up that workspace we
want to set up our environment variables
or terraform variables again so we'll
need to set up that for aws so i'm going
to just go to the registry here
registry.terraform.com
or dot io
and we'll go to aws here documentation
aws providers scroll on down just
because i can never seem to remember
these key names and so we will
put in this one here
and i will need to actually get my
credentials again these are secrets so
you should not share these with anybody
again i'm going to get rid of mine
eventually here especially before i
publish this course
and i should be able to paste that in
there didn't get it
it's very finicky the um
the copy paste here with uh
vs code so we'll mark that as sensitive
we'll add another one here
and in this case it is called secret
access key
okay
and we will save that and so we're all
set up for aws with the exception that
we need to define our actual required
providers again we're going to go back
to well we don't actually have to we
could just go grab it from here if we go
back here and grab the required provider
there
and so that needs to go
just after back end here doesn't matter
the order as long as it's in the first
level of the terraform settings
and we'll also want to specify the
provider
and i'm just going to set the region
here
as us east one
and it's double quotations i don't think
terraform supports single quotations
and then i just need an aws instance so
what i'm going to do here is go up to
my getting started here and in here
we're going to grab it from the aws code
and we'll just scroll up
and we'll grab this
okay but we'll have to make some
modifications because
we don't have a local here so we'll take
that out and i'm just going to hard code
this value for the time being so t2
micro
uh and that looks good to me i'm just
going to double check here that is all
good so we'll go down below type in
terraform init
great and that's just going to start
setting up
that for us there
so the thing is is that
we're going to
want to ssh into this me machine and so
we're going to want to set up
like a data key okay
and so the way we're going to do that is
we're going to need to use um it's
called aws key pair so what i'm going to
do is make my way over to the
documentation here
and i'm just going to type in database
key pair
okay
and this is pretty much what i'm looking
for so i will go ahead and paste this in
if you're familiar with aws you can uh
you know associate keys but this is the
easiest way so we're going to need to
generate our own key and attach it there
once we have our key
in there we can just reference it so i'm
just going to go down here and add it
right now so we'll go key underscore
name
and
i think what we'd want to do is use
an interpolation there or directive
and we want to do aws key pair
dot
deployer
dot key name
okay
and i'm just looking at that to see
if that is correct
the coloring is not right here but um i
don't think that's why like that is the
problem because the syntax definitely
looks correct to me here
so i guess i'm just not going to worry
about that right now
another thing we're going to need is the
public id so again with the outputs we
will just type in output
and do public id
ip sorry i like to say id
and
we'll set our value here adabus instance
my server
okay so we're going to need some kind of
ssh key so we're going to go ahead and
generate ourselves a new one
um
there is a s or a linux command called
ssh keygen
it's basically the standard for
generating keys and so i'll just hit
enter here and i'm just going to call it
terraform
and i'm going to hit enter and enter
again and notice that it has generated
out in the root.ssh directory actually
it might have dumped it right here and
that's no good i'm going to delete that
the reason i i can't have it in this
folder is that i'm right now mounted to
a windows directory and so chamod which
is what we need to modify the
permissions won't work if we do that so
i'll have to do this again and i'll have
to type the full path
okay
and so this will generate it out in the
correct directory i'm going to do a
chamod on that 400. the reason why we're
doing that is that whenever you launch
an instance i'll show you later but uh
when you in sessions manager but aws
will not accept
um
a uh like a key unless it has uh it's
only readable okay
so we will go here and do ssh terraform
and put on the 400 we don't need to do
it on the
the public key there and we need that
public key so we'll do root
dot ssh terraform dot pub
we're going to copy the contents there
this might take more than one go because
the paste and vs code is not great
double check the ends here make sure
there's no spaces that causes a lot of
issues check the front here ssh that
looks good to me
okay and so when we deploy this instance
it's going to take that ssh key and and
install it on the server for us which is
really nice
um so we need to now set up a
secure security group because we're
going to need
a way of accessing port 80 and 22. so
back on aws here we go the top here and
if we just type in security groups i
never remember if it's under ec2 or aws
if we go down here there is the security
group and so here is where we have an
example so i'm going to go ahead and
copy this in here
and we're just going to go ahead and
modify that okay
so i'll just paste it right here
and i don't need any tag on that
and so we have our egress rule we have
our ingress rule
and so for ingress rule we want one for
http
because we're going to install apache
and just have it running on
port 80 here
okay
we're going to be using our default vpc
and so that doesn't have an ipv6 so i'm
just removing it out of there
and
we're going to have to reference some
kind of vpc so for the time being like
we're going to use a external data
source we'll have to change that but
this will be um
we'll call this sgmyserver
sgmyserver
we're going to have to set our
description here so this will be my
security group
my my server security group
notice that we are explicitly setting an
egress port if you're familiar with aws
this is usually set for you by default
but when you're using terraform you have
to explicitly set it because if you
don't it won't be there when you deploy
it
um
so
we're going to need to have that vpc
and so we just need the id and we could
technically just open aws and grab that
key
so if we go over to aws here and go to
the vpc
and go to vpc ids
we could just technically grab it that's
the default vpc but the problem is we're
going to probably have to refer to this
vpc in other places so we can't just
grab the id and put it in here
that's not going to be good enough
so what we'll need to do is we'll need
to actually reference the existing we
don't want to set up a new vpc which
might use the default one so that's
where data sources come into play data
sources allow us to uh externally
reference resources um
and so like if i wanted to figure out
how to reference a vpc i would just say
terraform
data source vpc
okay and then i should be able to easily
find an example here so here's an exact
example that i want
so i will go ahead and grab that it's
very simple
i'm just going to call my main because
that other one was called main and this
is where we would want to actually place
the id so i'll go back here
and grab my vpc id
okay so now uh this actually acts as a
resource and we can access all of its
attributes so
that's going to be very useful like
notice how we're referencing cider block
if we had just hard coded vpncid we
wouldn't be able to do this which is
what we need
um so
let's make sure the egress
we don't need an ipv
well we can just leave that alone that's
fine so what we need is
um to reference this here so we'll say
data dot aws vpc
notice that we're using data dot in the
front because it's a data source that's
how we always reference them and we'll
just do dot id down below this has to be
data because it's not a standard
resource it's a it's from a data source
all right and that is good
so
we have our data source so that looks
pretty good to me
oh but we have to reference the security
group actually down below here otherwise
it's not going to work
so i think for that it is vpc security
um group
ids
and then there that's where we'd have to
reference that so our resource up here
is called
absolute group sdg my server
so we'll just have to type that in again
down below here so we'll say aws
security group
dot s g
my server dot id
and that should apply we didn't actually
create a port 22 here so we'll go here
and copy
this and uh we do not need
uh we don't want the cider block of the
vpc this is what we if we want this we
want this to be the internet so we're
going to say 0.0
uh i'll just copy the one down below
here just so i don't make any mistakes
but this just means from anywhere
okay
and we only want rip to work so what
we'll do is go to the internet here and
type in what's my ip
and so that is my current ip
i'm going to go here and make a cider
block
forward slash 32 just means use a single
address
and i actually put that in the wrong
block here so i'm just going to go ahead
and paste it up there
and we're going to go
and clear that out
and so that will give us access
well
i think i messed that up sorry so
one is supposed to be one's supposed to
be down here so we want the ssh to be
our ip address here so sorry we'll say
ssh port 22 port 22
and i'm going to go back and copy this
one here because i just cleared it out
by accident
okay
and so we have the that port 80 open
that ssh open
um the only other thing that we need is
a file to configure our resource so what
we're going to do here is make a new
file i'm going to call this
userdata.yaml or maybe cloudenit.yaml
because that's now we'll do user data
yaml but this is basically uh cloud
cloud in it when you're using aws this
is gonna might vary for providers but
you have to start the first line as
cloud config even though this is a yaml
file this is important for each of us to
know what to do i want to install httpd
okay
and i'm going to do run cmd
systemctl start
httpd and then we have to do sudo system
ctl enable hdb so this is going to
install apache which is just a web
server start it up and enable it so on
reboot it will work um one thing i want
to show you if i have not before cloud
init examples
if you're just wondering like how do you
know what to write there there's a bunch
of examples on cloud in it and then uh
notice like it starts with that so we
could literally create users and do all
sorts of things here but for our
purposes we're just going to keep it
really simple
um i don't know if it matters if it's a
yml or a yml sometimes you have with the
a sometimes you don't but i'm just gonna
do it that way anyway like that
so we just need to set our user data
here so we're gonna have to pull in that
script so we will type in um
we'll need to reference our data so
we'll need to create
a new data source and this is going to
be called template file we'll call it
user data
and here we'll say template
equals file
i think i called it cloudinet here
oh no we renamed it user data
there we go and so now we just need to
reference that file
so if i go down below
and we say user data equals data
template file user data and then i think
you have to type rendered
there
so this will deploy a server that's open
on port 80 ssh only allow it on our
address to ssh into it it's going to
copy over that key
and it should run the script and install
apache so we can see that server and
we'll output our public ip address there
so i'm going to do a terraform plan to
see what happens
because we did do a lot there right
see if it takes it
i don't even know if we did terraform in
it yet
if we didn't it will complain
so it says here a data source 8bitsvpcid
has not been declared in the root module
it's probably
um no we're doing data
right so that shouldn't be an issue main
oh i didn't write the word main on there
so that's on line 29
so i think we just need data here or
sorry um
main
okay
and we'll try another terraform plan
and sometimes if you want to speed it up
you can just type terraform validate
before you do your plans that's why you
see me do validate a lot without doing a
plan first even though they both do it
okay and so what we're having here is an
error we're saying inappropriate values
for egress so description prefix list id
security group self are required so when
you're specifying things in blocks even
if they're optional sometimes like
blocks being this sometimes you have to
still specify them
so
we have
we don't have prefix id
so we should go look this up because i'm
not sure what it's expecting here
so we'll go down here
to prefix id
okay so that's just a list
so i'm going to go here and just
provided an empty list
okay
i have a feeling that's for ingress
egress
and it wants security groups
right there it's also a list okay and
then self that looks like it is what
whether the secret group is added by the
source or not i think that's a boolean
so what i'm going to do here is do
security groups
self equals false
it's not like i know what these mean in
granular detail it's just the fact that
it's like hey we want these fields and i
just go and i go okay i'll give you some
defaults
because i don't plan to use them for
anything right so
um and we will paste that in there
there's some weird characters there
okay so we'll go down here and do tear
from plan and we'll see if it likes it
now
i don't know if we're missing a
description here we are so description
for growing traffic
try this again here
all right so we didn't get any errors it
looks like it's all good and it will
provision so the aws root module does
not declare variable name adabus access
key id but a value is found in the
terraform tfrs if you if you meant to
use this value okay that's fine
so what we're going to do is now try to
provision and see if it works i'm going
to do auto approve
all right and
looks like it's off to the races i will
see you here when it's done okay
all right welcome back so after a little
while there i just wanted to make sure
those two checks had passed uh we're
ready to see if our server is working
and by the way there is a way for us to
make sure that terraform only completes
uh when those two checks have passed and
that's where we can use null resource
and so we'll look at that later on but
for the time being we'll just manually
check that stuff when it's done so what
i want to do is go grab that public ip
address go and paste it up here and look
where apache page is working so
everything is working as expected let's
see if we can ssh into that instance so
what we can do is type in terraform
outputs
and see what we have here it might just
be output my fault here
and so notice that um oh we get a lot of
stuff okay so i just want
i'm not sure why i'm getting so much
output here all i want is the public ip
address but notice that it's uh giving
me a bunch of stuff here that doesn't
make sense so i must have made a mistake
here if i go down below
yes i forgot to do public ip all right
so what i'm going to try to do here is
see if i can do a terraform refresh
and see if that well actually sorry
terraform refresh is an old command so
i'm going to do
refresh only
and see if we can get that change that
change to reflect
refresh only is like we didn't change
any infrastructure but our state does
not match our um
our
uh like the actual
objects within the cloud so this way we
can just pull that information okay
refresh doesn't always work as expected
but in this particular case i think it
should work pretty well
yeah see it's going to replace all that
information with just that
and we're going to type yes here
great and so now if we do terraform
output it should be a lot more sane
and if we just want to get that single
one there whoops we can do public ip
but what i want is i just want um
i want it in raw because i want to be
able to use it as a bash command so i
can ssh in so i'm going to do ec2 user
at sine dollar sign
parentheses here
and i'm going to hyphen i to specify
where my
ssh key is my public key or sorry my
private key i suppose
so we will do ssh terraform and so that
should allow us into the server that's
much nicer than having to type the ip
address every single time i'm going to
type in yes
and i'm in the server so there we go
so we successfully provision with cloud
internet the other way to provision is
with terraform and packer but we'll
leave that for the the packers section
um but uh yeah that is that's all we
need to know for cloud in it
um so there we go
[Music]
all right so i just want to show you
some other provisioning things like
local exact remote exact and uh file so
let's get to it um for local exec i'm
just going to go ahead and google that
quickly here local exec terraform not
working let's just say it is working
here and we'll scroll on down and so
what this is going to do is run a local
command or execute something locally on
the machine that is running terraform
now right now we are using a remote
provider so where this is going to run
is actually in the run environment which
is not very useful to us so what we're
going to do is switch back to the local
provider here in a moment but we're just
going to go and add this provisioner
just use the default one here that is
provided to us from the documentation
i'm going to go up the top here and i'm
going to comment this out so we'll go
here
i'm not used to migrating from remote to
local so i'm not sure what's going to
happen
probably actually before we do that we
should go and
[Music]
tear down our infrastructure so before i
do that i'm just going to go terraform
destroy we'll just say apply delete
auto approve
okay
terraform
did i spell terraform wrong
delete
it should be that well i'll just do
terraform delete then that's fine
i'm spelling something super wrong here
terraform
good
destroy
you know what it probably is it's
probably the destroy flag
there we go
and so we're just going to tear down
what we have and then uh
we will set this up for local and then
we will deploy that okay so i'll see you
back here when that's all destroyed
all right so our resources or our server
is destroyed so what i'm going to do is
go here and comment out the remote back
end for the time being
and we are going to do a terror form
uh apply or sorry terraform init because
we've changed out our back end so it's
now local a change in the back end has
been detected which may require migraine
existing state
if you wish to migrate it sure we will
say migrate state
i'm not used to going from remote to
local but local to remote
but seems to like it worked out okay so
we'll say
terraform
apply
okay and we should end up with a local
state file
we'll say yes here
and so what i'm hoping that will happen
is that we will once this is done it
will output
a file called privateips.txt in this
folder but we'll see what actually
happens here so i'll see you back here
when the provisioning done and it
actually has rand as private ips okay
all right welcome back so uh we had
waited for this to execute and notice
that it says local exec executing and
here is that file with those ip
addresses so that is how local exec
works okay
so we'll move on to remote exec using
the same file here
[Music]
all right welcome back so we just did
local exec and so let's take a look at
remote exact so in our documentation
we'll just go down one and here we have
an example i want something a little bit
more simple than this
um
so what i'll do is just kind of grab
this code here and we'll just kind of
tweak it
so we'll go down below
we don't need both local and remote here
so i'll go up here and
i'm just going to take this command here
okay
and paste it on in here but i want to
make sure that it actually goes
somewhere that i can find it
so i'm actually going to just
ssh into the server we'll just hit up
until we find that ssh command we had
earlier there we go
just because i can't remember the root
directory here so we'll say pwd and i
think that we can get it to put it in
here i don't know what this is going to
execute like in as what type of user i'm
hoping that it will execute as the ec2
user if it doesn't i don't know how
we're going to find this file or the the
command that it's going to run here but
what i'm going to do
is put in home ec2 user and
we will have the echo command in here
and we'll just actually copy this
wholesale
okay
and i'm hoping that this will place it
where we want it to go
if not like it's not a big deal it's
just the fact that uh it'd be nice to
just be able to easily see that
local exactin remote are a little bit
different so this one takes just a
command and this one can take multiple
inline commands or a bunch of other
stuff you can read the docs on it it's
all covered in lecture content
um so
this should
do the same thing this one says aws
instance web private ip address so i
don't think self is going to work in the
way that we expect it to here
uh it might it should actually yeah
so let's give this a go and see if that
will work
to do this because it like from the
perspective of terraform nothing has
changed in terms of the infrastructure
so we're going to have to do a replace
so we'll do terraform
apply replace and then we'll have to
give it the resource addressing names
let's address instance
dot
my server
and i've got to type that right if i
want that to work terror form
oh you know what it's because i'm logged
in the server
common problem i have here
replace equals
database instance my server
enter
and so i'm just hoping that this is
going to work actually you know what i'm
going to stop that before it happens
because
we're missing the e there
it doesn't matter because i would have
had to confirm that action so
i guess i didn't have to panic there
it's still wrong i kind of put a forward
slash on that
so we'll just hit up again
and we'll try this one more time
this time i think i got it
we'll say yes and i'll see you back here
when it's done provisioning we'll esta
station the server and see if we can see
that file but maybe like the best we'll
get is just the command that it's
executed okay
all right so we didn't have much luck
here um it says missing configure uh
connection configuration for provisioner
so probably what we need
is we might need to specify a connection
let me just see here so provisionary
invokes a script a remote resource this
can be used as etc
the example just shows this
right and so down below missing
connection configuration so i'm thinking
what it is is that it just wants the
connection
information so there's like a connection
block for provisioners
so we will go and type in terraform
connection block
i wasn't planning on showing this right
away but if this is what it requires
then we will provide it that it's not a
big deal
so i just want one for ssh i really wish
they just had oh they do right there
there's an example so what i'm going to
do is go ahead and grab this
actually this probably tells us where it
would execute which is kind of the
question we had there before
um this does not use
root first so it's gonna be ec2 user
but there's no password
okay
let's go down below here so the address
of the resource to connect to
so i would assume that's just the ip
address so we just say um
self
dot private ip
actually that'd be public ip sorry
public ip
uh there is no password
so we'll have to pass the private key so
that's how we're going to do it so we
will take that out here
private key
the contents of the ssh key this can be
loaded from a file on disk using the
file function so we've done that once
before with file
and
we actually did this this one i believe
oops
trying to search in this file here
there we go so
i'm just going to go down below here so
i can see what i'm doing
um
paste that in there whoops
you know this uh this vs code doesn't
always work how i want it to so we'll
say private i
private key
oh sorry this is
template file
private key
i mean it's not a template file it's
just a file
i don't know if we need to really assign
it to data
i'm going to go google this i'll be back
in a sec all right so i took a look here
and it seems like it's very simple it's
just something like that that's always
wondering that maybe we don't have to do
a data source there
um so what i'm just going to do here is
just paste that in there like that
and we will go down below
to our connection here
and this is going to be at the root
terraform
okay so that looks good to me
let me just go double check if there's
any other parameters we're missing
uh the host the address used to connect
to the resource required the other one
didn't have it i'm surprised that now
i'm kind of like wondering if this is
going to work because that other one
didn't have the host so maybe it's old
the path to use for the script um
user type host
hps this all looks fine there's really
not that much to type in here so
i think that we're all good to go and i
think that this connection block is in
the right area it's with the provisioner
so let's pull the trigger and see what
happens
so we'll try another replace here
okay
say yes
hopefully we're just lucky here so yeah
that kind of answers the question what
what it would use would be ec2 user
there so
all right so i'll be back here if we run
into any errors okay
all right welcome back so uh looks like
it finished here and it did establish a
remote connection it didn't say that it
failed said that it connected and it
probably executed that command that we
were expecting here
it's not saying that it failed in any
way so let's go ahead and log in and see
if we can see it if we don't that's not
a big deal we don't have to really dwell
on this to make sure it's perfect more
so important that we just kind of go
through the motions so that we
understand what this is hey the file is
there look at that so we can open it up
let's see if it's there perfect
okay so that is a remote exect and so
then we can move on to i suppose
transferring files okay
[Music]
all right so this last one should be
really easy because i think that we can
just modify this one and call it file
and then specify file so file takes a
source and a destination
or a content which might be just easier
in our case so we'll just say
destination here
and we'll say content
we'll go look up how this works for file
um
yeah this one's a bit easier so that's
what i'm going to do
a little copy this over here
and
i'm going to just say
bar soon which i think is the name for
mars in that book there
and
we'll say dot txt
we want the uh directory to be in the
home
uh home
what did we say there before when we
logged in
it is
i think i might need the full path here
to know
yeah help me see too
so we'll say home ec2 user
bars soon
and the contents will just be mars
and so i think that's all we have to do
to get that to work
content destination
okay so let's go give that a go and see
if it works
so terraform we'll need to do a replace
again we're actually logged in the
server here so i'll just exit
and we will go ahead and replace that
again
just double checking making sure
everything's okay good we'll hit enter
let's make sure we don't get any errors
here
looks like it's good press yes
and i will see you here in a bit okay
all right so it says that it's been
created or at least replaced let's go
take a look at our server give it a
refresh it's probably in our
initializing state we should probably
still be able to log in there so we'll
sshn
and we'll type in yes
we'll type in ls
there's our file file bar soon i'm just
going to cat it to see if it works
um and i don't think the uh contents is
there
oh no it's there okay
oh i guess because i wrote cat oh no
it's right there it's just there's no
line break all right so that all worked
out great so uh we're pretty much done
for provisioners here so what i'm gonna
do is just tear this all down
and we'll just we're all done okay so
we'll just do a terraform just or i'm
going to do a terraform apply
auto
or sorry destroy
auto approve
and we're all good so yeah i'll see you
later
[Music]
all right so it looks like we do have
one more uh follow along here for
provisioners and it isn't all resource i
thought it was in another section but uh
we can do it here so i just noticed that
i went back and i broke up the
provisioners into separate folders there
so that when i share this repository
it's gonna be easy for you to find all
those examples but let's switch over to
this new folder i have here which is for
the provisioner null resource
and let's create ourselves a new main
dot tf file
so you know null resource just keeps
cropping up in a lot of different use
cases but one in particular that's very
helpful for is waiting for those status
checks uh when spinning up an aws
instance so what we're going to do
um is we're going to go to maybe one of
our examples like the cloud init
and
we'll go ahead and grab this one okay
and so now what i'll do is make my way
down to null resource here
and i do not believe i got rid of
this remote workspace but just to make
it easier we're just going to keep it
local
okay so i'm just going to delete that
out of there
and to simplify this further i mean we
don't need all this stuff while we just
leave it in it's not a big deal
so i think that's what i'll do i'll just
leave it in because i don't feel like
ripping all this out to streamline this
but
what we want is to create a new resource
called
null resource here and just a moment as
i have
a reference for this it's not easy to
remember so
okay and so what we'll do here is create
ourselves a null resource
and i'm just going to call it status
and it's going to have a provisioner
inside of it here
and it will do a local exec
and what it's going to do is execute a
command
this is going to be the aws ec2 weight
instance status
ok
check and so this is used to check
whether it is done or not and so we'll
have to do some interpolation and what
we need to provide here
is the instance id right so down below
what i'm going to do is type in depends
on
and
i think just type in ec2 instance here
okay
i don't use depends on very often so
let's just go look it up and check its
reference so depends on terraform
to see an example and so here it's
actually referring to a particular
resource
that seems like a good idea to me
so
what i'm going to do is go up here
and just bring this down onto a new line
i'm just going to say aws instance
my server because we want that this to
provision before this does and for null
reasons we absolutely have to specify
that relationship
okay so we need to get the instance id
here
so
i'm going to
just try to take a single one here
and
i think the instance id i'm not sure so
let's go look up on the terraform
documentation so registry.terraform
we'll make our way over to providers
over to aws into documentation and we're
going to type in abus instance
and so what i want to know is if we do
id do we get back the id i think we
would
oh well i can't seem to find it very
quickly there but i'm almost certain
that if we do
dot id that's going to give us the
instance id back
so we'll just type in instance my server
dot id
and
i mean other than the fact that the
coloring looks a little bit off i think
that is fine
and so we'll go ahead and try to
provision this and see if it works so
we'll do a terraform validate here
because i find the terraform plan a
little bit slow
actually before we do that we have to do
a terraform in it
this is a new repository
i think there's not supposed to be p
here so i'll remove that
and this will probably fail if we don't
bring in the um
uh that provisioning file there so we
need this user data file here so let's
bring it over
or it's going to complain
i believe it's with a a so let's rename
that so it has an a in there
there we go
okay back to this file here we'll try a
terraform init
or sorry a terraform
validate
let's see if it throws any errors
we have one error here blocks of type
resource are not expected here
so maybe my nesting is incorrect and it
is because i haven't nested within
a resource we cannot do that so let's
cut that out
and we will place this resource here at
the top level
and we will run that again
and so we have something else failed
initiate provider registry hashicorp
null to obtain schema unknown provider
um
we'll do terraform init again
since it's asking for it
it's installing the hashicorp null i
think it's because we added that null
resource so if we go over here to
[Music]
the registry
go back to the top level we type in null
so i believe this is what controls the
null resource here
okay
so if we want to read a bit more about
it i think it's all there so it is a
separate plugin
so now that we have that i'm going to do
terraform validate
okay looks good
and
what we'll do here is go ahead and
do terraform apply
and i'm happy with it because it passed
well i guess we should do a plan first
and yep it's just going to create stuff
so that's all fine so what we'll do
is type in terraform
apply
auto approve
and what we're watching for is to see if
it's going to wait for the status checks
because that's what we care about
okay so if we go back over here we're
gonna have to pay close attention
see what happens
you
great so we scroll up here it looks like
we hit an error
um so it's saying
that it does not like our command
oh this is supposed to be easy too
sorry spelling mistake so we will i
don't know if this provision so i'm
going to refresh here
it did spin up an instance
so we will have to tear down here so
or what we could do is just do it
terraform apply replace
that probably easier to do
we'll do data as instance my server
and we'll go ahead and write yes and
we'll see if it works this time
okay notice that it's executing our
status check here
we may be interested also just try out
this command while we're waiting up here
if i press the plus i can open up a new
uh terminal and i can even try it myself
here
so notice it's just kind of hanging
because um it's it's set to wait
so until it's actually uh working
uh and then it returns that's when it
will proceed so that's probably how it's
working here so i'm just gonna go ahead
and delete this window here and so it's
just waiting until it gets a valid check
so i'm going to go refresh here
notice that it's initializing so we'll
just wait
all right so notice here it says the
creation is completed if i give it a
refresh the stats that pass the check so
this null resource worked it as intended
and once this command had completed and
the small resource existed then it was
ready so basically that is null resource
you can also do triggers with it so
let's take a look here quickly
so a map of arbitrary strings that when
change will force the null
resources to be replaced so that is also
something else we can do not something
we're going to explore uh right now but
um
yeah there you go
[Music]
okay so we are done the uh provider
section but i forgot to tell you to
destroy the uh resource here i was just
doing another follow along and i noticed
that i still had it running so i'm just
going back here and doing a terraform
uh we'll do
destroy
okay so yeah just in case always
consider that you run destroy at the end
of these fall belongs okay
and we'll just make sure that is going
to work here just before we end here yes
great and so we're all good
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at terraform
providers so providers are terraform
plugins that allow you to interact with
cloud service providers like aws azure
gcp
software as a service provider so github
angolia
stripe or other apis such as kubernetes
or postgres servers there's a lot there
there's like over a thousand providers
so providers are required for your
terraform configuration file to work so
you have to have at least one provider
providers can come in three different
tiers we have the official one so
published by the company that owns the
provider technology or service verified
so actively maintained up to date and
compatible with both terraform provider
communities so published by community
member but no guarantee of maintenance
up to date or compatibility providers
are distributed separately from
terraform and the plug-in must be
downloaded before use so if we do
terraform init this will download the
necessary plug-in provider plugins
listed in the terraform configuration
file so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the
terraform registry so this is a website
portal to browse download or publish
available providers and modules and just
remember providers and modules are
plugins within terraform both of them
okay
so to get to this website we go to
registry.terraform.io
and everything published to the
terraform registry is public facing so
let's just distinguish between providers
and modules and i feel that i should
have given providers a little bit more
attention in the uh in its own slide but
i'll give it a clear distinction between
providers and modules here so a provider
is a plug-in that is a mapping to a
cloud service provider's api so if you
wanted to call individual api actions
that is what the provider is providing
to you when we're talking about modules
a module actually relies on a provider
plug-in but a module is a group of
configuration files that provide common
configuration functionality this is
going to help you enforce best practices
reduce amount of code reduce time to
develop scripts
so the way to think about it is imagine
that you have to do something in your
csp like aws and there's just common
things that would go along with it so
let's say you're launching a load
balancer auto scaling group with ec2
instances that's a bunch of services
that you are just very common you'd have
to configure it together so there could
be a module
that allows you to do all that with
writing very little amount of code and
we'll choose best practices when doing
that okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at providers and
modules within terraform registry really
quickly so um here is the aws one here
and so i just want to point out that
this official one is by hashicorp it's
not by aws but it does mean that it has
a proper support so you know it's going
to have pretty much one-to-one mapping
to the itabus api
um and so it has really really good
documentation now i complain about
terraform not having great documentation
for learning like their language but for
the actual documentation of doing things
practically they're really really good
and here's just an example where we see
app mesh and they just give you full
examples for basically everything it's
really great
and if you need a code sample to get
going like to actually install it within
your configuration file it's right there
over here so you can just go ahead and
grab that for terraform
modules
it looks pretty similar so the idea is
you get your module code on the right
hand side here you want to check out the
examples it's going to be dependent on
who is developing these modules this one
is made by anton so he has lots and lots
of really great examples and then you
can see a list of dependent modules here
under sub modules so it's not too
complicated so there you go
[Music]
so we're taking a look at terraform
registry which is a public registry but
let's talk about private registry how
would we do that well that's where we
use terraform cloud it allows you to
publish private modules for your
organization within the terraform cloud
private registry when creating a module
you need to connect to a version control
system of vcs and choose a repository so
here you can see
we can be using something like github
gitlab bucket or azure devops
and of course we're going to cover
terraform cloud a lot more further on in
the course and it definitely does more
than just
act as a private registry but i figured
this is the best place to put it against
the terraform registry okay
[Music]
let's take a look at how we would get a
list of the current providers you are
using so all you'd have to do is type in
terraform providers and you'd get a full
list
this command is useful if you have a
very complex
architecture where you're using a lot of
files and modules within terraform i
wanted to just show this command just
because i saw it on the exam and so it's
just an easy point if you happen to get
that question okay
[Music]
so we know we can set multiple providers
in our terraform configuration file but
there are some variations here that you
should know so one thing is is that if
you need to have an alternate provider
you can use this thing called alias so
if you just notice here there's the
alias this is useful if let's say you
want to have resources within different
regions of aws is a very common use case
when you want to reference uh what
resource should use what provider you're
going to have that little provider
attribute and then you're just going to
do
what the name is of the provider
followed by the alias you can also set
an alias provider for a parent module so
notice here
in the required providers we have this
attribute here and we're using this
configuration alias
and then if you need to set an alias
provider for a child module but more or
less you just need to remember these two
up here okay for setting an alias
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're giving closer attention to
modules so a terraform module is a group
of configuration files that provide
common configuration functionality to
enforce best practices reduce the amount
of code and reduce the time to develop
scripts i definitely had a lot of
confusion understanding the difference
between a provider and a module
initially
but the clear thing is that a provider
is just an api mappings to uh the
service okay so on the example here on
the left we have aws as a provider and
the example is to show you if you had to
create a vpc you'd have to specify many
networking resources and uh just notice
that i have the three ellipses there to
suggest there is a lot more that you'd
have to configure but by using a module
and there's one called the aws vpc
module it basically has this short
domain specific language
that allows you to quickly provision
a vpc so
the easy way to remember modules is
imagine clicking a wizard that creates
many cloud resources like it must have
the vpc wizard that's basically the idea
behind modules just to kind of give a
better contrast to the value that
modules have we'll look at the azure
provider so imagine you had to provision
an azure virtual machine this is how
much code you'd have to write so it's
going to vary based on providers so aws
does not require this much work it's
very short uh gcp requires a little bit
more work and for some reason azure
requires a lot so this is a case where
you'd want to use a module so there's a
module called compute and network module
and it reduces the code to amount of
this still a bit long but that's just
what it is okay
[Music]
all right let's talk about the fine line
and this is understanding the gray areas
of responsibility between terraform
infrastructure as code and third-party
configuration management tools like
ansible so there are cases where
when you get outside of aws as your gcp
you might see
providers like for postgres database and
you might say okay well what part of
terraform should be automating it and so
that's a little bit more complicated
question because terraform does more
than one thing so terraform has
providers modules and provisioners and
then on outside of that if we're not
even using terraform we have third party
configuration management tools that we
can use like ansible and the thing is is
that you could have ansible do
everything but that does not mean that
you should have it do everything and
with terraform
more or less most of these levels you
can have them do everything but that
doesn't mean that they should right so
the idea is to try to figure out what
should be where and how to define that
so let's talk about creating a database
so if we created a database that is like
setting up a new service so that is
going to be under the providers
and so you'd use the postgres terraform
provider to set up a database now you
have users and so users are
an entity they're not just like loose
data so there's something you can add
remove add permissions to and we would
treat them as entities and so it
wouldn't necessarily be under the
providers but that's a great place to
put it under modules
okay then you have your data so where
would the data go
well data is not necessarily an entity
it's just a bunch of data so i would say
that that is for provisioners that can
run random scripts and then when we want
to do things like backup tables to data
warehouses or truncate data
daily tables things that are repetitive
tasks that is what we're going to use
ansible for or a third-party
configuration management tool outside of
terraform you wouldn't have terraform do
that stuff at all so when you have a
task done one time to set up the
database like seating data it's going to
go to provisioners when you have
repeatable tasks for ongoing maintenance
it's going to be out as a third party
provider and if you have something that
is like identified as an identity like
as a resource that you want to manage
like asset management
which are these things these are going
to be over here in providers and modules
i do want to point out that a
provisioner can be using ansible but
you'd still want to use ansible or
third-party configuration management
tool uh isolate or separate to do these
kind of things you do not want terraform
running these okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are moving on to our providers
section so we already covered aws but
let's go take a look at some different
ones because i just want you to get a
bit of familiarity with something else
so you understand that there are
different challenges with each one and
how the providers are a little bit
different so let's take a look at azure
first and you're going to need the azure
cli installed so if you do not have that
already go to azure cli and get that
installed
it's going to vary based on your
requirements the other thing is you have
to have an azure account so i'm just
going to go to my portal here
to my sandbox
i guess i haven't logged in in a while
so i'm just going to have to open up
that for azure
hopefully they don't make it too hard on
me here
there we go and i'm in my azure portal
so what i'm going to do here and if i'm
still running ml studio i really got to
shut that down
uh it doesn't look like i am so that's
totally fine okay so anyway
um coming back to
azure what we want to do is make sure
you're on the registry go to providers
go to azure and we're going to grab the
information to configure this
and i have a new folder here called
providers azure so just make a main.tf
and that we're going to paste the
contents there and just make sure you're
in the correct directory so make sure
you're seated into that
and i know because i've done this before
i know that we need to
specify
features empty in here cannot tell you
why i just know that you have to
but there are a lot of different methods
for authenticating with azure some very
easy some very difficult we can use the
cli when we're working in local mode
when it comes to
using terraform cloud the remote version
it's a lot harder we have a lot a lot
more options but we're going to take the
easy route here and use the cli and this
is going to be reliant on us doing the
azure login okay
so
um we have the provider
um i'm not sure why the provider name's
not there i didn't delete it out
i believe it's azure rm so we'll just go
back here and make sure that is correct
so i'm just gonna click click
up here at azure azure rm
okay
and if we scroll on down i think it even
shows you
yeah you have to have it like that okay
so
um
we'll do that and i'll just type in
terraform init
and it doesn't like something i don't
know what happened to the names
we'll just copy it again no biggie
somehow i must have replaced it by
accident
and we'll do features here
and we'll do terraform in it
and one of the easiest things that we
can create in terraform is probably a
resource group if you're not familiar
with the resource groups they're just
kind of like a folder for your resources
so i'm going to go here and make a new
one
let's just say resource so i believe
it's azure
rm underscore resource group
as you can see i've done this a few
times
and i'm just going to say you know my
resource group or i will just say um
providers azure providers terraform
azure providers sure why not
and
we will give that a name
okay and we'll have to give the location
i'm going to do
east us
all right and so that says that has been
successfully initialized and so
um
i can do terraform plan this is not
going to work until i do a login but i
just want to see what it prompts us with
if we attempt to uh
provision this without any credentials
in place
actually to be fair i've probably done
it before so i'm actually just going to
run it because i think it'll just
actually work for me because i might be
i might already have credentials
but what you'd want to do is just do
easy login so i'll type in azlogin
and that's going to authenticate my
machine to azure
so see how it opened up my browser i'm
going to log in
it says you are now logged in you can
close this great
i'm going to close that and if we go
back
um you know we have established a
connection there so
doesn't look like there's any error yep
okay we're all good so now if i was to
do a plan
i don't think it would really throw an
air until we do an apply
see if this will work
while it's going we'll just navigate
over to resource groups
as you can see i have a bunch of junk
resource groups here that i'm not even
using
some point i should clean that up
and
it says we're going to create this
resource group sounds good to me so i'm
going to type terraform apply and just
see if that works
it's a bit nice not having to handle any
it was credentials you know like passing
those along with the cli though of
course once you get into these other
ones it becomes a lot more difficult
um every time i have to set this up i
have to really uh read through this it's
like a lot of work
but i imagine if you're working in azure
every day it's not a big deal but
basically you're just going to be
setting a bunch of these in terraform
cloud okay so you'd have to get your
subscription id tenant id client id
um and it's going to vary based on a few
different uh scenarios there so
anyway what we'll do is make our way
back over here and it says
do you want to perform these actions we
are going to say yes
and it says it has created that resource
so if we make our way over to azure
um and we give this a refresh sometimes
their console is not always up to date
like s aws is so it could be
not showing up here and actually exist
and so
i don't see it yet
and that's terraform for you so i
believe that it does exist that it is
there because it says here
that it has created this here
but yeah the um the azure portal is just
like that it just takes time to update
so i would just say let's assume that we
did create it correctly because it did
say that it made it and we'll wait for
the cash to buy bust or whatever it has
to do to
make this show up here i mean it's also
possible it could have ended up in a
different
tenant or or that but i don't think so
because this is my main one so
let's give this another refresh there it
is see yeah so you just have to wait
again terraform or sorry uh azure's
portal is a lot slower than the bus but
it also does a lot more so i guess
that's kind of a trade-off there anyway
so now that we've have a resource group
probably a great idea to set up a server
i'm going to tell you right now setting
up a virtual machine in azure is
extremely painful um i think that if we
wanted to go take an example and see
like
azure virtual machine
tutorial
for terraform
hashicorp has one
here
and
actually no this is actually just on
microsoft but look at all the stuff just
to set up a single virtual machine like
you have your resource group your
virtual network your subnet your public
ip your network groups your network
interface
like just tons and tons and tons of
stuff so i don't do it this way what i
do is i go to the modules
because that's the easiest way to set it
up for
azure so we'll say oops we'll go
registry
and if we go to modules and we go to
azure
there's one for compute
we just type in compute up here
azure compute
and this is like way way way easier so
we have a linux server a windows server
things like that
we are going to need we have a resource
group but we are going to need our linux
server
because i do not want to spin up a
windows machine
just because uh like linux is just very
inexpensive that's the reason why it's
not because i have an issue with windows
i'm working on a windows machine right
now
uh we'll go ahead and copy the network
in because that is just something we
have to have
and it might be nice to have the output
of the the name of the server so we'll
do that
and we might need to modify this so that
it makes sense because
i named my resource group that so this
one is just called example there so i
might just have to swap that out like
that
and
i really should have just named an
example i would have saved myself a
whole lot of trouble but i did not know
i would have saved time if i did that so
we'll just scroll on up here and i think
that is okay
it's not specifying
what size a server it is and that is
something that is very important to me
because i want it to be inexpensive
so i i know what we have to say it's
called vm size
and a very inexpensive one is standard
uh b21s
okay i remember that for my azure days
making the azure courses
and that will be
very inexpensive and we're not going to
keep it around for very long so it's not
a big deal
and i think that this is correct i'm
just going to double check
this looks all fine to me
so what we'll do is go ahead and see if
this will provision so we'll do
terraform
apply
i actually want to do terraform init
because we've installed a new module
okay and so we can now do terraform
apply
and we'll just review it make sure that
everything is okay and it's happy with
it
yeah i would say that um azure is the
hardest
thing to use with terraform and that's
not terraform's fault that's just the
complexity of azure
um
but you know again that's a trade-off
you know azure can do a lot of things so
you just have to decide
what you want okay so we will type yes
there's way too much to review there and
i'm just going to hope that this
succeeds
and what we'll do
is we'll go
back to the top here and i'm just going
to go over to my virtual machines
and
we'll refresh here so we don't see
anything yet
okay and that is creating
this is going to take a little bit of
time so i'll see you back here in a
moment okay
all right so it looks like i might have
made a spelling mistake or a minor tweak
here so it's saying that uh b b21s is
not valid so what i'm going to do just
to find out what sizes there are and get
the right name i think we can find it
this way here
and if i go to
b1
ls
okay so maybe i just missed the uh the l
in there i'm just going to double check
yeah so i guess i missed that so let's
put the little l in there
okay and let's see if that fixes that
problem hold on here
b1 ls
b2s
okay well sure
whatever it wants right i just wanted to
be cost effective so i mean you might
have to look this up because you know
might be the future and they've
changed change them here um but i
remember this being a valid option
okay well it must be my mistake so
i want just check it one more time b1 ls
i don't trust it so i'm going to copy it
just in case it's a capital i and so
what we'll do is try this again
and maybe we'll have better luck this
time and actually just to save myself
some time i'm going to just do auto
approve
okay and i'll see you here in a bit
alright
okay so after
a little bit of waiting there it looks
like it deployed successfully so we're
gonna go over back to our virtual
machines here and give it a refresh and
there it is so yeah it wasn't too
difficult to get that working um but
yeah hopefully you can just see that
when you want to figure out these
providers here all you have to do again
is go to here
and go to the documentation go to the
first section and that's where the
authentication always is and that's the
hardest part honestly is just getting
beyond that part but you are going to
find different challenges locally and
also with the terraform cloud because
the configuration is different so let's
move on to a
another provider
all right so i actually forgot to
destroy the resources here so i just
kind of cycled back here i was actually
in my gcp
one here a moment ago but i just want to
make sure that you've destroyed your
resources there as well so just type in
terraform
uh destroy
okay
all right and just type in yes
and you're all good to go
[Music]
all right so we just did azure and we've
obviously done it the best so let's go
ahead and do gcp
and using gcp with azure is actually
very nice because google's api is very
concise and so it's not a lot of work to
set up anything there
but authentication is kind of a pain um
again aws still has the easiest method
of authentication just dropping those
keys in not to say that the methods are
bad there's just again kind of a pain to
set up so what we're going to do is grab
our provider information
and
we will have a new folder here i'm
calling this main.tf
and we'll paste it in here as such
okay
um
and
if i remember correctly to configure
this we need a bunch of stuff it's like
credentials and other stuff i'll go back
here and just see what information we
have
and so this is this one's a bit odd
because it doesn't show that maybe it's
under guides
um
configuration reference
we're just looking for the credentials
adding credentials
okay
oh maybe it's under here credentials
yep so this would be the options we want
here i think this is under the provider
because i'm just starting to recognize
the name like credentials projects
region zones these are the things i
remember having to set for it so what
we'll do is go over here and again see
like the documentation's a little bit
harder to get through i mean it's
probably all here it's just a lot of
work to read honestly
um and so i'm gonna do credentials
okay i'm going to do project
i'm going to do region
i'm going to do zone
and i'm likely going to want to do this
in us central 1 because that is
usually what i like to do for
tcp
i believe this is u.s central one there
i'm just making sure i've spelt it right
that doesn't look right to me
and so we'll have to create ourselves a
new project probably so what we'll do
is go over to google cloud
bye bye azure
and
we can create ourselves a new project
probably be a good idea for this
console
and we'll give it a moment here
and i'm going to go over
up here to the top
and
i'm going to i think that was the test
one i did a while back but i'm going to
just say make a new project here
and this one is going to be terraform
gcp
example
and we'll go ahead and create that
it's usually a very very quick
creation in progress
we'll give this a hard refresh here
okay
uh and it is now ready so we'll just
switch over to that project um i need
the project id which is right here so
we'll grab that there
and we'll paste that in there
and now we need credentials
so
i never remember how to do this we'll
say json
credentials gcp i just remember that
it's a json file there's something like
with service accounts and things like
that
so
seems like we'll go here
and
we want to go into
our
gcp one here
and i'm just going to check my app as a
reference
i don't remember being that hard
my server's account
click continue
i do not remember this whatsoever okay
let me just read through here quickly
yeah i do think we have to create a
service account i just don't remember
what rules click the select the role the
role field effects which resources you
want i just want everything okay so
um
i want to be i just i'll be an owner
because that'll give me full access to
everything there and we'll go ahead and
hit continue
uh this is optional so i'm just going to
hit continue here
and so now i am in and so from here what
we can do is go ahead and create
ourselves uh i guess we don't have to
create any things we just have to
download our key
so just looking at this here
um
[Music]
which one is it
i cannot tell
august 18th
that's kind of today um so i think this
is where our key would be
so if we go to manage keys
should be able to
download them here
maybe i can create it ah here we go okay
it's tricky so it just downloaded it
right now
and like this is so hard for me to
remember like i just have a really hard
time with tcp
around permissions and credentials i
don't know why it's my abs brain for you
and so what i want to do is place it in
this folder just to make our lives
really easy
okay and we'll just paste that on in
there
i'm really surprised i can remember all
that okay and but i guess the thing is
once you're set up you just you don't
ever have to think about the stuff again
but every time you have to do it's very
painful okay so our credentials are in
and so this should
work
um
we're gonna need something to provision
so i'm going to go back over to gcp
we'll just say gcp terraform
actually it might be up here
and i want to go back to the
documentation and i believe that was
like it's probably like it always starts
with the name so it's google and their
services compute so it's probably
instance
compute engine
there it is okay
and
we'll just see what kind of examples we
have here might scroll down have
something at the bottom nope the only
example we have here is this
so i'm just going to quickly read
through it and see if it is good for us
to use
um
yeah it looks fine i know that we're
going to need a boot disk
and we're going to need a network
interface
we don't need to scratch this we don't
need all these things so i'm just going
to pair this down okay
so we'll go ahead and grab on all this
stuff
just seems like so much
and i'm gonna go down below
and we do not have to place in a service
account we do not need metadata for this
example
we'll take out the metadata information
the network interface is fine we don't
need to put anything in here
we will have it on the network
as default because it'll save us some
time we do not need to specify the
scratch disk
we definitely need a boot image and
i'm going to go debian 10 for fun i feel
like 10 is probably out
we don't want tags right now it's not a
big deal
is the zone uh it's almost the zone i
want actually i don't think i even need
to specify the zone i think it will just
like pick up on what i have in my
credentials
the machine type i want this to be
inexpensive i believe it's called micro
and we need to give this a name so i'm
just going to say terraform instance
and i'm just going to say like vm
instance up here
and let's give that a go
terraform plan
i'm just hoping that it's going to pick
up that credential file here locally and
i did that all right
okay so what we'll do is scroll up says
no changes objects have changed outside
of terraform well haven't provisioned
anything yet
oh you know what i'm in the wrong folder
okay i always tell you to be in the
right folder and i'm not even the
correct folder myself
so we need to go back a directory
saying like i hadn't provisioned
anything what is it talking about so
we'll do terraform in it to get gcp
installed there
i was very surprised like we weren't
getting errors okay
okay good and so now we'll do a
terraform plan
and while that's going on i'm just going
to bring this up into gcp and make our
way over to compute
okay
and
[Music]
one to add no problems good so we'll do
a terraform apply
auto approve
it has not been used in this project
before oh so we've got to enable it of
course
compute api
well
didn't take me to the right place
that's something i don't like is their
uh
their api jumps around everywhere i
don't want to try it i just want to use
it says it's enabled oh i'm in the wrong
thing
we'll go down here to terraform gcp
example
and now we'll enable it
maybe we just didn't see it because we
were in the wrong project
i like how the search just vanishes here
like that's a great ui choice there
google
okay
you can see like azure really has other
than the fact that it's slow it has a
really really good
uh ui that's someone that likes using
aws for you
um
oh i guess it probably would have
brought us here anyway um so i think
we're just waiting for this to enable
oh maybe the search was here the entire
time okay i was just complaining because
i didn't see it
i don't know why they just wouldn't keep
that expanded all the time though
honestly
i'll hit enable again i'm pretty sure
that it is enabling
this is initializing it is now enabled
sometimes it's better to trust what's
over here as opposed to what's here
so i believe that it's enabled and the
ui is just being a bit slow so i'm going
to go here to auto approve
and what i'll try to do is maybe just
click back here
there's nowhere to go back
i'm just going to click into another one
sometimes that helps
then we'll go back to compute
is this enabled yet
required compute zones get permission
forbidden
well i'm an owner so i should have
everything
okay
at least this is enabled now i'm going
to try this one more time just in case
the permissions were still kind of like
enabling there
okay um
so that's our problem
service accounts
click into that
okay maybe i was creating it in my app
and i was in the wrong place that's
probably what where i was and that's why
i was so mixed up yeah so this is in um
another test account and so when i
created that service account i created
in the wrong place if you made it in the
right account you're not going to have
this problem as i did you can just you
probably aren't even countering this
error
but i am so i will go ahead and manage
keys and we will create ourselves a new
key
sorry about that
and and i mean it makes sense because it
says my app here so clearly i generated
the wrong one
okay we'll drag that one over
yes i understand it's very secure and
i'll go here
and i will copy that
what we'll do here
whoops i don't want that there we will
scroll on down
and delete that
we'll do an auto approve
and i believe that this will work now
we'll have the correct permissions
so yeah i believe it is working now oh
that was fast there we go
and so we'll go back over here and we
will make our way back to compute
vm instances here
and there it is okay
so we can go ahead and do a destroy here
terraform destroy
yes
and we're all done okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at hashicorp
configuration files also known as
terraform files that which contain the
configuration information about
providers and resources
this is basically core to terraform and
that's what we're doing so terraform
files end in the extension of tf or
tf json and we'll talk about the json
case a little bit later but terraform
files are written in the terraform
language and so here is kind of an
abstract way of looking at the language
i know it's confusing here but don't
worry we're going to reiterate on it to
make more sense but terraform language
consists of only a few basic elements
you have blocks and so these are
containers for other content and they
represent an object so i'll have a block
type which can have zero or more labels
and a body you have a block label it's a
name of a block you have arguments which
is uh which is what you assign a value
to a name so notice like we have
assignments so we have identifier to an
expression okay they will appear within
blocks so here it is within a block as
you can see
expressions represent a value either
literally or by referencing and
combining other values they appear as
values for arguments or within other
expressions
you might come across hashicorp
configuration language so hcl and this
is the low-level language for both the
terraform language and alternative
json syntax i don't know if we'll be
getting into it in this course um or if
there's even an easy way to distinguish
it because it's basically terraform
language but just if you see hcl just
think terraform language is the easiest
way to think about it okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at the alternate
json syntax so terraform supports
alternate syntax that is json compatible
terraform expects json syntax files to
be named
tf.json so we mentioned that earlier and
so this is generally what it would look
like okay
the syntax is useful when generating
portions of a configuration
pragmatically since existing json
libraries can be used to prepare the
generate configuration files
and that's pretty much it would you want
to work on this it's up to you
but
yeah so that's the reason for this
alternate syntax
[Music]
all right let's take a look at terraform
settings so the terraform configuration
block type terraform curly braces you'll
see this within your configuration file
is used to configure some behaviors of
terraform itself so here is what it
looks like and what's very common is
you're going to see those required
providers so there are different things
that we can put in here so we can put
the required version so this expects us
to match to a particular version of
terraform required providers this is the
providers that will be pulled during the
terraform init we can also do
experiments here so these are
experimental language features that the
community can try and provide feedback
on and then we have provider metadata so
this is module specific information for
providers okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the
hashicorp configuration language also
known as hcl i'm going to tell you i was
really confused at the start working
with terraform because sometimes they
mentioned things like hashicorp
configuration files hashicorp
configuration language tariff language
and i could not discern you know what
the difference was but so this is the
idea here is to give you that clarity
okay so hcl is an open source toolkit
for creating structured configuration
languages that are both human and
machine friendly for use with command
line tools and it's an open source
project so you can find it at github.com
forward slash hashicorp hcl so the idea
is that they have this baseline language
that you can extend for your own use
case so
terraform is using it and so
it uses a good like it uses the language
itself but then it goes ahead and
extends it by adding additional
functionality for its specific use case
and this hcl based language is not just
for terraform it's used for packer
templates vault policies
boundary controllers and workers console
configuration waypoint application
configuration nomad job specification
and this one isn't a hashicorp product
but this is an open source project
called shipyard and you can use it for
shipyard blueprints surprisingly
sentinel which is a hatchet corp
policy as code
service um does not use hcl but it has
its own hc acl custom language uh but
the idea is that you know we're looking
at mostly uh the use case is for
hashicorp services
but if you wanted to extend this
language for your own use case you
totally could
and so i think that's really cool but
hopefully that kind of distinguishes
between hcl and terraform language okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at input
variables so also known as terraform
variables or just variables are
parameters for terraform modules that is
the way we get data in to our
configuration scripts is via input
variables so you can declare variables
in either the root module or child
modules and the way you define them is
via this variables block there at the
top and just to kind of go over the
possible fields for that block we have
the default option so the default option
which is here is going to be the default
uh variable if you do not set it
for type this is an argument that
specifies the value types that are
accepted for the variable so this case
up here we can see string and this one
is a list
for description this specifies the input
variable's documentation we don't see an
example there i believe that is optional
but it's always great to put a
description in when you can there is a
validation block so a block to define
validation rules usually in addition
addition to type constraints so we don't
see that here on the right hand side but
the idea is that you know this just
makes sure that there's less of a human
error entering the wrong information you
can also have sensitive this limits
terraform ui output when the variable is
used in the configuration and we will
cover sensitive a lot more in this
course outside of just this one slide
okay
let's take a look here at variable
definition files and these allow you to
set the values for multiple variables at
once so variable definition files are
named with the dot tf vars extension or
if you want to use the alternative
syntax it's the
tfvars.json file by default
if you have a file called terraform.tfrs
within your project directory this will
be automatically loaded so it's pretty
common to make that file
to create a
definition file it just uses the
terraform language so you would just
assign
values here you wouldn't make variable
blocks but you just
define these um
identifiers and give them values okay
[Music]
another way of loading input variables
is via environment variables and this is
very common
way of loading them if you have your own
cicd process
for terraform so if you're using
terraform cloud or you're using some
kind of build server that's going to be
the primary way you're going to get
variables
into
those build servers
probably won't be doing this much
locally but the way it works is that
terraform will watch for any environment
variable starting with tf underscore var
underscore followed by the name this is
very important to remember because it
definitely will show up on the exam
so let's say we wanted to set a variable
for an image id so we do tf underscore
var
uh and then image id probably most cases
when you follow the name it's going to
be a lowercase
underscore i don't think you'd probably
want to uppercase that stuff and you
just set the value okay
[Music]
so there's a lot of ways for us to load
input variables we just saw two so we
saw terraform tfrs and environment
variables but there's a lot more caveats
to this so let's just run through them
so we already covered uh terraform.tfrs
the idea here is that if you create this
file and it's in your project it will
automatically be loaded we're running
terraform apply you can name other tfr
files so i just call them these
additional tfr files but they won't be
loaded by default you'll have to use a
command line to load them this is useful
if you have like a dev and prod
environment and you want to swap those
out now if you want to have
files that auto load then you can just
put the dot auto here and give it any
name you want this would be useful if
let's say you had a very large terraform
tfrs file and you wanted to break it up
to make it more human readable
you could do that then you have the
hyphen var file flag when you're doing
tear from apply or
or plan and this is actually how you
load up these additional variable files
if you need to override a single value
you can use hyphen var so here i'm
overriding the ec2 type to be t2 medium
and then lastly here we have environment
variables we cover this this is where it
starts with tf underscore var underscore
followed by the name and this is going
to be very common when you are using
code build servers or runtimes to run
this in a ci cd automated way now
there's a presence to which these get
loaded meaning that uh
that certain configurations of vari or
input of variables will override other
ones so as we go down this list these
ones will override the previous one so
at the top you have environment
variables if you have a terraform tfrs
file that will override the environment
variables
if you have the json one that will
override that one if you have auto files
that will override the default
tfrs file and then on the last list you
have hyphen var and hyphen var file will
override the rest so there you go in
terms of the exam they're not going to
ask you the precedence here but you're
going to need to know what var var file
are environment variables are in this
default one okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
output values which are computed values
after a terraform apply is performed
output values allow you to obtain
information after resource provisioning
such as a public ip address output a
file of values for chromatic integration
cross reference stacks via outputs in a
state file via terraform remote state
and so here's an example of an outputs
block so notice that there's a block and
you specify some stuff there you can
optionally provide a description it's
not necessary but generally with outputs
i would recommend putting that in there
you can also mark it as sensitive so it
does not show in your terminal this is
important if you're doing like logging
stuff you don't want to compromise those
values there but understand that
output values um
even though they might not be outputted
to your terminal or sd out
they will be visible within the state
file so if somebody opens up the state
file they're going to be plainly visible
there so just understand that sensitive
does not protect the values there okay
now in terms of how we would use the cli
with output values
if we type terraform output it's just
going to print out all the values that
are within the state file i don't show
this in the example here but if you
wanted to use a um
a like
bash command to
parse json you could extract them out
and see they're just plainly in the json
okay if you need to get exactly
a particular field you type in terraform
output and then followed by the name if
you want it in a json format all the
output then you could give that flag i
don't know if it would work with this
one i actually didn't test i just
thought about that here for this one
here
if you want the raw output of it meaning
like if you output a string and you want
it to be escaped or what have you then
you could use it pragmatically by
passing it to something like curl to do
something but the idea with all these
output values is that it's one way of
inspecting but you could also use this
in a configuration script or or
something to do kind of like an after
action okay
[Music]
all right so we're taking a look at
local values also known as locals that
assigns a name to an expression so you
can use it multiple times within a
module without repeating it so here what
we're going to do is define our local
block up here and then the idea is that
we're assigning these names or ids
expressions or values so that we can
reuse them throughout our code
notice that we can define multiple local
blocks in the same file
and i just say this because like when
you use required providers you're only
allowed to have a single block but this
case like with variables or locals you
can have many
and you can even nest them within each
other so notice down here we're
referencing local within a local so
that's totally possible and i imagine
it's in the order to which
it is specified we can do static values
or computed values so we can actually
here's a function write an expression
and then it'll output a value
once a local value is declared you can
reference it via the dot as local dot
the name so here notice within our abuse
resource we have local and common tags i
have to point this out but when you're
referencing you use the singular local
because you might get an exam question
which shows you local dot or locals dot
and
the trick here is you got to remember
which one it is locals help
can help dry up your code it is best
practice to use local sparingly since
it's in terraform it's intended to be
declarative and overuse of locals can
make it difficult to determine what the
code is doing this all comes back to
describing terraform as declarative plus
where they give you functionality that's
imperative like but the idea is that uh
you know if you overuse these you can
run into trouble okay
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we are taking a look at data sources for
terraform so the idea here is you want
information defined outside of terraform
and stuff defined by another separate
terraform configuration or modified by
functions so the idea here is we are
going to define ourselves a data block
and we have an external resource we're
looking for so we're saying hey i want
to see if i have an aws ami we're going
to use these filters as a way of kind of
selecting it within our aws account so
we'd have a provider set up and so it'd
be looking within that account to find
it and it's even saying look for the
most recent ami okay
and once we
have
found that data source we can just
reference it so notice we're using data
to reference it there so data aws ami
dot web id
so there you go
[Music]
we're taking a look here at name values
and these are built-in expressions that
reference uh various values you'll find
your configuration scripts we do cover
these in their respective sections but i
wanted to consolidate them here in one
place just so that you get a second
chance to reinforce this information
because crux of questions on exam could
be based on knowing how the name values
work so let's go through them the first
is resources i'm going to get up my pen
tool here and so the way resources work
is that you start with the resource type
so adabus instance and then you're going
to do the name of it so there's nothing
that
starts before the left-hand side of it
so just remember it just starts with
that resource type then you have input
variables and that starts with var
period so that's the singular var then
we have local values and again that's
singular so local period for child
modules it starts with module period
again singular for data sources it's
going to be data singular just remember
singular because they can have a match
up on the on the exam questions where
it'll be like data or data
for file system and workspace info we
have path.module this is the path of
module where the expression is placed we
have path dot root this is the path of
the root module of the configuration we
have path cwd this is the path of the
current working directory and in
practice
the default cwd is the same as the route
so those would be technically the same
we have terraform dot workspace this is
the name of the currently selected
workspace then we have block local
values these are things that appear
within a body of a blocks so this could
be within a resource provisioners things
like that so we have if we're using the
count meta argument we're going to get
count and with that we'll have count dot
index so we can say okay this is the
uh fourth iteration of you know uh this
this count loop um then we have for each
and this allows us to have the key and
the value so we can access that during
our iterations we have self so selfless
uh references information within
provisioners or connections
so it's just like a self-referencing
thing name values resemble the attribute
notation of map or object values but are
not objects and do not act as objects
you cannot use square brackets to access
attributes of name values like an object
so there you go
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we are going to be learning all about
variables and outputs so let's get to it
here uh and
the first thing we're going to do is
create ourselves a new folder and just
so you know that these file names might
change because i have yet to actually
publish this as i'm creating this course
so you know if this one isn't 0 4 0
because i just decided not to do the
terraform registry one because i'm doing
it later that you know the numbers might
be different okay but in the course i
will link up the correct repos if you're
trying to find them what we'll do is
type in main.tf
and we just need to provision something
so we'll probably go back all the way to
our getting started one and try to grab
something from there
so i will go and grab this aws instance
here
and we will also grab its outputs
because that's probably a good idea
and we will go and grab its provider
here
all right and we will also go ahead and
grab a variable because we're all
learning about variables so we're gonna
have to have some kind of setting here
and we also need our terraform
configuration block so i think that's in
my main
and we will go ahead and grab that so
we'll go to the top here
paste that in
okay this looks all good to me actually
we're just going to use a local backend
for this to make our lives a lot easier
and we don't need tags i'll just remove
that for the time being
and so this should be good enough
yeah i'm happy with this so what we'll
do is go ahead and deploy this instance
but actually this is all about learning
again about
uh variables right so we said that
there's a lot of different ways to
inject them so we did we have the
terraform.tf vars
and other ones like that so let's just
go down the road or go down each one and
see
if we can learn how to do all these okay
so the first one is going to be
terraform dot t f bars
and then here we're just going to
specify the instance type
that's going to be a t2 micro
put that in double quotations
and we'll go ahead and type in terraform
uh plan
and just see if that gets populated
oh we have to do terraform in it first
we also don't even need to deploy this
infrastructure because
we're going to just be able to um
run terraform plan if it's populated
then we know that it's working as
expected right
and while that's going on i'm just going
to go to the documentation here and
we're just going to pull up
terraform variables
because i'm pretty sure it's just
straight here in the documentation it
talks about all the different ways
there's like a list when they talk about
the um
uh the variable definition files
download are down here so they kind of
mention all the different use cases
there and i mentioned that obviously in
the course
um but we'll just go and now do a
terraform plan
and so what i want to see is it's going
to use a t2 micro here so if we scroll
on up
we can see that it says t2 micro so it's
loading that from our terraform tfr it's
just to prove that it is i'm just going
to write a nano
and we're going to go down below and run
terraform plan
and if we scroll up
we can see now it's a nano so
let's say we didn't have a terraform
vars file we had something that is just
anything we call it um
variables
or how about just vars to make our lives
a bit easier so let's just say vars.tfrs
and if we do terraform plan
is it going to autoload that file no see
how it's prompting us because if it
doesn't have the word auto in it it
doesn't know to load it so what we'd
have to do here
is we'd have to do terraform plan
var file and then say vars
dot tfrs
and so now it should load that file
okay we're gonna scroll up see if it's
nano
it is good i'm just gonna go change this
to a medium for fun
so let's say we we didn't want to have
to always do that hyphen var file
because we always want this to be loaded
because it's just an additional file
what we can do is put the word auto in
it
all right and so now if we do terraform
plan it should just pick that up
okay we're going to go ahead and scroll
up
and we can see we have that t2 medium
okay
so
let's say we just wanted to input it
from the uh the api here so i'm just
going to rename this here
or from the cli so what we can do is
type in var
uh instance type
equals
t2 nano
and so if we scroll up here
this should be t2 now so
yeah it's pretty much all the variants
that we need to explore but also notice
that there is uh
an order of presidents right so this is
the order that will load in and later
sources taking precedence over the
earlier ones so the later it is the more
likely it's going to override it so what
i'm going to do
is i'm going to create myself a
[Music]
um
new file here and we're going to say
terraform
dot tf vars
so i just want to show how that plays
out
and we'll have our
vars.tfrs file which is fine
actually we'll do the auto
okay
and so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to start off small
so this is going to be
instance type
equals
nano
and then this one here is going to be a
micro
and so i want to see what happens if i
run terraform plan is it going to
take
this one or that one right
and we're going to scroll up and we can
see that it's a t2 micro
so it's taking the one from the auto
file because
it's second president's right so this
one has priority over this one
and then if we want to uh override that
there we could do
um hyphen var and say
instance type
equals t2 medium
and so that should override those there
and we'll scroll up and see we can see
there's a t2 medium so that's pretty
much all we really need to explore in
this one here
and so we'll just move on to something
like outputs okay
[Music]
you know what i thought about it and i
think that maybe what i should do before
we move on to outputs is actually just
look at how we define these variables
here and some of the additional options
so here we have variable instance type
and we specified it as a string of
course there are different types but
there's a few other things that we can
do we can provide a description
okay
so we'll say
the size of the instance
i've never really noticed where the
descriptions show up i'm assuming that
if you were to run this without any kind
of like terraform bars or anything so
what i'm going to do here is just go
ahead and delete this file here
and delete the auto file here
and i think that if we were to run it
the prompt would show up there so i'll
just clear that out
i just want to see where it shows up
yeah so it shows the description there
okay
there are some other options so i
believe we can do sensitive
i think it's just sensitive true
here yep
so we can do sensitive
i'm not the best at spelling so i'm just
going to put that off screen so i can
see what i'm doing
it will say true and what that should do
is it should obscure
it should obscure the actual
value here so if i type in
t2.micro
and hit enter
it should obscure it in the plan
if we scroll up here
so notice it's sensitive so when you're
inputting it doesn't hide it i'm
actually kind of surprised that they
don't kind of blank that out as you're
typing it in
um but this is the only place that it's
going to hide it and the thing that you
need to understand is that just because
it's there does not mean it's going to
be hidden in the terraform state file so
what i'm going to do
is i'm actually going to go ahead and
deploy this
because i just want to show you
that it's visible in the terraform state
file so we'll say t2
micro here
and i believe it's already created the
state file
you know it's still empty so i'll have
to wait a little bit
but while that is going on we'll look at
something else like validation
i don't really play with validation much
but i'm sure we can figure it out in two
seconds so valid validation just make
sure that
the input is as you expect it to be
so if we go here
and
we need to give it a condition
and so can is a built-in function so i
assume it's going to just be true or
false we probably should go look that up
so we go like built-in uh functions
terraform can
which is right here
so can evaluates the given expression
returns a billion indicating whether the
expression produced a results without
errors
okay so that sounds pretty good to me so
we'll go back over here
to our
file here and so we have can
and
in the input variables we have
regex and that's probably what i'll use
here just to make things a little bit
easier
and so what i want to do is i want this
to be a t2
or we even say t3 here so regex expects
this to be a t3
and i don't need the second parameter
here so i can just take that out and
make this a period here
t3 is just another line of adabus
instances
instance must be a t3
type
ec2 ec2 uh instance
okay and so notice this finished and we
were seeing if the sensitive would show
the um the size of the instance within
the file here or would it be sensitive
so we'll say instance type and so notice
that sensitive does not obscure it in
the terraform state file i'm going to go
ahead and just uh destroy that so say
terraform
actually uh we don't have to do that
just yet let's go ahead and actually
test our validation here and see if we
got it right
so what i'm going to do
is just do terraform plan again
and i'm going to take out the sensitive
option here
terraform plan
and so the condition for the variable
must refer to var instance type in order
for the incoming tests so i guess we do
have to specify a second parameter here
um the condition for the variable
instances must refer to var instance
type
okay
so i think it just probably wants it as
the second parameter
because we did see that a moment ago
right
you would think that it would just like
infer it because it's already there eh
um the validation error message must be
at least one full sentence starting with
an uppercase letter ending with a period
wow
grammar police
your given message will be included as
part of the larger terraform error
message written as english prose i guess
like if you're publishing your module
and they want you to do it properly
right so i guess that's a good way of
enforcing good practices there and so
i'm going to try t2 micro and i'm hoping
that my validation works
and it's here it says that it must be a
t3 type and so
that that's where that error is working
uh so we're all done here i'm just going
to go ahead and do a terraform destroy
or actually i'll do it apply because i
just like it to happen right away so
we'll say destroy
auto approve
okay
and we'll go off screen here and i'm
just checking if there's anything else
of interest that's pretty much it for
the variables so we'll move on to the um
actually you know what i want to keep
this instance up and running because
we're going to use it for outputs okay
so um i think that's all good for now
i'm going to switch this over to t2
so that it stops complaining
okay and we'll look at the output cli
[Music]
all right so let's take a look at other
things we can do with the outputs here
so i'm going to go and type in terraform
outputs cli
there's nothing super complicated here
but i just want to go through some of
these options with you okay
so
we'll go back here to
our terraform here and we should have
for output so i want to show you
terraform
output and that will output all of your
um
your
defined outputs then we can provide its
name so we can say public ip
and that will give us an individual one
you can give it a raw command and this
is really useful when you are
doing something like ssh or you want to
pipe it to another command you saw us do
this earlier when we did ssh so we did
ssh and then we gave it some kind of
address and then we did this
dollar sign parentheses and that's
actually part of the bash language and
so that was great so that we were able
to directly interpret it and we had to
use the raw so it was escaped as double
quotations
right uh let's see if there's anything
all sets of interest um you could say no
color json is something i did not show
you before so let's give that a go
so we'll just go back
and say json
okay and that could be really useful if
you wanted to parse that there is a um
there's a uh
a bash
library called i think it's like jy or
jq it's for parsing json so you could
use it with that like uh jq library
nope
jy
nope parsing json um parsing json bash
maybe it's like jq
yeah it's jq
so i think i might have this installed
here jq
and so this is a very useful tool if you
want to
parse out stuff here so what we could do
here is we could say json and make a
pipe and then say jq maybe period i'm
not sure what that would give us
probably everything
but if we wanted to just grab the name
see which is like hyphen r we could try
that
so we could try hyphen r
type
okay
or
oh so he has like a little period there
so maybe
we need to do this
i mean i've used jq in the past it's
just like i never remember how it works
so
maybe we do man.jq here might give us
some examples
that's not very helpful
so i could say like
jq examples
so
i know period will get us the start of
it
here we have fruit
period accessing properties
okay so i think what we need to do here
is
do public ip
like that
and yeah it returns a string and so we
can do value
okay and so the jq's pretty commonly
installed a lot a lot of instances so
that's something that you might find uh
that you might want to select things
here right
okay
um but yeah that's pretty much uh it for
outputs and we'll move on to the next
part here okay
actually again i probably should talk
about some of the output options here
and show those to you as well
because there are some things we can do
so i believe we can set sensitive as
well
so just want to
go and type in
terraform outputs here
i cannot type well today
and we can give it a description and we
can set it as sensitive so that's
something that we should give give a try
here and see what that does
sensitive
equals true
okay
and
i think that if we do terraform output i
wonder if we'll have to do a refresh on
this for that to work
great so it's still showing it and i
want it to be sensitive so i'm going to
do terraform refresh or actually again
it's terraform apply
um
refresh only
oh it's asking for the type again t2
micro
and so refreshing state allows us not to
have to reprovision it right so would
you like to update the terraform to
reflect the detected changes
um
yeah i'm fine with that yes
i think because we had tags before on
that resource possibly so now see that
it says it as sensitive okay so what
we'll do here is type in terraform
output
and so now it does not show us what it
is
so yeah there you go
[Music]
all right so now in this follow along
what we're going to do is learn about
chaining outputs from a sub module
because this is something that uh really
shows up a lot in the exam and so
even though we're not into the module
section of our follow alongs we have to
kind of learn how to create a module
or a sub module i should say so what
we're going to do here is create
ourselves a new folder and i think that
it generally likes it if you call them
sub modules you could technically name
the folder whatever you want
but that's what i'm going to call it and
within there i'm going to make a new
file and i'm going to call it main.tf
and so what we can do is take any of our
code that we like and throw it into that
module
i'm going to
[Music]
grab the
instance here and actually while this is
going i just want to go ahead and
destroy our instance here
um that we were running before oops
destroy
auto approve here
and
yeah t2 micro and it's because i
it wants it every time even on a destroy
which is totally fine but anyway so what
i'm going to do
is i'm going to grab our instance and
we're going to really end up with
basically nothing in this file here
but i'm going to go and
um
go into the sub module here and
basically grab everything okay
and we're going to go ahead and paste
that in there
and so basically this specifies
everything that we want but we need to
pass we want to get these outputs and
reference them in our main tf here so
the way we're going to do that is we
don't have these resources here anymore
so i can just take these out and i can
take this out here
and what i can do is i can just say
module
and i'm going to say
aws
server
and i'm going to then specify the source
so the source is going to be in sub
modules
and we'll do
forward slash forward slash here
and probably it would have made more
sense if i named this something like aws
so i'll just say like database server
i've already changed my mind
okay because it didn't make sense like i
had to make some modules maybe folders
within that and i just didn't really
want to move all that around
and so if we want to reference this one
here it's going to start with module and
then the name of the module here
and then the resource
and so that should uh get us that value
i'm just going to go ahead and hit
sensitive and so i believe that this
should work
so we'll do a terraform plan here
the module is not yet installed so we'll
do terraform net fair enough
great and so we'll do a terraform plan
and we'll see
if that's going to work now we
technically have to give that module an
input and so see it's expecting that
input to have instance type so what
we'll have to do here
is specify instance type
and i guess we'll just try t2
t2 micro here
let's see if it likes that
so we have another issue here
unsupported attribute
in the output
module aws server aws instance my server
is a object known after apply this
object does not have an attribute
named aws instance
um i think i might need to specify
oh sorry we just want the outputs so
this is actually we don't want to
reference it this way we just want to
get whatever the outputs is so we just
do outputs here okay
because it we can't access the aws
instance that way it just doesn't make
sense
so we'll go ahead and hit apply again
here
and so here it says
object does not have that maybe it's
just output
and that doesn't work so just give me a
second i'll be back okay all right so i
pulled up the documentation and here it
says you know i don't need to put the
word output or outputs i don't know why
i thought i had to do that and so i
should just be able to do this
so let's see if that works here
see if we're in good shape
okay so to reduce risk of accidentally
exporting sensitive data that was
intended terraform requires that any
root module output contain sensitive
data be explicitly marked as sensitive
if you do intend so
it's not our intention to
mark it as sensitive so i'm going to say
sensitive false
this is line nine
so
let's run that again
not sure if it's in our other one here i
don't think so because it's line 28 eh
oh sorry okay so we had we had it in the
other one so we'll just take it out
okay and we will run that there
cool and so let's go ahead and just
deploy that to make sure our sub module
works
terraform uh apply auto approve
but yeah throughout the course you'll
you'll see that we're going to be
repeating some things because you know
it's impossible to show you chaining
outputs without covering how to build
out sub modules but we'll just have to
do some variants
down the road there but i just want to
make sure that this works as expected
and that we get an output
so i'll see you back here when it's done
deploying okay
all right so after a short little wait
there you can see that uh we have our
public ip address and so that is coming
from our sub module so that's all in
good shape there so what we can do
is go ahead and just start to store this
instance i'm just going to double check
to see if the next tutorial
requires it we technically covered local
values earlier but i guess we could
cover them again
um so yeah i'm going to go ahead and
just
destroy that instance
so we'll just say apply
destroy
auto approve
um
gotta type it right
two piece
there we go okay great i'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
all right let's go take a look at local
values again i know we covered this in
the getting started but it helps to do
things more than once
and since we've had an opportunity to go
through the documentation we understand
there's a few extra things that we can
do with it
um like nesting things in or be able to
find them twice
things like that
but there's really not a lot to do that
is new here so we're just going to go
through the motions of it again just so
that it's part of our memory so remember
we've made this into a sub module here
and so this is probably the best place
to do a local's value and it's not
complicated at all so we're just going
to do locals
and we could use this to abstract a few
different things so that's the variable
i'm going to go up here one second
and uh we'll do this for the instance
here
oops
locals
okay we could say ami
this is probably not what you'd use it
for but you know we just have to have
some kind of use case for this
so local.ami right
and uh i'm not sure if you can do this
let's see what happens if we do
can we do var instance type
kind of would be kind of redundant to do
that but let's just do it anyway
and what i want to do is a terraform
plan
you know the key thing to remember is
that when we're defining the block it's
called locals we probably don't use an
equals here
um and it's the uh the singular when we
are referencing it okay
so just scroll up and see if that is
correct
yep everything is working as expected i
was going to pull that out because this
really doesn't serve much purpose
but again we just had to go through that
um just so that you remember how it
works okay
so i'm just removing that out of our
code
okay and there we go
[Music]
all right so we're going to be looking
at data sources now we did experience
creating our own data source in the
getting started when we referenced an
aws vpc and so data
data sources are resources that already
exist that you want to reference
in your code and so a good example would
be using it
ami the amazon machine image to change
what is being served so if we were to go
into our server here it's using this
particular ami but we could totally use
a data source
for that and so anytime you're looking
for something you would just type in
uh you know edibus ami data source and
you'll get some examples here and notice
that we have some interesting options
like filter and stuff like that these
are not available to every single um
i might have actually have to update my
lecture content because i might have
highlighted this as a global feature but
i realized that this filter option here
is actually reflecting what is in the
aws cli so i i originally had thought
that this was part of the language but
apparently it's just a reflection of
this because if you look up something
like an rds instance
okay and you say data source
and you go here
this one doesn't have a filter option or
at least i don't think it does i'm gonna
type in filter
right or if we were to go over to google
so we'd say like google compute
and we would say data source
terraform
maybe even a project doesn't really
matter notice it doesn't have a filter
option so i just want to
clarify here that this filter option
really is particular database because
that's what their cli supports and
that's being reflected by
terraform okay but let's say we want to
reference a different kind of instance
and so i was looking here and this is
kind of an example where they are
they are selecting an ubuntu instance
and so that's something that we could do
to
select something there
notice that the owner is not ourselves
here so if you go over here
notice we have self and so this is an
account id for aws and this is a
particular version of ubuntu so if i go
ahead and grab this here
uh and what we'll do whoops
the one thing i don't know is that this
instance like what um
what region it's in because a bus you
have to launch your amis in the same
region but what we can do is paste this
on in here and just notice that i'm just
under the instance documentation here
okay
and so
it's very important to get something
that is
again in the same
region but
we're not specifying the ami image it's
going to filter and find it so i think
what it's going to do
is based on any region it will find it
there okay so here i can just go data
dot adabus ami
and we just choose the id and that
should
work
okay so we'll just type in clear and
we'll say terraform plan
all right so a data resource aws ami has
not been declared in your module
aws server
so let's just take a look here
it is defined right here
maybe we aren't giving it the right
thing here
i'm looking for the thing that we can
reference so id is set to the id found
in the ami in addition the following
attributes are expected the arn
so i'm pretty sure yeah it was the id
that we wanted
okay it says the data source aws my id
has not been declared in the module
dot aws
server
okay i have not seen this error before
because we're working in a sub module
it's not really any explanation so when
in doubt what i'm going to do is do a
terraform in it and see if that resolves
that issue
okay and we'll just try this again
and it still doesn't like it
oh i also have a name so i guess i have
to provide that as well so that's
probably my mistake right there
okay
there we go and so what i want to do is
just scroll up and see if it selected an
ami from aws so notice that it's pulling
this one here and that's going to be for
the relevant region
again i don't want to provision this
because
i don't
but
you know i just wanted to show you that
that's how you use data source and i
really want to emphasize that this
filter option that you see here is
particularly to aws and the options are
going to vary based on how you can
select stuff and not everything is
available you have to uh google each one
and see what uh resources you can pull
in for data sources okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at resource
meta arguments so the terraform language
defines several meta arguments which can
be used with any resource type to change
the behavior of resources and so we'll
quickly go through the list here and
then we'll deep dive on each so the
first is depends on so this is for
specifying explicit dependencies we have
count which is for creating multiple
resource instances according to account
we have four each which is used to
create multiple instances according to a
map or set of strings provider so this
is for selecting a non-default provider
configuration lifecycle this is for
lifecycle customizations provisioner
this is and also for connections for
taking extra actions after resource
creation so there's the quick list now
let's jump into them
[Music]
all right the first resource meta
argument we want to look at here is
called depends on and this is the order
of which resources are provisioned and
is important when resources depend on
others before they are provisioned
terraform implicitly can determine the
order of provision of resources but
there may be some cases where it cannot
be determined or like the correct order
so this is where you can be a bit more
explicit so here we have some terraform
configuration where we have an ibus
instance and it relies on a policy and
so what we're doing is we're setting an
explicit depends on here so that it
knows that it requires that now in a
normal use case you would not have to do
this but it's hard to find use cases
where this happens but when it does
become a problem you'll know because
your resources will not provision
correctly you'll get an error so there
you go
[Music]
let's take a look here at the account
resource meta argument and this is when
you are managing a pool of objects so an
example here would be a fleet of virtual
machines where you want to use count
so here on the right hand side we have
an example of us using that in terraform
so we can specify the amount of
instances we want so here it is for and
then we'll have access to this name
value called count.index so
the tags will start at zero so it'll be
server 0 1 2 and 3.
then just down below here i just want to
show you that with count you can accept
a numeric expression so you know if you
had a variable that you had set as the
subnet ids or even just an arbitrary
number like you want to have x amount of
servers
this would allow you to do that okay but
just so you know those numbers must be
whole and a number must be known before
the configuration which you'd put in
your input variables okay
[Music]
all right so let's take a look here at
4-h which is for iterating over resource
meta arguments but it's slightly
different because it allows you to map
over dynamic values giving you a little
bit more flexibility so here's an
example of us defining a4 each and
notice that we have defined a map
sometimes i call it an object because
they're so similar but this is a map
and the idea is that once you have your
a map defined with your 4-h you will now
have access to these name values so you
could do each dot key or each dot value
to extract that out
um you can also just use it like with an
array so here we have an array and then
we use two set to turn it into a set
which it will accept as well
and then we can just pull out the key
because there will be no value so just
an example of with a map and then with
something that looks like an array okay
[Music]
to understand the resource meta-argument
life cycle we need to understand how
resource behavior works and so when you
execute your execution order via
terraform apply it will perform one of
the following to a resource so the most
common one you'll see is a create
so these are resources that exist in the
configuration but are not associated
with a real infrastructure object in the
state the way you can tell it's creating
it will have this nice little green plus
sign
the next one is destroy so resources
that exist in the state but no longer
exist in the configuration and so that's
going to tear down your resources out of
your cloud providers this is represented
by a minus symbol then you have update
and place so the resources who arguments
have changed so the idea here is that if
you have a virtual machine and let's say
you change the size of it it's not going
to destroy it it's just going to modify
its settings this is represented with a
tilde and the last one here is destroy
and recreate so resources who arguments
have changed but uh which cannot be
updated in place due to remote api
limitations so there are just some cloud
resources that always require destroy
and recreate and this is something very
easy to trigger if you are using
the replace command or
the older terraform tank command in
order to
replace a degraded or damaged instance
so let's talk about
life cycle so life cycle blocks allow
you to change what happens to resources
on the create update and destroy
lifecycle blocks are nested within
resources so here is a resource uh which
is just an azure resource group and
within it we have a life cycle block and
we're setting our first option here
that's possible called the crate before
destroy so this is a boolean and when
replacing a resource first create the
new resource before deleting it so the
default is destroyed old first so this
is more about just the order of how it's
destroyed prevent destroy so ensures a
resource is not destroyed then we have
ignore changes uh and this is based off
a list of attributes that you feed to it
so don't change the resource on create
update destroy if a change occurs for
the listed attributes so maybe um
maybe you uh you're just changing your
tag and you say don't don't change uh
like don't tear down create or do
anything strange if we change a tag okay
so there you go that's uh life cycles
[Music]
so we're looking at our last meta
argument here which are resource
providers and this goes along with the
idea of an alias so here we are defining
ourselves a provider in google cloud but
there's a case where we might need to
override the provider
at a at a per resource level the way we
do that is by creating an additional
provider and setting an alias and then
here we could change something like the
region and then once we have that set we
can then reference our provider
explicitly under a resource
and so that's all there is to it
definitely on your exam you will see a
question about alias or you'll see that
example so definitely want to know how
to do that
[Music]
okay hey it's andrew brown from exam pro
and in this follow along we're going to
be covering all the different types of
meta arguments okay so what i'm going to
do is just cd into the directory i
created for our first one right that
arguments depends on and we're going to
take a look at this as always we're
going to create ourselves a new main.tf
file as soon as i can find
the correct folder here so we'll say
main.tf
and i'm just going to go to my variable
outputs and just grab some existing code
to save myself some time i think
everything is self-contained into this
subdirectory here so i'm just going to
go ahead and grab that there
and i'm just going to take out some of
the code that i do not need
um
so we have an instance type which is
fine
um
we don't have
we don't need that
we don't need validation we don't need
to put the description in there
we have this big old one here
for the ami
and what i'm going to do here is i just
want to
specify an ami manually just to make our
lives a bit easier so i'm here
and i'm just going to go and launch a
new instance not for real but i just
want to go ahead and grab this id here
and what we will do
is go back here and paste that on in
and i'm just going to hard code hard
code the instance type t2 micro
oops
and i'm going to scroll up take out this
instance type variable
okay so then we get a very small file
makes our life a lot easier
and so as always we need to do our
terraform init
that's going to initialize our back end
there
and we saw it depends on earlier it
wasn't super complicated how it worked
it was just that if you wanted something
to be wait for the creation of something
before you do something else that's what
it would do so i think in this case what
we should do is make an s3 bucket so
we'll say and i've got some old tabs
here so just close these out
and we'll just say like uh aws s3 bucket
terraform
and these aren't really related in terms
of their use cases but just the fact
that we can set this on anything so what
i'm going to do is go ahead and grab
myself
this code
here and
i'm not sure how that happens just close
that out there
and so i'm just going to go ahead
and paste in
this s3 bucket here
and this is like having a unique name so
you have to provide something that is um
well i guess we can just call this
bucket but here this is like having a
domain name so i would strongly
recommend to be very unique here so i'm
just gonna pound in a bunch of numbers
and just say
um
depends on
because i don't want anyone to be using
that
i don't need to private i don't need to
set any tags and that should be enough
but what i want to say is that i want
the bucket to only be created
after the aws instance is created okay
so if i go here and put depends on
okay
and then we say aws instance
my server
so now it has to wait for the server to
be provisioned before the provisions of
the terraform are the aws bucket there
so we'll go terraform plan
and if we just expand this a bit
we'll see that it will
create our instance
and then our server you know i'm
actually curious is what would happen if
i was to take this
and
paste it here
with the order change in the plan would
it actually show in order of creation or
is it just saying these are all the
resources and what we're actually going
to see is after the fact like what order
we'll create it in
so i go here
okay so
i guess it doesn't really matter it's
just the order that it appears in or
not necessarily just
all right i'm just curious about that so
what we'll do is we'll go ahead and say
terraform apply
auto approve
and we'll let that go ahead and
provision
and so if we go over to our adabus
account here
and we go over to s3
okay and you'll notice that it's not
creating the bucket as of yet and as we
watch our input here notice that it's
creating the adabus instance first right
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
wait for this to finish and then i'll
see you back here okay
okay after a short little wait we can
see that equator our instance first and
then our s3 bucket
okay so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to tear this all down
and hopefully it tears down to a problem
but we'll say tear down or sorry
terraform
uh apply
destroy
auto approve again if you uh find that
too much to type you can always just
type in terraform destroy and then
confirm the plan but i like to do this
all in one go and so i'll see you back
here in a moment once everything is
destroyed okay
all right so after a short little wait
there our server has been destroyed our
bucket has been destroyed so now what we
want to see is if we were to take the
depends on
and we are to move it um down below here
we're obviously gonna have to change
this because we can't self-reference
ourself or we're gonna be an infinite
loop but we'll paste that in there and
call this whoops
we'll call this uh a
bucket here
and so what should happen is uh when it
does the terraform
apply it should try to create the bucket
first and then the instance and we'll
know that by the output here so it
doesn't like what i typed in this um
because i guess it didn't take what i
typed
so we'll just scroll up here
paste that in oops
copy and paste when you're in the mode
and vs code is terrible okay we'll hit
up
and so now what we should see is the s3
bucket being created first okay
so see that the s3 bucket is being
created first and then it's going to
create the instance i'll see you when
this is done creating uh and then we'll
just tear it down okay
all right so that's done there and so
let's go ahead and just tear that down
because we're all done with it and i'm
doing destroy auto approve so that's
just going to automate that process
and uh you know then i'll see you into
the next follow along okay so see you
there
[Music]
all right so we are on to learning about
the meta argument called count so this
one is pretty simple the idea is that we
are going to provide a thing that says
count here and that's going to create
additional number of servers okay so
what we will do is we will go to our
depends on here code that we were just
working on i'm going to copy it and i'm
going to paste it into a new file here
called main.tf in this new folder
and there's a few things we don't need
we don't need this s3 bucket whoops i
don't know what i keep on pressing to do
that probably the side here but we'll
take this out and we'll take out our
depends on and so what we're going to do
is specify a count i want two instances
and we are going to also make sure that
we name this so we know which server
we're looking at
and we're going to say server
we'll do interpolation and we'll do
count.index
and so that should be good
and
what we'll have to do is just do one or
zero to get that public ip address so
what we'll do now is go ahead and switch
folders it's very important make sure
you're in the right folder
i do that all the time where i'm in the
wrong folder here whoops so we'll do 0 5
1 for mine again it might be different
if i update
the numbers when i do publish this
course
we'll do terraform init as always
and then once that is done and that
should not take too long we'll do
ourselves a terraform apply and we will
carefully look to see if it's actually
going to provision two instances okay
so this shouldn't take too long the unit
just depends on how much work it has to
do to fetch that information
great so now what we can do is do a
terraform apply and i'm just going to
expand this up here so that we have a
better opportunity to look at it
apparently i've introduced an error so
maybe it's tags or tags
so we'll try that
i think they show it here on the page so
yeah it's with it's plural okay
and so what i want to do is just make
sure that we're going to have two
instances so we'll scroll all the way to
the top here it says server one
server zero so it is doing that so
that's pretty good so we'll type in yes
and that's going to go ahead and create
those two instances so i'll see you back
here when it's done okay
all right so after a little wait there
um both of our instances have created so
what i'm going to do is make my way over
to our ec2 console here give it a
refresh and i want to see that there are
two servers running notice one is zero
and one is one
and i want to show you our outputs
because in our outputs we said that we
wanted the uh instance that is index one
so that's server one here and its public
ip address is 54 242 81 205
and so that is what we get there and so
that's pretty much all there really is
to this
i think it might be interesting to show
splat to see if it works here
so i want to see if i can get all the
ids returned so i'm going to just try or
public ips
so i'm going to give that a go
and see if that works and so we'll do is
terraform apply uh we're not apply we'll
do
yeah apply
and we'll just say only refresh because
we don't need to reprovision our
resources we just want to see if we can
update our outputs there and this is an
opportunity to show off splat
uh maybe it's refresh only
and uh notice here that the outputs is
going to change to a list so we'll say
yes and so now if we do terraform output
okay we should get a
list back here we say public ips
right
oops
public ip
i don't think we can do this but i'm
just curious if i was to do this would
this work
no it does not okay so yeah um you can
get the ball back you use splats and
we'll talk about splats later but that's
uh all there is for now for this okay
oh and as always i forgot to destroy our
instances there so let's just type in
terraform um
apply auto approve
destroy and then we are all in good
shape okay
so yeah just make sure you destroy those
instances
[Music]
all right so now we're going to learn
about the four each so um what i'm going
to do is just copy the count because
they're kind of similar
okay
and so what i'll do is create a new file
here and we'll call this main.tf
we'll paste in the contents here so the
difference is that instead of using
account what we're going to do is use an
object to iterate through and change you
know some particular properties so what
we can do is maybe change the size of
the instance so we say nano
[Music]
micro might be an example here
so t2 micro
g2
micro i should have made the first one
nano there
and i could even do a small i suppose
and so instead of the instance type
being set here what we're going to do is
just say each dot value
and then for the server name we'll do
each dot key
now this splats not going to work for
a map because that's what this is this
is a map data structure and spots only
really work with lists
so what we can do is use the values
function to extract because that this
would return if you just had this my
server this is going to be a
map okay
so what we can do
is just put the parentheses around here
and that will turn into a list
at just the values and then we should be
able to get our public ip address that
way i think
so what we'll do
is make sure we're in the right folder
first that's always important
tell you how many times i mess that up
we'll do our terraform init to get
things going
and you know we might not even
necessarily need to apply this as long
as the plan looks good because if this
was not correct this part here would
probably error out like i definitely
would
okay but we just want to see that when
we do a plan that this is correct
great so what we'll do here is now type
in terraform plan
and so we have an error here i think
it's because it's supposed to be values
not value
so i'll just correct that there
and these are all like built-in
functions so we go to
[Music]
while we're waiting for that plan to
generate there i'll try to show this to
you quickly built-in functions not here
so we would just type in
terraform
built-in functions
and probably under collections that's
where these things become very useful
these all these functions here
and so values is the one we just use
here for the map so i'm sure there's
other ones that would come into play
so now if we just scroll up what i want
to see is that we have three instances
so notice here the public ip is going to
give us three back which looks correct
to me
the first one is server small
notice that it's a t too small
we have our
[Music]
oh this is too small as well
nano and then that says small
and if we go up to this one here
this is micro
so micro that makes sense maybe i just
entered the value incorrectly and maybe
you're watching me this entire time yeah
i did so this is just supposed to be
nano up here
and so we'll run that again
i have to say i really don't like how
plans are laid out i find them a little
bit hard to read
but um i guess it's just the level
complexity you have so there's not a lot
of ways around that so we have the t2
small
the t2 nano
and the
t2 micro notice it doesn't really
respect the ordering of this they're all
just kind of there in the plan
but yeah so that would definitely work
i'm not going to run this i'm going to
consider this done and we can move on to
the next part here okay
[Music]
sorry i killed the screen there a little
bit earlier we have to specify the
region again so we'll just say
us east one
because it needs to know where to take
the uh take those operations
and so it says you can apply this plan
did i not
did i not uh oh
sorry i guess i hit up i really
shouldn't have done that so we'll try
this again so we'll say terraform apply
uh auto approve
i hit up on my arrow and it was going to
an old one which is a bad on me here
so we'll try that
and so we have an error here the image
id does not exist the image id does not
exist and it's showing the same one here
this is my east server and this one
is my west server
so
it's kind of interesting because
that should be right again i don't know
if it's because we're doing that weird
alias so what i'm going to do
is i'm just going to copy this here
and give us back our default provider
i'm going to try that again and see if
that resolves our issue
we're using a data source so there's no
reason it should not be able to find it
because it's best it's pulling it based
on the uh
the alias theorem
unless i don't understand how data
sources work and i have to set the
provider for it as well
it looks like it's working so i'll see
you here in a bit unless we have an
error okay
all right so we gave it another go and
we're getting this error again but i
mean it shouldn't be too hard to try to
figure this out because it's looking for
amazon 2 ami hvm
and you know if we are in
aws here we should be able to figure it
out like this one's the hvm up here so
that's what it's pretty much selecting
so we should be able to go to one of
those regions and just confirm what it
is we're looking at
so
this one here is for
west
it didn't complain about east but maybe
it didn't ever got to east it just ran
west first and it complained but here it
says that it completed the creation of
it so let's go first check out if that
instance actually exists i assume that
uh it does not but maybe it does
whoops
and so
we have our e-server and that one worked
out fine
and then if we go over to our west
server here
it doesn't exist
so that's a bit curious to me
i'm just going to check to see if that
is uh that ami actually exists in the
oregon region i i'm not i wouldn't be
surprised if it didn't it's right here
ami 0 c 2 d
and we look at this and it doesn't say
that it has something that says 0 0 dfe
so what i want to do is scroll up here
and look at my plan and see what it did
so for wes it's using 00dfe that's fine
and then for east it's using the exact
same thing
so
maybe it's my own mistake here let's
just go double check here
um
no it looks correct so
i guess i'll do a little bit more
investigate investigation i'll be back
here in a second okay
all right so i'm not sure why this isn't
working as expected because
as i read the data source is supposed to
be agnostic it shouldn't matter
where it's coming from here
and it should take into account the
provider here the only thing i saw that
somebody was doing different was doing
interpolation around here so
maybe we'll give that a go and see if
that makes a difference i don't see why
that would matter
but uh we're just grasping at stuff here
okay
and we'll just try this one more time
and see if that actually succeeds okay
i think we might have to enter where we
want that maybe not because we provided
the default provider there
okay and it still has this problem all
right
so i mean i don't feel like i should
have to do this but i'm going to do this
anyway to see if it resolves the issue
what i'm going to do
is just copy this and make a second one
and let's see if that resolves the issue
because these are supposed to be looking
uh in that particular area where that
resource is and just to double check
here we have
[Music]
usc's 2 here you know what i'm curious
about i wonder if it's just using the
data source for the provider
so
i'm just going to undo that for a second
and what i'm going to say here is i'm
going to set the default to be usc 1
and we will try this again and let's see
if east and west fails because that
would be very interesting if that
happened eh
and we probably just figured out by
looking at the plan file
so here that is changing and so what i'm
going to do is just scroll all the way
to the top here
and i want to see what it's going to be
set as if it's still the same value or
it's a different value
um
and i can't really tell i guess we'll
just have to wait for that to provision
so i'll see you back in a bit
all right so after a little bit of
digging i looked at the actual sources
here it says for selecting a non-default
provider configuration you use the
provider
option so
you know a lot of people are saying that
they're agnostic and that's how i
thought they worked but i guess you do
have to specify the provider so i
suppose
we will just have to duplicate this
twice
alright so that was kind of an
interesting investigation something we
can
try to remember for later so this would
be east
and this would be west
and so i'll just have to specify the
provider here and we'll just say adabus
west
and for this one we'll say adabus east
and then we'll scroll down below
and so i don't think we need the
interpolation here i will leave it in
it's not a big deal
um where did we put the name well right
in front of it okay great so
we'll do east here
we will do west here
try this again west here
oops that's the east one
and then there's the west one here okay
great and so we'll try this again
and so i think this time we're going to
get what we want
so i mean that's really interesting that
if you don't provide a provider you have
to choose
an operation for it to happen and um
it's great to know that uh
you have to set providers for data
sources but you know you learn these
things pretty quick because when you get
into practical
applications you start uh
intersecting with those things but i'll
see you back here in a moment when this
is successful okay
all right great so it says those have
been provisioned so what i'm going to do
is pull up aws here
and we are going to
make our way over to here
and
i'm gonna go over
to
us west one i think we said it too i
can't remember
and so we should have an instance there
great
and we'll make our way over to us east 2
and we have our server there great so
that's all we wanted to learn here so
i'm going to go ahead and just tear this
down so we'll say
terraform apply
destroy
auto approve
and we are good to go
see that it runs here for a little bit
and then i'm just going to stop here
great and i will see you in the next
follow along
all right so
we're going to learn all about alias and
so what i'm going to do is create a new
file
here in our next folder main.tf i'm
going to make sure i'm in that correct
directory
0 53 is what i have right now it might
be different for you later on in the
course
and so what i want to do is go to my uh
anything like maybe count here
and grab this one because i'm just going
to
update this ec2 instance for our alias
and we're actually going to have two
instances
okay we're going to have an east in the
west so i'm going to say east
and west
and i'm just going to change this here
to my server
my west server
my eserver
and what we can do here is just bring
this down and the whole point of this
tutorial is to show you about aliases so
here we can go alias
and
we'll call this
east and we'll have i don't know if we
can do this but i'm going to try anyway
i actually never tried but i wonder if
we can have a um
like a provider that has no default
like where it does not have an alias
because i think that'd be a really great
way to be very explicit
so here we have our instance i want this
to be the east server
and then i want to have a west server
and then for our server name this will
be server east
and for this one it will be server west
and so then we'll add in our provider
and this will be aws
west and then for this one it'll be aws
east the only thing here is the ami is
not going to be any good to us so what
we can do is go grab some code so here
uh this is like hashicorp supports
terraform two amazon links two and so
here's the code that we need to pull
that so what i'm going to do is just go
ahead and
grab this aws ami here
okay and i'm just going to paste this
above
our instance here
and so that should grab that uh that
instance
we're going to need the name
so i'm going to go down here
just paste this line here and we'll just
modify it so it's database
amazon linux 2 has to start with data
because it's a data source
oops we don't want to change our
instance type that's a mistake
we want to
do that for the ami here
okay and we'll go down
and replace it for both because we both
want them on amazon links too but this
way it'll pull the correct ami
so we have server east server west we
have the east and west public ip
so it generally looks good i don't know
if this is going to arrow but i guess we
will find out so as always we'll do a
terraform init
all right and so now that tara for a
minute is done we are going to do a
terraform plan
uh and see if that works
and so notice it says the region where
aws operations will take place
so
um i guess what we'll do is set it as
usc 1 because we have two resources set
um provider database region
because we set the provider explicitly
in both
i'm kind of curious what would happen
because it's saying usc 1 usc 2 and
that's something i didn't specify
what i want to do is i just want to be
even more particular and set one
provider that is totally and by the way
this is supposed to be wes that's a
mistake
i'm just going to set it to something
that i know is very different okay
so
southeast and west will just change this
a little bit
so how about
we'll do
us west one and then usc's two which is
a little bit different
and we'll do that because i want to see
what it prompts
so we'll just say us east one here
and so the arguments owners is required
but no definition was found in our data
source which i'm kind of surprised
because we copied that straight from
hashicorp
so maybe it's just a little article or
maybe i did not copy that particular
line
so it should say who the owner is
yeah say we're like owner alias
but that's fine we can just look it up
here
because here it says owners and we just
specify that as amazon it's not a big
deal
the real challenge to terraform is just
dealing with the changes but i mean like
it's pretty pretty powerful system so
you just get kind of used to it
so i'm just gonna try to fix that
indentation
i don't know if we need that owner alias
there if we have owners up here but
we'll try this anyway and see what
happens
okay
i mean the major regions for north
america is either uh usc 1 or usps2 so
that kind of makes sense uh incorrect
attribute value type
so we have aws instance us west data dot
abus ami
is an object with multiple tributes so i
think the thing is that we just had to
specify its id because that's actually
returning the ami it's just not going to
infer it
so that's just my mistake as per usual
so we'll just go there and place in the
id
um so what we'll do is we'll just take a
look here and see if it's going to
provision the right place so this looks
all good um so let's just go ahead and
pull the trigger and see how it goes
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we are on to our life cycle for the
resource meta arguments so what i'm
going to do here is just pull up the
documentation so we can just take a look
at an example for this so it's under
providers
or sorry it's under resources meta
arguments life cycle
and so you have this option where you
can kind of set the behavior of it
we covered this in the lecture content
so like create before destroy so by
default one terraform must change a
resource argument that cannot be updated
in place uh terraform will instead
destroy the existing object then create
a new replacement such as like create or
destroy or maybe prevent destroy would
be more interesting to do
and a lot simpler to do so that's what
we'll do we'll just set ourselves a life
cycle thing but what i'm going to do is
make my way over to
one of our pre previous examples
an easy one to pull from right now is
still count because it's very easy to
modify so i'm going to copy the contents
of that
and what i'm going to
do here is open this up
and make a new main.tf
and we will paste that on in here
and apparently i did not copy it
i don't know for me like coding and vs
codes like coding with like oven mitts
on it's really hard i wish i could just
use full vim but we're on a windows
machine so you don't get to see the full
power of my coding
um so what we'll do here is get rid of
that count because we only need a single
instance here
and
we'll just simplify this to my server
and we'll just change this back to my
server
and so we are going to specify lifecycle
and i think it's just destroy but let's
just go double check or prevent destroy
maybe
we go over here
actually it's a boolean so it's probably
lifecycle as a block
yeah it's a block
okay
and we'll say true so we should be able
to create this instance but when we go
and try to destroy it that's where we're
going to
see the effect of this service
so i'm going to make sure i cd into that
directory that i just created with that
new file and we're going to do a
terraform init
and so we did our terraform init but
what we're going to do is do a terraform
plan
actually we'll just do apply because i
have a lot of confidence in what i wrote
here
if it blows up on our face it blows up
and we'll just correct it here but i'm
pretty sure that this is going to work
out pretty okay
and so we will let this provision and
i'll see you back here in a moment okay
great so that looks like it's
successfully provisioned and so let's go
ahead and try to do a destroy
so we'll do a terraform apply and we'll
say destroy
and auto approve and then we'll see what
happens here
because that life cycle should prevent
it from being destroyed
and so there it says resource abs
instance my server lifecycle prevent
destroy set but the plan calls for this
resource to be destroyed to avoid this
error continue with the plan
either disable it or reduce the scope of
the plan using the target
so what i'm going to do here is put
false
and then we'll try this again
and it should destroy the instance and
if that's the case
then uh what we can do is we'll just end
here and we'll move on to our next step
but yeah it looks like it's destroying
so we are in good shape okay so there we
go
[Music]
all right so we're starting our
introduction here into terraform
expressions because there's a lot we can
talk about here so expressions are used
to refer to or comp or compute values
within a configuration so terraform
expressions is a large topic and we'll
be covering types and values strings and
templates reference to values operators
function calls conditional expressions
for expressions
splat dynamic blocks type constraints
actually i don't think we covered typing
strains just because there's nothing
really to say about it but we definitely
cover version constraints so yeah let's
start off this section and go to it
so we're taking a look here at types and
values for expressions and so the result
of an expression is a value and all
values have types and so we have
primitive types no type and complex
structural collection types that last
one is a bit more complicated than what
we are presenting here we're going to
simplify it and then cover it later okay
so for primitive types we have string so
you have your double quotations which
represent your string then you have
numbers so this can be uh integers or
floats then you have booleans so this is
either true or false for node types we
have null uh and so null
is different in all different types of
languages so it's very important to
understand how it works and so null
represents absence or omission when you
want to use the underlying default of a
provider's resource configuration option
so when you're saying null doesn't mean
it's nothing it's going to be whatever
the default is
and the default also could be nothing
it's just depending on what that is on
the provider so for collection or for
collection types complex structural
types we have list or tuple and this
generally looks like an array then you
have map and object and this looks like
basically like a json object or
a ruby hash or i think they call it in
python a dictionary
so that gives you an idea of the basic
types but for this last one here because
this i found really confusing list
tuple's map object we definitely
explained this more in the course okay
okay so we're giving a little bit more
attention to the string type because
there's a little bit more going on here
so when quoting strings you've got to
use double quotes uh at one point
terraform i believe supported single
quotes i think it only supports double
quotes now and honestly you generally
want to just use double quotes because
double quotes always support escape
sequences this is pretty much standard
across all programming languages
but the idea here is you can do things
like new line carriage return tab
literal quotes literal backslashes
unicode characters both basic
multilingual plane and supplementary
planes
there are some special escape sequences
this makes sense when we look at the
next slide for string templates but
there's these things where you can do
interpolation and so you might not want
to actually do them you might want to
do it without and so if you just use
double of the symbol that will allow you
to do it
then there is also the ability to have
multi-line strings and we use here doc
for that and so here doc is a little bit
different in all languages but here
we're using unix style so that means
that we're going to start with these two
angled brackets to the left
our opening angle brackets followed by
some word that is all an upper case it
doesn't have to be eot it could be
whatever you want
i always like to type here doc and then
it has to end at the same indentation
level with the same
word all uppercase and then everything
in between will be treated
as
um
as multi-line the nice thing about this
is that when you have this you can
actually just use double quotes wherever
you want because you don't have to
escape them okay let's take a look at
string templates because this is the
real power of strings so the first is
string interpolation and this allows you
to evaluate an expression between the
markers so the idea is instead of having
to do double quotations and do plus
signs to stitch together uh strings what
you do is just do a dollar sign
curly braces and then put the the
expression or variable that you want to
be
converted okay then you have string
directives and these are slightly
different this allows you to evaluate an
expression uh for a conditional logic
between the markers so
let's say we want to have an if-else
statement so if the name is blank
um
then use
var name or sorry if it's not blank then
use the name provided otherwise
put it as unnamed okay you can also use
interpolation directives with here docs
so you know just to show that you can do
it um and then the last one thing here
is you can uh
strip out white space that would
normally be left by directives blocks by
providing a trailing tilde um so just
notice this little tilde here on the end
because these do take up space so if you
were to view it there'd just be an empty
space there if you want that space to
vanish then you just put that tilde on
the end so there you go
[Music]
let's take a look here at the possible
operators that we can use within
terraform expressions and so just a
refresher operators are mathematical
operations you can perform two numbers
within expressions i'm not going to show
full examples here and the outputs of
them because this is pretty common for
programming or scripting languages and
also the exam's not really going to
focus on the use cases for these so it's
just more so to tell you what is
available to you so you know what you
can use the first is multiplication so
you take two numbers and times them to
get a larger number division so uses a
forward slash modulus if you never use
modulus i really like this it allows you
to see if something is divisible by a
certain amount and then you get the
remainder you have addition subtraction
uh if you need to flip to a negative
number you can just put a minus sign in
front of it if you need to do um equals
it's doubles if you want to do does not
equal its exclamation equals then we
have a less than so that's a open angled
bracket less than or equal so that will
be followed by an equal sign greater
than is a closing angle bracket and then
followed by an equal sign for greater
than or equal you have or which uses the
double pipes you have n which uses the
double ampersands if you need to flip a
boolean you can just put an exclamation
in front of it so if it was true now it
is false if it was false now it is true
i'm not sure what it would do for a null
i would think that it would turn it to
true but yeah so there you go
[Music]
we're taking a look here at conditional
expressions and this is pretty much the
only way that you can do if else
statements uh within terraform but it
works out fine and so it's actually
using the ternary style of if else so
what that looks like it's a single line
so the it starts with a question mark so
that's the if and then it's the true
value and then the colon represents the
else and then you have your false value
it's ternary because there's three
things one two and three okay so that's
the way i remember uh this thing it's
not a a preferred way of doing ifl
statements in other languages
because it is a little bit condensed but
it makes sense when you're using
scripting language and you're really
restricted on per line actions so this
is what it would look like in action so
we'd have a variable that is a
if a does not equal blank then use
the variable or set it to default a as a
string so that's kind of an example
there
just wipe that away there the return
type of it of the if and else must be
the same type
so
if you have a number
okay and the one if statement and then
you have a string they have to be the
same so
uh
obviously we want a string to be
returned in both cases so what we'll do
is use this built-in function to string
to turn this into a string so that we're
not going to run into any problems so
there you go
[Music]
all right we're taking a look here at
four expressions and so these allow you
to iterate over a complex type and apply
transformations a four expression can
accept as input list set tuple map or an
object
i want to distinguish this between for
each which is a resource meta argument
which allows you to iterate over
a a resource or a collection of
resources
that are similar but four expressions
are for these primitive types or not
these primitive types but these
collection structural types that we
talked about in types and values okay so
here's an example of something we might
want to do imagine we have a list of
names and we want to iterate through our
list and
make them all uppercase so we could do
that with this four so we have the four
with the in and then we're providing the
value of each item in our list uh it's
easy to think of list or tuple as an
array so i'll just call it an array okay
then you have a map
and so this is where it has a key and
value this is going to be for maps or
objects and the idea is that we can then
go apply transformations and notice that
we are returning only a single string so
we're actually going to get back
something like a tuple and so how does
it decide whether it returns a
a array or something that looks like an
object we'll explain that here in a
moment the last one here is we have a
list with an index so it's very similar
to the first one but in this case
we want to know the index here so
imagine this says zero is andrew
one is cindy
two is peter and it would come back as
an array or list so let's talk about the
return types the return types are
defined by the um
the braces or brackets that are around
the actual expression so if you have
square braces we're going to get back a
tuple so let's just think of an array so
for in this case where we had our list
it was returning back a tuple okay
if we have curly braces it's going to
return an object so here we have a list
so it's like an array that's coming in
here and then we're specifying as the
return
uh this kind of object structure and so
that's how we're going to get that so
that's that
there's one other thing we want to
mention which has to do with
reducing or ordering so an if statement
can be used uh to reduce the amount of
elements returned so in this case what
we're doing is we're using an if
statement
and so we're saying unless this is true
so if this is true then return if it's
not then return less of what is there so
if there's any blank names that are in
our list
they just won't show up it'll just only
show names that are actually there
then we have implicit element ordering
so since terraform can convert an
unordered type so map objects and sets
to an order type list or tuples it will
need to choose an implied ordering so
for maps and objects they're stored by
key a to z set of strings stored by a
strings a to z everything else is going
to be arbitrary ordering so there you go
[Music]
all right we're taking a look here at
splat expressions and these provide a
shorter expression for the four
expression which we just looked at so
what is a splat operator a splat
operator is represented by an asterisk
it originates from the ruby language and
splats in terraform are used to roll up
or soak up a bunch of iterations in a
for expression so here is an example
where it's for list sets or tuples so
here we have a list and the idea is that
we're iterating over uh this id or in
this case we're iterating over um
it's objects or sorry a array and then
that array is containing a bunch of
objects and so we're accessing the name
within it and so instead of writing it
like that we don't even have to use a 4
at all what we can do is put this
asterisk here and this is going to
equate to the same thing so here this is
going to return all the ids and in this
case it's going to return a all the
lists and allow us to access
the interfaces along to the name okay
so let's take a look
at splat expressions uh when we're
applying them to lists so if the value
is anything other than a null value then
the splat expression will transform it
into a single element list if the value
is null then the expression the then the
split expression will return an empty
tuple and so this behavior is useful for
modules that accept optional input
variables whose default value is null to
represent the absence of any value to
adapt the variable value to work with
other terraform language features that
are designed to work with collections so
i know that's a big mouthful it's just
kind of like an
edge case to these splat expressions
this is not going to show up on the exam
but i just wanted to show it to you in
case you're interested here and just
notice the splats being used over here
okay
[Music]
so we're taking a look here at dynamic
blocks and this allows you to
dynamically construct repeatable nested
blocks so i want to emphasize that this
is a very powerful feature that can lead
to abuse where your code becomes
difficult to read but it's also very
flexible it will absolutely show up in
the exam so pay close attention on how
this works
so let's say you needed to create a
bunch of ingress rules for your ec2
security group
and so this would lead to a lot of
repeatable elements for rules within
your resource and so what you can do
with dynamic blocks is you can define
objects locally so here i have my
ingress rules as an object so here's one
and here is two
and then using dynamic block what i can
do is use a 4-h to reference those
ingress rules
and within this dynamic ingress block
we'll have our content and this will
specify the things that we're swapping
out so the idea is that it will iterate
over this and apply all those values
there so it's something you can't do
with a 4-h or a count this is basically
the the most advanced
iteration but just understand if you
remember this use case and it's very
easy to understand or remember
how to use it
when you're doing an exam okay
[Music]
we're looking at version constraints so
terraform utilizes semantic versioning
for specifying terraform providers and
module versions so semantic versioning
is an open standard on how to define
versioning for software management so
you have your major minor and your patch
and so here are examples or variants on
this here so we have um you know where
you see major minor and you can have
this rc
this rc1 or you could not have it or you
can have beta and this can all be read
about on the semver.org but just to
quickly go through it
major version is when you want to make
incompatible api changes
minor is when you add functionality that
is backwards compatible in manner
patch is when you make backwards
compatible bug fixes
there are additional labels for
pre-release build metadata that are
available as extensions so that's where
we see
those little
additions there at the top a version
constraint is a stream containing one or
more conditions separated by commas so
you have your equals
or no operators or sorry your
equals or no operators so match exact
version of the number so it's either
with the equals or not with the operator
at all okay that's what i'm trying to
write there excludes an exact number uh
version so if we just said does not
or will not be uh 1.0.0
then you have a comparative one so that
the version has to be greater or equal
to
1.0.0
um and then we have one with the tilde
so allows only the rightmost version of
the last number to increment so what
this means is that the the last number
here um is only allowed to increment
okay so let's talk about progressive
versioning because this kind of ties
into semantic
versioning but progressive versioning is
the practice of using the latest version
to keep a proactive stance of security
modernity and development agility and we
like to describe this as practicing good
hygiene when we're uh working with our
code okay so by being up to date you're
always pushing left on things that need
to uh stay fixed or compatible uh you'll
have to deal with smaller problems
instead of dealing with a big problem
later on
run nightly builds is a good example
where you might have golden images and
the idea is to provide a warning signal
just to kind of elaborate on that a
nightly build is an automated workflow
that occurs at night when developers are
asleep so if the build breaks because a
change is required for the code the
developers will see this upon arrival in
the morning and be able to budget
accordingly so what i'm trying to get at
is that when you are
like
putting in your providers especially if
you copy from the terraform
the terraform website to get the
providers and modules what they'll do is
they'll actually have it set as the i'm
just going to roll back here for a
second but they'll actually have it set
as the equals what i'm saying to you is
you want to use something like a tilde
or a greater than or equal sign so that
you are staying progressive okay so
that's just one thing i want you to
watch out for and we will talk about
that when we go through the fall alongs
okay
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we are moving on to our expressions
section starting with string templates
let's learn all about that and we are
going to have to cd into a new folder
here
so i have one called expressions and we
will make ourselves a new file called
main.tf
we'll define a local backend and i'm
going to just define a new variable
i'm going to call this variable hello
and i'm going to give it a type of
string
okay and that's all i'm going to do
there and then what we're going to do is
create ourselves a tf var file so we'll
say
terraform dot tf vars
and then there we'll just set hello
to world
and so what i want to do is enter
terraform console
okay this is going to allow us to just
run arbitrary expressions i want to show
you how you quit it you just type exit
and so we'll do is make a string so
we'll just first do a hello world
i want to show you that you can put a uh
a new line there and we'll get back a
multi-line document this is uh um this
console doesn't allow for multiple lines
so we can't write our own here doc but i
can show you what it looks like
and then we can interpolate a uh a
variable there so we'll just say hello
and notice we get hello world so that's
how interpolation works it's not super
complicated
uh directives is a little bit different
where we have string
right so we can do instead this
but the control word's a bit different
because you're using the uh
this um
percentage sign the directives when
you're doing something like an if else
statement so what we could do
is
say something like
barsoon here
okay
and
what i'm going to do is just exit out
here clear so i don't know if it um it
reloads the uh the variables there if
you just change them on the fly
but what we'll do is we'll just say
hello
and we will write ourselves
an if statement so we're going to say if
var.hello
equals
bar soon
what it's going to do is then print out
um
it's going to instead print out
mars
okay
otherwise
what we're going to get is
um
world okay
and you know what's really interesting
is we're using the if and else
here
but i i could have swore that the only
thing you had was ternary operators so
like if you look at the um conditional
expressions
notice here that it's doing this and
it's not showing the documentation the
efl so
you know maybe
maybe that's just for a one-liner and if
else does exist for expressions and i
might have missed that in the course
but you cannot blame me if the
documentation shows it like that okay
so what i'm gonna do here is just go
ahead and hit enter
and here we get hollow mars so that
pretty much
uh shows you how
string interpolation works um for both
interpolation and directives
we'll just type it exit and so that's
all we want to do there okay
[Music]
all right so let's learn about four
expressions so four expressions allow us
to kind of iterate over something and do
something fun with it
and so what we're going to do is create
ourselves um some more complex types
here
so how about instead like this was just
hello a second ago we'll change this
over to worlds and what i'm going to do
is just list out a bunch of worlds here
from the uh the book uh you know john
carter books
so we have barsoon
we have
jasooom
we have things like sesum
okay and then we have oops
so assume and then we have something
like cosum okay
and so the idea here is now that we've
defined that there we've got to go back
to our main tf i'm just going to update
this to be worlds
this will just be a list
all right
and so what we'll do is make our way
over to terraform cloud or sorry
terraform console
and we'll try to do a for loop here so
i'm going to do square braces for
and we'll just say w in var dot worlds
and
then what we can do here is
make a colon whoops
okay and then type upper
w and so that returns them all in upper
case there
and if we were to use the splat operator
and technically this is something we
want to move on to the next part
but um
yeah we'll leave it for the next video
i'll just keep that separate so that is
for just if we had a list imagine if we
had this as the as an index here
or we'll say map
because what we can do is actually map
these two names
so bring this down here
and this would be earth
now you can use the colon or the equals
just whatever you want to use here
they're both supported
actually this is an earth this is mars
and then this one here is earth
and this one here would be
jupiter
and then this one here would be venus
okay
um and so i think we still need to
define it over here
so i'm just going to say worlds map
and then what we can do here instead of
having lists we can say map
and we'll try to iterate over this so
it's going to be very similar
except the difference is now we have a
key and we have a value
and so if we just want to return the
names in capital we can just do k here
oh that's the index uh what if we do
[Music]
oh you know why it's because um
we have to do worlds map
okay so reference to undeclared variable
map so we do have to exit and restart
and oh sorry the input was complaining
there so i'll just copy the one up here
so i have to type it again
nope it did not work as we thought okay
so i do have to type it by hand
kind of a pain but i guess that's just
how it works so we'll say 4k v in var
dot worlds
map
and then we say upper
b here
okay or we could just say take the k
here and get the other values now i
didn't show you this a moment ago but if
we do worlds here
we can specify an index and an index
would come first so it would be the
value like the world the second and the
index is first so notice that i is all a
number
the index of it and then the that is the
value there
um we could probably also return this as
a map so notice that square braces are
going to give you a list or and then
curlers are going to give you map which
kind of correspond to their actual data
structure so if we wanted to turn this
into
the opposite here what we could do is
just say
we probably do stringer interpolation
like this here and do i
and then do equals or even maybe
a colon here
and then do the world like that and it
didn't like the way i specified it so
i'll try it like this instead
extra characters after line four
so
i don't see that wrong there just give
me a moment i think um
oh you know what it's we need to use in
this case i think we have to do it this
way
okay so you use the hash rocket so in
that particular case you have to use the
hash rocket that's what that symbol is
called the equal zero
um and so that's how we can get that
value there so that pretty much
outlines how to use um the for loops and
next we're going to go probably look at
the splats okay so i'll see you back
here in a moment i'm just going to exit
this
actually before we move on to splats i
just want to add one more thing to four
expressions which is filtering so we'll
just go back here and get back into
[Music]
our terraform console here
and what i'm going to do is write
another four
and it probably would make sense to use
the uh the the world's list we just did
there so i'm going to do kv
type in var worlds
map and so the idea here is that i only
want the
let's say we'll say the upper i only
key value here
but i would just say at the end here i
can say if
the v the value equals and i can't
remember what we set these as
so this is key in value so if it is mars
i think it's double equal so if it is
mars
then only return it that way or we could
say the opposite say
give me everything but mars
okay so i just wanted to show you could
use that if to do that filtering so i'm
going to exit there and we'll move on to
splats okay
all right so we're moving on to splats
and what we'll have to do is create
ourselves a new
variable here i'm going to call this one
worlds
splat and this one is going to be a list
and so if we go back up here to tf vars
we'll make ourselves a new variable down
here and we'll just call this one splat
and it's going to be a list but it's
going to contain inside of it a bunch of
maps okay so we'll do pretty much this
up here
okay um but what's going to happen here
is going to be slightly different where
we are going to
[Music]
set um one is the name
so we'll just say like um
earth name
that's actually mars name so it's a mars
name here
for all these
and then over here these are going to be
earth name
so i think that is valid and what we're
going to do here is just type in
terraform console
and if we wrote that correctly oh no we
got an error so it says expecting an
equal sign to mark the beginning of a
new attribute value
so
i mean this should be okay
uh
oh you know what i think this colon is
just missing here
that up again
there we go we're fine so if we just
want to look at that variable i think we
just type it in here and it might print
it out for lucky
yes so there it is um so
what we're going to do here is use a
splat to get maybe the mars name or
something so if we used a for loop but
we'd have to probably write we could try
this
but we'd have to do four and then it
would be for the actual
map so say m for map
in worlds splat
and then we would have to do m
dot
mars name
and so a reference to the attribute
by one access trigger specifying the
resource name
so i mean that looks oh you know it's
because we didn't write var okay
i say we but it was really me um so you
know that's that but we could write this
in a more concise way
okay so we use the splat
mars name
okay so you know that's a lot more
convenient if we're just trying to
access variables like that um i think
that if you're trying to do
things like
if you want to do upper here
i think you still have to use a four
expression
okay i don't think you can do this we
could try it but i really don't think
that will work
no and if we look at the documentation
they don't show an example like that so
you know it's not that bad but you can
see that it's for a particular use case
you can't use that for
maps or
whatever the equivalent the other map is
object
but it's useful for this one particular
use case okay
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we are on to the dynamic blocks follow
along so this one should be uh pretty
fun because it's uh quite a powerful
feature so what i've done is i've
created a new folder here called dynamic
blocks i'm going to make a new file here
as always it's going to be main.tf and a
really good example for this would
probably be a database security group
just because there's all those ingress
and out outgress or egress rules so what
we're going to do is just define our
terraform settings block and i'm just
going to pull up over here and make our
way over to the registry for terraform
and what we're going to do is go over to
the airbus provider and um go to the
documentation
and actually i first want to grab the
provider itself because that is
something very easy that we can do here
we'll just move that on over so we can
see what we're doing
and paste that on in and we're going to
have to define our provider of course
so we'll name that as aws the profile is
going to be
default
and our region will be us east1
okay and so now what we need is to
go create ourselves a security group
so we have of course done that
previously here but
let's pull up the documentation here i
believe it was actually under vpc so
let's just go down to vpc here and we
will expand that and then underneath
here there should be aws security group
there it is and if we scroll on down
there's the thing okay so what i'm going
to do is copy uh this code here and go
over
and we'll just paste that on in
and there is our security group so
i remember that we had to have the
description
remember it complained about that
so outgoing
for everyone
and uh we need to also have a few
additional things
we will just scroll on down here because
it wanted the prefix list ids
okay
remember we needed that
um i think there was like self false
and there was like security groups
i think was actually eight of security
groups in particular
let's just double check to make sure
that is the case
it is called
uh oh it's just security groups okay
so
we'll say self equals false
we do not need cider block 4 here or 6.
we do not need this one here
and it doesn't really matter what we set
this to so it could be set to the main
cider block that's totally fine
but we are going to need to add a data
source just like last time
for the vpc
so let's say vpc we'll call that main
and i think it just needed the vpc id it
was as simple as that
and so we will go over to aws
over to um dpc
and
from there we are going to go to rvpcs
and i will go grab that vpc id
okay so we've grabbed our vpc id
and then we just need to name this as
data
and then we're going to name this as
data we don't really care what the cider
block is it's just again for
this demo purposes we don't need tags
we'll take those out
and
um
yeah everything else is fine okay
so
this now comes to the fact that we want
to
uh use dynamic blocks before we do that
let's just well i think i didn't leave
the console there last
but what we'll do here is
just do our terraform init
and as that is pulling that stuff we're
going to look up dynamic blocks
terraform
so we'll go here and so dynamic blocks
is like way more powerful than
the 4-h
where what we can do i'm just trying to
find that example there but we have
uh we have to set the
dynamic part the for each you know i'm
pretty sure i have these in my slides so
let's just use my slides as the
reference here
dynamic
ah here it is okay so the idea is that
we'll just set up a locals with all of
our information here and then we'll
create this dynamic block and then
provide the content okay
so i'm just gonna move that off screen
so i can see what i am doing here as we
type it in and we'll see if we run into
any problems
um failed to query the available pro
packages could not retrieve the list of
available versions for the provider
not have a provider registry terraform
name all modules should specify the
required providers so i'm not sure why
it's complaining here but we'll scroll
all the way to the top
and the required providers is correctly
set here
so it shouldn't be a problem
not sure
what it doesn't like
um
so we'll just type in terraform
providers here
the vpc
um
is vpc a module
you know what it's probably because i
didn't do aws vpc that's probably my
problem here
terraforming it
and as that's thinking there we'll just
pull this on down and we'll start to
make our locals block
okay so we can go here
make some locals
and we'll do our ingress
and
we'll just go like that
and the idea is we can say port whoops
we can set the port like that 443.
uh we have to always have a description
so we'll just set that as well so port
we can set
as much as we want here so i'll just go
hit enter
okay
and
i think that looks right yeah so we have
one ingress here and then we'll just
copy this and make a comma
vs code's not really formatting the way
i wanted to and so we'll do port 80.
and then down below we will need to
specify
our
um
for each okay so that's going to be
within our dynamic block so what we're
going to do is tab in here i'm going to
say dynamic
and we'll type in ingress because that's
a match for what we're doing
and then from there we can do our for
each equals local ingress
and then we need to specify our content
i don't really understand why it's
called content and things like that but
i just know that that's what we have to
do and it's not really that big of a
deal
um so
we'll go here and paste that in
we can take out our ingress block there
we know we're going to need self these
all here but what's going to change
are these ports so
we will go here and we'll say ingress
value port
and this will also be ingress value port
and then this will be ingress
value description
if we really wanted to we could also set
the
protocol
protocol pro
to call
and this could be then tcp
and so we just say ingress value
protocol
so it just saves us from repeating these
over and over again if they're all the
same
there's a lot you can do with uh dynamic
blocks but honestly you shouldn't do
anything
too crazy
we'll do our terraform plan and see if
this works
whoops
bring that up there
um an argument vpc id is not expected
here okay so
that was me just guessing from memory
and i guess i guessed wrong
so what we'll do
[Music]
is we'll just look that up
database vpc data source terraform
oh it's just id okay
so what we'll do is just set id here
and then we'll just hit plan again
that should resolve our issue there
uh inappropriate value for attribute
egress security groups is required okay
that's fine
well this one uh it says
doesn't say uh
serious groups
and this one doesn't say security group
so that's probably our problem here so
we'll just hit terraform plan again
and here it says this
vpc id does not exist probably what
happened is they might be in the wrong
region
it's a very common problem
on aws just because of the way their ui
works
if i can get this window over here
and so this is because we're in usd
we're supposed to be in usc 1 here
and i'm going to go up
to here
we will save that
i'll hit teraform plan
and we could probably like use the
filter and also just say choose the
default but it's just so easy to put
that in like that
um so
it doesn't seem like we have any
problems serious let's go ahead and
execute it let's just double check to
make sure these values are correct
so for the ingress
um
port 443 port 443 it's probably just
because i didn't update the description
probably because of a copy paste job yep
okay and let's just make sure this works
so we'll say terraform apply auto
approve
and we'll give it a moment
and it's already created so it's that
fast we can go here and take a look at
it if we like
it's not that big of a deal
um
so we should see it in here i just have
so many
uh junk security groups here this is a
bit hard to find
oh allow tls is what we called it so
here it is
go to our inbound rules
80 443 and that's pretty much it so
terraform
apply
destroy auto approve
okay
and there we go
[Music]
all right so i want to talk about
versioning very quickly here and so i
have a new folder called versions i'm
going to make a new file called main.tf
and we're going to create a terraform
block but what we're also going to do is
set required
uh providers or sorry required uh we're
not providers required version and so
what this is going to do is say
explicitly what version of terraform we
want to use and i'm setting it this as
1.0.0 and i'm using this tilde arrow if
you're wondering you know what is the
logic behind all those things i think
it's all explained in the semantic or
semver.org so if you want to learn more
i strongly recommend you read through
this to understand all the stuff inside
and out highly applicable across the
devops sphere not just to terraform um
but you know if we go over to terraform
github repository and we drop down the
branches and go to tags here we can see
all the versioning we are using version
1.0.0 and uh gold goes up to
1.1.0 alpha which is not out yet and if
you wanted to really know what's going
on here you go to releases and you can
read what they have done so here 1.0.7
remove check for computer distribute
prevent object types with optional
attributes for etc empty uh containers
so when you're looking at the patch the
patch which is the third number the the
right most number that's going to keep
you up to date in terms of security for
the the major minor version that you
have for the 1.0 and you absolutely
always want to be using the latest and
so that's what this tilde does it says
take the the far row uh
the the farthest number to the right and
make sure it's the latest version that
has been published
and you know this comes back to my
progressive versioning slide which is if
you want to have really good hygiene in
terms of your
devops what you should be doing is at
least setting the tilde for sure like
this the tilde arrow or i would even go
as far as saying equals arrow and if
you're really concerned about um you
know not using the next major version
you could say you will less than
you know like less than
um
less than uh you know one point
two point zero even if it's not out
that's a good indicator to say okay well
i don't wanna go too far ahead of time
but if you wanna have progressive
versioning you should really be setting
it like this okay
um and this is going to be applicable
for your abs providers um anything else
so you know if we go over to
um if we go over to the registry
and we choose
whoops
aws and we drop this down here we have
that required version as well so
as you copy it in you're going to notice
that it's actually hard coded but i
would strongly recommend again
if we go here
and take this and at least at least do
this
uh and if you're really
really being clever you could do that
okay and these are also all in github
repositories as that's how everything
works so you can go here and click
and you can go over to the tags and see
the versioning and you can go over to
the releases and it's the same thing you
can read about all the things that have
changed okay
and that's something that you should uh
you know consider doing all right so
that's all there really is to this uh i
might want to show you one more thing
and this one is with terraform cloud so
i'm going to go to terraform io
and we're going to open up our terraform
cloud and i'm going to sign in i
probably haven't signed in a while so
i'll probably ask oh no no username and
password that's great what we can do is
in a workspace we go to settings
and
is it version control no it is general
and under here we can actually set the
terraform version so if you happen to be
working with a particular version uh you
can go and say okay only use this
version for terraform cloud and that
will um
that will not upgrade it'll just keep
you there if you need for legacy reasons
but again you know what you really
should be doing is um using that
progressive versioning
doing nightly builds and discovering
overnight that things are breaking
so you can go fix those in the morning
okay
and that's it
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at terraform
state so what is state well it's a
particular condition of cloud resources
at a specific time so give an example
imagine we expect to have a virtual
machine running centos on aws with a
compute type of t2 micro that would be
the state that we are expecting okay
so how does terraform preserve state
well when you provision infrastructure
via terraform it will create a state
file named terraform tf state it's very
important to remember that name because
it literally is an exam question the
exact naming of that okay this state
file is a json data structure with a
one-to-one mapping from resource
instances to resource uh or to remote
objects and if you're wondering what is
a remote object versus a resource
instance i cannot tell you i would
imagine one is a representation of
things that are deployed in the cloud
and the other one are
objects or or things represented in the
state file but they don't clarify it so
i just have to take a guess so this is
kind of what the json structure looks
like you can see you see resources this
is describing like a type of instance
and stuff like that
there's not really any case for you to
ever go through the terraform state file
and look at it but we might take a peek
just so that we get familiar as to what
it is doing
so just to kind of give a diagram to
help you visualize this imagine you have
your configuration file so you have your
main tf maybe a variables tf a tf vars
to load in your variables and then you
run a terraform apply command what it's
doing is using the terraform api and
it's going to create what we'll say
these we'll call these remote objects
but maybe these are resource instances
but uh it will go ahead and create those
things and then those will get
represented within a state file so the
idea is that whatever is in the cloud is
going to match what's in that file okay
now there is a
cli commands for terraform state and
it's good just to quickly go through
them so we have terraform state list
this will list resources in the state
terraform state move this will move an
item in the state terraform state poll
poll current remote state and outputs to
st out terraform state push so update
remote states from a local state
terraform state replace providers so
replace a provider in the state
terraform state removed so remove
instances from the state terraform state
show so show a resource in the state
some of these are a little bit
interesting so we'll definitely look in
greater detail to move and some of these
we will just explore through our follow
alongs okay
[Music]
okay so we're gonna give special
attention to terraform state move
because it's definitely on the exam uh
and it is a little bit interesting to
what it can do so terraform state moves
allow you to rename existing resources
move a resource into a module move a
module into a module so if you were just
to rename a resource or move it to
another module and run terraform apply
terraform will destroy and create that
resource but state move allows you to
just change the reference so you can
avoid a create and destroy action so an
example for renaming a resource we would
have terraform state move and then we
would have the we would identify the old
one so here we have packet device dot
worker and we are renaming it to helper
so it's we that's just how we're doing
it okay if we wanted to move a resource
into a module what we do is say
something like
packetdevice.worker and then do
module.worker.packetdevice.worker okay
so the idea here is that we're moving it
into
this module here
uh and i think we could probably even
rename it at the same time but we're not
doing that okay so move module into a
module so here we have module app and
then we're moving it into the
parent one so we go module dot parent
module dot app okay so what's important
to remember for the exam is that
terraform state move is when you want to
rename existing resources they're not
going to get into these more complicated
use cases but that's how you rename a
resource okay
[Music]
okay let's talk about how we backup our
state file so all terraform state sub
commands that modify state will write a
backup file so read only commands will
not modify it so imagine listen show
will not cause a backup file to be
created terraform will take the current
state and store it in a file called
terraform.tstate.backup so this is what
it would look like
backups cannot be disabled this is by
designed to enforce best practices for
recovery to get rid of the backup file
you would need to manually delete the
files so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are on to the terraform state
follow alongs and these are honestly
just all about the terraform cli
commands as we do cover terraform state
throughout this course in a variety of
different ways so you can't just really
contain it to this one little section
here but let's go explore these things
and so i have a new folder here on the
left hand side and as always we're going
to go ahead and create ourselves a new
main.tf file and we need to just
provision something and so we've done
this multiple times over so i'm just
going to go back here and i like to
always go back to the count one because
i find this is the easiest one to
update and we will go
down here into our
terraform state file and while the it's
not our actual terraform state file but
our main file here and we will go and
get rid of the account here so there's
just a single one and we will just say
my server
okay
and i think everything else is fine this
is all good and so we just have to make
sure we are in the correct directory and
i'm going to do a
terraform in it
okay
and we'll just give that a moment there
and once terraforming it is happy we're
just going to go ahead and do an apply
because we do need a state fault to be
able to do something right
great so what we'll do here is just type
in terraform
uh apply
and then we will run um
auto approve
okay
and we'll just give that server a little
bit of time to provision there that
script
and i'll see you back here in a moment
okay all right so after a short little
wait there our instance is provision and
now we can go ahead and do some
terraform state cli stuff so
just waiting for my console to be a
little bit responsive there great and so
what i can do is type in terraform state
and it's going to show me a bunch of
commands i can run so we got list move
pull push replace provider remove show
i haven't much found a use for push or
pull
but
definitely list move
and show or something that we want to
look at
we could also give remove a try but i
don't find much reason to use that so
let's do the first one which is
terraform
state list and what that is going to do
is it's just going to tell us what
instances we have there or resources we
have provisioned of course if we had a
lot more this would be a pretty big list
if we do show it's not going to show us
anything because we have to specify
something so we'll do aws instance and
we'll say my server here and so we
should get a lot more detailed
information here okay
so just going to pull this up here
and as you can see we are getting all
that information about that resource
there
if you wanted to rename something that
is a
something you're definitely going to
want to know for the exam and that's
where we use the terraform state move
all right the way you should think about
it is kind of like how
bash has moved that's the way you would
rename things there as well
so imagine that instead of being called
my server we wanted to call this uh
[Music]
our server i don't know
and so if we wanted to rename it like
that then what we'd have to do is type
in terraform
state
move and then we would type the old name
so adabus instance
our server
and then from there we would say aws
instance
oh sorry the original one would be my
server
and then we would do aws
instance our server okay
and so it says move database instance my
server to our server
so if we were to open up our state file
here
okay and we were to take a look at the
actual name so we just look at our
server
you can say that resource has been
renamed the only issue though is that
just because we've renamed it here and
we've moved it within our state file
does not mean that these changes are
reflected um actually uh in our in our
system actually nothing really matters
because it's just a name but let's go
see what happens if we do a terraform
plan okay
i don't think it would matter but we'll
find out
and so down below i mean that's just a
syntax error because we have changed the
name
so this is now our server right
and we'll just do terraform plan here
so terraform has compared your real
infrastructure against your
configuration found no difference so no
changes are needed because like the
logical name that terraform is using the
the our server
is just something that's within the
state file it's not like any of those
changes are reflected on the cloud on
the cloud provider so there's no need to
change anything there so you know that's
pretty much it
um you know if we go back to just
terraform state here
we do have replace provider i'm pretty
sure i have used that one before let's
go take a look at that really quickly
terraform replace
provider
so the command will update all resources
using the from provider setting the
provider to the specified to provider
this allows changing the source of a
provider which currently has resources
in state
so that's kind of cool
um
so i guess this one here we see we have
a hashicorp aws to the registry acme
corp act media bus
i don't know if we really have much
cases for this but i guess here the idea
is that
if you had forked because all these are
public facing right so if you forked it
and made your own changes that could be
a case where you'd want to do that there
right
so that's pretty much it uh whoops
that's pretty much it there um so there
you go
oh and as always we have to make sure we
tear down our resource there so i'm
going to type in terraform
apply
auto approve
destroy
and there we go so i'll see you in the
next video okay
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we are taking a look at terraform init
so it initializes your terraform project
by downloading plugin dependencies so
providers and modules creating a dot
terraform directory so that's a hidden
directory and creating a dependency log
file to enforce expected versions for
plugins and terraform itself so on the
right hand side here we can see we have
that hidden directory but also notice
here that we have a terraform lock.hcl
that is our dependency lock file
uh and so our dependencies are all going
to end up within this um see where it
says providers that's the provider
version there okay so terraform init is
generally the first command you will run
for a new terraform project if you
modify or change dependencies run
terraforming it again to have it apply
the changes you need to know that for
the exam because they will absolutely
ask you that
the first command here is uh and these
are ones with flags so you can just do
terraform in it but we have some extra
options so terraforming it hyphen
upgrade upgrade all plugins to the
latest version that complies with the
configuration version constraint
terraform init hyphen get plugins uh uh
and i think it's supposed to be uh
equals false there but skip plug-in
installation terraform init plug-in
hyphen d-i-r
equals path so force plug-in
installation to read plug-ins from only
target directory and then we have
terraform init hyphen lock file so you
can change the lock file mode it
actually doesn't say what the modes are
so i don't even know what you do in that
case and i could not find examples but
it is an option
i just want to
make it very clear that there is a
dependency log file but there's also a
state lock file and the way you know
that they're different is that one has
dot lock in it and the other one has dot
tf state this one up here is for
dependencies this one of course is for
state a terraform init does not create a
state log file that is going to happen
when you do a terraform apply okay
[Music]
let's take a look at terraform get so
terraform get command is used to
download and update modules in the root
module so when you're a developer you
own terraform modules and you may need
to frequently pull updated modules but
you do not want to initialize your state
or pull new provider binaries
and so the idea here is terraform get is
a lightweight
way
because it's only updating the modules
it's not pulling providers in most cases
you want to use terraforming it with the
exception of local module development
this will not show up on the exam but i
saw terraform yet i was just so confused
about it so i just wanted to make sure i
included it here okay
okay so we're going to be looking at
three cli commands that are used to
improve debugging configuration scripts
the first is going to be terraform
format this rewrites terraform
configuration files to a standard format
and style terraform validate this
validates the syntax and arguments of
terraform configuration files in a
directory and then you have terraform
console an interactive shell for
evaluating terraform expressions and so
let's go jump into these three okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at terraform
format so this command applies a subset
of terraform language style conventions
along with other minor adjustments for
readability so terraform format will be
uh by default look in the current
directory and apply formatting to all
your tf files so let's look at some
examples of what it would format so the
first is adjusting spacing two spaces
indent so here we have something and
it's over indented and so by running
terraform format it fixes the
indentation
we can also get syntax errors so notice
here that we have a problem and so what
it's saying is is that this bracket
okay
is supposed to be up here okay but it's
all it's down here
and the last one here is we can do
terraform format hyphen hyphen diff
that's going to show what it would
change okay so there you go
[Music]
let's take a look at terraform validate
so this runs checks that verify whether
configuration is fantastically valid and
internally consistent regardless of the
provided variables in existing state
validate is useful for general
verification of reusable modules
including correctness of attribute names
and value types so here's an example
where i just had some code and there was
a problem it's just saying you're
missing an argument because for a
database instance you always have to
specify an instance type so when you run
terraform plan or terror from apply
validate will automatically be performed
one thing i need to mention about
terraform validate is that it does not
go to external resources to check things
are valid so if you have
a
a value and it's expecting a string
that's all it's going to check for it's
not going to check that the string is
actually a proper
uh like type of size so if it's supposed
to be like a t2.micro and you write you
know gobbly goop in there
it's not going to know that that's not a
valid type so
but we do cover that in the fall longs
and i think we have like some practice
exam questions that cover that use case
okay
[Music]
we're taking a look here at terraform
console and this is an interactive shell
where you can evaluate expressions so
the idea is you type in tariff or
console and what i can do is i can you
know use like built-in functions and
expressions so there i'm using min
and i've actually entered it in
incorrectly so there it's throwing an
error and here i'm using the correct way
of using it so i get the output so this
is a great way just to kind of test very
simple things um you can't do things
like define variables or or resources or
define providers but you if you need to
figure out how the expressions work
before you apply them in your code this
is a great place to do that okay
[Music]
all right let's talk about terraform
plans so this command creates an
execution plan also known as a terraform
plan and it consists of
reading the current state of an already
existing remote object to make sure that
the terraform state is up to date
comparing the current configuration to
the prior state and noting any
differences proposing a set of change
actions that should if applied make the
remote objects match the configuration
and so this is an example of one that is
generated you're going to see it uh
throughout this course multiple times so
it's not going to be
unique that's why i don't have to make
that too big for you there terraform
plan does not
carry out the proposed changes that's
going to be the responsibility of terror
form apply
and a terraform plan file if you happen
to generate one out is a binary file so
if you open it up it's just machine code
you cannot make sense of it okay
so when you run terraform apply you have
speculative plans and save plans and so
speculative plans is what's going to
happen when you run terror from apply so
the tariff so terraform will output the
description of the effect of the plan
but without any intent to actually apply
it when you have a save plan you're
going to have this hyphen out flag to
save it and you can name that file
whatever you like
and it will generate out that save plan
file and again that's a binary file so
you're not going to be able to see what
it does and what you can do is then pass
it along to terraform apply so you do
terraform apply whatever the file name
is and when you are using terraform
apply what you have to understand is
that it will not allow so it will not
ask to uh manually approve it as you
normally would it would just be auto
approved so that's one thing you have to
watch out when using those safe plans
but you know i just wanted to make it
concretely understood the terraform plan
can generate a file
and it's not actually the one that's
doing the apply okay
i don't have it written in here but when
you do terraform apply it also is
running terraform validate as well okay
[Music]
let's talk about terraform apply here so
terraform apply command executes the
actions proposed in an execution plan
and it has two modes the automatic plan
mode and the saved plan mode so for
automatic plan mode that's just when you
run tara from apply what it's going to
do is execute the plan validate and then
the apply
you can or you have to
manually approve the plan by writing yes
but if you want to skip that process you
can use the hyphen auto approve flag to
automatically approve the plan
we just saw save plan mode like how it
worked in the previous slide but let's
cover it again so when you provide a
file name to terraform to the save plan
file it's going to be terraform apply
file
and it's going to perform exactly the
steps specified by that plan file it
does not prompt for approval so if you
want to inspect a plan file before
applying it you can use terraform show
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to be taking a look at
speculative plans and save plans just a
little bit more in detail there's not a
lot to talk about when we're talking
about speculative plans because we've
been using them throughout that but
we'll just contrast them against the
save plans
and just how you would actually use them
with the apply
this stuff isn't super complicated but
what we're going to do is make a new
file here i'm going to call this main.tf
and
you know what i'm just going to go ahead
and grab our code here from the last one
to for the state file there and we'll go
up and i'm just going to rename this
back to my server
and we'll save this as my server
and there's only a single instance so
i'm just going to take out that there
i'm going to cd back there and we're
going to make our way into the plan and
apply i'm going to do a terraform init
and we're going to wait for that to
finish so you know we've been seeing
speculative plans throughout all the
follow alongs and that's just where it's
going to show you that information but
we can also save that uh that plan out
to a file i don't think there's a
particular naming convention for the
file it just has to be named as
something
but we'll give it a moment here for this
to initialize and then we'll do that
with the out command okay
so what i'm going to do is just type in
terraform plan hyphen out and then we
can give it whatever name we want
probably it'd be good to name it like
dot plans that's what i'm going to do
here and so i'm just going to call this
my save plan
okay and what that will do is output
that file
in a moment here
so it ran and then it output it if we
open it up notice that it's a binary
file so we can't actually um inspect it
in any way but if we are happy with the
these here what we can do is type in
terraform apply and then we can just
provide it the name my saved plan dot
plan and hit enter
and so what it should do is just proceed
to deploy and it won't even review it
should just deploy at least that's what
the documentation says so hopefully it
does not contradict what happens here
okay notice that it's already carrying
out the the action so
uh you know save plans would be really
great if you are setting up a um like a
tool to review so this kind of makes
sense when you're looking at terraform
cloud and it it applies the plan and
then you proceed to the next step where
you accept the apply i would imagine
that they are using that but i guess
when you're using a ci cd pipeline
that's something that would be really
useful but anyway we're going to let
this finish creating and then once it's
done we're just going to destroy it but
that's pretty much all i wanted to show
you was the fact that you can
use the hyphen out command to
output that stuff so we'll just go here
and type in terraform apply auto approve
and destroy
okay
and we'll give it a moment there and
we're all good so i'll see you later
[Music]
all right let's talk about managing
resource drift so drift or configuration
or infrastructure drift is when your
expected
resources are in different state than
your expected state and the way we can
resolve drift are in three different
ways in terraform we can replace
resources so when a resource has become
damaged or degraded that cannot be
detected by terraform we can use the
hyphen replace flag we can import
resources so when an approved manual
edition of a resource needs to be added
to our state file so we use the import
command and refresh state so when an
approved manual configuration of a
resource has been changed or removed
we're going to use the refresh only flag
to reflect the changes in our state file
it's very important to know these three
different ways they will all show up in
the exam and in practice you're going to
need to know them okay
[Music]
let's first here take a look at
replacing resources so
we can use the terraform tank command it
is used to mark a resource for
replacement the next time you run apply
and why would you want to mark a
resource for replacement well the idea
is that um you know and here's the
command here but a cloud resource
becomes damaged or degraded and you just
want to return the expected resource to
a healthy state so that's the idea
behind it and the unfortunate thing is
that terraform taint was deprecated in
version
0.152 however there is a better way of
doing it now and so it is recommended to
use the hyphen replace flag and
providing it a resource address when
you're doing a terraform apply so it's
basically the exact same thing the
reason why they made this change was so
that um
you actually have an opportunity to
confirm your change beforehand because
terraform tank would just run and this
one down below will actually prompt you
to say are you sure you want to do this
okay but it's not complicated you just
do a hyphen replace and then you use the
resource address of the thing that you
want to
um uh use that for and this can be used
for both plan and apply uh the replace
flag appears to only work for a single
resource so you can't use multiple
resources it's just one at a time and
that's something that you should
remember okay
[Music]
so we just saw a resource address and
resource addressing is very important to
know for the upcoming command so let's
just give it a bit more attention here
so resource address is a string that
identifies zero or more resource
instances in your configuration an
address is composed of two parts so the
module path and the resource path and
just expand out that module path it
would be module.modulename module index
and then on the resource spec this is
resourcetype.resourcename and then if
there's multiple instances you give it
an index so modulepath addresses a
module within a tree of modules a
resource spec address is a specific
resource instance in the selected module
so a module is the namespace of the
module module name is user-defined name
of the module module index when the
multiple uh so when there's multiple
specifying index on the other side
that's your resource type your resource
name and instance id uh most of the
times you're going to be just working
with resources but once you start
getting to modules it becomes pretty
simple it's always going to be module
period
because
that's just i think that's the name of
the name value so it's always going to
be module dot and then the module name
but here we have a very simple example
just for resource type so
here if we had a resource called abus
instance and it was web and there was
four of them and we wanted to select the
third one we'd do aws instance dot web
square braces three and that would get
us the third virtual machine so there
you go
[Music]
okay let's take a look here at terraform
import and this is a command that is
used to import existing resources into
terraform so this is how you define it
so you'd say what resource you want and
uh you can just leave it blank so you
define a placeholder for your imported
resource and configuration file and you
can leave the body blank and fill it in
after importing but it will not be
autofilled so you do have to specify all
the values okay so the idea here is
you're going to do terraform import aws
instance dot example and then the name
of the id so that maps over to the
resource address and the id okay the
command can only import one resource at
a time this sounds very similar to
that other command we saw for replace
not all resources are importable you
need to check the bottom of the resource
documentation for support okay
[Music]
okay so we're going to look at
refreshing and so we're going to break
this between the old command refresh and
the new command refresh only across two
slides so terraform refresh command
reads the current settings from all
managed remote objects and updates the
terraform state to match so here we have
the terraform refresh and i just want to
point out that
the
terraform refresh is basically the alias
for terraform apply hyphen refresh only
hyphen auto auto approve so you
technically have this functionality in
the latest version it's just that you
can't use the old alias terraform
refresh terraform refresh will not
modify your real remote objects but will
modify the terraform state
so terraform refresh has been deprecated
and the refresh only and with the
refresh only flag
like it's been replaced with it because
it's not safe since it did not give you
the opportunity to review proposed
changes before updating the state file
so that's why the reason they got rid of
it let's take a look here at the refresh
only mode so hyphen refresh only flag
for terraform plan or apply allows you
to refresh and update your state file
without making changes to your remote
infrastructure just to really make this
clear i want to give you a scenario and
i want you to pay close attention here
to understand the difference because
this is so important on the exam and
also extremely useful
for your day-to-day operations so here's
a scenario imagine you create a
terraform script that deploys a virtual
machine to aws
you ask an engineer to terminate the
server and instead of updating the
terraform script they mistakenly
terminate the server via the aws console
because they don't know any better so
what happens if you were to run a
terraform apply versus with a refresh
only flag so that's what we'll do with
and without the flag so without the flag
first terraform will notice that the vm
is missing terraform will propose to
create a new vm so the state file is
going to be what's considered as correct
and the changes and so changes to the
infrastructure will be made to match the
state file okay if we use terafrom apply
hyphen refresh only terraform will
notice that the vmu provision is missing
uh but with the refresh only flag
it's going to know that the the vm
is missing and it's intentional okay so
i have a couple spelling mistakes there
but the idea is that it knows that the
vm is supposed to not be there so
terraform will propose to delete the vm
from the state file so just the json
code from the state file so the state
file is considered wrong and changes to
the state file will be made to match the
infrastructure so hopefully that makes
it clear okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we are on to the manage resource drift
follow alongs and there's three things
we want to check out replace import and
refresh
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
go over to our folder here the the
manage resource drift we're going to
make a new file as always call it
main.tf and i think the contents here is
going to be pretty much the same as our
last one so i'm just going to go ahead
and grab that
and
we'll type clear we'll back our way out
i'm going to just do terraform in it
okay
and uh the idea here is that we're just
going to provision this resource here
and we're just going to replace it we'll
have to try to import something and do a
refresh maybe we'll do replace import or
we'll do import last just because that
one is a little bit more
challenging
so we'll just let this initialize here
and then we will
deploy it and then we'll try to replace
it
great so that's all good so we'll do a
terraform apply and we'll just say auto
approve and let that go
great and so that is done there and so
what we can do is go ahead and replace
that instance so the reason we would
want to do this is let's say our
instance became damaged or degraded or
let's just say we in general just want
to replace it and actually i think
through some of the fall longs we had to
use replace in some instances so we've
already kind of had some experience with
it but the idea is we just type in
terraform
apply
and then we can just do replace and then
we give it the database instance
um like its resource name here so we
just say my server now this used to be
called terraform taint and depending on
when you set the exam uh you know if
it's really close to when i uh when i
launched this course then you might
still come across questions that are
terraform tape but now it's just this
hyphen replace uh replace command here
and so what i can do is just hit
enter i actually don't really want to
execute this i just wanted to show you
it because i want to move on to the
refresh one which is going to take a
little bit more time here
and just if we scroll on up look what
it's doing it just says we're going to
replace this so destroy and then re
recreate it so this is a great way to to
re uh force that now notice when you use
the hyphen replace flag you're only able
to provide a single resource and that's
just how it is so i'm going to go ahead
and here type no now let's take a look
at
refresh so a great example of this is if
we make our way over to the vpc console
and we go over to ec2 what we're going
to do is just um
go ahead and destroy this instance
okay so somebody came in and let's say
you know you're working on your with
your team and they and you told junior
saying hey we need to destroy the server
because it's costing us a lot of money
and they get they go okay and they're
not aware of all the terraform
infrastructure or maybe there's an
urgency to uh tear it down really
quickly and so they use these uh the ui
to do that and so here i've terminated
the server but the problem is that my
state file still thinks that this uh
this exists so give this a moment to get
into a shutting down stage there we go
and so now what's going to happen if i
do terraform apply
and i don't know if we have to wait a
bit longer for it to destroy there but
it's going to check the state and see
whether that server exists it's going to
tell us what action it's going to take
okay so
there's no changes so we'll just wait a
little bit here
okay
so i'll just talk to you here in a
moment i'm just going to wait for this
to shut down okay
great so after a short little wait you
can see my server is now terminated so
what i'm going to do here
uh once my console is responsive
sometimes it just does this i have to
like click a few times to get it to
react there we go so what i'm going to
do is i'm just going to
[Music]
write terraform apply
okay
and we're just going to see what happens
here
so notice that it's trying to add the
server because the server is gone right
but the thing is is that we actually
want the server not to be recreated when
we run this again and so the problem is
that
our state file is not telling the truth
it should be updated to reflect the fact
that that instance is removed i think
this is where we could use the terraform
state removed to actually remove it
as a resource but another thing that we
could do is use the terraform refresh
and actually now it's called terraform
apply uh
reflect refresh only okay and what
that's going to do is it's going to
check the actual state against uh the
actual or sorry the actual the state
against the actual resource and notice
it's just going to remove it because it
says hey you removed this from aws and
this is your intention right you
actually want it gone so let's go ahead
and say yes to that okay
so yeah there we go and we'll move on to
importing okay
all right so now let's try to actually
import a resource in here so imagine
we've already created something like an
s3 bucket and that's what we're gonna do
i'm gonna make my way over to s3
okay and we're going to go ahead and
create ourselves a new bucket here so
we'll say create bucket and i'll just
say
my new bucket
and i'll just put a bunch of random
numbers here because these are unique
names just like domain names so it's
easier if you just kind of like dump a
bunch of random things in there and so i
want to go down here and just uh oops
create
this bucket here
okay so i have the name here for that
bucket which is this one here and so we
want to import that as a resource so i'm
just going to go over here and type in
whoops terraform import
we're going to take a look at how we can
go ahead and do that
so
um it's not really telling me much
terraform import
so i'll just go ahead and type the
command i thought we'd get a little bit
more information there
okay
and
this is not helping much either so i'm
gonna go pull up my handy-dandy uh notes
here because maybe i
did myself a favor whoops
and i detailed it out and i keep on
hitting the same button here and it's
just not opening the search
okay
so we'll go look for import
great here it is so
um yeah we have to provide the
placeholder so that's what we're going
to do
so just go up here and this is going to
be resource
um aws s3 bucket i think it is
just to go double check that there
go over to our documentation
look for s3
that's what it is good
and
this is pretty much all it is it's just
the name the resource and the name so
i'm sure it's not that hard to type but
i'm just going to do that anyway
we'll just say bucket
and then we need our bucket name that
we're going to import
so go ahead and copy that
and we'll paste it there get rid of that
space
and so now all we need to do is type in
terraform
import
aws
s3 bucket
bucket
and then we need to probably provide
the id and i guess the id is the bucket
name here so we'll go ahead and paste
that bucket name in we'll see if that
takes
okay so that bucket is uh being added
great and so now what we should be able
to do is if we want to tear down that
bucket we should be able to do terraform
destroy
i don't think everything can be imported
so there's some things that might not be
uh possible to import so we'll go ahead
and type yes
and it says that it's destroyed and so
we will go back here give it a refresh
and it is gone so there you go
um so we covered them all replace
refresh and import
[Music]
so let's take a look here how we would
actually go about troubleshooting
terraform so there are four types of
errors you can encounter with terraform
uh the first is language error so
terraform encounters a syntax error in
your configuration for the terraform or
hcl language you have state errors so
your resources states has changed from
the expected state in your configuration
file core errors so a bug that has
occurred with the core library provider
errors so the provider's api has changed
or does not work as expected due to
emerging edge cases and when we talk
about what's easy for us to solve and
what's hard well the first two are very
easy and the other two are harder to
solve so for language errors we can use
format validate or version to uh
resolve our language errors version
would just say hey what version are we
using maybe we need to update it right
validate would detect if something's
wrong with
the the the syntax and format would fix
formatting syntax but
you know that probably wouldn't fix that
much there for state errors the idea
here is we might want to use refresh
apply replace everything that we saw in
the drift section for core errors
we might want to go check out the log so
tf underscore log is um basically just
the way of saying like hey these are
where the log files are or is logs
turned on we have a whole slide on that
but really like all you're going to do
is use the logs to find information and
and then report a github issue since all
terraform is on github
you just go there and then somebody
would try to resolve it
and the same thing with providers so
providers are all hosted on github and
so you would just use tf logs to try to
find some information there but uh we'll
take a look a greater look at tf log and
how to
you know get that information for the
harder to solve cases okay
[Music]
okay so let's talk about how we would go
about debugging terraform via the log
file so terraform has detailed logs
which can be enabled by setting the tf
underscore log followed by
the type of environment you want to run
so the variables that we have or the
environments we can specify is trace
debug info warn error or json json will
output logs at the trace level or higher
and use parsable json encoding as the
formatting okay
so logging can be enabled separately so
you can do this via tf log core
or
you can get it at the tf log provider so
if you just want core stuff or if you
just want provider stuff uh you just set
those environment variables and as we
saw in the previous thing that there
were you know there was core errors and
provider variables so that could be a
good way to
uh do that and so tf uh tf core tf log
core and tflog provider take the same
environment variables we see on the
right hand side their trace debug info
etc okay
if you want to choose where you want to
log things you just can set the tf log
path i don't think i actually say where
the default path is i think it's
actually in the the project directory
but if you want to override that you can
i imagine it either takes an absolute
path or a relative path um and here's an
example of a terraform log so this is
for everything and so there you can see
information i'm going to get my pen tool
out here for a moment but you can see we
have information about the provider this
is using um
there then there's some back and local
stuff so you know there's some
information you're not expected to
understand this information uh generally
but you could go bring it to the
provider but you could probably solve
something you know if you were to read
the core code or the providers okay
[Music]
okay so we looked at tf log um which is
the terraform log but there's also a
crash log and so if terraform ever
crashes and basically this means it goes
into panic because it uses the go
runtime it saves a log file with the
debug logs from the session as well as
the panic message and backtrace to the
crash dot log and so i imagine this is
go lang information so i don't use
golang that often
but you can see we have dot go dot go so
i think that there's not much you can do
with it so this is where you would just
create a github issue and pass it along
to the terraform team because they're
going to be able to make sense of it
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are on to the troubleshooting um
follow alongs here so you know there's
terraform logs and there's crash logs
i've only ever encountered a crash log
once i don't know how we're going to
replicate that so i don't that's going
to be
something we're going to be able to
cover here but definitely terraform
debug log is something we absolutely can
do so what i'm going to do is go down
below to my troubleshooting folder make
a new file as always type in main.tf
and we will pull from
not this one we'll go grab from our plan
and apply
since we had a really simple server
there
and we'll paste that on in
apparently i did not copy it so we'll
try that one more time
and we'll go back over here and we will
paste that in
um and that all looks good to me so what
we'll do is just cd back
and we'll go to the troubleshooting
folder and i'm going to do a
terraforming net and as that's going
we're going to go look up how do we set
up that log okay
so pretty sure i have it in my slides so
i'm just going to go ahead here and look
up log
okay
it's really great when i always have uh
the code on hand here and so the idea is
that through the tf log we're going to
set an environment variable and we'll
set this trace so we can get a lot more
information okay
so what i'll do here
is i will go and
um
i'm going to set it when we do the
terraform apply so
i'll just say tf log equals trace
and
we will then do the terraform apply and
hopefully we should get a lot more
information
already you can see that we're getting a
lot of stuff see all these traces and
debugs as we normally wouldn't get them
we might want to
dump all this data to somewhere so maybe
that's something else that we can do i'm
just going to say no for the moment here
and let's go ahead and try to set a file
here so we'll just say tf log
path
and
i don't know if it would take a relative
path so
yeah let's give it a try let's see if we
can give it a relative path and just say
um terraform dot log because i want to
see if we can get it to log right in
this folder here and it did that's nice
okay
and so again i'm just going to type no
and if we open that up
there's all our logs
okay
so you know it's not that complicated
you can also separate the logging so
they have the tf log core and the tflog
provider
um i guess it would just be like if you
were if you just wanted to log
the core stuff so i'm going to go ahead
and delete this
so let's say you're or let's say you're
trying to debug the provider i guess you
could just go here
and type in
provider it might not log anything i
don't know we'll just hit enter here
and we'll see if we get any output
okay i'm going to just type no
so open that up yeah we do get stuff and
see what says provide in the beginning
okay
and that's pretty much it so there you
go
[Music]
all right i figured i would just include
one more thing here because when you are
troubleshooting a lot of times you do
have to go
to the github and open up an issue
and so i just want to show you where
that is just in case you're not that
familiar with github or you're just you
use github but you're not used to
opening issues so here i'm on terraform
and i can open up an issue
and i can go here and create a new issue
and here you can see that there's
different information like feature
requests reported reported security
vulnerability report bug
if there's something else it's going to
go here and that's going to go to the
discussion but if we report a bug i'm
just curious if they actually tell you
to include the logs here
terraform version configuration file
deep debug output so this is where we
have the tf log and they're telling you
to do it as a trace if you have a crash
output so yeah that's pretty much it i
just wanted to show you where that would
be and also this would be the same for
any of the providers so if you go
up to
a provider here
like aws and this one is of course
supported by hashicorps so if we go to
issues and we open up a new issue we're
going to see this something very similar
and they're going to probably ask for
the debug logs again here but here they
might just say can you only give
give us for the provider
um
i'm sure it's somewhere out here panic
output right that would be that here we
are the debug logs right
um and for modules probably the same
thing like if we went over to the
modules i'm sure it's very similar but i
don't know how you get that output for
that
so like if we just go to one of these
sub modules here
and go to issues i just want to see if
anton is something similar
so
yeah that's pretty much it so there you
go
[Music]
all right so we're on to our module
section so let's first talk about how we
would go find a module i know we already
saw this earlier when we were looking at
the terraform registry but let's just
cover it again and talk about some of
the uh
details of a search okay so tariffer
modules can be publicly found in the
terraform registry and so on the
left-hand side when you're under the
modules within the terraform registry
you can
filter your providers okay
but another thing you can do is you can
type in search terms and you can do
partial search terms like azure compute
but what i really want you to know is
that only verified modules will be
displayed in search terms and so i
assume that means verified and also
official ones and the reason i'm giving
this extra emphasis is because it was an
exam question so i just want you to know
that only verified and official ones are
going to show up when you search okay
[Music]
let's talk about using modules and
there's our public modules and private
modules so public modules are going to
be on the terraform registry and private
modules are going to be in terraform
cloud or i suppose terraform enterprise
so terraform registry is integrated
directly into terraform so it makes it
really easy to start using them so all
you're going to do is
use the module block so i'm just going
to
highlight that there then we have the
name of our module we're providing the
source of our module and then there's
the version of our module terraform init
command will download and cache any
module referenced by a configuration now
looking at private modules it looks very
similar
it's just that the name is different so
we're specifying the hostname in front
here and a namespace as well so to
configure a private module access you
need to authenticate against terraform
cloud via terror from login
so that's something there
we definitely cover that a lot in the
practice exam so just in case you know
you know all the edge cases there
alternative alternatively you can create
a user api token and manually configure
credentials into cli to configure the
file so there you go
[Music]
let's talk about how we would go about
publishing modules and this in
particular is for the terraform registry
so these are public modules so uh if we
want to publish modules it supports
versioning automatically generating
documentation allowing
users to browse the version histories
showing examples and readmes and all of
these modules are actually going to be
hosted on github so the idea is you're
going to put your
module there first and once a module is
registered to push updates you simply
push new versions to properly form get
tags uh you have to name the your um
your modules in a very particular way on
github so the thing is it has to start
with terraform hyphen then the provider
so aws and then the name so hyphen vpc
and the way you publish it on teraform
registry is you have to connect and
publish uh via your github account so
you just hit sign in with github and
it's just going to give you a drop down
you're just going to choose the repo and
that's as simple as it is okay
[Music]
all right let's talk about verified
modules so these are reviewed by
hashicorp and actively maintained by
official contributors to stay up to date
and compatible with both terraform and
the respective providers so here's an
example of a module from our friend
anton down below and as you can see it
has a little badge that's how you know
that it's verified so verified modules
are expected to be actively maintained
by hashicorp partners verified badges
aren't
an indication of the flexibility or
feature support but just to kind of go
through some things here very simple
modules can be verified just because
they're great examples of modules unfair
divide modules could be extremely high
quality and actively maintained
unverified modules shouldn't be assumed
to be poor quality unverified means it
hasn't been created by a hashicorp
partner
so you know that again it's not
indicative of quality but it just means
that it's gone through a bit of vetting
okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at the
standard module structure and this is a
file and directory layout recommended
for module development and this is the
idea if you were to go and publish your
own module this is what people would
expect to see so if you had a root
module that's what it be and you have
nested module i want to point out that
when you are writing terraform you
technically are creating modules even if
you aren't intending them to publish
them into the terraform registry
but you know when you make a main.tf
you've basically made your own root
module okay so the primary entry point
is the root module these are required
files in the root directory so your
main.tf is the entry point file for your
module variables tf is the variables
that can be passed in outputs.tf are
outputted values readme describes how
the modules work license the license
under which the module is available for
nesa modules which are optional but must
be contained in the modules directory a
submodule that contains a readme is
considered usable by external users a
submodule that does not contain a readme
is considered in for only internal use
and the idea is to avoid using relative
paths when sourcing module blocks so
hopefully that gives you an idea okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are on to our module section so
you know we looked at the structure of
how modules should be just pulling up
the documentation over here
and scrolling on down to our shared
module structure so this is pretty much
what we expect we expect that main
variables output readme license and then
you you may need a modules directory
there if you are learning to write your
own what i would strongly recommend is
to check out anton so anton um he
basically uh he's an abused hero just
like myself but he
built and maintains
like a ton of really good modules for
terraform and you can go through any of
these and find really good information
so like for instance the rds instance
has a very good example of how modules
like should be used and so we have
folders within folders you can see
everything is very well organized and if
we have a readme that tells you that
it's exposed and
how he's defined everything are very
good examples but for our purposes we
just want to make
something very simple
and so let's go ahead and create
ourselves our own module so what i'm
going to do
is go over here and we've actually done
a lot of this work already um when we
were using cloud init so i think that
would be a great place to kind of grab
that stuff and so what i'm going to do
is go ahead and grab this entire file
here and we're going to scroll on down
and make ourselves a new directory
here under modules
and i'm going to make a new file here
and i'm just going to call it main.tf
and we're going to go ahead and paste
that on in there and so i think that we
should have outputs as well
what should it be called should be
called outputs
based on convention so
we'll have that
and i just made that a folder didn't i
okay we'll just delete that there
and we will go ahead and create a new
file called outputs.tf
and we also need a variables
tf
and we need ourselves a readme
and we should also have ourselves a
license
okay
and so what i'm going to do is just
copy paste over here from anton because
he's done a lot of the work here so we
have this license here the apache
license
if it's good for anton it's good for me
okay
so we'll go ahead and paste that on in
and so now we have that and let's go
take a look at the readme and see what
kind of work uh has been done here i
assume it's just like to show how it
works
yeah
so you know we'll just say in here um
terraform module to provision
an ec2 instance
uh that is running
is running apache
okay
not intended for
for production use
just showcasing
how to create a custom module
on terraform registry
okay
so nothing super fancy there and then
we'll just give our um brackets there
for the time being
i don't know if there's like even
uh something for
these other you have these three
backticks that will you can actually um
highlight in particular oh so there is
one for hcl so that's great so what i'll
do is just type in hcl there
and so now what we need to do is just
kind of break up our main.tf here
and i did not forget the fact that we do
not have the um
uh the configuration file but we'll get
to that in a moment
so we'll go ahead and paste that onto
here
and then in our main tf we might have
some variables
do we have any
variables we do not
i assume we don't
specify any kind of back end so let's
just go take a look at what
anton has done here
in his main.tf
we go to the top here and just looking
through here
i do not see any
kind of
thing there so that's fine and you know
what i should be doing is i should be
making a new folder here
and this is going to be
new folder we're going to call this aws
demo
apache
okay
or maybe what we should do is actually
call it
hello world
it technically is a module
so we'll say idris module
apache
maybe example would be better
okay and so i'm just going to uh reveal
these in the folder here and i just want
to
you know place the contents of them in
here okay
and i've decided that we're going to
want to actually use our module so
what i will do is create a new file here
it's actually making the subfolder
actually want it
at the top level there so i might have
to just touch that file there main.tf so
it'll show up there we go and so if i
expand that now we have our main tf here
and then we'll just call our module so
we'll say
um
just waiting for my page to become
responsive here there we go so we'll say
terraform
and we had module and then we need to
call our module aws module is it module
or modules let's go up the top here
terraform aws rds
oh it has to start with the word
terraform
okay
so i'm just going to rename this
hopefully this doesn't cause me a bunch
of issues
we'll say terraform
i can always start with terraform aws
and then apache
example
okay
so we will go back over here
and so we'll say terraform
i think we can actually name this
whatever we want so i can just say like
apache
and
we have to specify its source
i don't really remember this so i know
we already did this before with
something
where did we do this where we had a
child one
getting started
no
on oh outputs that's where we did it
over here okay so just pulling up our
old one here
just to save us some trouble
since i cannot seem to remember off the
top my head how that works
so here we are just going to
specify the source locally and so that's
terraform adabus apache example
okay
and what i want to do here
i'm going to close off some of these
older tabs so we're less confused on
what's going on
um i just want to continue to break up
this file here so we'll go to our main
and we don't even need a terraform block
pretty sure we should be specifying a
terraform provider again we'll take a
look at
what
what's going on here in this one here
maybe it's under versions
i kind of like that let's go call that
versions could also call providers but
and so
yeah that's where we were seeing it
there okay so what i'll do is go back
over to here
and we will cut that out
and we will paste it in here
and probably we should be very
aggressive and with our progressive
versioning and do this
okay
i'm not sure if you specified the
provider here so i don't see the
provider listed i don't know if you'd
actually have to
[Music]
list that
i don't think so
no okay so what i'll do is i'm just
going to
grab the provider out of here
oops
we'll cut that out and we'll put that in
our top level main file here
okay
and so um here we'd want to specify our
aws vpc
i wonder if there's like a way we could
just select it by default so
what i'm going to do here is just make a
new tab
there is vpc data source
select defaults in region
maybe there's a good example for us
data aws vpc
i was just hoping there was something we
could grab in two seconds
there is not i don't i don't feel like
fiddling around with filters to figure
it out so what we'll do is we'll just
assume that we have to provide that as a
variable so we'll just say var
vpc id
okay and then in our
variables here we'll just do variable
we have to spell it right though
vpc id
type
string
and so we can just close our versions
here that's fine
so that's set
um this has a security group which is
totally fine
that's hard coded to our ip address so
we might want to provide our own ip
address
my ip
okay
and so
with cider
okay so
provide
your ip eg
i might just go grab mine really quickly
here what's my ip
32.
it's probably some built-in functions we
could use but
oh well
my ip right
um
that's fine
we have our deployer key
um we only need this if we want to
log in but i i suppose we could do that
as well so we could just go here and say
variable
public key
type equal string
var
public key
uh we will need this user data file so i
will have to go back to
our tutorial that we did this in so
[Music]
this would have been for
remote exact no cloudinet okay and then
we'll just go ahead
and grab the contents of this file
and we will go ahead and create this in
here
userdata.yaml
we will paste the contents
okay
so that is good
um we probably would want to dynamically
select the data source for the ami we
have done this multiple times over
the last time we did it
uh did we do this for alias
yeah we did so we'll grab it from here
and we will go over
back to the data source here um
kind of getting a little bit mixed up
here
so just close some of these other files
so we will want
this here and so i'm just going to say
my server i notice like anton likes to
do this which is i guess really good if
you just have one of everything
i think that's a pretty good idea i
don't think i grabbed the right thing
here because that is not
this is just another server we already
have that
so i'm going to go back over to
that other project there under
what do we say it was under alias
main tf
yeah it's right here i just didn't go up
a bit that was my problem
so we'll copy that
and we'll paste that in there we'll just
go up a bit and we'll just say
amazon linux 2.
we will scroll on down here
and we will just make sure that we get
this correctly
i don't think we need interpolation
again but i don't feel like updating
this we'll just keep it the same
and we'll go over here and we'll just
say amazon linux 2.
you might want to
pass along the instance type so say var
instance type
put the oops
double quotation there on the end
um we'll go to variable
and we will say instance type
we'll just default that to t2 micro
okay
um
this is a real file here
deployer key instance type this is all
fine this is all fine
um we have this file here
this is old
so we can go ahead and just remove that
um we want cloud in it yeah cloud and
it's still happening that was just an
additional thing there
maybe they can name their server so we
can just say like
var
server name
okay i think i'm pretty happy with that
could have spelling mistakes i don't
know but um that seems all fine to me so
what i'm gonna do
is go back to my main file here
and i'm going to do a terraform init
i just wonder if i have to
apply the provider looks like i don't
have to i think it's pulling it from the
the sub module there
yeah it is okay that's great
and it should complain on terraform plan
if we don't provide the values in here
so if we go to our variables
we can go here
and i'm pretty sure that anton has a um
i'll probably cover this in the course
but i think he has like a way of
generating out his documentation
um
which is something we might want to look
at at some point
but uh we know that we're going to need
some of these keys here or these values
here so i'm going to go to my main
over here
i'm just going to go ahead and paste
that in
so we have server name whoops
it's a bit of a mess
try that one more time
so we have server name we know we want
to set that
we want our t2 micro here as instance
type
okay
we have our public key here
we'll figure that out in a moment
we
have the
ip address
and i'm just going to go ahead and grab
mine there because we already have it
it's going to save me some time
let me go grab that to ssh key so i can
save myself some time there so we have
ssh
um
terraform
oh it's root right
for this anyway
terraform
i guess i actually just want to cat it
so we'll do that root
dot ssh
terraform here dot pub
and we will go ahead and grab the
contents there
copy
i'm just going to paste it in like that
make sure this the end is the same there
that is all good
um
we just did this so that's fine
vpc id
just make sure you are in the correct
region but first we're going to switch
over to vpc because right now we're in
global region which is not going to help
us that much
i want to be in north virginia so i'm
going to go over here
we'll go to our vpc
we'll go ahead and grab that
something i don't know is like how would
i override the region i just assume i
can just specify that
it would know so right now this is all
hard coded for uh usc 1 so
i do specify that up here
to the provider which region is so i
think that's fine
so we will clear that out
and i think that's
what we need
okay
so
if this all works um then we can put
that in our documentation so i'll do a
terraform plan here
so it says to work with apache module
data amazon linux 2 it has to be west
okay so i just forgot to remove
something in here
which is probably like there's a
provider or something in here
west so we'll just take that out there
okay
hit up
and
invalid value for the path parameter no
file exists at user data this function
works with files that are distributed as
part of the configuration source code
so this file will be created by a
resource
uh you must instead obtain the result
from an attribute of that resource okay
so
doesn't like the way i'm specifying this
i'm not sure what i'm supposed to do
here so i'll come back here in a moment
okay
all right so just thinking about it for
a moment i bet i have to use some
built-in functions to do this so we
probably could get the absolute path
because under the file system functions
they definitely have a function like
this and see this is calling path dot
root
um but we have to really figure out what
it is that we want to use now we check
this in our named uh named value so
maybe we can find that in our
slides here if we go named
values if we just find that here yeah so
for a module
um there's these here right so file
system and workspace info path of the
module where the expression is placed
path of the root module of the
configuration so i think we want
path.module
okay
and so i think if we were to do like a b
absolute path
and then we were to do
path.module again i don't know i'm not
publishing these on a regular basis but
this is my guess
and probably what we could do is do
interpolation
and i don't know if this is proper but
i'm going to do it this way because
sometimes like file systems don't use
like windows will use backslash so i
don't know if we're allowed to do that
like this
and how that will work
but i'm going to do it anyway okay
and so we don't need file here
just yet
actually any interpolation here we're
just going to take that out
and
[Music]
uh
we don't need
yeah that makes sense
and
so we do file like that
so let's see if that works
okay if that doesn't work i'm gonna have
to do some digging okay
fingers crossed
wow okay that works so
i guess we'll know once we provisioned
it so what we'll do now
and i want the outputs in the main
module here so we're going to grab those
and we learned how to do that in the
outputs
section there so we're going to go back
and i'm just going to see how i did that
i'm a large
proponent of like always using your old
code as you can tell
so
we'll go up here
paste that in like
that this is apache
so we'll just say apache here
and
you know hopefully that works as
expected so we'll do
terraform apply auto approve
i'd be pretty pumped if that just worked
first time doing that
path there
because that was definitely a big guess
on my part
seems to be creating no problem
okay well i'll see you here in a bit and
then we'll just verify if the server
works okay
all right so that is finished
provisioning i don't think it's past the
initializations but you know sometimes
it does work even if we don't do that so
what i can do is just checkbox this here
whoops and we'll just open that address
in a new tab and see if we get that page
not sure why it's not filling in the ip
address it's kind of annoying
but we'll go here and paste that in
because it's trying to hit the https
and so yeah there you go so it looks
like our module works
and that means that we can just wrap up
some of the documentation here and then
we can
go ahead and see how we can publish it
on the terraform registry so
what i want to do is just update my
documentation here
and so
we will go back to our readme
not this readme the actual
readme for
this here
and we will paste in our hcl and we'll
just clear up some of our values so um
own ip address
right and then we'll just clear that out
and say like zero zero zero zero zero
zero
and then here you know it's the same
thing it's just like
okay
so nothing super complicated here
um and so
pretty much this is ready to move on to
the publishing thing so we'll make that
a separate little follow along here uh
but this is pretty much done here okay
[Music]
all right so we're gonna go ahead and
start publishing our
um module here to the terraform registry
and by the way if you forgot to and i
might not have told you but you need to
go and
destroy that previous instance let me
just do terraform apply auto approve
destroy
okay
and what we need to do is make our way
over to github
and we're going to have to create
ourselves a new repository here
so we'll go here and i'm going to create
myself a new repository i'm going to put
it under exam pro co and we'll and we're
going to name it exactly what it is so
terraform aws
apache example i think that's what we
called it
probably have to spell that right though
and if i look here on the left hand side
terraform aws apache example okay
and we're going to set that as public
and
we're going to go ahead and say create
repository
and we're going to go ahead and
initialize that so
just waiting for the server to finish
the string there that's all good
and so what we'll do is cd into the
subdirectory here
and we'll go get a
net and one thing i want to do is
actually go check out what um
terraform
module vpc github
doesn't matter which one i just want to
see what he put in his dot get ignore
file so i can figure that out as well
and i'm just going to copy that because
i bet it's good
okay
so say new file here we'll say dot
get ignore
get
ignore here
and paste that contents
okay
and i'm just going to click back here
and see if there's anything else i'm
missing doesn't seem like it
and what we are going to do here whoops
going to go get
add all
we go back to our github instructions
here if i can find it
and we're just going to go down the list
so we'll copy that in
okay
and then we'll make our first commit
and we'll create our main branch
and we'll paste that in there
create our origin
okay so that's set up for main tracking
and so if we refresh this
it is now set up there the only thing
that's not showing up is our
highlighting which i'm a bit surprised i
think it's because i didn't name this
reamy.md so we'll just rename that here
to
dot md
we'll say get at all
get
commit m
fix readme file type
okay
get push
and we'll flip back here
and there it is some crazy indentation
there i'm not sure why maybe that's
what's happening on mine
i'm going to go into the main
order to the readme here
is it really that crazy like it's that
level of indentation
it should shouldn't be
okay well i mean it's not a big deal
it's just aesthetic
you might want to update the description
here so this is um
well we have a little spelling mistake
there too
i'm going to leave it in there just
because i know like how much spelling
mistakes bother people and so that's
going to give somebody an opportunity to
uh you know interact with my uh repo so
i'll just leave it in there that's like
my personal little touch
so
uh now that that's all set up um what we
want to do is actually just publish it
so
we're gonna go ahead over to the
terraform registry
and click on here
and i want to just go ahead and sign in
and sign in with github
and i guess we're granting to everything
here because it doesn't seem like we
have any other option to say
just a few there if there is i'm i'm not
being smart about it okay
and i need my password for github so i'm
just going to go ahead and grab that
off screen here
i'm just getting it from my um
provider
i like my password thing
and i'm having a really hard time
finding it right now there it is found
it okay
so we'll just paste that on in there
we'll hit confirm
and so
what we want to do here is go and hit
publish a module
and we're going to go select the repos
that already kind of autofilled and we
are going to agree to the terms of use
we probably should read it right
i agree that i won't do anything bad
okay
that was me reading the whole thing i'm
a speed reader we'll go ahead and
publish no release tags found that are
in the valve format please ensure the
repository has at least one tag
formatted v version where version is
semantic version
that's fair so what we're going to do
just to
see how that is we're going to go
terraform modules
again it doesn't matter github
and we're just going to take a look at
uh one of the repositories here
i'm just wondering if it's
how yeah so he puts the v in front of it
i really don't like the v
and i think that we don't have to it
says yeah v or version so
i'm going to i'm going to do the
opposite of what anton's doing and i'm
going to not have the in mind
okay
so
what we'll do here is go over to the 110
modules and i'm going to go get tag
1.0.0
um
oh sorry we've got to go into the
subdirectory there and we'll again do
that
probably still have that other one open
there i don't know why i have two now
i'm gonna just close this redundant one
i don't need to
and we'll do git tag
push
or it's get push tags
i should know this i do this all the
time there we go so our version has been
pushed and so now
i'm going to try this again and hit
refresh
click on that publish the module
give it a moment
and there we go i'm in so
yeah um
there it is
cool eh
and that's all there really is to it uh
you can see that i've had less than 100
people provision this so
i guess i have some work to do to
promote this but you know if you want to
provision it and give the project a star
and i become
uh super famous here i wouldn't mind it
um but yeah you'll notice like i i did
the aws there and it picked it up and so
it shows the aws logo
um but yeah so we're all done here uh i
don't think there's any infrastructure
for us to tear down so yeah that was fun
[Music]
let's talk about core terraform
workflows and these have three steps
write plan and apply so write plan and
apply we saw this kind of in the
terraform
life cycle
and the idea here is that
you know it's just to try to describe
what it's going to be for your team and
requirements as you grow
and you're utilizing this workflow so if
you're talking about individual
practitioners so a single person a team
using oss so they're not using they're
using open source software so using
terraform but they're not using the
terraform cloud platform and then what
it would be like if they're using the
terraform cloud platform in terms of
this right plan apply you're going to
see these examples don't perfectly fit
here i am just presenting
a summarized version of the
documentation and the reason why is
because on the exam this is one of
the subdomains that you need to know
so i'm not saying that i think these are
perfectly presented but i think that i
have to cover them because they are on
the exam and i you do learn something
here so we will go through them okay
[Music]
so let's take a look at a terraform or
team workflow for a single person an
individual practitioner looking at the
right step first so you're going to be
writing your terraform configuration in
your editor of choice on your computer
but the thing is you'll be storing your
terraform code in something like github
even if you are an individual user
you're going to be putting in git or
github or some kind of version control
system you're going to be repeatedly
running terraform plan or even possibly
terraform validate to find syntax errors
and the great thing about this is that
you get this tight feedback loop between
editing the code and running your test
commands because it's all on your local
machine we're not sending things off to
build servers or
other services so it's very fast and
easy
talking about the plan stage so when the
developer is confident with their
workflow in the right step they commit
their code to their local repository
this is the stage where it's a local
commit it's not a remote commit
they may be only using a single branch
so just probably working in maine or if
you're still using the old syntax master
branch uh once their commit is written
they'll proceed to apply that'll bring
us to the apply stage so they will run
terraform apply this is on your local
machine it's not part of any other
process you're just running terraform
apply and they'll be prompted to review
their plan after the review the final
review they will approve the changes and
await provisioning after a successful
provision they will push their local
commits to their remote repository so
this is where you will then finally
commit your code
so there you go
[Music]
so we looked at what it would be like if
we had a single person working with
terraform let's talk about if it's a
team and they're not using terraform
cloud they're just doing it uh the
old-fashioned way okay so each team
member writes code locally on their
machine and their editor of choice as
per usual a team member will store their
code in a branch in their code
repository whether it's a
per feature per user
per whatever is up to you
branches help avoid conflicts while a
member is working on their code but
branches will allow an opportunity to
resolve conflicts during emerge into
maine it's no different than working
with you know code because that's what
it is a terraform plan can be used as a
quick feedback loop for small teams so
we still have that option but as your
team grows larger a concern over
sensitive credentials becomes a concern
and so this is where you may need to
introduce a ci cd process
so that it's it's going to be in control
of the credential so the idea is that
you don't run plan you just push to your
branch and it could run it or it only
happens on pull requests that's up to
you know your team and how they decide
to set it up when a branch is ready to
be incorporated on pull requests an
execution plan can be generated
i guess when we say execution plan this
could be a speculative plan okay so it's
not something we're going to run it's
just something we're going to review and
displayed within the pull request for
review to apply the changes the merges
need to be approved and merged which
will kick off a code build server that
will run terraform apply that's the
apply stage there so this is all good
but
what we need to kind of highlight is all
the work and labor that goes into
setting up your own team if you're going
to do it all
from scratch without terraform cloud so
the devops team has to set up and
maintain their own ci cd pipeline they
have to figure out how to store the
state files whether they're going to be
in a standard backend remote state or
they're going to encrypt it and put them
into the code repository which is not
recommended they are limited in their
access controls so they can't do
granular actions to say okay i only want
to allow this person to destroy and this
person to apply it's not like that with
git repos
they have to figure out a way to safely
store and inject secrets into their
build server's run time
and that's not argue arguably it's not
very hard depending on the solution that
you choose but it is a thing that they
have to figure out
they might need to manage multiple
environments and this can create
additional overhead because for each
environment you'll have to
create another cicd pipeline okay so
hopefully that gives you the idea of the
effort here and this is going to set us
up to say what terraform cloud is going
to solve okay
[Music]
let's take a look at what our team
workflow or our terraform workflow will
be if we are using terraform cloud so 18
will use terraform cloud as a remote
back-end of course they're using uh
their favorite editor as per usual
working on their local machines to write
that code the input variables will be
stored on tara4 cloud instead of their
local machine terraform cloud integrates
with your version control system such as
git to quickly set up a cicd pipeline a
team member writes code to a branch it
commits per usual so that doesn't change
a pull request is
created by a team member and terraform
cloud will generate the speculative or
execution plan however you want to call
it for review in your version control
system the member can also review and
comment on the plan in terraform cloud
after the pull request is merged
terraform cloud
in the terraform cloud runtime sorry the
terraform cloud runtime will perform a
terraform apply and a team member can
confirm and apply the changes within the
terraform cloud uh ui okay so terraform
cloud streamlines a lot of the ci cd
effort storing it starting at securing
sensitive credentials and makes it
easier to go back and audit the history
of multiple runs so in terms of the exam
if and i didn't see any questions on
this but i know they exist they're just
going to be asking you
you know which like they might describe
something and say which kind of workflow
does this fit and so if you generally
know the difference between terraform
cloud working with the team
open source software without terraform
cloud and individual workflow it's not
too hard you'll be okay all right
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are on to the terraform workflows
and so i you know i listed out here
individual terraform workflow but i
think really what i want to do is just
show you how to use
the vs
the vsc workflow because we've been
mostly working with the cli and also
just like committing our code in a way
that we should be doing it okay
so what i'm going to do is
i guess start a new project here
and i'm just thinking about it here uh
we did just create that module and i
kind of feel like using that module
right away just to kind of get this
going so what i'm going to do
is create myself a new main file here
main.tf
and i'm going to go back to the previous
project here where we have this i'm
going to copy this over
and we are going to
paste that on in here
and
so this has
my credentials here there's some
sensitive stuff that i probably wouldn't
want to be passing in here so what i'm
going to do
is make myself a
variables
dot or sorry not variables terraform dot
tfrs
and i'm going to just copy the contents
here
like so
and i'm going to paste it on in as such
and then what we're going to do is set
up a bunch of variables here so we'll
have var.vpcid
we'll have var
and we'll just name them all the same
okay
we probably could grab that uh that key
via um using like the file system but
i'm not gonna do that
and i'm gonna grab this here
oops
far.server name okay
and we do need to set up our variables
so i'm going to make a new file here
we'll call this variables
uh walt variables.tf would probably be
better right
and we will go
to our modules here
and luckily all we've got to do is grab
this
so we'll grab that
and i'm going to go to our new one here
am i on the right nope i'm still in
modules
workflow is good we're going to go ahead
and paste that on in
i'm just going to remove the defaults
okay we want to explicitly set all these
okay and so
that's all set up and we're going to
have to create ourselves a new
repository so i'm going to do git whoops
get init
and i'm going to go ahead and make
myself a new repo
i'm going to make this a private repo by
the way
so we will go
to github here make a new repo
and
yeah i'll put it under roman king and
this will just be like
vsc
terraform or
version control system
i always get that vsc vcs mixed up you
can't tell i'm dyslexic and i literally
am dyslexic so uh we have that set as
private and that's totally fine we're
going to create ourselves that
repository
and we have established that init i
think i'm going to go ahead and grab
the dot get ignore file that we
had there a moment ago with our modules
that was in our sub module there because
i thought that was pretty good
good ignore there so we'll go ahead and
grab that
and we will create ourselves a new file
this will be dot get ignore
we'll go paste that on in there
and so we just have to go through this
whole process so
get at all
get commit
switch over to maine
and we will switch over
to this i kind of want this menu i'm
sure you can move it to the right but i
kind of want on the right just so when i
click over here i'm not clicking onto a
different file
and we will go ahead and push this
let's refresh this nothing has been
pushed yet
get remote ads so we add the main
did our commit not work here
oh you know what i'm i'm in the wrong
folder
that's fair
as always wrong folder andrew okay so
we'll do get at all
whoop
oh well get in it i guess
get at all
get commits
get branch main
hit add remote
hit push
sure we'll set it like that
we will make sure that our code is up to
date
great no read me and that's totally fine
um and so what we'll do is make our way
over to terraform cloud okay
so we'll go over
here just gonna close that out we will
sign in
and i'm gonna just create myself a new
workspace we haven't really done
anything with this provisioners i can go
ahead and delete this we're not even
using this anymore let's go ahead and
delete that
yeah delete terraform cloud
put the name in provisioners
delete this workspace
and we'll go back to our workspaces here
we'll create a new one
and we're going to choose a version
control workflow we're going to go down
to github choose github.com
authorize it give them everything
please disable block up popper
okay so we'll go up here
done no no no no always
always allow here sorry so go to github
here
authorize terraform cloud
this is in my personal account
um we only need it for our select
repository so what did we call this it
was
vcs
there it is it's a private repo install
and there it is
i'm going to select it
and if i have to do anything there
terraform working directory
workspaces with no terraform working
directory will always trigger runs
like i said we'll be doing that
the default branch is
i'm not sure what it is but i'm going to
set it as main
uh the branch from which to import new
versions this defaults to the value your
version control provides by default
branch well then it's going to be main
anyway so i don't have to change that
we don't have any sub modules so we'll
go ahead and hit create workspace
okay so our workspace is set up
um we are going to need to set
our variables so we're going to make our
way over here
and
[Music]
we're going to go ahead and add this
here if there's a way to do like an
import i would love to know if like
terraform is watching this like
hashicorp
if there's a way i'd love to know how to
just like one import my file there but
you probably have to bring it one over
at a time it's probably like a security
reason for that so go over here into our
variables whoops rtfrs
and we should probably check to make
sure that this works
um
now i think i'm pretty confident with it
so we're just going to copy these over
so first we have our vpc id i'm just
going to make this a little bit smaller
okay so we have vpc id
we're going to save that
and then we have this ip address
i'll just copy this one at a time
and we'll add that
we need our public key this we will
consider i guess sensitive
and we will paste that on in there
we will specify our t2 micro here
that would be instance type
we are going to need our server name
here
okay and we do need to set our abs
environment variables here so i'm going
to go over
to aws provider terraform
i can never ever
ever remember
those environment variables even though
i work with aws the most and super
frequently i can never remember them
so we go here to this to documentation
we're going to scroll on down
and
there they are so we're going to grab
that one
and uh did i close nope i didn't okay
good so we have that key
and i'm just going to cap my aws
credentials again i'm going to get rid
of this so there's no chance that this
is going to get abused at any time here
and we need a secret here
fun fun fun fun fun
and i should be making these sensitive
because they are super sensitive
and we'll add a variable here
and this one will be our defaults
us east one
we will save that and so this is all set
up
okay and so it should trigger whenever
there is some kind of change to the
repository now i don't know if it's
going to change every time so like if i
make a change or i add a readme file i
don't know if that's going to trigger it
and so i think that should be
interesting to find out okay
so
your configuration has been uploaded
next you probably want to configure
variables we just did that
what's cue plans
oh okay like if we want to run something
and so triggered a few seconds ago i'm
not sure
what it's talking about i didn't do
anything
unreadable module directory unable to
evaluate the directory sim link at
terraform oh that's right because we've
published it we actually never tried our
module
after we published it and we need to
refer to it and that's a great
opportunity for us to update this file
here
so
we want to
reference it from
terraform so we'll go registry terraform
and we're going to find our sweet sweet
module can i go to my profile to show my
module under there
i've published a module what are they
talking about
i've definitely published a module um so
we'll go
to modules here
and we're going to go over to
[Music]
what we call it terraform aws
apache
oh it's not going to show up because
they don't show uh show them under there
eh
oh well it's under modules here aws
no i don't like that
okay so
that's a bit tricky but i think we can
find it so
this one here is terraform aws module so
we could probably just do terraform
apache example
what
come on my module's published
they told me it was published
right
i'm not crazy am i
we'll do it one more time
yeah i was already published
well there it is okay so we found it was
a little bit tricky and so
we just got to grab
grab this here
and i'm just going to go
and swap out the source and i guess we
should set the version
and we will do a terraform init
oh but something we haven't done is set
up our our workspace here so that's
another thing we're going to have to do
um
we don't have any instructions i don't
think in our cli or sorry in our
overview here no
so we're just going to have to go back
to our getting started one where we've
actually used terraform cloud and use
that as an example so we'll go over to
our
what is under providers now it's under
main
here it is and so i'm going to go ahead
and grab this
here
and we'll go back here and we'll paste
it in at the top
and this one is going to be
vcs
what did we call this terraform
terraform
and
i feel like i'm missing a curly brace
here yeah i am
and so what we're going to do again is
do terraforming nets
and then we're going to go
terraform plan
because that's what you would do you'd
say okay does this plan look good before
i push it out right
running the plan and the remote back end
output will stream here we'll stop
streaming the log so
i guess we can
see the run happening
not seeing the run here
but it was streaming it out it said so
if i went to
[Music]
where does that run here
copy that
and we'll grab it here
so here we can see the run
this was started as a speculative plan
so it cannot be applied and that makes
sense right
uh if i go back to my runs here does it
show up so it doesn't show under here
but we can see it in isolate i don't
know why they do that i guess it's
because it's not a real run it's just
kind of like a speculative one
so i'm not really sure about that why
they would do it like that but that's
what it is
um
so
i think this is all good to go like we
just we look at over like yeah this is
great right and so now what we'll do is
we'll go get
status
we'll say get at all
git commit hyphen m
and this is going to be
um
make it work you know because that's
what we want to do we want to make it
work and we'll do a git push
and so what that should do
oh i just pushed to the main branch you
know what like that's not what i should
have done i should have made a pull
request and then merged it in but the
point is it doesn't matter if you push
anything
uh there it should deploy it and wow i
really spelt work wrong w-o-w-r-k
terrible
that's awful
uh so we'll give that a moment to deploy
it's now in plan so we can close in here
and watch it if we want
oh it's a pending so it's waiting for us
to accept it there eh
wow this is actually really nice i have
never seen this before in the ui so i
guess when it does that you can go here
and this is a lot easier way to navigate
i think that if i knew this earlier i
would never ever ever
output here because it just sucks there
and so if i'm happy with it i can
confirm and apply i can add a comment
looks great
and since we actually haven't deployed
anything yet i actually do want to go
ahead and confirm it i just have to
write a message so
i will
accept
everything that goes wrong here
so that's pretty cool
and so we're going to watch that run
and i'll see you back here when the
server is provisioned okay
all right so after a little wait here it
looks like our server is provisioned and
you know it shows us that we have our
resources have been created there
and we can see our outputs and so if we
go over to aws we'll just see if our
server is running and it absolutely is
and so now what i want to do is actually
do a branch and then push that branch
and do a pull request because as far as
i understand it's going to output some
stuff for us in our
pr
and that's what i want to see so what
i'm going to do is make a new branch
here we're going to go get checkout
hyphen b and we'll just say um
add tags
and we're going to go
into here
and
i want to go down
to our module
so our modules here
and i don't think we're going to be able
to modify
the server directly and add tags to it
so i guess what i'll have to do is just
add another resource so i probably
shouldn't have called it tags it's kind
of like too late now i actually no it's
not too late i'm going to move back and
fix that so we'll go back here go check
out main we'll say get checkout hyphen b
and i'm going to say s3 bucket
we'll do that instead
and so we will add our s3 bucket so this
will be resource
abs s3 bucket
and we just need a name here so we'll
give it a name
and uh we can randomize out the name
because there are functions like random
with um
with what you may call it here so i'm
going to go built-in functions i'm just
googling this really quickly here
terraform random
you know even if it wasn't that we could
probably just use a uuid as well
that'd probably work pretty well
yeah let's do that
so i'm gonna go here and
curly's here and we'll just say um
vsc
vsc vcs you can't imagine how many times
i made that mistake when i made the
lecture content way too many times so
what we'll do is do a terraform plan
just to see if it's happy with that
we actually have to give it a name
say bucket
and so it's going to just run that plan
there
and we'll just wait here
um an argument name
named name is not expected here
okay so maybe it's called like bucket
name or something
it's just called bucket
terraform
this is just called bucket
it's just bucket
my bad
bucket
i guess the only problem with using the
uid there is every time we run it it
will change
so we probably shouldn't have called it
uuid
like that
that's probably a bad idea now that i
think about it
yeah so i think what i'll do instead
of doing that
is i'm just going to set a new variable
in here
say like
bucket
and i'm just going to default it to
something like
and we'll go back over here
and i'm just going to say var bucket
and
i'm going to do another plan here just
make sure everything is okay
great and so that plan is all good and
so now what we're going to do is
go get add git commit m
add bucket
we're going to do git push it's going to
ask us to push up stream so we're going
to copy that paste that in there
hit enter and what we'll do is make our
way over to our browser
we're going to go over to
github here
and i'm not going to bug
hashicorp today i'd like to bug them
quite a bit
and we'll go to github and we'll find
our new project what did i call this
vcs right
vcs
terraform
there's a
thing here so i'm going to go ahead and
create this pull request
and it's asking to merge into main
and i'm going to go over to
terraform and see if it does anything
interesting
oh we got all our resources there that's
pretty nice
uh we'll go back over to
[Music]
here there are no conflicts we can
definitely merge and accept this
i thought i thought it would
generate out
a plan here i really thought that it
would do that
so i'm just wondering if maybe i don't
have it configured how i think i do
um don't trigger speculative plans for
pull requests to this repository
for pull request of the repository
that's that's what i wanted i want to
turn that on so we'll update that
so now my question is if i go back to my
pull request is it going to generate one
i don't see one
maybe it's from then on out so what i'm
going to do is get rid of this
pull request
close this pull request
and i'm going to reopen it maybe that
will trigger it
ah see here here we go so now i think
it's going to create a speculative plan
here first
so we're just waiting for that to finish
great and so uh if we
we see that it generates a speculative
plan i guess i thought it would output
it in here we go show all checks so it's
not here
but it produced i guess a speculative uh
plan
somewhere
i really thought it would be in line
here
okay
if we go to runs
i don't know where those speculative
plans go so
they're somewhere right i mean it's
great that it ran it um i just wish i
knew where they were
and maybe like it would show us
a link to it in there so maybe i can
get a link
details
yeah there it is okay
so maybe like someone could click in and
just review it and that's what they
would do so what we're going to do is go
ahead and merge that pull request
still using my old emails there but
that's fine so we're going to add that
bucket
and we're going to go back over to
[Music]
here
and we're going to see that's now
running there
so that's pretty much it for workflows
and that pretty much covers
like i mean technically we did it as an
individual and so you know if i was an
individual i would use the the version
control system
like as opposed to the cli
um but this will also be for terraform
clouds we're not
like covering the the remote one the uh
the middle tier there just because it's
a lot uh like the um
the terraform workflows for teams
without cloud because it's just a lot of
work
um and you know i honestly think that
you should use terraform cloud there
so you know once this is done we need to
kind of pull it down but you know i
don't want to get rid of it because we
might come back to this particular
project
and so maybe we can just destroy the
resources here
so i'm going to go to our settings and
just take a look here
what enabled the setting allows destroy
plans to be created and stuff like that
um queueing a destroy plan will will
redirect to a new plan
and will destroy all the infrastructure
managed by terraform is equivalent of
running the terraform plan
destroy
so i think we'll try that once this is
done
shouldn't take too long here
oh maybe we have to accept it in here
so i think that's the thing is like if
you were to
if you were to have pull requests it'd
be kind of annoying to have to like
double accept this every time so i think
this is where you would go to general
and you'd have auto apply turned on
right and i'll flip that on because
that's gonna get annoying
if i'm gonna have to keep on doing
that okay
and so that's applied this will go
pretty fast it's already done and so
we'll go back over to
settings here because i just want to
destroy the infrastructure but i don't
necessarily want to get rid of the state
file or anything else
like all the work we put into this so
i'm going to say cue a destroy plan
and i'm just going to
type in the workspace name so this is
vcs
terraform and i believe this will just
tear everything down
but we'll leave our workspace in place
so give it a moment
because i definitely think we're going
to come back to this when we're looking
at terraform cloud okay
so we have four resources we want to uh
possibly destroy there
and it has auto applies so it's gonna
just automatically start doing that
we're not even gonna confirm it
i wonder if they should make like a
feature that should just be auto
like auto approved for just apply or
you know etc like that that might be
something they should might want to
offer
because in that case i kind of felt like
i should have confirmed that because
it's not going through the um
the version control system where i'm
doing a pull request i just
happened to be destroying it
but anyway that's good for now and i
feel like this satisfies it and we'll
come back to this
the setup okay
[Music]
all right we're taking a look here at
back ends and each terraform
configuration can specify a back end
which defines where and how operations
are performed and where state snapshots
are stored so terraform divides their
backends into two types we have standard
and enhanced first looking at standard
this is where you can only store the
state
and it does not perform terraform
operations such as terraform apply so to
perform operations you have to use a cli
on your local machine and the reason why
is that standard back-ends are basically
third-party back-ends so a standard back
end could be aws s3 and so you know this
is a storage service it doesn't have the
capabilities of pragmatically triggering
things okay
when we have when we talk about enhanced
back-ends we can store both the state
and perform terraform operations so
enhanced backends are subdivided further
so we have local so files and data are
stored on a local machine executing
teraform commands and remote so files
and data are stored in the cloud so
terraform cloud the reason why they can
perform terraform operations and when
you look at local and remote local is
your machine so of course it can execute
terraform and then remote is terraform
cloud which has its own runtime
environment it's basically a build
server so it of course
can do both those operations and that's
how you're going to remember the
difference between those two okay
[Music]
alright so we were just talking about
standard and enhanced back-ends that i
was saying that standard back-ends are
basically third-party providers so it's
something other than terraform cloud so
let's take a look at what options we
have available to us starting with the
major cloud service providers so aws has
simple storage s3 azure
has block storage account notice it says
azure rm because that's just the name of
what they call it i don't know what the
rm stands for resource manager i imagine
google cloud storage is an option then
we have alibaba we have openstack we
have 10 cent and then we have um
manta which is part of joynet's cloud
storage so
i don't think a lot of people are going
to remember join that joynet was very
popular provider like post or pre 2010
so i remember them 10 cent is a asia
provider i think they were
a texting service they're very popular
but they're not the largest provider
over in asia alibaba is
and of course we have the the three
major ones here and then openstack is
for uh private cloud okay then on the
other side of it when we're looking at
more exotic or things that aren't cloud
service providers we have
artifactory
we have hashicorp console etcd postgres
database kubernetes secrets and you can
also use the acp protocol
now notice i have these little locks
here that's indicating which have state
locking which do not if you don't know
what state locking is don't worry we'll
talk about it here in a moment
would there be a question on the exam
saying oh which service you know doesn't
have state locking and the answer is no
they would never ask that it's to
minute but just notice that the only
thing that doesn't have state locking is
uh artifactory which i'm kind of
surprised because it's a universal
repository manager
and there's the one case like with hp
protocol where it's optional so it's not
that you can't have it it's just that
it's not uh it doesn't necessarily have
to be there and in particular some the
the state is um or the locking state
locking is
by another service so for aws it's
dynamodb that is doing the state locking
and then with alibaba uh alibaba's cloud
storage it's table store okay so
uh you know there's not much to know
here but uh you know it's just kind of
interesting if you want to have a
different kind of back and maybe you
want to use postgresql familiar with it
you can actually store it there okay so
let's take a look at what it would look
like if we were to use a standard back
end so here's an example for aws
since i think s3 is very popular
so if you were to set up your back end
so here i have a bucket
here and i've
i have to name the state file so i call
it state file and then i give it the
region and there it is so the backup of
a state file will reside on your local
machine so the backup's not going to be
an s3 configuring a standard backend
does not require terraform cloud account
or workspace um
because
you know it's just it's totally separate
from it so that's something i wasn't
sure when i was first using was okay can
i use a standard backend but i still
have to have a terraform account or
workspace and the answer is no all right
[Music]
all right so we're taking a look at
enhanced backend so we're going to start
with local and then move on to remote so
for the local backend we store the state
on the local file system and it locks
the state using the systems api it also
performs operations locally and when we
say local we just mean a local machine
we don't necessarily mean it has to be
our workstation a code build server
could also be considered
a local machine okay it just means
anything but terraform cloud that is
running the terraform code
so by default you are using the back end
state when you have not specified any
kind of back end so normally you'd see a
background defined in here and we don't
so it's going to just default to the
local
you can specify the back backend with an
argument local most people don't we just
leave it blank
and you can change the path to the local
file
and working directory so i think that if
you were to specify you'd want to put
the path
in but generally again we keep that
blank
you can set a backend to reference
another state file so you can read its
outputted values this is a way of
cross-referencing stacks so just notice
that we have this thing that says
terraform remote state we're going to
repeat this later on in the course
because this is a very important concept
and i feel that it gets overlooked in
the documentation but it has to do with
local backend so the idea is that
you could say hey um i have this other
file that has a back end and i'm just
going to use data sources
its back-end and then point to its
actual terraform state file okay
[Music]
all right we're taking a look here at
remote backends for the enhanced
back-end type and a remote backend uses
the terraform platform which is either
terraform cloud or terraform enterprise
uh by default i usually just say
terraform cloud when i'm referring to
the terraform platform but just to
understand there is a distinction
between terraform cloud and tariff
enterprise enterprise being the
on-premise um offering okay
so with a remote back end when terraform
apply is performed via the cli the
terraform cloud run environment is
responsible for executing the operation
so that's what you get when you get
terraform cloud you get this run
environment so it's basically just a
built-in
code build server
to run terraform commands for you one
thing i really want you to know about
remote backends because this really
tripped me up uh when i was actually
trying to make the follow along which is
the fact that because the terraform
cloud run environment is the one
executing the command your provider
credentials need to be configured in the
environment variables in terraform cloud
so you know if you had a project and you
configured it with um tfvars locally and
then you were to swap out your remote
backend uh it's not going to work the
way you expect it to because um again
the terraform cloud run environment's
not going to take your credentials and
then move them to the cloud okay you
have to do that yourself
when using remote backing you need to
set a terraform cloud workspace
so you would go ahead and go to
terraform cloud and just go create one
you create one or multiple ones for a
single project if you use a single
workspace for a project you're just
going to use the workspaces
name and if you set multiple workspaces
via prefa you can use a prefix okay and
the way this prefix works is that you're
going to say like my app or something
and when you go to run terraform apply
what it's going to do is prompt you to
say which environment do you want to use
so
and this is what you've created in your
terraform cloud workspace you've created
one called dev you created one called pr
prod and saying which workspace do you
want to deploy to
i want to know that uh you can only set
either name or prefix you can't set both
okay so just understand that
[Music]
so since we're talking about back-ends
let's talk about back-end initialization
in particular the back-end hyphen config
flag this is more of an exotic option
but i figured we should go over it
because it could appear on your exam
so uh the flag for uh the back-end
config flag for teraform init can be
used for partial back-end configuration
so in situations where the back-end
settings are dynamic or sensitive
uh so they cannot be
statically specified in your
configuration file this is what you
would do
so here would be your main.tf and notice
it says back in remote
and it has no details in it
so then what you do is you create a
separate file called backend.hcl
and now you're specifying the workspace
the hostname the organization
and then with terraformingnet you're
going to then say okay use this file as
the backend information that we're going
to inject into our backend remote so
there you go
[Music]
okay we're taking a look here at
terraform remote state and i give this a
lot more attention the course because i
feel that it gets overlooked within the
terraform documentation it's such a
powerful feature and something that i'm
used to having in cloud formation which
is cross referencing stack so i want to
make sure that you know it too so
terraform remote state data source
retrieves the root module output values
from another terraform configuration
file using the latest state snapshot
from the remote back end so the idea is
that you can reference a state file from
somewhere else you can do it uh via a
remote backend and a local backend so
just take a look here
we see data and the data sources
terraform remote state and we're setting
the back end as remote on the right-hand
side here it is local and if it's a
local backend we give the path to the tf
state file if it's remote that means
it's another workspace in terraform
cloud so we set the workspace that we
want to access and then when we want to
access those resources we're using data
sources so we do data dot and then it's
terraform remote state and then we
specify it notes that it's no difference
whether it's remote or local but you're
going to be getting data from outputs
okay
so only the root level output values
from the remote state snapshots are
exposed resource data and output values
from nested modules are not accessible
to make
module outputs values accessible as a
root module output values you must
explicitly configure a pass-through in
the root module so here's an example of
us doing a pass-through so we have a
module called app and it has a source
and then we're just setting an output
notice that we are just grabbing the
value and passing it along
i want to tell you about the alternative
to terraform remote state because if you
can you should use these as opposed to
using tariff remote state so tariff
remote state only exposes output values
its users must have access to the entire
state snapshot which often includes some
sense of information it's recommended
explicitly uh
it it's recommended explicitly
publishing data for external consumption
to a separate location instead of
accessing it via a remote state so what
would be alternatives well you've seen
this because when we looked at data
sources we were technically reusing
alternatives but the idea is that you
are going to say aws s3 bucket aws
referee 3 zones and these are kind of
already set up to work with aws
or whichever provider okay
so
um that's that there
but uh you know hopefully that's pretty
clear so the idea is that when you can
use these data sources because you know
they're actually working off of live
data right like it's hitting a resource
it's not just looking at a state file
that contains data okay
[Music]
so we had mentioned state locking just
briefly when we were looking at standard
back-ends but let's go take a look in
detail what these are because they're
very important for your workflows so
terraform will lock your state for all
operations that could write state this
prevents others from acquiring the lock
and potentially corrupting your state so
state locking happens automatically on
all operations that could write state
you won't see any message that it's
happening if the state locking fails
alright so terraform does not output
when a lock is complete
however if acquiring the lock is taking
longer than expected terraform will
output a status message so neither on
failure and neither when it is complete
just if it takes too long so there's a
transient issue something with like a
networking issue
you can disable lock so
what you do is use the hyphen lock flag
but it's generally not recommended you
can force an unlock there's cases where
you know just does not unlock or and so
what you'll have to do is use the force
unlock command
um if you unlock the state when someone
else is holding the lock it could cause
multiple writers force unlock should
only be used to unlock your own block in
the situation where automatic unlocked
failed to protect you the force unlock
command requires a unique lock id so
terraform will output this lock id if
unlocking fails so this is what it would
look like so you have terraform force
unlock and then whatever the id is
hyphen force so yeah there's a lot going
on here but
yeah that's what it is
[Music]
all right so let's talk about protecting
sensitive data so terraform state file
can contain sensitive data so long-lived
database credentials and is possible
attack vector for malicious actors and
so when you're dealing with the local
state
when you're using local backend the
state is stored in plain text json files
you need to be careful you do not share
the state file with anyone you need to
be careful you do not commit this file
to your git repository when you're using
a remote state with terraform cloud
the idea here is the save file is held
in memory and is not persistent to disk
the state file is encrypted at rest the
state file is encrypted in transit with
terraform enterprise you have detailed
audit logging for tampering evidence to
take it one step further so you can just
see that there's a lot of work that has
to be done when you are using it locally
but with terraform cloud this is kind of
the cell for terraform cloud is that
it's just going to do everything
possible to make that secure would it be
secure to use a remote state with a
third-party storage let's talk about
that so you can store state with various
third-party backends but you need to be
careful to review your backend's
capabilities determine if you meet your
security and compliance requirements
some backends are are not by default as
secure as they could be so for example
abs3 you could have you have to ensure
encryption and versioning is turned on
and you need to create a custom trail
for data events so you can get
tamper evidence logging if you turn on
uh data events for
custom cloudtrail events but one thing
that if it's important to you is that
you know if you use s3 it's not held in
memory you know that be using a cloud
hsm
or kms so you know you have to
understand there are some trade-offs
okay
[Music]
let's take a quick look here at
terraform ignore files and if you know
it get ignore files it's pretty much the
same thing so when executing a remote
plan or apply in a cli driven run an
archive of your configuration directory
is uploaded to terraform cloud and so
you could define paths to ignore from
upload via the dot terraform ignore file
at the root of your configuration
directory if this file is not present
the archive will exclude the following
by default so dot get dot terraform uh
and dot terraforming nora works just
like a document ignore with the only
difference is that you cannot have
multiple terraform ignore files in
subdirectories only the file in the root
directory will be read so there you go
and yes i know there's a double though
okay so
don't worry about that
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are moving on to our uh back ends
and so the first thing we're going to do
is try to use a standard back end so
we're going to back something with
amazon s3 so what i want you to do uh is
we're going to go find our folder here
which is called back ends and i think
i'm just going to break this up into
multiple files or folders i should say
because i feel like we're going to be
doing more than one thing so i'm just
going to rename this folder to
standard
s3 here
okay i'm going to create myself a new
file
called main.tf
and what i'm going to do is type in
terraform here
and what we'll do is we'll go
to the internet and we'll see uh how
this looks like for a standard back-end
so we'll type in
standard
s3 terraform
okay
we're gonna scroll on down and there is
our example it's pretty darn simple uh
to set up terraform there or for um
uh you know aws
and so we have our backend defined there
and we're going to need a new bucket so
uh we'll name that here in a moment so
i'm going to just call this
uh terraform
backend and i'm just going to pound into
a few numbers here
and we're going to have a key and so
this is going to be our state file so
i'm just going to call this
terraform dot tf state
and we'll keep the region to us east one
so now that we have our bucket defined
at least the name we're going gonna go
there to aws and go ahead and create
that bucket so you know we have
something to put that in
so we'll make our way over here and i'm
gonna go ahead and create myself a new
bucket
okay scroll all the way down hit create
and so now we should have that bucket
that's all good to go but we're going to
need something to provision because we
don't necessarily have anything here so
what i'm going to do is go to one of our
previous tutorials
um actually i think the code in the
last one is pretty good with the
exception that we don't want to have it
backed by
um
we don't want it backed by all this
stuff up here so what we'll do is go
grab all of this here
okay
and i'm just going to go ahead and paste
that on in
and i will also
bring over the variables.tf because
we'll need that as well so we'll say
variables tf
and paste that on in
and we'll also grab our terraforms tfrs
to save us some time
um let's just call terraform
tfvrs
and we'll paste the contents in there
and so now what we should be able to do
is go into our folder here
and i'm going to do a terraform init
i think that should just be in good
shape there
now notice that we set it to s3 but we
didn't specify a provider or details i
assume that it would just pick up those
environment variables if they are set in
our credentials but i guess we'll find
out here in a moment
what's going to happen okay
and while that's going i'm just going to
look here and see what they have for
permissions
um
i'm just looking for
general permissions configuration like
region and things like that so
you know uh it looks like we would have
to set a particular region and stuff
like that but what i'm going to do
is i'm just going to go ahead and do a
terraform
apply and see if this just works
and while that is going we're just going
to give a read here so region is
required
if the dynamodb table is used
the following configuration is optional
so the access key the secret
i'm endpoint maxwe tries the profile
and i am using the default profile so
that's totally fine
i would just assume you know if we want
to do something besides the re like the
default profile we do like profile
default here or what have you
and so down below i'm just going to type
in yes
well it's going we're just going to keep
taking a look here
see how there's a lot of options here um
dynamodb endpoints so custom endpoint
for dynamodb api this can be sourced
from the itabus dynamodb endpoint so i
guess if you provisioned a table or
created a table you just specify these
two options to
add that there if you want locking okay
but we'll give this a moment here and uh
see it all spin up okay see you back in
a moment
all right so after a short little wait
here um our server is done provisioning
so what we can do is just confirm that
and we'll go into our
terraform folder here
and give it a refresh and so there we
have our terraform tf state file
and i want to see if there is a backup
and so
and here i don't see one
so i'm not sure what's going on like
when local when you're local you're
always going to get a backup here um i
didn't turn on versioning here it
probably wants us to have that
versioning
is highly recommended that you enable
bucket version on the s3 bucket to allow
the state recovery in the case of
accidental deletion or human error
i guess my one thought is is that um how
would you keep track of previous
versions right like if i was to
update this
you know what's going to happen so
here i'm just going to
[Music]
maybe just change the instance size so
we'll go over to variables
or sorry our i think it might be set in
our tfrs there and we'll change this to
a nano
and what i'm going to do is go ahead and
deploy this again so we'll say terraform
apply auto approve
because what i'm really curious about is
like the versioning right because if we
turn on versioning and then we look at
s3 uh will we see those mobile versions
because that's just a way of like
recovering older versions of the state
file and that might be something that is
important for us to do
because again i don't see any backups
over here i could probably open up this
folder here
and yeah so i don't see any backups
all right so i'll see you back here in a
moment
great so after a short little wait there
this deploy is done so we'll go back
here and give it a refresh and so yeah
we don't uh we don't have a another file
here it's just the same file that it's
overriding so this is probably where
we'd want to turn on our versioning
and so i'm not sure if we can we have to
empty the bucket versioning as a means
i'm not always turning versioning on all
the time
we'll go here and enable it
you might need to update your lifecycle
rules to manage previous versions of
objects which is totally fine
okay
and so what i'm going to do is
go back over here
and i think if we go over here we can
actually see um
let me see like the version here
hmm
because where there used to be like an
option here to see multiple versions but
that's totally fine so
i'm going to go ahead and see if i can
do a terraform destroy
okay
because i'm not sure if that file that
we've placed uh up there is actually
being versioned it might be the one
after this not only turn version on
there's like no way to actually delete
things
at least that's what i remember
so we'll see how this goes and i'll see
you back here in a moment okay
all right after a short little wait it
turned everything down so i want to go
back here and give this a refresh and so
our state file is still there
um and that's the thing with versioning
oh it's right here that's the button so
we go here and we can see our multiple
versions okay so i guess we might have
just peeled back one there and so what
i'm gonna do is just switch this back to
micro
okay
oops i don't wanna i don't wanna destroy
but we'll say terraform um
uh terraform
plan again
i actually don't want to plan i just
want to apply it
auto approve
okay and my thought process is still
again like if i'm doing destroy am i
like just falling back to the previous
state file of the previous version
and the reason why that matters is that
um you know if you keep on destroying
that means that um
you know you're not gonna you're not
going to have a state file that actually
reflects
uh what it is unless the terraform
destroy is writing a new version if it's
doing that that would actually be pretty
useful that's what it might be doing
um and so that's something we should
really be sure of here
so we'll do an apply and what i want to
see is another version appear and then i
want to do a destroy and i want to see
if it removes the state file or just
adds another one
with the remove things and i think it's
going to be the latter okay but we
should just definitively know here so
we'll see you back in a moment
all right so this just finished here so
we're going to do is give this a nice
little refresh
and you can see we have a new state file
and so what i'm going to do
is now do my terraform destroy
so do terraform
apply
destroy auto approve
okay
and
i will see you back here
when this is done destroying and we'll
see if we have an additional file or if
the last one was removed okay all right
so another short wait here and our
deploy is done so what i'm going to do
is refresh and what we have is another
state file so that's what it's doing
it's just updating the save file
removing all of those things and
applying it there
some other things that might be
important to you is turning on
encryption so
if we go down to encryption it's it's
disabled by default
so there is an option to turn it on here
but i also noticed in the back end that
they have it here as well i'm not sure
if that would flip the switch for you or
if the fact that you need to have this
enabled as well it would be also really
great if they told us if this was a
boolean or not i'm pretty sure that's
what it is
um so if i was to go over
to
here
and we'll go up here and say encrypt
and say true i'm not sure if it would
take that
just type terraforming it here
if you wish to migrate automatic
migration for state terror from init so
it sounds like it might have to do a lot
of work there so i think you probably
want to turn that on before you do this
but that's something you want to do is
probably have encryption and then make
sure that no one can delete the original
option option or the
object obviously versioning takes care
of that for you
um but yeah that's pretty much it so
we'll move on to uh the next part of
our back end stuff okay
and uh just as always let's go ahead and
destroy our
infrastructure there
i almost forgot to do this as per usual
um you probably might want to tear this
down so if you want to do that i think
you would have to suspend it
but preserve existing object versions um
do not change
okay that's fine we will save that
change there
and i'm gonna go ahead and press enter
yes here
okay and we'll go back to our objects
and i want to show the versions i just
want to see if i can empty this bucket
here
whoops i don't want to open that but hey
we can see the contents of that file
which is nice
probably would help to show that as
we're doing this
we'll go ahead and delete all these
say permanently delete
and we'll go back over to our back end
here
and now our bucket is empty and so if
you want to delete this bucket just go
back a layer here
and we'll go ahead
and delete this bucket
there we go
[Music]
this is andrew brown from exam pro and
so we just set up a remote back end or
sorry a standard back end with s3
but that was just for a single uh
workspace so imagine if we wanted to set
up this for multiple workspaces so the
first thing i'm going to do is go ahead
and create a new bucket and by the way
we're not going to go and create a bunch
of aws accounts because i realize that's
a lot of work for some people but what
you i want you to do is go and create
that bucket so just make sure it is
named the same here and since we're
using the same project we might have to
do like a terraform init on this or even
a migrate
um
so
this looks like oh sorry i'm
initializing the wrong directory here we
got to go into
120 that's the one mine is called here
and we'll do a terraforming it here
oh sorry sorry that's the wrong workflow
it's 1 30 for me
having uh what like one of those days
where i'm a bit forgetful here but we'll
type in tara from init and because we
had just used it we'll have to do like a
migrate state on it
okay
if that's giving us too much trouble
another thing that we can just do is
just open this up
i don't want to find it in a folder i
just want to reveal that in my explorer
here sorry
so we'll go uh reveal and file explorer
and i'm going to bring that over
and i we've deleted these so we don't
have them anymore so it's not a big deal
if we delete them so say continue
try again
and
really won't let me delete this here
of course that permission the one who
created it
we'll say continue here
okay but that's fine we'll try to do uh
terraforming it on it now maybe it will
take now that there's just the modules
there
there we go
it's not always easy
great and so now we can do is just do
terraform
workspace list to see what workspaces we
have
or it's just workspace
and we do terraform workspace new
um
staging
and i do not need to update my geforce
drivers today
and then we can do one for production
and so the idea here is what we need to
do
uh and i have uh it's all in the s3 back
end here but i'm just kind of walking
you through it but the idea is
what you'd first have to do
[Music]
is set up
a variable here
and we you know we should probably put
this in our variables folder
if you don't since that would probably
be more proper
and what this is doing is it's saying
okay the default setting is a map
and we have one value called staging or
key and one key called production and
this is going to be pointing to a role
and this role is going to be in whatever
account is doing the provisioning so you
can have one account that is just
provisioning both the development or
staging and production environments
and so you'd have a user and so if i
went into
[Music]
uh i am here
and i went to my users
i guess i just have to create a role so
i just create a role
again we're not going to go fully do
this but it'd be like another items
account or third party we'd have to put
the id in there uh and that's the way we
would go assume that role so once we've
created those we still be providing the
account ids for each of those
and the name of the role there over to
whatever it is
once we have that then we can go over to
our provider which is in our main here
and we can just
provide this
assume roll here
okay and notice over here it's getting
the variable and then we're passing in
terraform dot workspace let's we'll
select whatever workspace we're in
server in production it's going to pass
production in here and that's going to
go through and select this and assume
that role and we will have permissions
to then deploy to that but
things are going to still be stored in
this single uh bucket as far as i'm
aware of
um and so that's one part of it but one
thing that they don't even cover in the
actual
documentation here
is how are you going to handle your
terraform.tf vars
because this is a file that generally
you don't want to be tracking
and so what you probably would do is you
create a new file here so i would just
go here and say
um staging dot
tf vars
right and then when you want to you just
fill in all your environment variables
in there but when you want to go execute
this
uh when you are in production you're
going to have to do terraform
apply and you just do var hyphen file
staging
tf vars okay and so there's not really
an easier way of doing this it's just
pretty much it and this will once this
runs it'll it will you know it will um
work that way so you probably just make
a staging a production one and that's
just how it would be you'd have to
update your git directory there so
whatever it would be
you'd have to go to dot get ignore
and just you'd ignore everything that
had tfrs um i bet that git ignore file
that we're using over here probably does
a good job of that if we just scroll up
and down yeah see already ignores it
there so that's pretty much how you use
multiple environments again it's just
too much work to set up here and it's
not really that important to the
certification so
there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to be looking at the
terraform remote state uh maybe not
remote because that might be too much
work to set up but um we'll definitely
look at local here so what i'm gonna do
is go on the left hand side here and
then just find uh my folder that i've
uh created there and i guess
i have back ends there so i'm going to
need a new folder
um i feel like i should have all the
folders here somewhere yes i do
and we're just going to make a new one
here
and we're just going to call it 131
back ends
terraform remote state
and then within this we're going to have
to have two projects so project one
and then we're gonna have project two
okay and we're not gonna treat these as
sub modules they'll both be root modules
uh meaning like we're not going to have
a main in here so we're just going to go
and make a main here main.tf
and then we're going to add another one
here main dot tf
and so what i want to do is provision
something in one place and then access
it somewhere else
so i think this is a good time to go and
grab
i have some things open here would be a
good time to go and grab anton's aws
module there so let's say a bus vpc
module
and we'll just expand this a little bit
here
so i just want to go ahead and grab that
and we'll make that project one
okay
so
this looks fine
i want to do us east though
and we'll just say
my terraform vpc so we uh
don't forget what it is i'm going to do
a usc 2 just in case i have one in
hanging around usc one that i didn't
delete
because i might have it from something
else
and
i mean the this doesn't necessarily need
us to specify the provider because it
should get pulled in from
this module here and so i'm just going
to navigate to that folder
uh 131 is what i've called it
and we want to go to project one here
and we'll do terraform in it
just wait a little while
there i'm just curious about are the
outputs to this
so there are a bunch of outputs here
and i'm just looking for the vpc id
okay so
um that initialized there and so i do
want to output
that value output outputs
i cannot remember so i'm just going to
go look at another project and see how
we do our outputs
main tf here
yeah just output like that
back to our project here
and this one is called vpc
and um
we can specify our provider if we want
it's going to use the default anyway but
we might as well be explicit here
just be explicit about the region so
we'll do region
usc to 1.
and it's going to be double quotations
here
and we'll do
[Music]
profile equals default
okay
and then we'll go down below and we'll
do a terraform
apply
and we'll see if that takes
we'll type in yes
and so that looks like it's going to
work while that is running hopefully it
doesn't break along the way but we'll go
set up our other main.tf and so we just
want a basic project i think we've been
pulling from the same one which is
counts all the way at the top here
or maybe we could pull into
the standard back end might be a bit
easier
yeah let's use this one
and i all i want is
this here the apache module that we
created
so we'll go down below
and we will jump back into
our
project 2 here
and we will paste that in there
and notice that we just have an error
down below
uh
can only create the following a b c so
there's a minor error there
usc's two
two two
oh it's because i set this as one up
here we're gonna do two here okay
let's say auto approve
we'll go back to this project here
and so what i want to do is specify a
data source
and this is going to be that terraform
remote state
and we'll call this vpc
and we're going to set it to the back
end here
saying oh we want to be local
and then we need to set the config path
this is going to be where the actual
file is located
so
i think that we could probably get away
with doing
this there
okay
and so then down below here i should be
able to data
dot vpc vpc id
this is going to need a configuration
file or tfr is there so i'm going to go
here
and just go
terraform dot tf vars
i'm going to go up to
our previous project where we might have
defined that
here
but there's one minor difference here
and that is that we are not specifying
the
cider or sorry we're not specifying the
vpc id here
okay
so we'll go down below back to this file
and we're just waiting for that vpc to
be created it's creating a nat gateway
uh oh i don't think i want that um now
gateways cost money i mean like it's not
a big deal we can just rip it out
um but i think what i would have done
here is
not had either of these i would just
said false and false
so we're going to have to wait for that
to finish to create this is going to
take forever um if you've watched up to
this point you know save yourself some
trouble and just remove that out
oh yeah so just finished
nope it's still going so i'll see you
back here in a bit okay
the problem is it's creating that
gateways in all the vpcs and there's a
lot so i'll be back in a bit
all right so we have to wait that long
but what i'm going to do is just do
false and false on this and i'm going to
go and do terraform auto or reply
auto
approve here
or actually i'm going to do terraform
apply because i don't know if it's going
to just tear down those resources or
actually
replace the vpc if the vpc doesn't get
replaced then we can move on to
the other part of this
i'm just going to go to the top here
because i'm really curious about the vpc
so the nat will be destroyed then that
will be destroyed
the gateway will be
changed road tables will be changed but
the vpc id is not going to change so we
can just say yes
okay
and what i'll do here is while this is
going
we can go figure out project two so i'm
just gonna open up a new uh terminal
here or window whatever you wanna call
it shell
and once that's loaded i'm just gonna cd
into that i believe it's uh 31 we're on
right now
and the numbers might change depending
on if i change them after the fact
so
uh we sourced our data source there i
want to go back to our project 2
and that's the tfvrs file
and so this should just work it should
take it
except this isn't the wrong project so
i'm just going to
close this out
project 2.
yes this looks
good so what i'm going to do is do
terraform
plan and see if this is going to take it
oh we got to do terror from init first
as always
great so um we just ran that there and
so now what we can do
is do our terraform plan
and while we're waiting on let's take a
peek over at our original one here so
that one got rid of all those extra
services we didn't know need
and so down below it says an input
variable with the name server name has
not been declared this variable can be
declared with a variable server name
um i thought we did define these
that's right there
did i name this far wrong terraform
tfrs no that is correct
oh it's because we don't have a
variables
okay so we just do variables
tf
we'll go back up to this one here
and we'll grab all of it
and we don't need this workspaces thing
um
we don't need a vpc id like that because
we'll just pass it along via the data
source
we don't have a bucket so we'll just get
rid of that
okay
and we'll do terraform plan again
and they're saying data vpc vpc id has
not been declared in the root module i'm
going to do terraform init just as a
sanity check there
and i'm going to go back to my main tf
here and just take a look
oh it hasn't been defined
did we put it in the wrong project here
maybe i put it in the 130 here while i
was doing it
did we put it in project one maybe
nope
okay well
wherever it's gone
oh no it's right here
okay so then what's it talking about
let's try this again
terraform plan
plus i named it wrong here
oh
um
what we have to do is do outputs or
output
i think it's outputs on this one here
data.bbc so a data resource name that
does not exist
oh you know what it is we also have to
do um
terraform remote state
like that
and now it should take it
the region is required but is not set
sure
it doesn't say for what but we'll i
guess maybe it's just talking about the
provider
region equals
us east 2
defaults or
profile
default
and so i'll go down here and hit up
okay and so if we just scroll up it's
going to take it so let's just go
provision that and see if it works
terraform apply auto approve
okay
and i'll see you back here if this
successfully works okay
all right so we've ran into a little bit
of an issue here notice that it's giving
us uh saying that it's running in a
different network
so
[Music]
the thing is what we're doing here is
we're passing
our
[Music]
vpc id here
which is coming from project 1
and so that should be setting this to be
usc 2 right because we have the region
set up as such
um
this is all right
so we'll go over here and this is all
right so some of the security grips all
i can think of is we'd have to go back
to our modules project
and if we went in here and checked out
the main
this is where we define our security
group
and we specify the vpc id here and that
is what we are passing through
so you know i would expect this to be
using
the correct subnets and things like that
but uh it's just not taking for some
reason
so
instead of worrying about that what i'm
just gonna do
is i'm gonna go back to project one
and i'm going to
tear this down
and the only reason i didn't do this in
usc 1 was because i thought i might have
already had one there so if we go over
to our aws account
and this won't be a problem for you this
is just a problem for me
but if i go over to vpc here
and we go to your vpcs notice that i
have two
and one is called
oh it's my terraform vpc
that's in north virginia
so maybe that never provisioned where we
wanted to be so but i'll be back here in
a moment
all right so we ran into a bit of an
issue here after waiting a long time it
didn't delete and so
uh if this happens there's not a lot you
can do except delete the resource out
manually this is like something that's
not great also notice that somehow i
ended up one with in north virginia and
also this one has um
a virtual private gateway so probably
what happened was i deployed in usc one
it wasn't correct so then i went to
usc's two
and uh so i just made a big old mess of
this so i'll have to go here and see if
i can delete it manually
and i'm just going to type in
delete
and we'll see if that takes
okay i'll try that one more time
it's possibly that it's not deleting
because of all the additional resources
so i acknowledge
and i really really want to delete this
so i'll go here and type in
oh hold on that's my default one so it
actually did remove it that time
what i would say is i would double check
to make sure there's no virtual private
gateways because those
you do not want to leave those running
that will cost money but these got
deleted out of here
um
maybe to also check endpoints or not
gateways
and so those are deleted as well i'm
going to go over back to my usc 1
and so this thing
uh if we go here oh it's all gone now so
i'm not sure why it was showing up in
both on that gateways that's fine those
are gone so we have my terraform vpc
here
and if i go down to
not gateways
there's nothing there and i go over to
virtual private gateways
i have one set up here i didn't want to
create one so what i'm going to do
and i'm going to see if i can fake it
here but i'm going to just switch this
over to one
and i'm going to do a terraform
apply refresh
only
let's see if it picks it up
and i'm going to see what it gets
so here it says terraform detected the
following changes made outside of
terraform
so that resource was deleted so that's
not really the behavior i'm looking for
i thought maybe we could like kind of
like attach it there but i don't think
that's going to work
so what i want to do is i just want to
delete this one here
and so we will go and
oh sorry i'm going to go delete the vpc
because it might just take everything
with it if we do it that way
and so we say delete vbc
and notice it has a virtual private
gateway attached
so i guess we're going to have to delete
that first
and we'll go up here and detach say yes
detach
and we'll make sure we don't have any
gnats
we don't that's good
so we'll go up to our vpc
and we'll go ahead and delete this vpc
and go delete
so yeah terraform is not always perfect
sometimes you have to go in and delete
resources
but generally it's pretty darn good
you just got to be careful what you're
doing and that's why you should always
be doing terraform plan and pushing
things through
a version control system like git
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
try this again and we're going to do
this through us east one
so i'm going to do a terraform apply and
i should be able to do this no problem
now because um
well there's nothing in my way
so
and while that's going on there i'm
going to switch this over to usc 1
and we'll say yes
and while that's going there i'm just
going to refresh
because once we have the vpc id we are
ready to start using it so down below
here it says
oh right right so this is set up for um
two so we'll set one
one
we'll hit up here and
i'm just going to do a sanity check and
make sure there's nothing in my other v
my other region here
okay good
we'll go back to north virginia here and
we already have the vpc id so because we
have that it looks like it might produce
a new one though zero zero nine
no it's the same one
i think
but what i'll do is i'll go back to
project two
which is referencing this state here
we'll go back
to the second one here and we'll just do
a terraform
init because we did change the region
here so it might want to do something
we'll do a terraform plan
i don't think we ran into an issue with
the plan last time
okay that's all updated there
okay great and so i'm really hoping that
this just works this time so we'll do
terraform apply auto approve
so there must be something we don't know
about how we developed our module and
it's not supporting other
regions again this is kind of out of the
scope of
uh the course here
um because we're just getting into very
detailed stuff but uh you know if we can
just kind of get this working here so
error launching source instance and
valid security group sg
subnet belongs to a different
server
okay so i'm going to see
what is going on here so we have the
state file here
and
except for that
i don't think it created a server let me
go see
go to north virginia here see if we have
any servers
no and we'll go over to ohio here
okay so i absolutely do not trust
the state files in here anymore so what
i'm going to do
is open them in file explorer here
for this one here i'm just going to
delete them out
and i'm going to delete this out and i'm
going to just
clear out whatever i can clear out
it probably won't let us delete
everything like the modules that's fine
and so i'm going to just try this again
terraforming it
who knew this would be so hard
um terraform apply
auto approve
and so what i'm hoping is it just takes
it i'm going to just also check our
terraform vars make sure everything's
fine here because we don't say anything
in there
so i should just take it
um
double p here
so the problem is there's a duplicate
key
so this is under um
i seem to talk about key pairs here
so we'll go here and we'll just go ahead
and delete that
we'll also do that in usc's i think it's
more of a problem in usc than anywhere
else
we'll delete that as well
and we will go ahead and hit enter there
i'm really surprised i didn't generate
like a unique name each time
i thought that would do that eh
and i guess the security group still
exists so we'll go here and delete that
out as well
so i think it's just this one here
delete
is the key pair back now do we have to
delete that no okay
and we'll try this again
maybe what it was doing is it was
picking up the old security group that
was that was pointing to somewhere else
i don't know
whatever issue we're having it was
pretty odd
and so
[Music]
let's complain about the security group
but now we're doing everything in usc
one so i don't know what its problem is
so if we go over to our security groups
wherever that is
it's under vpc
security groups
so here it's 0 0 9 fe all that kind of
stuff there and if we go to the original
project here
0 0 9 f e so it is using
the correct vpc right
and
this one here
is fine if we go over here to this one
this is in us east one so that's totally
fine as well
so there must be something that's not
being set for it so it must be using
like the default vpc
i think it really has to do with our
original module here so what i'm going
to do
is i'm just going to specify our
original source there
and so this one's going to be
what was it
just type in child module
terraform here
source
local just doing this off screen here
uh yeah you would just do a period or
something the other one like a double
slash or something i can't remember so
this is in our
this is up one directory and it's up
another directory
and it's in our modules
here
modules terraform aws apache
example
okay and so this will just allow us to
modify this and and kind of like fix
what
whatever issue we're having with this
terraforming it let's see if we can find
it there
uh there wouldn't be any version
constrained on here so that's right
we'll just take that off
and so i think what's happening is our
um
our resource is trying to launch in the
default security group
so we'll open up our main tf here
and so this should be using that
right
and that should be using that
and we don't set like a vpc here we just
set the vpc security security group ids
i'm just going to scroll up here for a
second
or this is on wc2 right or wsl2
and so this would be terraform in it
to reform
autoproof
okay so if this is the problem what
we'll do is go look up aws instance
this is insane
because maybe we're not specifying the
security group correctly but i'm pretty
sure we are
so we'll just say vpc
this is the
optional ec2 classic default vpc only so
that's the old way of doing it
a list of security groups ids associated
with
subnet id
do we set the subnet id here we don't
aha so that's our problem
so we can go subnet id here
and that's what we want to set so the
vpc subnet to id to launch in
um
i'm not sure how we're going to grab the
subnet here
so we'll go over to adress vpc
so it's just easier to type it up your
abus vpc
and i'm looking for
a subnet
aws
vpc get for subnet
terraform
i guess that would be one way of doing
it
so we could just
i suppose select them that way
so we're going to say data
dot um
oh we're in the wrong one we're in the
example aren't we oh no that's right
okay
so then we would just want to go up to
[Music]
the vpc up here
so data it's vpc main
um
vpc id equals data
dot
vpc.main dot id
and these are subnet ids
i assume what this is going to return
back is like
an array
so i'm going to i'm just going to take a
guess here and do aws
subnet ids and just choose zero here
and we'll see if that fixes our problem
terraform init because we might have
changed our module there
and there's a command terraform get this
i think would be the perfect case
because we're just updating the module
we're not updating the provider so
that'd be the time that we would use
that
so now i'm going to try this again and
see if this works
a reference to data source must be
followed by at least one attribute um
accessible there the problem is i don't
know what this is right so
that's not really helping me out here uh
what this in particular would be
um
so
it was subnet
ids a set of attributes found by the ids
found this data source will fail if none
are found
so if that's the case then what we're
going to be doing is doing dot ids
and then maybe zero like that
okay
it was
subnet ids has not been declared
oh okay so maybe we do
subnet ids ids
is that going to work for us now
by the way this looks all messed up
oh just maybe the indentation here that
doesn't look right
um
yeah this is this is super messed up
hold on here
apparently i lost some of the block
okay so we said subnet ids.ids
a data source vpc main has not been
declared
it's right there
what are they talking about
um
so what i'll do is i'll just cut this
here or like cut it
paste this below here
data vpc
main id
i don't know if we can do like it
depends on on this probably not
apparently we can we can do it i'm
seeing an example where they're doing it
depends on
so what i could do is say
and then i would just specify
data.aws
vpc.main
and we'll see if that helps it out there
we can do terraform init again
and try that
if it doesn't like that maybe we can go
into the directory itself and see if
that will fix it
um
and we'll just do terraform in it here
maybe
i remember ever having to do a knit with
inside of it so
i don't think that's the case
oh you know what it's just this mistake
and you might have caught that
vpc
but the depends on is probably a good
idea
data.vpc.main
we'll try this again
must be a whole object um
okay well we'll take the depends on out
then and we will try this again
because it should be able to infer the
order uh into which it works
a data source another vpc vbc has not
been declared in this
stupid module this is so stupid
data.awsvpc
oh because it's not called vpc it's just
called main
okay
my fault
and so here it says elements of a set
are identified but only their value and
does not um
it does not have separate indexes or
keys with it it's only possible to
perform operations across all elements
in a set
so
let's just look up set so set terraform
i just want to get like the first
element in a set
first element in a
set terraform
one
one takes a list a set of tuple with
either zero or one elements if the
collection is empty
one it returns null otherwise one
returns the first element
so what we can do here is if it's doing
an id i suppose what we could do
is go down to our
subnet id here
and we can say one
and we will try that
apparently it doesn't take an index
invalid value for list parameter must be
a list set or tuple with either values
either 0
or 1 elements
is a set of string with six elements
so
i don't know what this thing is like i
don't know how you would go and say all
right just show me what this value is
what i could try to do here
i'm just trying to think here how could
i see this value
without having to provision the resource
and that's what i don't know
um
[Music]
it's very very frustrating
um
i'll be back in a second okay all right
so this is what i found and what we have
to do is actually convert because this
is actually a set and we need to convert
it to a list at least this is what i
think so what i'm going to do is take
this out of here and we'll wrap it as
such and then we'll give it zero and
maybe that's our problem here
please be the answer
okay so i think it's created now so
yeah that's kind of like and we're not
in that section under the built-in
functions but
this is just where sometimes the data
set returned is a
set
or
those are really frustrating to use and
so i guess you just have to cast it into
another type
um that one function i think should have
worked with it but it just decided not
to for whatever reason
um but in this provisions that are uh
we're all done here and we're all in
good shape
so
yeah that is all good so we can do is
now just tear this down because that
worked no problem
we'll say apply auto approve
okay
and while that is destroying what i'm
going to do i guess i already have the
third one open here i'm going to just
update the code here git
status git add
um
here git commit
oops
fix my module so
should use
the subnet specified
for the vpc from the vpc
okay and we will do a get push
we'll do a git tag 1.1.0
we'll do a git
push
tags
and so now for mo from now on we'll just
use the version 1.1.0
um so that's destroyed we'll go back to
original one here we'll do a terraform
apply auto
approve
destroy
i just want to show you as it's
destroying that if we want to do remote
it's pretty much the same thing we're
just setting the back end as remote and
we're applying that configuration values
there
i'm just going to stick around here just
to make sure that this does destroy just
because
for some reason it just might not
so this was project one
oh we're in project two in both of these
folders okay that doesn't help that that
much
but we're going to wait until this is
destroyed
and then once that's destroyed we will
um
tear down the
vpc okay
all right so we'll just make sure we go
into the other project here project one
and we'll do the same thing
tear that down
so yeah i realize this fall along is a
bit of a mess i could go back and
reshoot it so it's a lot more
streamlined but then i feel like we will
miss all of these kind of little things
and without getting that kind of
experience you're not going to know how
to debug that stuff on your own so i i
feel that i'm just going to keep this
follow along as is
you know hopefully you find value at it
but it will be a frustrating experience
and you'll know this because you'll get
to the end of this okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to be looking at how to
uh force an unlock okay and so what
we're going to do
is as always we're going to need a new
folder here so i'm just going to expand
this and i'm going to
uh reveal in my file exp
explorer here and we're going to make a
new folder here we're going to call it
uh 1 3
uh
locking right okay like force unlocking
i suppose
and i'm gonna try to do this with
terraform cloud because i feel like that
will be the easiest way for us to do
this so i'm gonna just go main.tf
and what i'm going to do is make my way
over to terraform cloud
i know we still have that other
environment that we're using
the uh vcs terraform one but um what i'm
going to do
is
i'm going to create a new workspace i'm
just going to call this one cli driven
we'll say create workspace and this one
oops we're going to say
force unlocking
and then that's going to give us that
nice little code there that we can grab
we'll paste that on in there
and i'm going to go back to our last
tutorial here where we had project two
and
because i need something that's going to
take a little bit of time so that we can
force and unlock right
so i'll go ahead and grab that code
we'll paste that on in there and we are
actually are going to use the version if
we can here because i would rather do
that
and this is going to be terraform
[Music]
it was apache example
i think i have to exam pro code to get
that module there
and it's going to be version 1.1.0
and we are not going to import our vpc
id here we're just going to set it like
we did before
so just say var vpc id
and we will need a variables here so
we'll
say and we'll have to go over to
our
project here
we'll copy that over
and what i want is to add the vpc id
here
okay
and i really don't feel like entering
all the state form files i guess i'm
going to have to there's not really any
way around that i suppose i'm going to
cd back here
terraform init
um
cannot apply constraint to a
non-registered url so i've clearly
entered that incorrectly we'll go up to
here and see what it was
this one's referencing it locally
we used it in another project here
maybe we used in the remote state one
here
nope
uh standard probably
there it is
okay so we'll go ahead and grab that
we're going to go down to our main here
we're going to paste that on in
and i'm going to do terraform
init
just going to initialize that back in
there for us
and while that's going i'm going to go
set up our variables because it always
takes a thousand years so we need to add
quite a few here so i'm just going to
pull this over here and then pull this
over there
i'm going to go look at a previous one
here where we have tfrs
so
we want a vpc id here
okay
we want our mo our my
cider block here
we're going to get our public key here
we're going to add another instance type
we're going to add a server name
and we're going to need our environment
variables never can remember these so
we're going to go over to the terraform
registry
have this open already up here so we go
to the top terraform registry
we'll go over to providers just make
this a little bit smaller here whoops a
little bit too small
and we will go to documentation scroll
on down
grab these keys here this is going to go
first that's going to be sensitive we're
going to cat as always
and we're going to grab the first one
here
paste that in
go grab the second one here
forgot the name here so we'll grab that
one here
we'll say uh whatever the region is here
i should really memorize these so i
don't have to ever have to
look up that page again
um that one's not sensitive we probably
want the secret sensitive that's
probably more important than the key
okay and so we're all configured here to
go
and so
what i want to do is deploy this but
before i do i just want to double check
to make sure that i know how to use the
force unlock so i'm just gonna
go here and we're gonna just pull up
some documentation so we're gonna say
terraform force unlock
and so we just write terraform force
unlock lock id
we need the actual key there
um
so we can disable it with the hyphen
lock command here
so that's what i need to find out so
all right i'll be back in a second okay
all right so what's going to happen is
um
when we run it it's going to give us
that output of a lock id when we do
terraform apply twice
so i'm going to do is do terraform apply
auto approve
to get this going i'm hoping this just
works
you got to spell that right with two p's
and we're just waiting for that plan to
start
and while that's going i'm just going to
open up a another one here
i'm going to make my way into the same
directory cd
one three
or it's one three two
oops
we've got to be quick here
that's old so i'm gonna close that out
that's old
i'll go back to this one i want to get
it before it finishes
so what i'll do is type in um
terraform apply
and what it's going to say is that it's
locked
if we can do this quick enough
oh interesting so it says waiting for
one runs to finish before queued so i
guess this is a case where if we're
using terraform cloud we're not going to
be able to get that lock id and i guess
the only way to unlock it would be to go
into
uh terraform cloud itself as it's
executing
right and see how it's running and from
there you could do a force unlock but
that's not what we were trying to do
we're trying to use the actual command
so i could show you
so that means that we do have to um use
a terraform back end
and so if that's the case what i'm going
to do
is
once this is done here so now it's
triggering the other one just gonna stop
that so we're gonna go back to our
original one here and i'm just gonna
tear this down
uh destroy
and i'm gonna go back over here and what
i wanna do is go back to our uh standard
back end tutorial
because that'll make it a lot easier for
us to do in that one
and so we will just go and close off
these here
close out our tabs
and what i want to do here is go to
[Music]
our main one here
and we need to upgrade that to 1.10
and the other problem is that we're
gonna have to actually set this up for a
dynamodb table so
not only we're gonna have to create this
folder right so
what i want you to do is go to your s3
and we wanna make sure that we already
have this uh bucket
and we do good
we'll go over to dynovaddb
and create ourselves a new
thing here
so say create table and as always
they're updating the ui and i just want
to call this like uh
force unlock
terraform i don't know what we'd have to
set as the partition key
that's a good question so
state locking dynamodb terraform
okay
so
which can be enabled by setting the
dynamodb table field existing a single
tip it can be used to lock multiple
remote state files
it's not saying here like
what we have to set up as the key for
this
okay so maybe we can just set it i don't
think it's going to auto create it but
let's give it a go and see what happens
okay
so i'm going to go down to dynamodb
options
here it is
custom end point to the adabus dynamodb
api this can be sourced from the
endpoint
and there's the table name used for
state locking the table must have a
primary key of lock id with the type
string okay so that's our instructions
there
and we're going to go back to dynamodb
we're going to set up our partition key
and that's going to be a string we don't
need to set a sort key here
default settings are fine
and that's going to go ahead and create
there
and so what i'm going to do is grab that
name
and what we need is dynamodb table
okay so i'm going to do terraform init
and we're going to migrate the state i'm
totally fine with that
yes
great and so now if i do terraform apply
oh right we have that old code in there
that we're not using
all right so yeah we have some old code
here we need to remove so we're going to
just take out
this workspaces thing um to see if
there's anything else remaining there no
i think that's it
so we'll go ahead and we'll try this
again
and uh we are going to make sure we're
going to switch to both of them in order
for this to work so i'm just going to go
here ahead of time okay we'll go back
over to here no problems this time
around so we'll say yes
and that is provisioning so i'm going to
go back to this one here and i'm just
going to type in terraform apply
and it should complain saying hey this
is locked right now you shouldn't unlock
it and so this is where you would grab
that id okay
and so you would just type in terraform
force unlock and then we'd paste the
value in here
and the thing is this is where you just
type yes but we definitely don't want to
do this because the other one is
provisioning but i just wanted to show
you how you get that id and pass it
along
um
and you know when i'm talking about
state locking in the lecture content i
kind of wrote about here it says state
locking happens automatically on all
operations that could write state you
won't see any message that it is
happening if state locking fails so it's
true as
locking is happening it doesn't tell you
that it's going on but it will tell you
when you do another terraform apply
we'll say hey
it's in it's in state so
i didn't technically lie here but i
guess that could be like a little
highlight that would have been good in
the lecture content there
um but i'm just going to cancel it out
there we're going to go back to our
first one here
and we can see that that was deployed
and
what we can do
for fun i don't think there'll be
anything within dynamodb because i think
that it will create the record and then
get rid of it but we just click into our
table here
and we go view items notice there's zero
items right now well no there it is okay
so there was a an id at one point
so i think that is good and what i'm
going to do is just go ahead and destroy
the infrastructure
type yes
and while that is happening
um well we gotta wait for this to finish
but once that is done then we'll go
ahead and we'll just tear down the
dynamodb and um
s3 bucket okay all right so that is done
destroying there so what i want to do
here is go ahead
and uh just delete this table
really don't like this new ui i don't
know who came up with this
yep we'll delete all that
make our way over to s3 here
and i'm going to go ahead and just
delete this table
we'll have to go in and just delete all
the records first
pretty sure we turned off versioning
there so there's no versioning right now
and
[Music]
oh i went into the wrong bucket not that
it matters that's old anyway
oh cool yeah so we didn't look at this
earlier but when we had production and
staging they placed them into these
areas here
okay
so that's kind of
cool um
i guess it's something i didn't look at
but
if we go terraform
workspace list are we in the default one
i would have thought we were in there eh
oh we're in the production one okay so
i mean i never showed this to you
earlier because we didn't actually
deploy it but um we actually did do a
deploy this time around
and i guess both the environments were
set up here and they had their own
folders so that's kind of interesting to
see
we'll go ahead and we'll just go delete
all this
and i'm just going to leave the bucket
around here just in case i want to use
it again but it is completely emptied
out so
we're good from scratch so there you go
[Music]
all right let's talk about resources so
resources in configuration files
represent infrastructure objects such as
virtual machines databases virtual
network components and storage and so it
pretty much looks like this a resource
type is determines the kind of
infrastructure object it is so here it
says aws instance and this would
represent an ac database ec2 instance
this is all defined within the
provider's documentation so you have to
kind of look at what name they use to
figure out what it is and even though
you don't see provider explicitly set
here a resource does belong to a
provider and you can explicitly set it
and you would do this when you'd want to
set a resource outside the default
provider that you have in your
configuration file um and so one little
thing that i hadn't mentioned anywhere
else and that's why i made this slide
was to mention about special timeout
nested blocks within resources so some
resource types provide a special timeout
nested block argument that allows you to
customize how long certain operations
are allowed to take before being
considered to have failed okay so there
you go
[Music]
let's talk about complex types so a
complex type is a type that groups
multiple values into a single value and
complex types are represented by type
constructors but several of them are
have shorthand keyword versions okay so
there are two categories of complex
types we have collection types for
grouping similar values so list map set
and structural types for grouping
potentially to similar values so tuple
and object and now that we have an
overview let's go jump into collection
types and structural types
[Music]
a collection type allows multiple values
of one other type to be grouped together
as a single value and the type of value
within a collection is called its
element type the three kinds of
collection types are list map and set
and so looking at our first one here
what we're doing is we are setting
ourselves something that looks kind of
like an array it's this list type here
and what we can do is use our index so
the indices 0 to reference the first
element which is mars so that's going to
make our user name mars for a map it's
very similar to a ruby hash or a single
nested json object and the idea here is
that it's very similar to the first
except now we're doing a key and value
and then we access it by based on the
key name so plan b
is going to return 50 usd okay
we have set it is similar to a list but
has no secondary index or preserved
ordering
all values must be of the same type and
will be cast to match the first element
okay so it's a great way to kind of have
um well i guess no secondary index but
yeah so you do two set and then it would
turn into this okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
structural type so a structural type
allows multiple values of several
distinct types to be grouped together
with a single value structural types
require a schema as an argument to
specify which types are allowed for
which elements so this is what they're
talking about when they say this schema
so when you actually define the variable
notice where it says object and you are
actually setting a is going to be a
string and b is going to be a string
there's this optional option which i
think is right now in beta uh but
hopefully by the time this course is out
or it's the future you have that option
there but just assume that they're all
required so that's what they're talking
about is that you are specifying exactly
what you expect the schema to be okay so
there are two kinds of structural types
we have objects and tuples and they're
going to look very familiar to
maps and lists because they're pretty
much the same but with explicit typing
so object is a map with more explicit
keying so this example we'd have name
for string age for number and so that's
what it would expect the data structure
to be for tuple multiple return types
with a parameter so we can have string
number or boolean so this is where we'd
have um a
as a string 15 or true as a boolean so
yep there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to look at
the collection and structural type so i
have a new folder down below
just in case we need to define some
things so i'm going to go here and just
call this main.tf
and we are just going to configure this
for local terraforms we'll just give the
brackets there and so the idea is that
we might have different kinds of
variables
and we had done this previously where we
created
a list and a map but we can do that
again so we'll have like planet
right
so that's list and then we just default
that to a value mars
earth
moon
and then we could also have you know
plans here and that would be our map
type
okay and so here we'll just set it
with the curlies
plan a
plan b
plan c
um
so we'll do terraform console and so
that should load
these variables for us to use
and so if i do var.plans
i get that and if i do var.planets
i didn't like what i did there input
variable has not been declared
i suppose it's just planet there so i
should have named that planets up here
and so what we're going to do here is
just go ahead and exit
type clear
i'm just going to expand this a bit
bigger so we're taking over more of the
screen now let's take a look at
structural types so these require you to
actually define um
parameters so what i'm going to do is go
down below and we're going to do the
object
and object is very similar to the map so
let's go down here
plans object
and so
here what we do is we'd say
type object
and we would just have to define some
settings here
so we could say
a is a string
all right we'll see if that works
the default value is not compatible with
the variable type constraint attribute a
is required
so that's fine um what we could do is
just
define this as like plan a
plan b
plan c
and now if we just do var plans object
when you are using this you know you
might want to specify some different
kinds here so you could just say like
you say like plan here
so we say plan name
plan amount
maybe it's like number
and so then we'd say plan name
plan amount
basic
maybe this would be 10.
okay and we'll just uh
type exit here and go back into
terraform cloud hopefully we don't get
an error here so the plan amount is
required so you know we can't have a
spelling mistake here
just do var plan here
um
well we named it correctly there and
when we went up here and specified it i
think we got it right plan object
so
sure what it doesn't like here oh you
know what we're not in terraform cloud
okay that's fair
and we're still spelling this wrong
oops
okay so there we go we got our basic
plan
and then we can do a tuple here so
i don't know if i've ever defined a
tuple before so let's just try it here
and so we'll just say uh
um
groceries or val or
random
type equals tuple
i'm just looking up if there's any kind
of definition i can find here
i'm not really finding anything but i'm
just going to go uh define this here
because i thought maybe it needed like a
schema or something but maybe it doesn't
so we'll just say
hello 22
false
okay
terraform console
typical constructor requires one
argument specifying the element types as
a list
okay so if that's the case then what we
could do is say string
number
boolean
the uh type constructor requires one
argument supposed to find the number of
elements
so clearly i'm doing this wrong so just
give me a second i'll be back in a
moment okay all right so i think the
problem here was just that i need to
make brackets here like this
we'll give that a go
boolean is not a valid option what if we
try bool
okay we say var.random
good and so i'll just go ahead and exit
that out i'm going to see what happens
if i change the order here so let's say
i do instead of 22 here
we go here
okay so notice that you know we can have
all sorts of kinds but they have to
match exactly the order that is there so
yeah that's pretty much it so there you
go
[Music]
the terraform language includes a number
of built-in functions that you can call
from within expressions to transform
your combined values so we have numeric
string collection encoding file system
date and time hash and crypto ipnetwork
type conversions so we are going to go
through all of these we might not go
through every single function but we'll
go through every single major category
uh in terms of the exam the only thing
that's going to show up might be string
functions why they do this i don't know
it's not a very good exam question but
those might appear but i think that this
is one of the strongest features of
terraform over something like cloud
formation
and i really want to just show you the
gambit of them okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at numeric
functions starting with absolute so
returns the absolute value of a given
number so 23 is 23 0 is zero and if you
get a negative number it's going to flip
to the positive for four what it does is
it rounds down to the nearest whole
number so see where it says 4.9 becomes
a four
you have log so it returns the
logarithmic i can't say that word
logarithm logarithm of a given number in
a given base so log 50 comma 10 is going
to give you that 16 comma 2 is going to
give you 4 okay
seal it it's where it will always round
up so see where it says 5.1 and it goes
all the way to 6. we have min so take
one or more numbers and return the
smallest number from the set and max
take one or more numbers and return the
greatest number of the set i don't have
examples because that's pretty
straightforward you know if there's a
two and a four it's going to return the
two in min if it's a two and a four it's
going to return the four for max
we have parse in so parses the given
string as a representation of an integer
in the specified base and returns the
resulting number
so if we have a hundred here in strings
it's going to and we say comma 10 we're
going to get 100 because that's the base
system it's base system 10
base system 16 we can see letters in
there right so it's able to translate
that this is two so that's basically
binary so zeros and ones so you get the
idea there
uh pow so calculates an exponent by
raising its first argument to the power
of the second argument so that's just
the way of doing powers and then we have
signum so determine the sign of a number
returning a number between negative one
and one to represent the sign
so there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
string functions the first being chomp
so removes new line characters at the
end of a string so you know if there's a
hyphen n or sorry backslash n you don't
want to see that there that's the way
you get rid of it then you have formats
it produces a string by formatting a
number of other values according to the
specification
so here there are uh percentage delight
so this is representing a uh a digit so
it's taking that number this says it's
going to be formatted as a string okay
um format list so produce a list of
strings by formatting a number of other
values according to a specification
string
so here we have an array and then we
have our specification so you can see
it's substituting the name there
we'll look at indent so adds a given
number of spaces to the beginnings of
all but the first line in a given
multi-string
so here we have a string um and what
it's going to do is see where we have
the interpolation here and then we have
indent i know the highlighting is not
great because it's a single string but
we have interpolation we have
parentheses two so give it a a layer of
two indentation
and then it's going to break that up and
give it indentation so we have join so
produce a string by concatenating
together all elements of a given list of
strings with the given delimiter
so you use delimiters is double click or
sorry is a comma and so it's going to
glue that together to make this okay
if there's only a single one there just
won't be any comma in there we can lower
all the text it's pretty straightforward
we have regular expressions so that is
an extremely powerful feature so here we
have the regex i don't know what the
regex format is
maybe it's pearl i'm not sure
there's like a bunch of different types
of regex standards so you know do you
have to figure that out so you know how
to use it and then there's a regex all
supplies to a regular expression to a
string and returns a list of matches
where this just is returning uh one okay
we have replaced so search is a given
string for another given substring and
replaces uh each occurrence within a
given replacement string so it's just
like the javascript replace we have
split this is the opposite of join so if
we want to split on the comma we specify
comma here we have str rev so string
reverse so reverse is a string so hello
becomes holley
we have sub
hole
sure i don't know
um so string so extracts a substring
from a given string by offset and and
length so we have a sub string and we're
saying we want one to four so we only
want uh one two three four here okay
because it starts at zero
we have title so make a title case we'll
capitalize the h and the w we have trim
removes the specified character from the
start and end of the string so we don't
want these and we tell it to remove
those
there's a lot of string functions so we
have trim prefix so removes the
specified prefix from the start of the
given string if the string does not
start with the prefix the string is uh
is returned and unchanged so here we say
we want to get rid of hello in the front
so we do that suffix is the opposite so
we want to get a rid of world out of the
suffix so we do that we have trim space
that removes all types of white space
from both the start and end of the line
so it gets rid of the new lines and the
spaces upper is going to put everything
to upper and there you go on the exam
they probably will ask you uh like what
string function does or which one does
not do something so this is the only
part of the building functions you have
to know for the exam i don't think it's
a very good exam question but it does
appear there so you need to know it okay
[Music]
we're on to collection functions and
these are the most powerful built-in
functions and there's a lot of them and
i made sure to give you an example for
each one because i really do want you to
know these because this is the power of
terraform the first on our list here is
all true so returns true if all elements
in a given collection are true or true
or it also returns true if the
collection is empty so it's either true
true right or we have true false so
because there's a false it's not going
to be true so any true is very similar
but there only has to be one that is
true so if this is true and there's a
false it's going to be true if it's
blank it's going to be false okay we
have chunkless splits a string
list into fixed size chunks returning a
list of lists
so
here we're telling it to chunk it every
two so grab every two and make them into
their own little array or list i suppose
we have coalesce takes any number of
arguments returns the first one that
isn't null or empty string if you're
used to postgres you use this all the
time but the idea is it's going to
grab the a in this case it'll grab the b
because that's blank in this case we'll
grab the one because that's the first
value we have coalesce list takes any
number of list arguments and returns the
first one that isn't empty so very
similar it's just using lists or if we
want to call them array so the first one
is available so it takes that one
we have compact so takes a list of
strings and returns a new list with an
empty string elements removed so it's
just going to get rid of that space
there and we'll get abc
we have concat so it takes two or more
lists and combines them into a single
list so that's very convenient we have
contains so determines whether a given
list or set contains a given single
value as one of its elements so does it
have an a yes it does does it have a d
no it does not
we have distinct so it takes a list and
returns a new list with any duplicate
elements
removed so we just want to make sure we
only have one of each so do we have any
duplicates here we have two a's
and two b so we're going to end up with
just a single list so only exactly one
of each letter
we have element retrieves a single
element from a list so get me the
element at
3 here so um wait retrieves a single
element from a list
okay well that's what it does you give
it a three and it gives you an a i don't
know why it's not clicking for me but
i'm i'm not following through here uh
index finds the element index for a
given value in a list so we say where is
b and the index of b is is one because
it'd be zero and this would be one still
really confused about this one uh
flatten takes a list and replaces any
elements that are are
lists with a flattened sequence of list
content so basically it says give me a
bunch of arrays or lists turn into one
flat list
keys take a map and return a list
containing the keys from the map so we
just want the keys a c and d
we want length this is pretty
straightforward so what's the length of
this zero this is two this is one
because it's a one
map or one thing key value in there and
if it's a string it's going to count the
characters so there's five characters
we have lookup so retrieves the value of
a single element from a map
given its key
if the given key does not exist the
given default value is returned instead
so we say
uh lookup a
and what we get is a y right look up c
and
it could not find c so by default give
us what instead
a match keys construct a new list by
taking a subset of elements from one
list whose indexes match the
corresponding indexes of values in
another list
that sounds complicated let's read that
one more time so constructs a new list
by taking a subset
of elements from one list who indexes
match the corresponding index of values
in another list that is confusing so we
have one list and another one so we have
this one here
and we have us west u.s east usd so we
say okay we have usc's so the elements
here is two and three so give us two and
three so that's what it does
that was it that was the tricky one i
can't think of what you use that for but
that's a interesting function merge
takes an arbitrary number of maps or
objects and returns a single map or
object that contains a merged set of
elements from all arguments
so it just merges them together so it's
just like concat
or i suppose like fladden uh one takes a
list set or tuple values from uh with
either zero
or one elements if the collection is
empty one returns null otherwise one
returns the first element if there are
two or more elements then one will uh
one will return an error
so
it returns null and an empty list it
returns the first one and then here it
says invalid function so it's just
saying is there one right is one or zero
uh ranges generates a list of numbers
using a start value a limit value and a
step value so we say 3 and we get 0 1
and 2.
generates a list of numbers using a
start value limit value and a step value
okay
uh reverse so takes a sequence and
produces
res or not reverse
reserve sorry reserve takes a sequence
and produces a number
uh induced sequence of the same length
with all the same elements as the given
sequence but in reverse order
oh it is reverse r e reverse i guess i
spelt it wrong here sorry reverse one
two three three two one just notice this
is a spelling mistake okay
uh set intersection so function takes
multiple sets and produces a single set
containing only the elements that all of
the given sets have in common in other
words it computes the intersection of
the sets
well that's tiring so from what i can
tell it's like they all have b so give
us b right
set product functions find all the
possible combinations of elements from
all
of the given sets by computing the
kardasterian product we're really
getting into math here so
we got app one and app two
and so we get uh development develop
okay so this continues on so it's gonna
say give me app one with development
give me uh
app two with development then app one
with staging and then app two with
staging and etc etc because that's why i
put the three dots there
set subtract function returns a new set
containing the elements from the
from the first set that are not present
in the second set and in other words it
computes the relative complement of the
first set in the second set
uh it lost me there but it says set
subtract so here i see a b and c a and c
minus it you get b okay
set union function takes multiple sets
and produces a single set containing the
elements from all the given sets in
other words it computes the union of the
sets
so it says set union so we have
a b b c and d and in the results we get
d b c a so i guess
um single set containing the elements
from all the given so yeah yeah i guess
it's just we get unique ones across the
sets uh we have slice and notice like
we're going through all these things
it's like you probably won't use these
more exotic ones so it's not a big deal
if we don't nail them here but it's
important that we go through these so
that you know you just know all the
options are here so slice extract some
constructive
consecutive elements from within a list
so here we are saying one and three so
we have b and c that's where they start
index one
[Music]
and then
extract some consecutive elements from
within a list
one
comma three
okay
sort takes a list of strings and returns
a new list with those strings sorted
lexographically so we have e d a and x
and so now they're alphabetical so a d e
and x
well i think this is the last one uh sum
takes a list of set numbers and returns
the sum of those values that's pretty
straightforward add them all up
transpose take a map of list of strings
and swap the key and values to produce a
new map a list of strings so kind of
like inverts it values takes a map and
returns a list containing the values of
the map so we saw this earlier we got
the keys this is where we just want to
get the values
zipmap so construct a map from a list of
keys and a corresponding list of values
so we have a b one two and this turns it
into a equal one b equals two i think i
saw this on the exam so that one you
might wanna remember but yeah that's
collection functions as you can imagine
they're extremely powerful but they can
also be really confusing so maybe just
use them a little bit when you need to
okay
[Music]
we're taking a look here at encoding and
decoding functions so functions that
will encode and decode for various
formats so imagine we need to encode
into base64 so we do hello world or
imagine we give that
encoded string and we want to decode it
back to hello world uh that's what we
can do so there's a lot of different
encoding decoding functions most of them
are the same they're just kind of
variants so we're not going to go
through every single one but i'll list
them out so you know what they are so we
have base64 encode json and code text
encode base64 yamlin code base64 gzip
url and code
base64 decode csv code json decode text
decode base64
yaml decode
and just notice that you know these
aren't one to one so there is one for
this
uh we have one for here
uh we have one for yaml
and this is unique this is unique this
is unique okay just so you can tell for
your encode i think this one's a very
common one that you'll use but the idea
is that let's say you have hello world
you want to replace that string with a
whatever friendly for a url right so it
just encodes it okay it's very useful
when you're making uh url links so there
you go
[Music]
we're taking a look here at file system
functions so this has everything to do
with the file system so the first is
absolute path so the idea is you give it
something that's relative and it's going
to give you something absolute
directory name so this is a string
containing a file system path and
removes the last portion from it so we
don't need the file name so we just
remove that off of there we have path
expand so it takes a fascism path that
might begin with a tilde and expands it
into uh its absolute path so this would
be like for home okay
base name so it takes a string
containing a file system path and it's
basically the opposite of directory name
we just want the file here okay
onto uh the next page here
this file will read the contents of the
file pretty straightforward
we can check if a file exists so we just
do file exists here we have file set so
it enumerates a set of regular file
names given a path and pattern
file base64 so reads the contents of a
file at a given path and returns the
base64 encoding that might be good for
images template file so reads the file
at a given path and returns its content
as a template using a supplied set of
template variables so that's really
useful if you want to do some kind of
templating
and just notice it's a two-set process
so this is the template file the actual
file itself and then we load it here
it's called a dot tpl
so there you go
[Music]
we're taking a look at date and time
functions the first is format date so
the idea is that we provide a
format that we want and then we give it
a time stamp that is in the rfc 3339
format and we get a variety of different
um
formats out there we can add time so
again it's gonna be that rfc 339 format
and we say add 10 minutes add one hour
then we have timestamp so you it returns
a utc timestamp string in the rfc 3239
format so you just say timestamp it's i
guess it would get right now and then
you get it in that format okay
[Music]
let's take a look at hash and crypto
functions so generates hashes and
cryptographic strings so the most
popular one out there would probably be
b crypt so here we just say hello world
and we're going to get this thing here
uh understand that a hash cannot be
reversed so once it is turned uh into uh
you know this format the only way you're
going to be able to confirm the contents
of it is to
hash something that is similar and then
compare it against it okay
so we have base 64
sha256 we have 512 we got bcrypt we have
file base64 64 sha-256 file based 64
sha-512 file md5 file sha 1 file sha 56
file sha 512 md5 rsa decrypts sha 1 sha
to v6 sha-512 uuid uid v5 so i only
showed the one because you know
it gets kind of boring to go through all
these and really it's just going to be
based on your use case what you're going
to be using on a day-to-day basis is
probably bcrypt md5 and uuids so there
you go
[Music]
let's take a look at ip network
functions these are the coolest
functions i think that are built into
terraform so we have cider hosts so what
we can do is give ourselves a um
a address and then we can give it a
subnet mass size and we'll get back an
ip address
and so you can see we have this both in
the ipv4 and the ipv6
we have cider net mask so here we are
doing saturn net mass so we just say
forward slash 12 and it's going to
translate it into the full ipv4
then we have cider subnet so this is
just where we say okay i want a subnet
of a particular size so we say 172 16 0
0 comma 4 2 and look it's going to give
us 18 0 back this doesn't make sense
that's okay i mean networking is really
hard but i just want you to know that
these functions are here for you okay
cider subnet calculates a sequence of
consecutive ip addresses within a
particular cider prefix so four four
eight four and then you get those sizes
there okay
[Music]
all right we're on to type conversion
function so the first we're looking at
is can so can evaluates the given
expression and returns a boolean value
indicating whether the expression
produced a result without any error so
can we use this right so we say local
dot foo dot bar and so you know if if
this foo wasn't defined then it would
say false but apparently we made it all
the way to bar okay
we have defaults a specialized function
intended for use with input variables
whose type constraints are object types
or collection of object types that
include optional attributes
and i don't show that one here because
it's not that exciting but non-sensitive
takes a sensitive value and returns a
copy of that value with the sensitive
markings removed therefore exposing the
sensitive values so if we have an output
here and we want to make it
non-sensitive that's what we could do
then sensitive as you imagine is just
the opposite okay
um we have to bool so converts its
arguments to a boolean value so if we
have a string that's true we can turn it
into a real boolean value we have to map
converts an argument to a map value to
set converts it to a set to list
converts it to a list two number
converts it to a number uh string to
string and then we last we have is try
so evaluates all of its arguments
expressions in turn returns the result
of the first one that does not produce
any errors the thing that's the hardest
to figure out is set i cannot find
really good examples of documentation on
the use case of set there are some cases
where you need to use sets which is an
actual type but even talking to da's and
technical writers they weren't even sure
themselves so
this is not something you're going to
come across very often but
there's like one case where i saw it so
i'll probably point that out when we do
hit it okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are going to go take a look at um
built-in functions as soon as my
terminal decides to be responsive i
don't know why as soon as i start
recording it decides to lock up
so let's just give it a moment there
there we go and so i have a new folder
there i figured we could just define
some variables so that we don't have to
uh
you know constantly write stuff in so
we'll just say main.tf
we're going to go terraform here
and so might be fun to you know set kind
of some kind of variable here and so i
have off screen here all the functions
so we're just going to kind of pick some
at random here to play around with so we
get some experience okay
so just going through strings
i think what we can do is define like
our string so we just say str here
and we'll just say type equal string
and we'll just say default here able to
say hello
world
forward slash n
something like that
okay
and then we'll do terraform console here
i gotta remember to do it this way
so we do var.str
okay so that accesses our string there
maybe we might want to take out the new
line for now
so i'm just going to kind of pull this
up over here
look at some kind of things we can do
okay maybe collapse that get that out of
the way all right so um there's a lot of
string functions and on the exam they
might actually ask you some which is in
my opinion i don't i don't really like
that but that's what they do
and so you might we might want to look
at something like split or something so
here we could do
hello world
okay
start that up again
so we'll do split
comma
var str okay and that would split that
into a list
we might want to do something
like upper so i think we did that
earlier where we did upper
okay
you might want to do trim
remove specify characters from the start
and end of a string so maybe we have
this here
and so we'll say
trim
var str
and
whoops that's not what i wanted it to do
trim bar str
like that okay
and uh there's again there's not a lot
that's exciting here maybe we'll try a
replace
so we can do replace
and we'll we want to replace we will
provide our string
and then the substring that we're
looking for so world
replace that with barsoon which is mars
there we go
so nothing super exciting over there
uh what's more interesting are some
things like these hash and cryptos
so something we might want to generate
out as a uuid
i think that we might be able to do this
here so let's just see what happens if
we try to call it like that
clear
terraform cloud
oops terraform console that's what i
meant to type
and so functions can't be called in here
which is totally fine
so go back and just set that like that
i just wanted to show you that
so if we did uuid we would get that
if we used bcrypt
so let's say bcrypt
hello world
okay
might be something interesting the ip
network here
so you might want to generate out a
cider subnet
right
the type of conversions is something
that you might come across a bit so we
already saw that when we converted a set
to a list and things like that
so maybe we might want to convert
something to a boolean so we might say
to bool
true
okay
these are pretty complicated the
collections
but we might have something that we want
to do here so last might be something
that's interesting where we have an
array so or
a list i suppose
so we might say like items
and make that a list
null
null empty
last
okay
bar
items so we might say coal
less
okay
and that didn't look like it pulled
anything out of there to perform
coalesce operation with a list of
strings use this symbol so we could use
that um
to do that so that just kind of expands
the arguments and so that what happened
here is null didn't exist all didn't
exist this didn't exist so it pulled out
last okay
maybe we might want to just use keys
maybe we might just want to use keys
here
okay so i'm gonna say like hello
world
goodbye
moon remember we can do uh hash
rocket arrow equals or colons just up to
your preference i just wrote that in for
whatever reason i'm used to using ruby
and that's what we use as hashrockets
that's the name of the symbol the a
equals arrow
um okay it didn't like that so i guess
we do have to do it this way that's
totally fine i'm not upset by that i
thought it supported all three
maybe it's like minus equals or
something i don't know
but we'll do say it's a var stuff
and then what we can do here is do keys
okay
and
it didn't look like it grabbed the oh
yeah i grabbed the keys that's fine okay
and then we might say values
all right
um
you know maybe we might want to try
reverse that one's pretty clear
one two three
okay so nothing super complicated um i
wonder if absolute would work in here
like the file system so we have absolute
path
but i don't know if this would produce
anything here oh it does okay so get abs
path
say path dot root
there you go
okay so that pretty much gives you a
general idea of built-in functions so
there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
terraform cloud again but in greater
detail so terraform cloud is an
application that helps teams use
terraform together uh and so there is
the ui there and terraform cloud is
available as a hosted service on
terraform terraform dot io it's actually
the app.terraform.i once you're logged
in and it has a lot of different
features so it can manage state files uh
have a history of your previous runs a
history of your previous states easy and
secure variable injection tagging run
triggers of chaining workspaces together
specify any version of terraform per
workspace global state sharing
commenting on runs notifications via web
hooks email and slack organization and
workspace level permissions policy is
code via sentinel policy sets mfa single
sign-on uh cost estimation integrations
with service now splunk kubernetes and
custom run tasks and that is not the
limit to what it does but this is what i
could fit on the slide okay
[Music]
let's take a quick look here at the
terminology or anatomy of terraform
clouds so we have an organization and
with an organization we have our
workspaces and a workspace represents a
unique environment or stack then you
have your teams these are composed of
multiple members and a team can be
signed to multiple workspaces then you
have runs a run represents a single run
of the terraform run environment that is
operating on an execution plan runs can
be uh
triggered by like you your the ui itself
or maybe like a git repo it could be api
driven or cli driven so there you go
[Music]
so there are three types of cloud run
workflows so when you create a workspace
you have to choose a workflow and you
have either version control workflow we
have cli driven workflow or api driven
workflow okay
so
just going over them in greater detail
for the first one which is that uh
version controlled workflow uh terraform
cloud is integrated with a specific
branch in your vcs so githubs via web
hooks whenever pull requests are
submitted for branch speculative plans
are generated whenever a merge occurs to
that branch then a run is triggered on
terraform cloud then you have api driven
so workspaces are not directly
associated with the version control
system repository and runs are not
driven by web hooks on your vcs provider
a third-party tool or system will
trigger runs via uploading a
configuration file uh via the terraform
cloud api so this configuration file is
a bash script that is packaged in an
archive and you're pushing it as a
configuration version so you're
basically creating configuration
versions every time you do that then
there's cli driven and this is the way
we're going to be using mostly in the
course so runs are triggered by the user
running terraform cli commands so you'll
run tear from apply
and or plan locally on your machine it's
going to just work as per usual okay
[Music]
let's take a look at organization level
permissions which manage certain
resources or settings across an
organization so the first
things that you can set would be
something like manage policy so create
edit delete the organization's central
policies manage policy override so
override soft mandatory policy checks
manage workspaces so create administer
all workspaces within an organization
manage vcs settings so set of vcs
providers and ssh keys available within
the organization and for an organization
we have this concept of organization
owners so every organization has at
least one organization owner and you can
have multiple this is a special role
that has every available permission and
some actions only available to owners so
this could be publishing private modules
invite users to organizations manage
team memberships view all secret teams
manage organization permissions manage
all organization settings manage
organization billings delete
organizations and manage agents so just
understand that there are these special
ones
just for this organizational owner and
then these are these other ones here
that you can set for other types of
organizational level permissions okay
well let's take a look here at workspace
level permissions that allows you to
manage resources and settings for a
specific resource and we have granular
ones and then we have pre-made
permissions so let's go through the
granular permissions first so these
granular permissions you can apply to a
user via a custom workspace permissions
and so we have read runs cue plans apply
runs lock and unlock workspaces download
signal mocks read variables read and
write read state outputs read state
versions read and write state versions
and so the idea is that what you can do
is just go and cherry pick out what you
want to assemble
your permissions for your user now if
you want something a little bit easier
to do you can use fix permission sets
and these are pre-made permissions for
quick assignment and they're based on
the read plan and write so we have read
runs read variables read state versions
for plans we have q plans read variables
read state versions we have write so
apply runs lock and unlock workspaces
download settings mocks read and write
variables read and write state versions
and then there are workspace admins and
this is kind of like the organizational
owner so a workspace admin is a special
role that grants all level of
permissions and some workspace
admin-only permissions those admin-only
permissions would be read and write
workspace settings set or
remove workspace permissions of any team
and delete workspaces so there you go
let's take a look here at api tokens so
terraform cloud supports three types of
api tokens users teams and organization
tokens so for organization api tokens
they have permissions across the entire
organization each organization can have
one ballot api token at a time only
organization owners can generate or
revoke an organization token
organization api tokens are designed for
creating and configuring workspaces and
teams they're not recommended as all
purpose interfaces to terraform cloud so
basically you just use them when you are
setting up your organization for the
first time and you want to do it
pragmatically okay then you have team
api tokens so this allows access to
workspaces that the team has access to
without being tied to any specific user
each team can have one valid api token
at a time any member of a team can
generate or revoke that team's token
when a token is regenerated the previous
token is immediately becomes invalid
designed for performing api operations
on the workspaces same access level to
the workspace the team has to access to
i would imagine this is when you're
setting up your own custom ci cd
pipelines or something like that i'm not
really sure exactly the use case for
team api tokens we have user api tokens
the most flexible token type because
they inherit permissions from the user
they are associated uh could be for a
real user or a machine user when you do
terraform login this is what you're
getting a a
a user api token okay
[Music]
all right so i just wanted to quickly
show you this access levels chart that
helps you understand
what kind of permissions you're giving
at the access level and notice there's
implicit and then required or explicit
permissions i'm assuming that this means
that you need to assign those
permissions to the user first before
they'd have it so just because you have
a user token doesn't mean you get all of
these orange
diamonds it's just the ones that you've
assigned to that user or team where i
believe that the organization you're
going to run into a chance where you're
going to have all these permissions by
default whether you want them or not so
just understand
that you have to double check this
before you use your tokens and that this
chart exists okay
[Music]
all right so we covered private registry
earlier in the course and we were
looking at the terraform registry the
public one but let's cover it again with
a little bit different information so
terraform cloud allows you to publish
private modules for your organization
within terraform cloud private registry
and tour from cloud's private module
registry helps you share terraform
modules across your organization include
support for module versioning a
searchable filterable list of available
modules a configuration designer which i
didn't find this thing but it sounds
really cool all users in your
organization can view
your private module registry um
authentic for authentication you can
either use a user token or a team token
so i guess this would be the case where
you might want to use a team token for
authentication but the type of token you
choose may grant different permissions
as we saw with the access levels uh just
the slide prior using terraform login
will obtain a user token just a reminder
and to use a team token you'll need to
manually set it in your terraform
configuration cli file okay
[Music]
so there's a feature within terraform
cloud that can do cost estimation uh and
it is a feature that will give you a
monthly cost of resources displayed
alongside your runs uh this feature is
only available starting at the teams and
governance plant and above but the idea
is that it will tell you for specific
resources and then give you a summary so
notice here that we have some pricing
i'm gonna get my pen tool out but we
have the overall cost and then it's
broken down per resource and so you can
see we have an hourly monthly and
monthly delta
i don't know what the monthly delta is
but
you know gives you kind of idea of cost
you can use sentinel policies to assert
the expectation that the resources are
under a particular cost so that's just
kind of a bonus there where you're like
okay i want to assure my spend is this
the only downside at least at the time
right now for cost estimation uh is the
amount of support it has so we have aws
azure and gcp so these are the
resources that it will support and so
you have to look through here and say
okay
you know is there any resources i'm
using outside of this that i really care
about um and that so i think that if
you're using like core services so like
ec2 instances
uh load balancers things like that that
should help you out so like we see aws
instance the load bouncer the volume
some cloud watch logs alb
for google it's just disk instance and
database so yeah it's just really
dependent on you know what's here so you
know it may meet your needs or you might
say okay this is not enough okay
[Music]
here's just a few options that i think
are worth noting within the terraform
cloud workflows we have a whole section
of workflows but i decided to put it
over here just because let's talk about
it one thing you can do within terraform
cloud is set whatever version you want
so you can go as far back as you want uh
and this is great if you need to
mix and match uh different workspaces
because you have different stacks and
they were built on different terraform
versions and you're just not ready to
upgrade them yet you can choose to share
state globally across your organization
for a particular workspace this could be
really useful if you need to reference
things wherever
you can choose to auto approve run so if
you don't want to always do that manual
approve you can do that this is great if
you are looking for that kind of agile
kind of workflow where uh if something
is merged then it should be rolled out
okay
[Music]
let's talk about if we had to migrate
our local state and we're using just the
default one two terraform cloud how
would we do it so to migrate terraform
projects that only uses the default
workspace tier from cloud it's pretty
easy you're gonna create a workspace and
terraform cloud you're gonna replace
your terraform configuration with a
remote backend so if you have nothing
it's using local and you just put in
your remote state
and then once you have that in there you
do a terraform init and it's going to
say hey do you want to copy the existing
state you're going to type yes and once
you've done that i believe you have to
delete your old state file
if you are migrating multiple
multiple environments or you're moving
from a standard remote backend it's a
little bit more complicated they
definitely have guides in the docs but
this is the pretty much standard one
that you're going to come across when
you're working very early and we'll
definitely see this as we are using
terraform in our follow alongs okay
[Music]
i want to talk about what kind of
integrations we have for terraform for
version control systems so we have
github github auth github enterprise git
lab get lab ee nce i assume that's
enterprise edition and community edition
big bucket cloud bitbucket server and
data center azure devops service as your
devops server so it's very simple you're
just going to choose from the one of the
four
right and then you're going to drop down
and choose what variant it is there and
connect your repo every single
provider has different configuration
settings so you might have to meet those
depending on what they are you can get
from private repos you might have to add
your ssh key or something like that okay
[Music]
let's talk about terraform cloud run
environment so when terraform cloud
executes your terraform plan it runs
them in its own run environment so what
is a run environment a run environment
is a virtual machine or container
intended for the execution of code for a
specific runtime environment a run
environment is essentially a code build
server so the terraform cloud run
environment is a single use linux
machine running on the x86 or x64
architecture and the details of its
internals implementation is not known it
is possible to install software on it
but the only issue is that we don't know
what it is is it debian is ubuntu you
just can't tell terraform cloud will
inject the following environment
variables automatically on each runtime
so we have tfc run id this is a unique
identifier for the current run
the workspace name uh the workspace slug
so this is the organization followed by
the workspace just gonna get my pen tool
to just kind of point out over here on
the right hand side uh we have the
configuration version and git branch so
you know if it is gonna be on main it's
gonna tell us that if it's going to be a
particular version we'll know that as
well we can get the shaw of the current
commit there's that version
and if you want to access these
variables you just define variable and
the name and then you can access it
throughout the code okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at terraform
cloud agents this is a paid feature of
the business plan to allow terraform
cloud to communicate with isolated
private or on-premise infrastructure
it's kind of like an in-between uh
between a terraform cloud and terraform
enterprise where you want to use
terraform cloud but you have uh
on-premise infrastructure but you're not
ready to move to terraform enterprise so
this is useful for on-premise
infrastructure types such as vsphere
nutanix and openstack the agent
architecture is pull-based so there are
no inbound connectivities required any
agent you provision will pull terra from
cloud for work and carry out execution
of that work locally agents currently
only support the x86 architecture or the
x64-bit linux operating system okay so
you can also run the agent within docker
using the official terraform agent
docker container if you just prefer that
over a vm agent supports terraform
versions 0.12 and above the system
require
this request the system requires i'm
going to change that
in the slide later on but the system
requires at least four gigabytes of
freedom space for temporary temporary
local copies and two gigabytes of memory
needs access to make outbound requests
uh so you need to have open port 443 for
app terraform io registry terraform io
releases hashcorp.com and um archivist
dot tara for my i o so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are on to our terraform cloud uh
follow alongs now we already did
terraform cloud version control system
earlier than i thought we were going to
do so i'm going to remove from the list
and what we'll do is focus on
permissions and maybe the api tokens and
things like that so what i want you to
do and i've got some old tabs open here
i'm going to make my way over to
terraform dot io
and i'm going to go log into terraform
cloud here
and i don't think i've ever done this
but i can upgrade to the trial account
because the thing is is that when we are
in our account here and we're trying to
look at
permissions and we're not using force
and locking anymore i might just keep
that around for a little bit but if we
were to go to our user settings here we
go to organizations
um that might not be a very good example
i guess i wanted like the organization
settings here
which would be
maybe here yep up here
and so you know when we go to our teams
and our users our users everyone's being
added as an owner we don't have like
granular permissions and that's because
we'd have to upgrade and so
i figured this would be a good
opportunity for me to kind of upgrade to
show you those more detailed role based
access control permissions just so you
know where they are so i'm going to go
the upgrade now and notice that we're on
the free plan and also take note because
um later on the course i talk about
pricing or we've already already across
it but notice that we have a team plan
and a team and governance plan this
one's at twenty dollars and this one's
at seventy dollars
so you know this is not something that's
reflected at least not right now on the
terraform website and so it just looks
like there's a team in governance plans
for 20 and this middle one's missing
the key difference here is this one has
sentinel policies code but you can see
on the free plan we are able to do
team based stuff
let's go switch over to the trial plan
i'm going to see if i can do this
without entering a credit card in
so here it says you're currently on
trial plan i didn't have to enter
anything in that's really great and so
that means now i have all these team
management options so if i go over to
team management
um i can actually go ahead and create
some teams
so i'll just say like developers
okay
and so now i have all these options so
we can say this person if someone's in
this team they're allowed to manage
policies they're able to do that
uh a visible team can be seen by every
member or we can keep them secret we can
generate
team api tokens which i guess we could
just like cover this as we do it but
notice we can go here and that generates
out that token that we can use i'm going
to go ahead and delete that token
um so nothing super exciting there you
know it's not like that complicated
if we want to
set things on the workplace now if we go
back to
workplace or workspaces here
and now we have team access
and notice i can go to add team
permissions here
and we can say select this team for
their permissions
and so these are these uh pre-built ones
in um
so we have read plan rights so these are
those three predefined ones that we
talked about previously and then we have
down here like assign permissions for
the admin of a workspace
we are able to set customized
permissions so if we toggle this
we should be able to do it i mean this
looks like it's the same thing no i
guess it's more granular so here i guess
we have our granular permissions that we
can set so for runs we can do read plan
or reply
lock or unlock a workspace
send unlocks things like that
it's not super complicated
if you want to drain out api tokens for
uh well there's the organizational one
there's the teams one and then there's
the user one so
if we go to
the organization
we can see that we can generate out one
here so i can say create an api token so
there it is let's go ahead and delete
that
and if we go back to
our teams
we did this earlier but we can generate
one here
and then if you want to generate one for
your user it's probably under user
settings
yeah so we generate tokens there as well
okay
so i mean again there's not a lot to
talk about here but
yeah so i guess that really covers
permissions and api tokens okay
okay so that finished uh deploying there
and so we can see our resources have
been created but one thing that uh we
didn't set was the prefix i'm actually
interested to see that that worked
properly but what i could do is say
prefix
and then do an underscore here i don't
know how that would affect it
and this actually happened over in this
repository here i'm actually using a
hyphen so i'm going to just change that
to that
i might have to do a terraform ended
there migrate the state
so that was a complete mistake on my
part but i guess my thought was that i
thought i had to have
um this is still on main and i guess we
never really set up a production branch
but yeah so now when we have the prefix
end it's actually going to prompt us for
the other one so the currently selected
workspaces are default
does not exist and so dev is showing up
and notice that we can't deploy domain
so i think the thing is is that if we
wanted a production one we would just
create that workspace and then it would
reflect here so the way you make uh
multiple workspaces here would actually
have to make them all so we'd have to
make a vcs terraform prod and i'm very
certain that it would just show up here
and then you would select the number
that you'd want uh though what's
interesting is the fact that we are in
the dev branch and we have to say oh i
want to deploy the dev1 so that's kind
of a little bit of a caveat there but i
guess there's not really any way around
it but i mean this pretty much
you know explores
what we need for um multiple workspaces
we tear from cloud and we did the remote
ones and
we're all good so there we go i guess
the last thing here we should probably
do is just clean up so if we go to
terraform dev here
we're gonna go down to destruction
and we'll run a destroy plan
here okay
and once this is all done you know you
can go ahead and
just delete these repositories
and notice this one is it has a private
lock on it so oh because it's actually
running right now so it's being locked
so
yep there we go so that's it
[Music]
all right now let's take a look at the
terraform registry the private registry
so just go over here and click on
registry at the top and we can bring in
public
public things here so i can just go here
and type this in and we can hit add
and so now
we just hit add terraform cloud
add to my organization and that's public
facing but we could also add private
facing modules
so if we go back to our registry here
i'm just going to go ahead and
down to publish here
and we go to github
and i guess custom
and so then i suppose we just have to
enter all the stuff in here so as an
optional display name for your v version
control provider
client ids client secrets
so it seems like there's a lot of work
to do we'd have to set up the ssh key
pair but i mean that's generally the
details that you need to know for that
okay
it just seems like a lot of work for us
to set that up um you know and the
course is just gonna be like hey can you
add a private module and be like yes
okay
so go ahead and just remove this
so you can add both public and private
modules
um you know so there you go
[Music]
i have mentioned terraform enterprise so
many times in this course but uh we've
never really talked about in detail and
now is our opportunity to do so so
terraform enterprise is the self-hosted
distribution of terraform platform and i
just want to point out sometimes i call
the terraform platform terraform cloud
just because that's the more prominent
uh version of it but terraform cloud is
a separate product
from terraform enterprise it's just one
is
assassin the other one is self-hosted so
terraform enterprise offers a private
instance of the terraform platform
application with the benefits such as no
resource limits with additional
enterprise grade architectural features
such as audit logging so you do you'd
have tamper evidence saml single sign-on
and i'm sure there's a lot more other
options there so let's just kind of look
at the architecture really quickly on
how this works so the first thing is you
have the terraform platform which is
going to be installed on a machine and
in particular this is installed on linux
and uh it's specifically installed on
debian okay so i believe that is the
debian logo as far as i remember if it's
not we'll find it on the next slide if
i'm wrong okay
you're gonna have to have some kind of
storage and there's a few different
options uh probably the most common is
going to be on something like s3 but you
can store it on the storage or on the
disk itself
you have to have a postgres database uh
so that's part of the infrastructure
because that is what the platform uses
and you'll also have to have your own
tls certificate to access the machine
but there are also cases where you know
these are going through air-gapped
environments but the idea is that you
have um ssl or tls it's like end to end
encryption it goes all the way to the
machine that's where it terminates okay
um you'll also need your terraform
license so you'll have to plug that in
once you start up the terraform platform
and say hey tell us the code so you can
unlock this um
this software for you to use on this
dedicated machine okay
[Music]
so the requirements for terraform
enterprise is going to highly vary based
on your operational mode that you choose
to run it in and that is really
dependent on how data should be stored
and when we were looking at the the
architectural diagram that was uh the
operational mode of external services
there's three types of operational modes
the first being external services that's
when you use postgres and then
use cloud storage so in that example
we're using s3 but you can use gcp azure
blob storage or mino object storage
but the idea is that postgres and the
cloud storage are external they're not
part of that linux server okay then you
have a mounted disk so this would just
be having a
persisted disk attached to
the vm so you know in the best case it's
called ebs so this stores data in a
separate directory on the host intended
for external disk so that would be both
the postgres database and the storage
volume itself you know postgres is still
a requirement in no matter what mode you
use then you have demo so stores all
data on the instance data can be backed
up with snapshots not recommended for
production use so this is
where you have ethereal data so you know
the data you know can vanish if you
restart the machine unless you make
physical snapshots
another component is credentials ensure
you have credentials to use enterprise
and have a secure connection so the
first is we need the terraform
enterprise license so you obtain that
from hashicorp and the other part is
having a tls certificate and private key
so you need to prove
uh your the you own
uh your own tls certificate okay
then we have the linux instance so
terraform enterprise is designed to run
on linux and it supports more than one
version so you know i said it was only
debian but i guess there's a bunch i
just forgot so we have debian ubuntu red
hat centos
amazon linux uh there's a variety for
those oracle linux
um so yeah i guess i'm just a big fan of
debian so that's i guess that was my my
thinking there for hardware requirements
we have at least 10 gigabytes of disk
space on the root volume at least 40
gigabytes of disk space for the docker
data directory so that would be the var
lib docker
at least eight gigabytes of the system
memory and at least four cpu
cores so there you go
[Music]
let's talk about air gapped environments
so what is an air gap an air gap or
disconnected network is a network
security measure employed on one or more
computers to ensure that a secure
computer network is physically isolated
from unsecure networks so the public
internet so
it's no internet no outside connectivity
industries in the public sector so
government military or large enterprises
finance and energy often employ air gap
networks and so i want you to know that
hashicorp terraform enterprise supports
an installation type of air gap
environments okay so to install or
update terraform enterprise you will
supply an air gap bundle which is an
archive of a terraform enterprise
release version so that's how you would
um you know provided okay
[Music]
so let's take a look at terraform cloud
features and pricing so i just want to
quickly go through it here so
we have three models we have the open
source software so oss we have the cloud
offerings and the self-hosted offerings
and all these tiers we have free
teams and governance technically it's
teams
and then teams and governance so they're
two separate plans but this is the way
they display it uh in their marketing
content but it really is a separate two
separate tiers in there you have
business and then enterprise which is
considered self-hosted so in terms of
feature set
across the board you have iec
workspaces
variables runs resource graphs providers
modules the public model registry which
is terraform registry workspace is a bit
odd because there are terraform cloud
workspaces right
and then you have local workspaces so
technically those should be broken up
into two separate things
or named differently but that's just how
it is with terraform so you know just
asterisk on that workspace is there for
the free tier you get remote state or
sorry for everything outside of the open
source you get remote state vs uh vsc
connection so that's version control
state connection so connecting to github
or
or git lab whatever workspace management
secure variable storage remote runs
private module registry uh once we get
into cloud we get team management
sentinel policy is code management cost
estimation the reason why i have that in
red is because on the exam it could ask
you when is sentinel policy available is
it available at what level and the thing
is it goes from
teams and governments all the way to the
enterprise level now technically there
is again
one called teams and there's teams and
governance so it's part of teams in
government it's not part of teams okay
once we get into business this is where
we start to get single sign-on and audit
logging so you know if you need it in
the cloud or if you need it self-hosted
both options are available
in the business we have the you can have
the self-hosted agents for configuration
designer servicenow integration you have
it for those uh as well
in terms of how many
runs you can have this is very important
because this is how many this is going
to put a bottleneck in terms of your
infrastructure right so on the free
terror you can have one current run
uh of a workspace in teams you can have
two and then at the business level and
beyond it's unlimited current runs for
uh how you would actually interact with
um
terraform you know this is going to be
through the local cli for the open
source software uh for these it's cloud
meaning that um
it's cloud that is triggering the
execution commands and then self-hosted
it's not in the cloud it's on that
private machine okay
uh then we have support so for support
it's all community um so that's just
going reaching out to da's maybe there's
a slack channel i believe that they have
a forum so they have like a forum where
you can ask questions and then they have
these layers like bronze silver and gold
i could not determine what these are
like what is offered in them and the odd
thing is is that you know there's a
silver and gold but it's offered both at
business and enterprise so i don't know
if like you can upgrade to from silver
to gold so it's optional or you always
get silver and gold could not get
clarification i tried asking the sales
team no one would tell me so i think you
have to really be deep in that sales
funnel to find out uh in terms of
pricing it's zero to up to five users so
the thing is
and this is really confusing about
terraform cloud and they really
shouldn't have called it teams up here
but you can start using terraform cloud
for free up to five users as a team
okay so just negate the fact that it's
not called teams what they're saying is
that teams is really about getting um uh
basic workspace remote management which
is actually our rba like um
our abc controls
uh role-based access controls so that's
the whole point of using teams so if you
need that and that's when you're at five
that's how you use it but you can use it
in the free tier as a team and you
absolutely should
once you get to the team's plan it's
going to be twenty dollars a month and
then if you need teams and governance
it's actually like seven dollars a month
so again it's kind of like a bit
misleading how they've labeled this out
but if you go and open up teams cloud
you can see
what the actual packages are
for uh business self-hosted
your contact and sales so i have no idea
what the cost is there so there you go
[Music]
all right we're taking a look here at
workspaces so workspaces allow you to
manage multiple environments or
alternate state files such as
development or production and there are
two variants of the workspace we have
cli workspaces a way of managing
alternate state files locally or via
remote backends and then we have
terraform cloud workspaces that act like
completely separate working directories
i'm going to tell you these two are
confusing because they don't exactly
work the same way but they have the same
name and originally workspaces were
called environments and so you know when
you're using terraform cloud it makes a
lot of sense to call them environments
and the cli workspace it's just a little
bit different so you know i'm not sure
if i'm going to do a great job
explaining the difference of these
things you really have to go through the
motion of it to really get the hang of
it but i'll do the best i can here okay
so think of workspaces as being similar
to having different branches in a git
repo workspaces are technically the
equivalent to renaming your state file
okay so in terraform 0.9 they used to be
workspaces used to be called
environments but people got confused
which i have no idea why but uh you know
that's what it is now so
by default you already have a single
workspace in your local backend called
default and the default workspace can
never be deleted so even if you don't
think you're using workspaces you
absolutely are even the first time you
use terraform at least in the cli
workspace okay
[Music]
let's get a little bit into the
internals this isn't really that much
detail but depending if you are on a
local or remote back end changes how the
state file is stored so if you're on a
local state or remote state it's going
to be different so
terraform stores the the workspace
states in a folder called terraform.tf
state.d
on the road state the workspace file are
stored directly in the configured back
end
in practice individuals or very small
teams will have been have known to
commit these files to the repos but
using a remote backend instead is
recommended when there are multiple
collaborators so i guess there's not
really much to say here but just
understand that when you have a local
state file it's going to be in that
terraform tf state d and then when it's
remote state you don't have to worry
about it okay
[Music]
let's talk about interpolation with
current workspaces so you can reference
the current workspace name via the
terraform.workspace uh named value so we
saw that in the lineup way earlier in
the course so the idea here is that if
you wanted to
see if the default like let's say you
want to say am i in the default
workspace then return five as opposed to
one because maybe you're very
comfortable spinning up more in the
default than whether it was something
else
and just another example maybe you want
to use it to
apply the name of the workspace as a tag
so here that would actually give this
virtual machine an aws the name web
hyphen whatever it is production or
development so there you go
[Music]
let's talk about multiple workspaces so
a terraform configuration has a back end
that defines how operations are executed
and where persistent data is stored so
like the terraform state so multiple
workspaces are currently supported by
the following back-ends azure rm
console
cos
gcs so that's google cloud storage
kubernetes local manta postgres
remote s3 they're not going to ask you
this on the exam which ones are
supported but you know for your own
purposes if you want to use multiple
workspaces with a
a standard backend you probably want to
know which ones certain backends support
multiple name workspaces allowing
multiple states to be associated with a
single configuration
that the configuration still has only
one back end but multiple distinct
instances of the configuration to be
deployed without configuring a new
backend or changing authentication
credentials why would you want to use
multiple workspaces for something like a
standard
um
a standard backend well the idea here is
that you know if let's say you're using
terraform cloud and you've reached your
limit of five users and it just gets too
expensive to go to the six user where
you have to pay for all of them uh you
know then the thing is is that you know
this is an option for you it's just kind
of like another option out there until
you are ready to pay for terraform cloud
at the next tier up so that's the reason
why i'm mentioning it here for you okay
[Music]
all right let's quickly walk through the
terraform cloud workspace and the
easiest way is to just show you
screenshots so uh you create a workspace
on terraform cloud so first you'll
create an organization mine's called
exam pro and within that you'll create
multiple workspaces from there you'll
click into your workspace and you'll see
like previous run states variable
settings we'll click into runs from runs
what we'll get is a list of what
happened previously we can click into
one of those and we can see our plan and
our apply we can leave a comment on each
run that has happened if we if we just
want to expand the plan and apply here
for plan we will see all the details of
what it would change and then apply is
it actually setting up that
infrastructure and whether it was
successful or not
um notice you can also download sentinel
mock files we'll come and talk about
that later when we get to our central
section
we can also see a history of previously
held states so these are snapshots of
that infrastructure
and so you can click in there and
exactly see what it looks like this is
useful if you want to go and download it
if you were to need it
so here's a diff of what changed since
the last state
okay and of course you can download that
stuff so you know hopefully that gives
you an idea of what you can do with
terraform cloud workspaces
[Music]
let's talk about terraform cloud run
triggers so
terraform cloud provides a way to
connect your workspaces to one or more
workspaces via run triggers within your
organization known as source workspaces
so runtriggers allows runs to queue
automatically
in your workspace on successful apply of
runs in any of your source workspaces
and you can connect each workspace to up
to 20 source workspaces so run triggers
are designed for workspaces that rely on
information or infrastructure produced
by other workspaces if a terraform
configuration uses data sources to read
values that might be changed by another
workspace run triggers lets you
explicitly specify the external
dependencies so the idea is just allow
you to say okay i have one workspace i
i've triggered that i want it now to do
that so this is really great if you have
a bunch of uh
of um environments or or stacks that are
reliant on each other and you want it to
kind of have a chain reaction the reason
i'm mentioning run triggers is that i
think it's a cool feature and b because
um triggers is something that is also uh
something else when we're looking at
provisioners and i just wanted to just
clarify that there's run triggers from
terraform cloud and then there's
triggers that are for um
well i said provisioners i really mean
null resources they have triggers in
that okay
so it's not going to show up in the exam
but it's just a good to know feature i
just want to make sure there's no
confusion with the other triggers
[Music]
let's take a look at some of the
terraform workspace cli commands that we
have available to us the first starting
with terraform workspace list so list
all the existing workspaces and the
current workspaces indicated by an
asterisk so that is our current
workspace there terraform workspace show
show the current workspace so right now
we're working in development terraform
workspace select switch to a target
workspace so here we could say select
default and now we're in the default
terraform workspace new so create and
switch to a new workspace
and then we have terraform workspace
delete so delete a target workspace now
understand that this is affecting um
your local ones uh for the cli commands
okay but um yeah so this would actually
show up in the exam they might ask you
like
you know which is select and what does
list do and things like that so make
sure you know these commands okay
[Music]
all right so i just wanted to contrast
against the local or cli driven
workflows via the terraform cloud
workflows because there's this great uh
table chart that's from the um
documentation that i want to show you so
terraform cloud workspaces and local
working directory serve the same
purposes but they store their data
differently so just looking here we'll
go down the components here so for
terraform configuration it's going to be
on disk for local for terraform cloud in
linked
version control repositories or
periodically uploaded via the api or cli
uh we have variable values so this is
where we use tfrs and when we're in
terraform cloud it's in the actual
workspace the terraform cloud workspace
and so that means that we are setting
environment variables to propagate that
into our code or inject those variables
into our codon execution for state it's
on disk or in a remote backend uh and in
the workspace for terraform cloud it's
actually in the workspace credentials
and secrets are in shell environments or
are entered at prompts workspace they're
stored as sensitive variables these are
environment variables again so there you
go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are on to our terraform cloud uh
follow alongs now we already did
terraform cloud
version control system earlier than i
thought we were going to do so i'm going
to remove from the list and what we'll
do is focus on permissions and maybe the
api tokens and things like that so what
i want you to do and i've got some old
tabs open here i'm going to make my way
over to
terraform dot io
and i'm going to go log into terraform
cloud here
and i don't think i've ever done this
but i can upgrade to the trial account
because the thing is is that when we are
in our account here and we're trying to
look at uh permissions and we're not
using force unlocking anymore i might
just keep that around for a little bit
but if we were to go to our user
settings here we go to organizations
um that might not be a very good example
i guess i wanted like the organization
settings here
which would be
maybe here yep up here and so you know
when we go to our teams and our users
our users everyone's being added as an
owner we don't have like granular
permissions and that's because we'd have
to upgrade and so
i figured this would be a good
opportunity for me to just kind of
upgrade to show you those more detailed
role based access control permissions
just so you know where they are so i'm
going to go the upgrade now and notice
that we're on the free plan and also
take note because
later on the course i talk about pricing
or we've already already across it but
notice that we have a team plan and a
team and governance plan this one's at
twenty dollars and this one's at seventy
dollars
so you know this is not something that's
reflected at least not right now on the
terraform website and so it just looks
like there's a team and governance plan
for 20 and this middle one's missing
the key difference here is this one has
sentinel policies code but you can see
on the free plan we are able to do
team-based stuff
let's go switch over to the trial plan
i'm going to see if i can do this
without entering a credit card in
so here it says you're currently on
trial plan i didn't have to enter
anything in that's really great and so
that means now i have all these team
management options so if i go over to
team management
i can actually go ahead and create some
teams
so i'll just say like developers
okay
and so now i have all these options so
we can say this person if someone's in
this team they're allowed to manage
policies they're able to do that
uh a visible team can be seen by every
member or we can keep them secret we can
generate out team api tokens which i
guess we could just like cover this as
we do it but notice we can go here and
that generates out that token that we
can use i'm going to go ahead and delete
that token
um so nothing super exciting there you
know it's not like that complicated
if we want to
set things on the workplace now if we go
back to
workplace or workspaces here
and now we have team access
and notice i can go to add team
permissions here
and we can say select this team for
their permissions
and so these are these uh pre-built ones
in um
so we have read plan rights so these are
those three predefined ones that we
talked about previously and then we have
down here like assigned permissions for
the admin of a workspace
we are able to set customized
permissions so if we toggle this
um we should be able to do it i mean
this looks like it's the same thing no i
guess it's more granular so here i guess
we have our granular permissions that we
can set so for runs we can do read plan
or reply
locker unlock a workspace
send on locks things like that
it's not super complicated
if you want to drain out api tokens for
well there's the organizational one
there's the teams one and then there's
the user one so
if we go to
the organization
we can see that we can generate out one
here so i can say create an api token so
there it is let's go ahead and delete
that
and if we go back to
our teams
we did this earlier but we can generate
one here
and then if you want to generate one for
your user it's probably under user
settings
yeah so we generate tokens there as well
okay
um so i mean again there's not a lot to
talk about here but
yeah so i guess that really covers
permissions and api tokens okay
okay so that finished uh deploying there
and so we can see our resources have
been created but one thing that we
didn't set was the prefix i'm actually
interested to see that that worked
properly but what i could do is say
prefix
and then do an underscore here i don't
know how that would affect it
and this actually happened over in this
repository here i'm actually using a
hyphen so i'm going to just change that
to that
might have to do a terraform ended there
migrate the state
so that was a complete mistake on my
part but i guess my thought was that i
thought i had to have
this is still on main and i guess we
never really set up a production branch
but yeah so now when we have the prefix
end it's actually going to prompt us for
the other one so the currently selected
workspace is our default
does not exist and so dev is showing up
and notice that we can't deploy domain
so i think the thing is is that if we
wanted a production one we would just
create that workspace and then it would
reflect here so the way you make uh
multiple workspaces here would actually
have to make them all so we'd have to
make a vcs terraform prod and i'm very
certain that it would just show up here
and then you would select the number
that you'd want uh though what's
interesting is the fact that we are in
the dev branch and we have to say oh i
want to deploy the dev one so that's
kind of a little bit of a caveat there
but i guess there's not really any way
around it but i mean this pretty much
you know explores
what we need for um multiple workspaces
we tear from cloud and we did the remote
ones and
we're all good so there we go i guess
the last thing here we should probably
do is just clean up so if we go to
terraform dev here
we're going to go down to destruction
and we'll run a destroy plan here
okay
and once this is all done you know you
can go ahead and
just delete these repositories
and notice this one is it has a private
lock on it so oh because it's actually
running right now so it's being locked
so
yep there we go so that's it
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at sentinel
which is an embedded policies code
framework integrated within the
terraform platform so what is policy is
code when you write code to automate
regulatory or governance policies and
features of signals include it that it's
embedded so enable policy enforcement in
the data path to actively reject
violating behavior instead of passively
detecting so
it's it's very active or proactive
fine-grained condition based policies so
make policy decisions based on the
condition of other values multiple
enforcement levels so advisory soft and
hard mandatory levels allow policy
writers to warn
on or inject reject behavior we have
external information so source and
external information to make holistic
policy decisions we have multi-cloud
compatibili uh compatible so ensure
infrastructure changes are within
business and regulatory policy across
multiple providers and central is a paid
service part of the team and governance
upgrade package so starting at team and
governance it's available for that
business and enterprise okay
let us expand a bit on the concept of
policy as code and relating to sentinel
so sentinel is built around the idea and
provides all the benefits of policy of
code let's talk about the benefits we
get with this so sandboxing the ability
to create guardrails to avoid dangerous
actions or remove the need of manual
verification codification the policies
are well documented exactly represent
what is enforced version control easy to
modify or iterate on policies with a
chain of history of changes over time
testing so syntax and behavior can
easily be validated with sentinel
ensuring policies are configured as
expected automation so policies existing
as code allows you to uh allows you to
direct integrate policies in various
systems to auto re remediate and notify
we're talking about sentimental and
policy as code we have language so all
sentinel uh policies are written using
the central language this is designed to
be non-programmer and programmer
friendly embeddable and safe for
development sender provides a cli for
development and testing and for testing
sentinel provides a test framework
designed specifically for automation so
hopefully that gives you an idea of the
benefits of policy code and in
particular with sentinel
all right let's take a look at the
sender language and also just a broad
range of use cases that we could use
these for so you can start thinking
about how to start applying sentinel the
great thing is that there are a bunch of
example policies provided by hashicorp
so you can easily um you know start
using them right away but let's go
through the big list to kind of give you
an idea where you would use policies
codes so for aws maybe you want to
restrict the owners of the aws ami to a
date of the data source maybe you want
to enforce mandatory tags on taggable
aws resources restrict availability
zones used by ec2 instances disallow
0.0.0.04.0 basically anywhere address
out to the internet um restrict instance
types of ec2 so maybe you only want
people using t2 micros require s3
buckets to be private and encrypted by
kms since that is a big um
a big problem for people on a bus where
their buckets get leaked uh require vpcs
to have dns host names enabled we're
looking at gcp enforce mandatory labels
on vms disallow
anywhere cider enforce limits on gke
clusters because those can get really
expensive restrict machine types of vms
just like aws for vmware require storage
drs on data store clusters restrict size
and type of virtual disks restrict cpu
count memory of vms restrict size of vm
disks recaro nfs 4.1 and
kirbrose i never can say that properly
on nas data stores for azure enforce
mandatory tags of vms restrict
publishers of vms restrict vm images
restrict the size of azure vms enforce
limits on aks clusters restrict cider
blocks of security groups for cloud
agnostic allow
only say
we can only use these allowed providers
say
or explicitly say what providers are not
allowed
limit proposed monthly costs prevent
providers in non-root modules require
all modules have version constraints
require all resources be created in
modules and private module registry use
most recent versions of modules in a
private module registry that's more so
like about the tooling around modules
now let's take a look at an example
and this is one for restricting uh
available zones on ec2 instances so like
what data centers you're allowed to use
and so we first import our language
functions that's going to allow us to
use particular
feature functions in this we're going to
specify our azs we're going to get all
the virtual machines we're going to
filter that and restrict that easy for
those vms we're going to define that
rule to make it enforceable so there you
go
all right let's take a look here with
sentinel with terraform so central can
be integrated with terraform via terror
from cloud as part of your iec
provisioning pipeline and where it's
going to sit is between plan
and apply okay
so the way you do it is you're going to
have to create a policy set and apply
these to the terraform workspace so it's
not that complicated to get it hooked up
um so yeah that's all there is to it
okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to learn a bit about
sentinel with terraform i'm not going to
say i'm amazing at it but we are going
to stumble our way through and see what
we can accomplish we know we can
download sentinel box and there's also
the ability to set policy sets and i do
know that uh there are a bunch of
pre-made um sendal policies so we go
send all policies here
uh terraform
uh and we go examples
uh there we are probably here
there are a bunch of ones that we can go
in here so i'm thinking that there's
something that we can do here um but
we'll have to figure our way through
here because i actually haven't ran any
policies myself so we have these two
environments i'm not using dev anymore
i'm done with this i'm going to go ahead
and destroy that and we're going to go
down to terraform destroy i'm pretty
sure i don't have any running
infrastructure actually i'm going to
double check by going to the overview
everything has been destroyed and so
i'll go back over here and we're going
to destroy this i'm going to type in vcs
terraform dev
great if we go into this workplace
or workspace
nothing is provisioned right now so i
want to get everything running again
because last time we ran a destroy so i
think that if we want to get this
working it should be pretty easy i'm
going to go back to
our
workflows file here and we're just going
to revert some changes so i'm going to
go back
and change this to name
and i'm just going to go whoops we're
going to go
into our 120 directory here and we're
going to get checkout main and that
actually might just revert those changes
there i don't think anything really
changed much other than this part here
and so what i'm going to do is just go
make a minor change it doesn't matter
what it is maybe a
space get at all whoops
git commit hyphen m
changes
get push
we'll have to do a get pull here
sorry get push
and so what i want to see here is a
trigger for the run
there we go and i'll see you here in a
bit when it's provisioned okay all right
so after a short little wait there it
looks like our uh branches ran so i
think our resources are provisioned
um it's cool we actually have cost
estimation i didn't have to do anything
to turn that on we already have it
notice that it's giving us an hourly of
um zero twelve cents the monthly is
going to be eight dollars in
you know 35 cents there if there was
more resources there we would obviously
get that i assume that it would show up
here in the top right
corner so we're not really interested in
the provision infrastructure but more so
looking at these uh sentinel locks so
i'm going to go ahead and download them
there and that's going to download as a
a zip
or an archive of some sorts
and so what i can do here
is just unzip it so i'm just going to
make a new folder
here and we'll just call these
sentinel mocks
okay i'm just going to open up the zip
and so here's all the stuff in here so
we have a variety of different files i
think some of them might be redundant
i'm not sure what we have to do with
them but i'm just going to go ahead and
grab these and drag them into the folder
here
okay and actually what i'm going to do
is
i'm going to just make a new section
in my folder here
whoops
just give me a second here
let's open up the explorer to anything
yeah we have a folder right here
because what i want to do is just drop
those files and so we can just see them
in vs code with the contents of them
there we go
so now i'm just going to go down to here
and we'll take a look so we have
sentinel hcl
all right and so that's just defining a
bunch of mocks
uh we have this sendal file here
so i was hoping when we opened this that
we'd be able to figure out what to do
with this and i have no idea so you know
what what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to do a little bit of reading and
i'm going to come back to you after i
finished reading this okay all right so
spending a little bit of time uh
watching some stuff so i was just going
through the deep dive of sentinel here
and just going through the documentation
and as far as i understand it looks like
that you write policies and then you can
also write tests for your policies to
assert that your policies are doing what
you expect them to do and i guess those
uh sentinel mocks are written in a form
of hcl
but it is a little bit confusing because
you get this folder with a bunch of
stuff in it and it can be either written
as json or
like this hcl like format but as far as
i can tell it's just saying what it's
done is it's generated out the the
current state of exactly what your
infrastructure is and i think that it's
going to check to see is it exactly what
you expect it to be
so i don't know if mox is that very uh
useful and might be a little bit too
much for this particular course so i'm
just going to say let's just kind of
ignore
blocks because they're just a little bit
too too difficult and out of scope here
let's
focus on trying to get a policy
implemented so i'm going to go back over
here and what i'm gonna do is i know
that
if i go to
settings
i mean i've seen it before i just can't
remember if it's under a workspace
no it's i think it's at the organization
level so we're gonna go to the settings
here and there we have our policies so
we here we can create new policies so
managing individual policies terraform
is deprecated policy sets now supports
vcs integration with direct api uploads
uh this provides a streamlined policy
management experience policies which
includes okay so this is the old way of
doing it and so we'll go here and create
a new policy set so connect a new policy
set
um okay so
i guess what we have to do
oh boy this is a lot different than i
thought it was gonna be so i thought it
was just like we're going to go here and
create it and then dump our code in
which apparently that's what it is but
it seems like we need to associate with
the policy set so just give me a moment
because i do want to show you the the
most up-to-date way to do this i'll be
back in a second all right all right so
doing a little reading here it looks
like what we have to do is create
ourselves a sendal.hcl file and this is
going to say what policies we want to
enforce so i assume this is basically
the policy set as a file and here we
specify the policies that we care about
um
i actually just want to go back to the
files we were looking at earlier because
we saw this htl file so i guess this
would technically be a policy set
is that what we call that here but
notice it says mock so these aren't
policies per se these are just grouping
mocks
but in any case
i think we'll have to create this file
so what i'm going to try to do
and i don't know this is going to work
but we'll just stumble our way through
here because the best way to learn is
we're going to create ourselves our own
sentinel file here so we're going to say
sentinel
dot hcl
and we're going to define ourselves a
policy
this isn't going to be the one that
we're going to use but i'm just going to
grab it here notice there are different
enforcement levels so
i don't really care we put it i just
want to see that we can successfully get
anything working here
and i'm going to go back to the examples
um if we can go find that there so
sentinel
policy examples and let's just go take
one of those and see what we can do with
it okay
so if we scroll on down
disallow zero zero zero cider block in
the security group that seems like
something that would be pretty relevant
restrict instance type of ec2 instance
that could be something as well that we
could do
so
you know i just have to decide what it
is we want to do here restrict owners so
there's a few that are good here let's
take this take a look at this one
because i feel like this might be very
simple
so yeah this is perfect okay so what
we'll do is we'll take uh this policy
here
so i wonder if i could just go download
this file here there's probably a
download button
well i can't find it so we'll just maybe
it's up here
no okay we'll just create this by hand
here so i'm going to go copy and
it looks like we can just drop it in
here so just go new
file here
and put that there and we'll just go to
raw
and we will go ahead and drop that on in
there
so i wish i had like send all
highlighting i don't know if there is
such a one for vs code if there is it'd
be really nice so we would type in
sentinel
um yes we do
this one has more downloads so we'll go
with that one
no rating as of yet looks like it works
so let's go give them a five star
i think that's only fair because uh no
one's done that yet
might be a bit too hard to uh i've never
written a review before but we'll go
here and say
works as expected
thank you for this uh
extension
okay so
what i'm going to do is go back over to
here and so here we have some kinds now
we're running a t2 micro i believe so
this policy should uh cause it to fail
that's exactly what we want but i'm just
going to go look up and down to see if
it's all correct it looks good to me so
i think we'll have to change over here
is the name so i'm just going to
clear this out and we'll say restrict
ec2 instance
type
we'll save that hard mandatory sounds
really good to me
um probably have to spell it right for
it to work r-e-s yeah strict okay great
and so what i'll do is just copy this up
here
okay and so we have our sandal hcl file
and it's referencing a local file now
the question is you know can we use the
same repository i assume we would be
able to
for our policy set but it almost seems
like it might encourage you to have your
policies separate from your repository
that you're testing and that might be
really good because let's say you have
multiple workspaces or environments and
they all require the same policy set you
wouldn't want to have them in your code
base like that but for the purposes of
this we're just going to keep it simple
i'm going to go ahead and
open up terminal here and we're going to
commit these these changes to our
repository
and this will end up triggering a deploy
even though we don't necessarily want
that to happen but there's no way around
that so
get well i suppose we could just cancel
it out but or not have the auto apply
but i don't feel like changing that so
we'll do git status here we'll go get
add all
git commit hyphen m uh
simple policy here
get push
okay
and so that's being pushed to our
repository that's going to trigger
a deployment we don't care i i assume
that it won't pick up the policy because
we have to connect the policy set
so
um apparently you use the api to upload
your policy set which is kind of cool i
suppose we could have done that but um
well too late
we probably should use vcs anyway you
know what i mean so we'll go to github
here and we will find our terraform
repository which is here
um you know policy
well we should probably name this right
so we
policy to enforce uh instance type
i don't know if we need a description i
guess we'll find it in a second here i
guess we could have also put the policy
in a um
a subdirectory there that might have
been okay to do
it's going to default to the main branch
which is fine policies enforce on all
workspaces or policies and force on
selected workspaces and we only have one
but that's what we'll do down here so
we'll say
update
the name is invalid
oh uh it has to be like
a proper name so
restrict
ec2
now again this is a policy set so you
could just say like um
you know basic server policy set that
probably better and then you probably
want a list to say what it does
restricts
um ec2 instances instance type
okay and we'll go down here and create
that policy set
and
that looks like we're in good shape so
we applied it um now will it actually
happen on this run because it's already
running i believe we go to this
workplace
workspace i like to say workplace it's
workspace
and we go over here this is already
planned and finished so what i want to
do is just trigger another
uh um deploy here so there's nothing
changed
so
i'm not sure what we do here um i guess
what we could do and actually this is
something that i'm i don't know but like
how would you trigger
a replace on here because if we're doing
let's go to plan and see what happens i
wonder if we could do that in the plan
here
reasons for trigger
do refresh only plan
because one thing i was thinking about
is like imagine i wanted to replace an
element you can do that hyphen replace
but i don't know how you do that through
vcs
but anyway what i'm going to do is just
go change anything in our code
um so it could just be a space it
doesn't really matter
get at
plus okay commit
trigger uh change
and we just want to observe
the uh
the policy working okay
so i'm just going to open this up here
i'm not sure if it's going to show up in
the plan section or the apply section so
we'll just wait here to see the plan
generate out
and so the plan finished
um we don't see any sentinel uh central
being applied there
apply will not run
let's expand that there this looks fine
i guess technically we didn't change
anything so that probably is not very
helpful so what i'm going to do
is go and change a variable because
maybe that's that's what's going to help
here
so we have a micro here which is fine
we're just going to change this over to
nano
that makes sense why it didn't do it
so we'll go back over to runs and i'm
going to trigger i'm going to start a
plan so
change ec2 instance type
we'll say start plan
okay so we have one change which is fine
we just okay so that part pass is going
to go to cost
estimation that passed it's going to
apply it because remember we have um
auto approve on the server so it's not
even going to ask us to confirm it
and so i want to see if that policy is
in place
well it's running i'm just going to go
review our policy here
just to make sure it's not like the
opposite saying like you cannot have
these so include now a loud ec2 instance
type so it's small medium or large so it
really should quit out on this one here
but it seems like it's working like it's
not uh it's not picking up the policy
but i'll see you hear it back in a bit
okay
all right so i didn't see the policy
trigger there so i'm gonna go back to
policy sets and notice here it says zero
workspaces which is unusual because i
definitely selected one but maybe i
didn't click through or hit add so i'm
going to go down here and click this one
again
and maybe i didn't hit this button here
okay and now i'll probably have to hit
update um paul this is set before we do
i just want to read about this these
parameters are passed to center runtime
when performing policy checks so i guess
i'd be like a way where you'd have a
generic policy and then you could kind
of put parameters in so that's kind of
cool
so i'm going to go back here and double
check to make sure that we have a
workspace set and so what we'll do is
just change the variable again
um so we will go to
our variables here and i'm going to go
change this back to a micro
and so i think this time we are going to
have better success okay so we'll hit
save
we'll go back up to runs
we'll go and start a new plan
change instance type
again here
and we will save that plan
and so that plan is now running i will
see you back here in a bit uh when we
see that sentinel policy i don't know
when it triggers i'll see you back here
in a bit all right welcome back so after
our cross estimation it did a policy
check and you can see that it failed um
and here the air says
import tf plans function is not
available so i'm not sure why that's
happening so i think that um
i mean our set failed but not for the
reason we wanted to so i'm gonna go
investigate this i'll be back in a
moment okay all right so uh what i've
done here is i've gone and looked up uh
like how to create a policy set and
hashicorp learn has this um example
project here
and if we go into its github project and
i go here
you're gonna notice that it it's like
this apparently does basically the same
thing restrict instance type and
apparently tag as well but it doesn't
have the tf
functions the tf plan functions here so
um
maybe we don't need that function in
there and maybe the the example is just
out of date at this time so import
common functions for sentinel
okay but this one doesn't have it it
does it does have it for mocks right um
so
maybe we just need to kind of like
walk through this really quickly and see
how we can fix this so the policy uses
the central tf2 plan import to require
that all ec2 instances have instance
types planned on the loud list
but
i don't
see that import there
okay and it is in here so i guess what
we'll do is just grab this one
okay
and i'm gonna go ahead and just delete
this one out here um
again this isn't working i don't know if
this would work with that one so i'm
gonna take it out
this is pretty clear what this does so
we'll just have that allowed types it's
interesting like here it's underscoring
that here it's like uh title case
there's some inconsistencies there so
they have a lot of types as well
um
and i'm just seeing if there's like find
resources in here
so allow types rule to enforce the name
tag
so i don't care about that
rule to restrict the instance type so
i'm going to go ahead and grab this one
here and let's just take a look at the
differences here
okay so instance type allowed rule all
these two instances as
that instance
change after instance type allow type so
this is way way different
um
so i mean i fully don't understand this
but i do know that this one
it will probably work so i'm going to go
down here
we have count violations i'm not really
worried about that
and
the rules different
like if i was really serious about this
i'm sure i could you know figure out the
logic here but again this is just for
the purposes of this learning so we
don't have to go too crazy here now this
says instance type allowed and mandatory
instance tags we're not dealing with
tags here so i'm just going to say
this
okay and so i think this will produce
what we want
so
allows those types
i don't know if it had this in here
get all instance types from the module
i think we didn't put this in here so
this might be kind of the equivalent
ec2 instances
filter tf plan resource changes
okay
contains a create or an update
um
i mean this isn't bad we technically
have a name set so you know what i'm
just going to grab this whole thing
because
then we're just going to have a much
easier time we don't have to worry about
it but it was nice to walk through that
file very quickly
because the name tag is set um in our
project a because we can see we can see
that it's the server name so
what we'll do is we'll just go ahead and
add this to our
repository here and the great thing is
that since it's the vs code or it's in
the same version control system i would
think that it would update in time so
what we'll do is just to get at all
git commit hyphen m
fix the policy
get push
okay
and we'll go back over here
and we will see
if the policy check happens and when it
does happen it's actually
erroring out because we're not using the
right instance size right that's what we
want to see
a little bit of trial and error it's not
a big deal i also read like over here
that the sendal file for hcl only
contains module and policies but then we
saw a single file or hdl file that
clearly had mocks in it so
i mean maybe maybe just only used
locally maybe it's not intended for um
production
um so
we'll go down here tf plan so it didn't
pick it up okay so what i'm gonna do is
go back to my policy set and maybe it's
just like the order of how this happened
so see this says it was updated last
five minutes ago
updated it a minute ago so this could
just be like a race case where um
you know this
ran before the other one so i'm going to
try to execute this again start a new
plan uh
trigger
plan
and we'll see if that works now because
again this said
literally updated a minute ago so maybe
it didn't pick it up
so you can see why it would also be good
to have your policy set in a separate
repo because if you're deploying this
you don't want to
keep triggering your deploys
so i think probably that's what you know
we should have done i mean it's a lot
extra work but you know this way you
kind of understand why
so waiting on that plan run i really
don't care about cost estimation i mean
you could make a policy to check based
on that i i'm assuming we just turn that
off if we wanted to
and we'll go over to cost estimation
here yeah we could just disable it
but the thing here is that it said our
policy passed
so we'll go here so the result means
that all central policies passed
so restrict the instance type so
description
main rule that requires other rules to
be true
uh ruleton force name tag is on all
instances that's true rule to restrict
the instance type
so maybe we don't understand uh maybe
this works in the opposite way oh the t2
micro is here okay so
i just want to see it fail so what we'll
do is go back up to our variables here
and we'll go to our instance type
and we'll just change this to nano
and we'll save that
we'll go back over here to our runs
oh this is still running the old one
here that's fine we can just cue up
another one here so we can just say
start a new plan
uh new instance type
okay and if we go back over to here
the last one wouldn't have done anything
because the infrastructure would have
been the same so
the previous one we just did here right
it would just been like oh no it's still
trying to apply it so i guess there is a
change
maybe we changed the instance type last
time i don't know
so anyway i'll see you back here when
this is completely done okay
all right great so we got an error if we
go into our instance type here
right and we look at it we can see that
it failed because uh it wasn't the uh
right uh type
so
um i mean that's pretty interesting so
the other thing i would say uh that we
could do is also kind of check out mocks
now because i kind of feel like i have a
better grasp on it now that we have a
test running so just thinking straight
about it a mock really is a
representation of the state of
infrastructure at the time of so if we
go back to our runs and we go to a
successful run like the trigger plan
here and this one was successful we
could go to the plans here and then
download these mock files
so we do have the ones from prior and i
think those are totally fine and valid
to use so what if what we do is go back
to our project over here and we have um
the mock files over here but really
where they need to be is within the
workflow directory because looking at
the documentation here
what it's saying is that you get all
these things and this basically
represents the state of those mock files
and then you need to make a test folder
and then a test data folder and then
there's gonna be something based on the
name of this uh the mock file so
what we'll do is we'll go
um
up to this folder here and we'll say new
folder
test
and then we'll make another new folder
here
test data
those folders are files
i think those are files
so we'll delete that it's just out of
habit to click the um
the file there so we'll say new folder
so we'll say test
and then we'll say another new folder
there
test data
okay
and so we have our sender file here so
we need to
um have i think a similarly named one
here so if we go back over here
um
this is foo whatever so i think we need
to have a folder in here
because it's all based on convention and
i just it's pretty not that hard to
figure out i don't have to read the docs
to know that uh we'll just put that in
here take out the word sentinel
and then i would assume that we need a
file in here what's it called like just
pass and fail so i'm gonna just do a
pass
file new
pass.hcl
okay and then we have our test data so
that was what we had down below here
so i need to go grab that information
i'm just looking for a folder where
i might already have open here if i
don't that's fine we'll just go ahead
down below and just right click
and reveal and explore
we'll go over here
and i need to move all these over so i
just copy them over and we're going to
go over to our terraform work
flow here
and i'm going to go here and paste that
data in
i don't know if these contain any kind
of sensitive data because if they're
based on the tf state file these might
be something you don't want to share
that might be a security vulnerability i
don't know but i definitely won't have
these available when i put this
repository up for free
um so we have those files in the right
place
and
we have all this stuff here so i i think
that um
like you notice it's not there so i'm
assuming that we need to open up this
file and copy into our main hcl file so
we'll go down below here and then i
think it's just a matter of copying all
this stuff right
we'll say cut
and then we'll go to
[Music]
um back up to here i suppose
into our
file it's getting a little bit confusing
with all the stuff eh
okay so that's in the right place
our test date is there good here we are
okay so what i'm going to do is just go
down here and paste that in
okay and so
we didn't write any kind of pass
test data test
so that's something we will need here
i'm not sure what we'll get so we'll
just scroll down here
so you can find the contents of a pass
dot hcl
it's not showing me anything here so
just give me a moment i'm going to see
what we have to do for this this test
okay all right so a little bit of
googling it looks like this one's on the
same track here so since we probably
copied the mock data from this one or
somewhere through here we could probably
just go grab this so
um this is pretty much what our pass
file will look like
so we'll go ahead and grab this here
i don't know if we really need a fail to
write a failing test i don't really care
about that i just want to see anything
pass here
we'll paste that in here we do have to
be sure that we are accessing our data
correctly so
if we're in test it's going to go up one
directory to the
terraform directory
but wouldn't it have to then cd into
test so i don't think that source path
is correct
i'm just going to double check that here
did you have an example repositories
let's take a look here what we have
um
yeah that's kind of odd so i think
that
if this is relevant it needs to go to
test data
because how else would it get there
okay
so we'll do that so test rules main
equals true
um
okay so that's a pretty simple test
and so i think the way we run tests is
there's like a sentinel test
thing here
i don't know if we have cinder installed
i don't think so
so there's no sentinel command
so i guess that's something we have to
install sentinel um
cli terraform
okay
over here
uh we're on technically linux even
though we're on windows we're on linux
so here it's just saying uh download it
and then put it in the correct path
so install so we'll get the appropriate
package here
and we're technically on linux
and
i guess we are 64-bit
just gonna download here
scroll up oh it is already downloading
okay great and so i'm just gonna go to
my downloads
and i'm gonna open it up here
so there it is and so i need to
get it into the user local bin here so
i'm just going to first
get it in anywhere so
because i'm just working here i'm just
going to go
open this up so reveal in the explorer
okay
and this is not where i want it to be
i'm just dropping here for the time
being
technically we could run it from there i
don't think it'd be that big of a deal
so i'm just going to go back to my vs
code here
and i'm going to just type sentinel
sentinel
it's there right
yep it's there
i'm not sure if it's executable but
i'm just going to type in sentinel here
signal test
okay so it doesn't think it's command so
maybe i have to do like chamod u plus x
that makes it executable on linux
said no command not found
well heck i'm right there maybe i have
to put a period forward slash like that
okay there we go so um i mean of course
you don't want to leave it in here you
and this would also end up in a
repository so this will go to like your
user local bin probably so
i'm going to say like move sendl
to user local bin
and so now i should just be able to type
sentinel it should get picked up
it does great so here i can do test
and down below it says open test no such
file or directory so it can't find the
mock data notice that it's going into
the test test data so that is no good
for us
we did say to go up a directory so maybe
if i go up back one more like this
would that work
no let's go put back in what they
actually had there which i have a hard
time believing that would be correct
so
open mock okay so that's definitely not
right okay and so
personally i just want this to work so
i'm just going to cheat
this is absolutely what you should not
do but you know like i don't wanna be
fiddled around with paths all day here
and so i'm just gonna give it an
absolute path and see if that fixes our
problem
okay and this will just say test data
here
um
so that should absolutely work i'm just
going to expand this here
this is mock tf plan
oh but it says pass in the name okay so
the problem isn't that it's the fact
that uh the mock data isn't named it's
because the thing is you could download
two different mocks
right so you could have a state that is
successful and failed and you probably
want to rename them to say passed or
failed so we don't necessarily have that
so i think my original thing was correct
where we had this test data
and so here we just have to make sure we
match the name so mock tf
v2 is fine here okay
again i don't understand the difference
between all these files i definitely saw
the documentation they explained them
all so
you know that might be something we want
to read through here
um so this is looking a little bit
better so mock tf plan hyphen version 2
sentinel
so that
is correct
um but the director it doesn't like the
direction it's going into that test
again so
again i'm going to just go back up one
more layer here
okay
there we go and it's passing so
um yeah so that's all it takes to um do
that again i think if we were to commit
this to our code i don't think that
these run
so we go like so we can just go add it
and see what happens so we'll say git
add
git commit hyphen m validation
and again i don't know if this mock data
should be allowed to be committed into
the
repository because we have a tf state
file here right
okay i don't know but i'm going to just
do a push here to see what happens
but again i i really think that we're
probably not supposed to have it in
there
um
so what we'll do
is
go back to
our terraform io
sign in
and we'll just see what happens here i
mean we don't expect the
this to pass because it's still using
the wrong instance type
but i was just curious to see if the
mock would appear in any way here i
don't think it does i think that's just
something that you'd have to do uh
beforehand and i think what you'd have
is you'd have a pull request and the
pull request could be used to run those
unit tests because that's basically what
it is okay so yeah that's exactly what i
thought would happen but down below here
it says the mock block is not supported
so
i wonder what you would do so if you
can't have mocks in the file
what would you do locally because you
need to
i guess the thing is is that the mock
file the sendal.hcl file would not be
in this fold so you might have the
central hdl file in your main repository
for mocking right and if you committed
it wouldn't run it because the policy
set would actually be in another
repository so i think that's how it's
supposed to work so
yeah i think really we want to have
policy sets in their own repository like
completely away from there because we're
seeing we're running into a lot of
problems but we pretty much accomplished
what we wanted to do with sentinel more
than i thought we were going to do uh so
that's pretty great so there you go um
in terms of this we probably want to
tear this down uh we do need to do
something with vault
and stuff like that but i think that uh
what we'll do is just tear this down and
you know if we need to
bring it back up we'll do that so i'm
gonna go to destruction here
and
we're gonna go ahead and just destroy
the plan here
okay
and we're all now in good shape
and so um yeah i'll see you in the next
part okay
but we're all done here for for sentinel
all right actually i guess we're not
gone here just yet because it looks like
our destroy run failed uh because we
didn't pass here so
um that is a bit of a problem so we'll
have to go to the variables
i guess it's a good edge case to know
about but um we'll go back and change
this to a micro even though it's going
to just tear it down anyway you know
so we'll go and type in micro save
variable
and we'll go back to our runs
we'll start a new plan
or sorry we'll go to settings here
destruction
cue the plan
i'm just curious giving a plan we'll
redirect a new up output here
okay cool um so i'm just going to type
in vcs terraform again here
okay and so
this should
work
and i will come back and just confirm
this with you okay so i'll be back here
in a second all right so the real reason
we can't uh get rid of this is because
we have those darn blocks in there so
um
what i'm going to do is go over to our
sender file here um up to i mean we
don't use this one so i'm going to go
ahead and delete that that's not even
something that's going to happen
and
we need to update our
hcl file here
okay
and i'm assuming that this supports
this okay
because this is not how we should be
doing this um and
here we go git add
git commit hyphen m
minor change
okay and this is going to trigger a run
here
i really wanted to destroy
so let's give it a moment there to start
so we can kill it
um
did i not push
oh maybe i didn't push
and we'll go back here
there's that run i'm going to go in here
i want to stop it uh cancel run
okay
and so now what i'll do is go over to
the here
destroy this
we'll run that okay we'll destroy that
and i will again see if this is working
and i'll see you back here in a moment
okay all right so i just wanted to
confirm there that everything is uh
destroyed so we're all in good shape
okay so uh yeah so we're actually done
sendal now for real okay bye
all right let's take a look here at
hashicorp packer so it's a developer
tool to provision a build image that
will be stored in a repository using a
build image before you deploy provides
you with the following immutable
infrastructure your vms and your fleet
are all one to one in configuration
faster deploys for multiple servers
after each build
earlier detection and intervention of
package changes or
of deprecationable technology so let's
take a look at what that workflow would
look like so you'd have your code you
commit it to your ci cd pipeline and
within that pipeline it would start up a
build server running
packer and that would trigger a build
image so you'd use a something to
provision it with so you could use
ansible or a variety of different
provisioners within packer
and then packer would then store it
somewhere so maybe this would be amazon
machine image because you're deploying
to aws
and then what you do is reference that
image in your terraform code and when
you provision it would get deployed to
your
csp so this would be aws in this case so
packer configurations is a machine uh
packer configuration configures the
machine via oops
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we are taking a look at hashicorp
packers so packer is a developer tool to
provision a build image that will be
stored in a repository so using a build
image before you deploy it's going to
give you the following benefits
immutable infrastructure your vms in
your fleet are all one-to-one in
configuration faster deploys for
multiple servers after each build
earlier detection intervention of
package changes or deprecation volt
technology let's take a look at what
that workflow would look like so first
we'd have github or or your git so
wherever you commit your changes and
from there that would trigger a ci cd
pipeline with within that csd pipeline
it would trigger a virtual machine so or
a build server that's a running packer
and so that would trigger the build
image process from there packer would
use some kind of provisioner like
ansible to provision the image and then
when it was done and and it was all good
it would store it somewhere like an
amazon machine image once it is stored
wherever you want it to go
then in terraform you would just
reference it using like a data source
and then from there you could provision
your resource okay so packer configures
a machine via a packer template and yes
i know the e is missing
so sorry about that but packer templates
use the hashicorp configuration language
hcl which we saw
if you remember way earlier in the
course
and that's what we're going to review
next is what that packer template file
looks like okay
all right so packer configures a machine
or container via a packer template file
and packer template uses the hashicorp
configuration language hcl so that's why
it looks very familiar to terraform and
a variety of other languages we've been
looking at in this course
and so what this file is doing is
provisioning a virtual machine on aws so
here you can see that it's a t2 micro
and the us west 2 region that it's
probably going to be installing apache
since it's named httpd
and the way it's going to be created is
via an ebs volumes let's talk about kind
of the components that we're looking at
here so when you have a packer template
file you have to specify a source and
this says where and what kind of image
we are trying to build so the source is
amazon ebs so it's looking for an ami
image or it's being backed by that ebs
volume there okay
in this case it's an ebs backed ami the
image will be stored directly in a bus
under the ec2 images and so we have the
build step so the build allows us to
provide configuration scripts packer
supports a wide range of provisioners so
we have chef puppet ansible power power
shell bash salt
whatever you want basically has it and
the post provisioners runs after the
image is built so they can be used to
upload artifacts or re-package them all
right and the place where this is going
to be stored is going to be on amis okay
so there you go let's look at how we
actually integrate terraform and packer
together in terms of a ci cd workflow we
kind of saw this in uh that overall
graphic in the first uh packers slide
let's just kind of look at the code okay
so to integrate packer there are two
steps you're going to build damage so
packer is not a service but a
development tool so you need to manually
run packer or automate the building of
images with a build server running
packer then the second part of that is
referencing the image so once an image
is built you can reference reference the
image as a data source
so if it's stored in abus ami we're
going to just source it from there
and the way we select it is what we can
do is say okay get us the most recent
one and use this regular expression and
the owner has to be us
and and those kind of parameters to
decide how to choose that image so
that's all there is to it you're just
using data sources to reference them
after they've already been built okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at uh using
packer with terraform and mostly it's
just about just using packer uh and so
what i want to accomplish here is to
generate an image and store that onto
amazon machine images and then load that
into a terraform file or like reference
it as a data source so i've never done
this before but it should be fun and
we'll figure this out so what we're
first going to need to do is download
packer so notice in the top right corner
we make your way to packer however you
want to and we'll go ahead and download
and this one is for windows it's a
binary but we are going to be using
linux uh we've done this so many times
these three two commands so i'm not
going to do that again here but if you
have yet to do so you can go and run
that and so i'm going to go ahead and
install packer and once packer is
installed i will come back here and we
will get to it okay all right so after a
short little white there packer is
installed and so what i want to do is go
into my packer folder here
and i'm just going to run packer and see
what we get
and so we have packer build console fix
format init so install missing plugins
looks kind of similar to terraform
build images from a template that that
sounds kind of interesting so i think
the first thing we're going to need to
do is define ourselves a template file
so uh i remember i researched one and
and put one in my uh slides here so
let's make our work way over there and
see if we can kind of just like use our
notes here as a reference so going down
to this packer file let's go ahead and
just write one here uh i don't say what
the name of the packer file is
that would probably help but i believe
that they're just named as dot hcl files
so what i'm going to do
is go into
this here and make a new file and we're
going to say
i guess apache.hcl since we're already
very familiar with how to install apache
that seems like the easiest way to do it
and again this is going to be very
similar looking to
terraform because it's
you know all based on hcl so we'll do a
type
string
and we are going to need some kind of
default ami so
uh we can go grab the one we've been
using all along here
um i think we specified it
and we can just go back to count counts
always a good one to go to
so i just want to go and grab
where is it um
count count count where are you anybody
see it
i'm blanking today so i'm just going to
grab it from aws
it's not a big deal
i'm just pulling up aws here we're going
to make our way over to ec2
and we're going to go ahead and launch
ourselves a new server actually i could
probably grab it from the old one now
i'll launch a new one just in case you
don't see anything there that might not
be fair i'm going to go ahead and grab
that ami id
and i'll just move that off screen here
for a moment and we're going to place in
that am id because i assume we want one
to override then we're going to say
locals
uh app name
and i think the example i wrote here is
is apache because that is what apache is
httpd not sure how they came up with
that name but that's how they call it
so we need to provide ourselves a source
so we're going to do amazon ebs
httpd
notice that like the source is not
called data it's just called source uh
if we go over to the documentation here
just when i want to show you here docs
if it ever loads
come on docs you can do it
so down below here or on the left hand
side we have sources so if i believe if
we were to go over to here and go over
to amazon ami
someone says amazon ami
overview
[Music]
builders
ec2
ebs
i'm just trying to find the same kind of
information that it has there eh
it's not really doing what i want but
anyway i know that this code is correct
even though we can't seem to find uh
this out probably just go type in
packer ebs amazon ebs
i really like to always refer to the
documentation when i can here
so it does say it's a
builder amazon eps
source
down below here we go
all right so yeah um i don't understand
this uh this builder flag as of yet but
uh we'll work our way through here and
figure it out okay
so i'm gonna go back and pull up my
vs code here
and
we're gonna put curly's here
and so we need our ami name here
so my server
dollar sign local
app name
instance type
t2 micro
region this is going to be us east 1
source ami this is going to be
the variable we set up above ami id
then we are going to do ssh username
that's going to be ec2 user
that's the default that abuse always has
ec2 user
we can do some tags here not really
necessary but it's good to probably give
it a name right so we'll just say
name
apache server
and actually we could probably just do
local.app name
maybe instead
and then we have our build step here so
we're going to specify our sources
and we're going to do
source.amazon.ebs.htpd
provisioner pro
visioner
shell
and then we want to provide a script
i think we can we can actually do it in
line if we didn't want to do a script
there but we know our script works so
maybe we should just stick to that so
i'm just going to call this
userdata.sh because we already have that
somewhere
before
so we'll do post process we don't need a
post processor so we just want to run
that script
i believe we have that in our terraform
workflow
we go over there to
our workflow wherever it is
might also be under modules if we go
into our module here
didn't we create one there called user
data
oh that's a yaml file
oh okay
i mean that's not a big deal um we could
probably just
okay so we're not going to do it that
way all right um
if we're not going to do it this way we
probably can provide inline things we
don't probably have to do script equals
so what i'm going to do is go back
to the terraform documentation here or
packer documentation i should say
and what i want to do is look at
provisioners
we're going to look at shell
so it has this inline step and i assume
that this is going to run in into
sequential order so inline array of
strings
okay so what we will do here is we will
type in inline
and i've done this like a thousand times
but i'm just gonna go google it
apache install aws tutorial
there's probably one on the adabus
website for it
for like user data
and this is pretty much has some of it
here i was just kind of looking for
these commands like the yum install and
the pseudo system start
so we're going to go ahead and grab that
and
then we're going to go
and grab the next few lines here
just want to start and enable
that's the three things that we need to
do
not complicated at all
and so what i'm going to do is type in
packer build and see what happens
now i didn't specify any adwords
credentials or anything like that i
assume it would pick up the default
and we're going to go to the top here so
it looks like we have to provide the
template name so maybe we'll do
apache hcl here
and it says
error parsing json invalid character v
for the beginning of the value
oh so it has to be
pkr.hcl okay
i'm really liking the user experience of
the developer experience for the cli
they're really good at telling us what's
wrong with them um pkr hcl
if there's like a default file i don't
know what it should be called
so we got a bunch of errors which is
fine unsupported argument locals an
argument locals is not expected here did
you mean to define a local's block it's
because i put an equals in front of it
supposed to just be this
not that we were really using locals for
much here
and it looks like it is provisioning
found in ami it's going to use that as
the the source one creating a temporary
key pair authorizing to port 22
uh
name packer builder so i don't know if
this uses i don't think it does but i
don't know if it uses amazon
because there's like ec2 builder image
and there might be a way to use it with
um packer directly but i'm not sure how
to do that
it's going to go over here i'm just
going to see to make sure it's not
running
a pipeline here is it
image pipelines
no okay that's good but what i will do
is go over to my ec2 here
and what i want to go do okay so packer
builders is running as a virtual machine
so it's actually um
going to spin up a vm and then bake the
ami that way
which seems a lot better
we'll go over to our amis and see when
that happens there
um
it's just unlock another those that red
stuff doesn't look good
seems it seems like it didn't really
matter
so thing like aws has
an entire pipeline for ec2 image builder
but it does cost money to run where i
kind of feel like
if all packer is doing is spinning up a
virtual machine temporarily to make that
image that's going to be a lot more cost
effective
i mean we could go look up what the cost
is to use ec2 image builder while we
were watching this
builder can't seem to type today
uh just pricing i just wanted the
pricing
it can't be free
oh is it there's no cost i could have
swore there was a cost for this
no cost image builders offered at no
cost other than the cost of the
underlying aws resource i think the
thing is that
it's that when you use um
ec2 image builder you have to use of a
particular size
you know if you don't really use aws
you're more wearing azure gcp i
understand why this is not much of an
interest but
i'm pretty sure
if i go here
that the size that you get for the image
what size of
each image does ec2 image builder use
because i remember was like really
really large un like unreasonably large
and that was the cost involved in it
can't find it today it's not a big deal
but waiting for the ami to become ready
so if we go over to our amis here and
give us a refresh we can see that it is
spinning so it is provisioning that ami
while that is going on what we can do is
just start setting up the next part of
this so
within
our packer here we can say new file and
i'm going to say main.tf
i'm going to go as per usual and grab
some default code from our account
example which is
right here
okay copy that we're going to go all the
way down to the ground here and
[Music]
i'm going to go into the main tf here
paste that on in
and we probably want to keep the public
ip around we actually don't really care
but i'm putting it in anyway i'm going
to take out the tags oh i want to leave
the name in so i'll just say like server
packer
okay
server apache packer
and
uh this is the thing that we want to
replace out this all looks fine so this
is what we need to figure out is our ami
here it's probably going to come in as a
data source it has to come in as a data
source and i'm pretty sure that's what i
wrote
in our documentation here so yeah it's a
my example things like that so
what we're going to do
is type in a bus
mi
packer image
and we'll just define that data source
so adabus ami
packer image
and we have executable users executable
users equals self
i'm not saying i know what all these
options do but like you just go to the
documentation you grab them you got
something works
true name regex
okay and so we would do something like
uh start with the little carrot
character
and
what did we name this this starts with
uh my server hyphen
probably would have helped if we named
it with like something like
packer in the name but
i think that's fine
um
we might as well
might as well go the full name here
and say httpd because that's technically
what it's going to be
um we might want to match for
more values here so
i'm not sure i guess like
we do that
because sometimes it's like three digits
or whatever but i don't know what packer
is going to do if we keep pushing
additional ones i'm not really familiar
with with that so
we'll just say owners equal self
and so now that should be all set up to
go as that is
running it finished so that's all good
we're going to say
terraform
init and here it says a block definition
must have a block content deliminator
so we have a small problem here
it looks correct to me
this is not right okay
we'll see if we can knit this
now whether our build image works
properly i don't know
so it'd be really good to write like
some tests for it i imagine that there
is some kind of way to do that
um
i guess it'd be like the post processor
scripts maybe you'd want to do that
where you'd want to
use that as a means for
testing
i'm not really sure
obviously different provisioners might
have
that kind of stuff built in so
you know it might be just part of the
provisioning tool you can use
so it initialized here we're going to do
a terraform plan
because i'm hoping that it might
complain about the data aws ami here if
it does not exist properly and it did so
your curry return no results please
change your search criteria and try
again
so
however i wrote this is probably not
correct so i will just take this out
here
try this
no results
so what i'll do is go over to
uc2 here and actually that's the only
name that's here
for the ami so i guess i could just go
here and grab the name
but maybe that's not the problem oh no
that might be fine so we'll just do this
name regex
okay
so let's go look up data aws ami
excavable users most recent name regex
owners
maybe we could just do like a filter
here
let's look at name x a regex to apply to
an analyst returned by aws this allows
for more advanced filtering not
supported by the database api filtering
is done locally on the aws
returns
so
i suppose that is good but like i just
need
it to work so i'm going to try the
filter instead
and i'm actually going to put literally
the name in my server
httpd
i'm going to take out the regex assuming
that is the problem
owners itself executable users itself um
please change the criteria
i don't know what x google users users
actually does let's maybe look up what
that is limit search to users with
explicit launch permissions on the image
is that required no so let's just take
that out
if more than one there isn't so let's
just take that out for the time being
who's the owner of this
we're the owner right we have to be
owner is this ip address that must be us
or sorry not ip but like our account
number
so i mean that should be fine
and incorrect attribute value type
oh okay so that was fine so we'll do dot
id
but you know if you're doing this like
if you wanted a continuous pipeline
you'd probably want to get the most
recent and have a better regex
and so i'll do a terraform apply auto
approve and see if this works
one thing i kind of wonder is like with
packer how would you do like a
versioning
because that's what i'm not certain
about so like i'm just kind of like
looking through here and seeing what
they would do for that
i would imagine that uh you're probably
supposed to like increment it and have
it part of the name
nothing's really speaking to me there
but you know like
the idea is that you want to have things
like
zero zero zero zero one zero two zero
three
but i imagine like there's some
pragmatic way maybe there's like a
built-in function or something that we
can do to do that
um or what you do is you just have a
variable probably that's actually what
you probably do
is you'd have like variable
like version
right
string
and then you'd probably set it and it
would come through that way
like you'd set it over here
it says our server has finished
provisioning let's go c and take see if
that actually worked
we'll go up to ec2 instances here
that is running
copy that
paste that in
um
the security group doesn't have any open
ports right
so it probably did work it's just we
didn't create a security group with us
so there are no open ports for us to
check i'm not worried about this i don't
care if it actually did work or not
because we more or less follow all the
steps there but i believe the reason
it's not working like there is just
because we don't have a security group
and i just don't want to
uh fiddle with that and put it into a
state so that it does not match
so anyway we're all done here so i'm
going to do a terror forum
um apply auto approve
destroy
but there we go we accomplished that
with packer that pretty much wraps up
all the main
follow alongs for the course so
hopefully that was a lot of fun
um yeah we'll just continue on here
all right so let's talk about
terraforming console because you're
going to hear consul mention throughout
the documentation and you might think
it's critical to the exam but it's not
so i just want to make sure we
understand its relation to terraform so
console is a service networking platform
which provides service discovery so
central registry for services in the
network it allows for direct
communication so no single point of
failure via load balancers it has a
service mesh so managing network traffic
between services a communication layer
on top of your container application so
think middleware it has application
configuration capabilities so console is
useful when you have a microservice or
service oriented architecture with
hundreds of thousands of services so
these are containerized apps or
workloads
and so the way console integrates with
terraform is in the following ways it is
a remote backend because console has a
key value store
and this is where you could
store the state of your terraform files
then also there's a console provider
because you can use terraform to set up
some things in console for you but
there's not much else outside of that
okay
all right we're taking a look here at
hashicorp vault so vault is a tool for
securing accessing secrets from multiple
secret data stores vault is deployed to
a server where a vault admin can
directly manage secrets and we have
operators also known as developers can
access secrets via an api vault provides
a unified interface to any secret such
as aws secrets console key values google
cloud kms azure service principles it
provides tight access control so just in
time which is reducing surface attacks
based on a range of time and just enough
privilege so reducing surface attack by
providing at least permissive
permissions we can also
record a detailed audit log so we have
tamper evidence so this is kind of the
idea of our
little hashtag fault stack so you have
your secrets engines these are
third-party services or sorry cloud
services that actually store the secrets
you have your vault cluster which act as
the adapter to your resources and the
resources which are going to access them
so again vault is is deployed to virtual
machines in a cluster and vaults can be
backed up via snapshots so if you do
provision them and you're worried about
the state of those vaults you can
definitely save those for later okay
let's take a look here at terraform and
vault how they would work together so
when a developer is working with
terraform and they need to deploy a
provider like aws they will need aws
credentials so abs credentials are long
lived meaning a user generates a key in
secret and they are usable until they
are deleted so the ada's credentials
reside on the developer's local machine
and so the machine is at risk of being
compromised by malicious actors looking
to steal those credentials so if we
could provide credentials just in time
expire their credentials after a short
amount of time so short-lived we could
reduce the attack surface area of the
local machine and so this is where vault
comes in because vault can be used to
inject short-lived secrets at the time
of terraform apply so imagine you are
you are the developer and you run your
terraform apply at that point in time
it's going to inject the secrets the way
we do that is via
data sources data source is always the
way we get data into our terraform
configuration file but let's look at
that in greater detail on the next slide
here okay
all right let's take a look at how this
vault injection via data source works so
a vault server is provisioned a vault
engine is configured like aws secrets
engine the vault will create a machine
user for aws vault will generate a
short-lived aws credential for that
machine user thought we'll manage and
apply the database policy and then
within our terraform we can provide a
data source
to the vault so that's what we're doing
we're saying vault about access
credentials and we are getting the
output from our terraform remote state
admin outputs backend uh and then from
there we can reference them into aws
okay
so when terraform applies run it will
pull short-lived credentials to be used
uh used for the scope of the duration of
the current run every time you run apply
you will get a new short live
credentials which is the whole point of
uh the short-lived idea okay hey this is
andrew brown from exam pro and we are
taking a look at vault
and so the idea here is that we want to
be able to inject uh secrets from vault
in a secure manner for our local
developer environments i really kind of
wish i included this screenshot or this
graphic within my slides i just found it
as as of now because it does really
represent all the types of secret
engines and capabilities of vault one
thing in particular i wasn't aware of is
that it has its own key value store
uh so that's what we're going to be
using we're going to keep it really
simple here um but the first thing we're
going to have to do is go ahead and
install vault so just down below i have
a link here that i found
and we'll go down below
and it's not shouldn't be too hard to
install so
we are on linux today i mean i'm on a
windows machine but i'm using linux
as the windows
subsystem there and so this is where
we're going to start and grab our stuff
so making my way over to vs code whoops
um and
i'm just trying to think should we use
this for a new project probably so i'm
going to just cd out here
and i'm going to make my way into
um vault which i apparently don't have a
folder for so i'm going to just go here
and we're going to
find
reveal and explore
and we'll make a new one
200 volts
okay and so
we'll start first install something then
we'll set up a project all right so um
[Music]
let's go through the installation
process here okay so we'll go do a curl
which is our first step
and that's just gonna grab the gpg i
think we already have it because we did
it for probably
the the cli4 um
terraform there but we'll just do it
again there it doesn't hurt i'll add the
repository again i think we already did
this when we installed the cli in the
beginning of this course
but we'll let it go again there i
remember this takes a little bit of time
so we'll just wait here for a bit
all right so now we need to run the last
command which is actually going to go
ahead and install vault here for us
let's go ahead and grab that line
and i'm going to go ahead and paste that
on in
i'm not sure if i grabbed that properly
we'll try that one more time
it uh oh yeah my console is unresponsive
there we go okay just happens when i um
i stop and start recording it just for
some reason times out like that so i'll
go ahead and hit enter there and that
will go ahead and install our vault
and then after that we're gonna have to
start getting it running um there is
again a tutorial to inject secrets i'm
not going to stick one to one with it
because
it does come with a repository but i
find that it is a little bit more work
than we want to do here we just want to
kind of get a basic example working
and i just want to make our lives a
little bit easier so i'm just going to
modify it as we go here
but uh yeah we'll just wait for that to
install i'll see you back here in a
moment okay
all right so after a short little wait
here i believe that um vault is
installed let's find out if it works so
we'll type in vault
once i get the responsiveness back from
my console here just give you in a
moment great oh nope there we go vault
and so vault is there and so what we can
do is start it up in a developer mode
and i remember from here they actually
had some pretty good instructions on the
starting of that
so
um like the way they do this project and
i have the repo here is that they um
they
provision vault with a bunch of
different things so i think they're
using like s3 here and that would
probably be a really
common use case for this but i really
want to simplify and i don't want to
have to provision that terraform and
cross-reference the stuff so we're just
going to uh simplify that so i'm just
looking for the command to start fault
because i saw a good one here
that was like
vaults um
ah here it is right there so vault
server hyphen dab that starts in the
developer mode dev root token id there's
something about like ceiling or
unsealing stuff i don't know what that
means but i assume that's a way of
securing the vault but we're going to go
ahead and just type that in so we're
going to go vault
server hyphen dev hyphen dev root token
id and obviously you wouldn't want to do
this for your production they call
there's education i'm just going to
stick with that to make our lives a bit
easier and so what that's going to do is
start up a vault server
it is running on this port here so
i suppose we should export that or or
keep this because we'll probably have to
reference it somehow
notice we have this like unseal key so
the unseal key and root token are
displayed below in case you want to seal
or re-authenticate
um development should not be used in
production so what i'm going to do
is i'm just going to create a
a
readme file in our vault here so let's
just say new file read me because i just
want to dump this stuff of course
you know you should not share these with
anybody but i just don't want to forget
these while we're working through this
so i'm going to go ahead and copy that
and we'll go ahead and save that
uh and
so
what i want to do now oops
did we lose our terminal
did i close it
okay i must have closed it so which one
we're working in second third one which
is it
fourth okay it's the third one so
don't be like me close out your old ones
so i'm just gonna close out these old
ones so i'm less confused
there we go and so it says that it
started on uh this address here so i'm
gonna go copy that address
and we're gonna open this up you can do
everything via the cli
i just want to
copy that there
but they have a nice ui which is nice
and so this is where we're going to put
that token education
and drop that down so there are some
other options or there's a lot of
options for authenticating but token is
obviously the easiest and probably not
the most secure uh it's just the way we
wrote it and notice that we have a
couple things pre-installed so we have
cubby hull which is a per token private
secret storage
and then we have key value secret
storage again i don't know much about
these because this isn't a um
this isn't a course on vault it's just
kind of us showing a basic integration
and more focus on the terraform side but
here is where we can create our secrets
we can of course use the cli to do that
and i think they showed in the getting
started here
and
we don't have to do it this way i would
i'd rather do to ui but you do like
vault key
key v put and you put the name of your
secret so here's secret forward slash
hello and then the key and the value
that's where the store i assume that
this would go to the well this would
specify we're using here so what we'll
do is we'll go over here
and we'll create ourselves a new secret
because we're going to want to store
something here so we want the path for
the secret
this is pretty common with um if you've
ever used
a parameter store you have a path
i don't know if it starts with a forward
slash
it may not end in a forward slash
probably can begin with it so i'm going
to say adabs
key because we'll do the key and the
secret right so
here
oh okay cool cool so we can do four
slash aws
and then down below i would just add
another one
maybe i gotta add each one at a time so
we'll say key and i'll go actually go
grab our proper ones
um oh i should have stopped that i'm
gonna have to s
start that up again
okay and we'll add a plus there because
everything lives in memory when you're
in the dev one so you really don't want
to shut that down or you'll have to redo
all this from scratch so what i'm gonna
do is just go back
here
and drag this down a little bit more
okay and i'm just gonna go see if i have
to relog in because i might have messed
this all up
yes i do so type in education so we
really don't want to stop running that
server during the duration of this
follow along
okay and so we'll go back into secret
here create a
secret sports slash jws
um we wanted to jason no i don't think
it matters
if we can add two keys that's all that
matters to me and so what i'm gonna do
is cat out
credentials of course this is not the
secure way of doing it so you know again
don't show people these things
and so i want this and i probably should
match the name
i'm going to like type in the whole darn
thing
and we'll grab this
oops
i want to see that value is correct good
we're going to add another one here this
is going to be our axis secret or axis
secret access key i really don't like
how those have been named and we'll go
ahead and grab on this
and um
i mean we don't really need to really
store the region here but why not
because we're doing all the rest of here
we might as well just throw them all in
here
for fun
and uh here it says maximum number of
versions i don't need anything beyond
one
because we're not going to be updating
these um require check and set so rights
will only be allowed if the keys current
version matches the version specified in
the cas parameter not sure what that
means maybe just like you're passing
something along when you are doing
something but uh i think this is all
good
you know what i'm just going to leave
that back to 10 just in case i've made a
mistake and we have to go debug that i'm
going to hit save and so there are
secrets
and so what we want to do is be able to
access them and so maybe this is our
opportunity to learn the cli here a bit
so i have it pulled up on the left-hand
side and so what i'm going to do is type
in vault
tv
get and we'll do aws i don't know if we
can start with the forward slash there
i'm going to hit enter
and um the server gave an http response
to an https client
so
i'm not sure
why that's a problem because
like i mean i understand that it started
up in hd http
but i mean i'm in development so
you know what else am i going to really
do here
let's see if i can just scroll up here
and if there's anything else
um
and i kind of swore that it installed a
private key as we were doing this
because i remember seeing that there
it was like a private key
i could have swore there was one
something but private key
so i'm not sure what the problem is here
i'll be back in a moment and i will
resolve it okay
so the suggestion i'm getting is that we
need to
export a couple of environment variables
so see here where it writes this so we
say you need to set the following so
maybe we will go through and set those
so i'll go grab that there
but here's the thing is like how do i
run that
because these are i think these are like
not the same so i mean i can't run it
over here can i
i don't think so
uh well i guess if we're doing a key
vault value there maybe we can
um
still no good what if we export the
vault token
i think we said it was education here
[Music]
let's do vault status
so yeah i'm not sure how we're going to
do it that way i mean it's not a really
big deal because i don't think that we
have to access it that way but notice
here
like
as i was reading here you know
they're just saying down below oh we had
to set
this and that so i'm not really sure
what i would do here so the output is
like this
run these commands and it should do it
again the error message can be similar
or different problems so
that or maybe i'm just specifying the
key incorrectly and that's why it
doesn't like it
so
um
let's just type in vault and see what we
have here so vault tv
maybe if we do like a list can we get a
list
list the secrets
um aws
aws
clear
i'm not sure what parameter it wants
there
uh let's go look it up so let's say like
tariff or was it uh vault
tv list
option seems to want another parameter
here
i'm going to scroll on down so
secret
forward slash my app
um
folders are suffix with the forward
slash the input must be a folder list of
a file will not return
um
do i have to put secret in front of it
secret
aws
no so i don't know what the issue is
there it just would would have been nice
to use it via the cli but the thing is
is that again we don't need to use it
that way we just need to
um you know set it and and get it but i
thought it'd be fun to kind of use the
cli there so
now that we have those set the way we're
going to extract out these values is by
using a data source
and so
what i want to do is just create a new
local project and i think we'd like to
always pull from our account repo here
so i'm going to go all the way up to
here and i'm going to go grab the main
and i'm just going to copy the contents
there we're going to go all the way down
to the ground and we're going to make a
new
main tf file here
we're gonna go paste that on in
and we just want my server
we don't need an output it's fine
this is all fine this is all fine but uh
the one thing is we don't want to use
our particular provider there so what
i'm going to do
um is i'm going to just open up
our
credentials file there
and i'm just going to change this to
something else like other so that it
doesn't load that profile there
okay i'm going to just
take these out of here
um i think we can leave that alone
and i think that's everything so what i
want to do now we don't need that count
we'll get rid of that count
we'll go check out the documentation or
the code base here
because it gives us a bit of an idea how
we need to implement this
we'll go over the operator
uh we'll go over to the main
and so they're setting some variables
here like name region path things like
that but again we want to grab it from
the source
they're actually cross referencing it
like this other they provision the admin
and grabbing it that way i don't want to
do it that way i wanted to use just the
data source like this
so
i'm not sure how that's going to work so
let's go look that up
okay so here it says read it's
credentials from an abra secret back end
and i'm not trying to do that i'm just
trying to read them from the key vault
okay so
we probably want vaults
generic secret would this be from key
vault
this resource is primarily intended to
be used with the generic secret backend
but it is also compatible with any vault
endpoint that is provided
but is that the key value one
that's not clear to me
um
so i think it is
so let's see if we can figure that out
here so i'm just going to move that off
screen here
and we're going to add ourselves the
data source so i guess we're really not
following that other tutorial at all
because it we literally have to use a
different um
key value there eh
so we'll say secret and this is going to
be like aws
credentials
maybe there's creds i don't have to
worry about spelling mistakes and we
need to specify a path notice it always
starts with like secret i don't know if
we always have to start it with secret
um so i will just say aws here
and there might be some additional
options i'm just scrolling through to
hear that so you have path so
this is the fully lo the full logical
path from which to request the data to
read data from generic secret back in
mountain vault by default this should be
prefixed with secret forward slash so we
do have to do that
reading from other backends as data
sources possible consult each back-end
documentation to see which endpoint
supports the get
version version of the secret to read we
only have a single version so we don't
have to specify that
so technically that should be correct
so what we will want to do now in our
provider is specify all those options
so again i'm just going back to the
source code this is off screen but we
need to set the region the access key
and the secret key here
and so this is going to be data and
it's going to be
vault generic secret
and
i guess it would be aws
and then we're accessing those things
like region
and so i'm going to go ahead and just
copy that really quickly
and we will go over back to our vault
here because the names are over here
so go grab that paste that in there
we'll go grab that paste that in there
and i'm just going to double check to
make sure if i've made any mistakes
this one it's showing it from the admin
so it goes admin outputs but we're not
outputting from anything we're just
grabbing it from
the vault there so maybe what we need to
do is just kind of review
how this generic fault works
so this does data vault generic and then
it does data and then square braces
so
i wonder if we always have to do data so
for example the vault there is a a key
named auth token the value is a token
that we need to keep secret
but yeah i don't understand is this a
json object or just a way of referencing
it because it doesn't specify that so
we'll just give it a try
nothing hurts with trying right so we'll
say data
and this might again might not be the
right way i don't know if it's single or
doubles there
it's doubles
so i just wonder if that was like the
one case where it's doubles
okay and we will do this
and so i think that that should
maybe work
don't know what i'm wondering is if i if
i'd led with a forward slash would it
have considered that and or is it now
double but i don't think so because look
here looks like it's stripped it out
because it just says aws here so we got
a secret since just aws
almost looks like there's a space in the
front of it eh
but it's not there so maybe there's not
it's just kind of like a little glitch
so
um
we need to go and cd into this directory
here
and we just need to do a terraform init
that's kind of interesting because like
we haven't set up the provider
i guess it's not going to happen until
we actually use the provider so maybe
it's not an issue just yet
i'm curious to see if it pulls any kind
of modules in for the vault generic
secret
so i'll just give it a moment there to
initialize
okay so after there we can see that it
did actually add vaulting so it must be
ready to take it from there
um i'm going to do a terraform plan here
and you know i'm going to just change
this to like my server with faults
now remember it's not going to be able
to pull from the um
from our local credentials because we're
not setting a profile and we overrode
the default just in case
so here it's saying a resource a data
resource vault generic secret aws has
not been declared in the root module
um it hasn't
i mean it looks like i did no
maybe i typed it wrong so we'll go
here
i don't think it matters but i'll just
put it above okay
and i'm just gonna double check to make
sure nope it matches oh because it's
eight of us creds that's fair
um you didn't use the option oh that's
fine so my question will be will this
correctly provision
because we will not know until we uh
use this right here
i suppose if we try to use a data source
for aws that would probably also
indicate whether it's working or not so
maybe we should try doing that
so we do like data
address vpc
and then we just do like id equals here
because that would have to use the
credentials right
um and so we'll just go well that's
actually it's not specifying any of the
the vpc here so maybe maybe we won't do
that because it's just too much work
um so what i'll do here
is i'm going to do a terraform apply
auto approve
and let's cross our fingers and hope
this works
and while that is running what i'm going
to do is just pull up my aws environment
here
and apparently i'm not logged in so
that'll give me a bit of time here to
kind of catch up here while this is
provisioning there
and uh so it looks like it actually
provisioned the server if that's the
case that means that our secrets are
being pulled correctly right so
if we go over to ec2 here
and we go and check out this instance
it is running so it worked
if we just want to do a sanity check to
make sure it absolutely is working we
can just introduce a bug into this
so maybe we go here and we just say
um i guess we'd have to make a new
version create a new version and what
i'm going to do is purposely introduce
some mistakes so we're just going to put
like an at sign here on the end we're
going to save that
and i'm going to make a minor change
like nano
and so what i'm expecting is for this to
fail let's see if it fails on the plan i
don't think it will
you're going to fail on the apply and it
does okay so the plan would tell us
whether it didn't work or not so that
clearly uh clearly means it absolutely
is pulling from it especially when we're
doing the plan
so um i want to go back to
our file there i just kind of lost the
folder i'm just looking for it
the i got too many um
too many chrome windows open here
there it is okay so we'll go back here
and we'll
what if we can just revert back to the
previous version
um see i don't know if i would delete
there i don't want to i don't want to
jinx it so i'm just going to go here
and take out that sign
we're going to go ahead and save that
and so that should be updated we're
going to do tear from plan
great and so what i want to do is just
tear this down so it'll say terraform
apply
auto approve
and destroy
okay and while that is destroying i'm
pretty pretty confident that's going to
work i'm going to stop my vault server
oh wait
was that going to still work did i get
the credentials in time
oh no
i
i made a big boo-boo okay so um
i uh i killed my vault server before i
was supposed to
that's really embarrassing um anyway
that's not a big deal because i kind of
wanted to stop the server anyway
but i want to go back into our airbus
credentials there
and turn that back to defaults
and i wanted to go back up here and just
flip that back so that we can get rid of
the server right so
i don't want to kind of lose these for
the tutorial so i'm just going to go
here and just comment those out for a
second
profile default
oops
region
usc 1
and
we'll do that again that's embarrassing
okay and i'm just going to preemptively
i'm not going to save this file but i'm
just going to do this for now
um it's still trying to connect
oh boy
so
just put these back in here
because it's set to the vault can i do a
tear from refresh probably not
no probably not uh what if i do a
terraform init because i did change like
i was using vault so maybe i just have
to do that to fix that problem
and let's try
destroy again
that was a big boo-boo on my part eh
nope okay so
let's go back over here
and start it up again
and i'm pretty sure there's like a way
to back up your vaults like there's
probably some kind of snapshot or
something um again i'm not that
deep into it so i cannot tell you if
that's the case
um so i guess we'll just go back here
and remake our secrets
because it shouldn't have persisted
right
if it did i'd be so happy
nope
okay
aws we'll leave 10 in there and then
we'll just have to copy all the stuff
over again because of my
bonehead mistake there so we have region
which is u.s east one
u.s east one here
and
go over here
well at least you know what to do if
that happens to you okay
um i don't need the
equal sign there
go ahead and add this one
okay and what we're going to do is go
ahead and save that
and we'll just quit out of that we'll do
a terraform plan
since we know that that will pick it up
right
great and we'll do terraform apply auto
approve destroy
okay so
again this only applies to development
but uh yeah don't kill your fault server
before you're done destroying okay
so i'll see you back here in a moment
all right so that infrastructure is
destroyed we can go back to here and
then we can stop our server and for your
benefit i'm just going to bring back
these in here
so you don't have to worry about that
and uh yeah we uh we accomplished vault
for injections now you might say well
how would you do this with terraform
cloud well the thing is the terraform
cloud already uses
a vault under the hood when you store
your environment variables there and the
idea is that
i suppose you don't need to pull them in
from all those sources
but i think that was one of my my
questions i had when i was talking to
one of the das which was like okay it's
great that terraform cloud has um
you know uses vault behind the scenes
but what if i want that to live
somewhere else
but maybe that's not really necessary um
because
i don't know but yeah that's it so we're
all done with vault hey this is andrew
brown from exam pro and we are taking a
look at atlantis which is an open source
developer tool to automate terraform
pull requests which you can find at run
atlantis.io so the idea is once this is
installed on your github and you merge a
pull request then it's going to go ahead
and do a terraform apply so this would
be a way for you to do um
uh get ops or to automate your uh your
infrastructure as code and uh the
interesting thing is that hashicorp
actually maintains this project they
didn't originally build it was built by
two people from another company and it
wasn't that they did not want to use
terraform cloud which can
uh do this but at the time i think they
had a hard time at the company getting
procurement because it was a very large
company and so they had to build
something so they built out this thing
um and anyway these two people end up
getting hired by hashicorp and hashgraph
maintains this project which is really
nice because it is an alternative for
terraform cloud um but uh yeah that's
all
let's take a look at cdk for terraform
and so to understand this we need to
first understand what is cdk so aws
cloud development kit is an imperative
infrastructure is code tool with sdks
for your favorite language so the idea
is that you can use something like
typescript python java c-sharp go and
ruby ruby's definitely there that's the
language i like to use and aws cdk is
intended only for aws cloud resources
because cdk generates a cloud formation
so cfn templates this is known as
synthesizing and uses that for iac
but cdk for terraform is a standalone
project by hashicorp that allows you to
use cdk but instead of cfn templates it
generates out it's going to generate
terraform templates and so basically
anything terraform can do you can do it
through cdk
and that allows you to do interesting
things like um use cdk to provision
azure resources so that is very uh
interesting uh and a great development
that i think that they're doing
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at grunt work
which is a software company that builds
devops tools that extends or leverages
terraform the reason we're talking about
them is that they produce a couple of
very popular open source tools that work
with terraform and you're going to see
their name because um
you know the co-founders there are very
active in the community uh jim has wrote
in a really good book on terraform so
you know it's no surprise that uh they
are present but it's worth giving them a
mention so you know who they are uh the
first thing i want to mention is the
infrastructure is a code library so
these are a bunch of reusable battle
tested production-ready infrastructure
code for aws gcp azure um and so they
have some free ones there and some paid
ones there then there's tara grunt so a
thin wrapper that provides extra tools
for keeping your configurations dry we
have teratest a testing framework for
infrastructure provisioned with
terraform we have grunt work landing
zones for aws this is a multi-account
security on aws we have grunt work
pipelines and then there's the grunt
work reference architecture
and so where we're going to focus our
attention here is just on terra grunt
and tara tess because those are things i
think are essential to know uh if you
are using terraform because you know
you'll run into those use cases where
you might want to use them okay
all right let's take a look here at
teragrun so this is a thin wrapper for
terraform that provides extra tools for
keeping your configuration dry working
with multiple terraform modules managing
remote state and this is accessible at
the tariff tara grunt.gruntwork.io
so the idea here is the concept of don't
repeat yourself so it's a programming
methodology to abstract repeated code
into functions and modules or libraries
and often in isolate files to reduce
code complexity efforts and errors so
the way that works is that you'll see
these hcl files which are the uh
teragraph code and they're actually
named terragrant.hcl and that's what's
going to be used to
abstract away or dry up your
terraform files so here is an example of
terror grunt now terra grunt does a lot
of different things and
you're going to uh find its use when you
actually use terraform in practice and
you run into these limitations in
terraform and you go and i wish there
was a way around it interrogant like
almost always solves that and so one
example is being able to generate um
dynamic providers and i don't mean like
dynamic values here in the sense that
there's that dynamic value feature of uh
terraform but i just mean the fact that
at the time of this it's very hard to
inject or to write out providers so they
have this generate function that allows
you to get around that
another really interesting thing is that
terra grunt supports better
granularity for modules by reducing lots
of boilerplate uh the way they do this
is is that you are referencing your
terraform files uh via the source here
okay so you're not including your
modules within your code you're just
referencing them and then you pass along
their inputs
and this is going to be very important
when we look at
wanting to write unit tests for your
infrastructure because
when you learn about how you test iac
you have to really break things down
into smaller parts and if you have a lot
of friction there it's going to make
your team not want to adopt that or it's
going to make that process really slow
but again this is more like at scale or
when you hit these kind of requirements
okay
all right let's take a look here at
testing in terraform and so what we have
here on the left-hand side is our usual
um
pyramid that tells us the layers of
testing and so i kind of want to walk
through the layers there and talk about
a bit of the tools that are available to
the terraform community and you know the
reason why we want to move up the
pyramid here to get uh better tests and
then we'll take a look at teratest at
the bottom we have static analysis and
this is where you test your code without
deploying and you've been doing it all
along when you do terraform validate
terraform plan or you're using sentinel
uh you're doing static analysis and that
just means that
we're testing you know like the
composition or the the shape of our code
or like its outputs to what it says it
should be doing okay but you can't catch
all your problems there and that's where
you move on to unit testing and unit
testing uh you know traditionally means
like in programming to test like a
particular functions its inputs and its
outputs uh it's a little bit harder for
infrastructure because um you know
you have to have it connected to other
things so it the definition is a little
bit warped but the idea here and
specifically with terraform is you're
just testing a single module and that
really says like okay well you need to
really pare down that module to be
of the small scope and that's where you
end up dividing your modules into very
small units of work
and so for tooling here we got teratest
kitchen uh terraform and inspec
um and so
uh yeah that's where that motivation
came with um you know teragram the last
thing saying okay let's split them up
into smaller stuff uh you have
integration testing this is pretty much
just using multiple um
uh
modules together you know so you say
okay well i know that this lambda
function is working but do i know it
works in conjunction with this sqsq or
something like that then you have
end-to-end testing and this is where
you're testing basically like business
use cases so it's not just saying okay
from a technical perspective but from a
business use case do or the customer use
case do we meet the requirements here uh
and this uh is very hard because what
you have to actually do is set up a
persistent test network environment but
once you have one you're going to be
really good shape one example of a
test environment and it is paid but
grumborg has their own called the grunt
work reference architecture uh but you
know if you had to do it without that
you'd have to just roll your own kind of
environment
so you know if you do want a good
breakdown of all these different kinds
uh you know jim from grunt work has a
complete talk on automated testing for
infrastructure as code i strongly
recommend it because it really gives you
a better scope than what i can cover
here
but let's just go take a quick look at
teratest so teratest allows you to
perform unit tests and integration tests
on your infrastructure it tests your
infrastructure by temporarily deploying
it validating the results then tearing
down the test environment and so here's
an example of what a
a test function would look like in
teratest it is written in golang i know
golang can be very hard to use but you
don't need to know much about it if you
you pretty much copy and paste it and
just kind of tweak the values to get the
result you want so you know hopefully
that helps to tell you how you would
test in terraform and you know a bit
about tear test okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
i'm going to show you how to book your
hashicorp certification so type in
hashicorp certification into google
we'll go to the first link and we'll
just scroll around and try to find where
it is that we can schedule so it's not
that clear as to where we can go but
let's say we click into the terraform
associate certification and we have
schedule and take the exam this will
bring us to this page and it will just
give us some instructions saying you
have to have your id things like that so
we'll say click here to go to the exam
platform so we click that and it's going
to bring us to the single sign-on so
notice or it's not single sign-on but
it's at ipd through offhashcorp.com so
we'll click on our github
and we will authorize that
you could probably sign up via ps psi
exams online if you don't have a github
account but generally you probably
should have one if you're taking a
hashtag corp certification so what i'll
do is scroll on down we'll click on
schedule and i'm just going to enter
some of my personal details here so
we'll say andrew brown
at andrew exam pro dot co
okay
and now i need to
choose my location so we're gonna choose
canada
i'm going to choose my time zone so i am
in
toronto
and so now i have some options down
below so you can see
we have available dates i'm going to put
mine between wednesday and friday so i'm
gonna take it wednesday
and i'm gonna try to find a time that
suits me
so
i'm thinking probably
8 p.m that's the time i like to take my
exams we'll go ahead and hit continue
and we'll just review our details here
and hit continue
and notice this is a remote online
proctored exam
it's probably possible to take it
in person but at this time this is not
possible to
take an in-person exam so this is for
the online process here and so what
you're going to want to do is go ahead
and go to pay now
or actually sorry you have to
acknowledge the terms
and then go to pay now
and so that would redirect you to the
payment portal i actually have a code so
i'm going to go ahead and enter my code
in and that's how i'm going to proceed
here but if you were paying you just go
to the pay now
okay and so mine has been set i'll go
ahead and click pay now
great
and so now my exam is uh ready to go so
that's all there really is to it they're
going to give you a bunch of information
that you need to follow through you need
to make sure you have your government id
and make sure that matches the name that
you put in so i put in andrew brown so
my government id needs to say that
and that's all there really is to it